Heat.
Heat. Heat.
Hallelujah.
Heat.
Heat. Heat. N.
Heat. Heat.
Heat.
Hey, heat. Hey, heat.
Heat. Heat.
Hey,
hey, hey.
Hey, hey, hey.
Heat.
Hey, Heat. Heat. Heat.
Heat. Heat.
Heat.
Hey, heat. Hey, heat.
Heat. Heat.
Heat.
We're back in the entertainment capital
of the world for day two of Riftbound
regional qualifiers in Las Vegas.
We began with the blade dancer, the
glorious executioner, and the prodigal
explorer all taking center stage. But a
lone Rexai, the void brewer lurks on the
8 tables. In the city where stars are
born and legacies are forged, our
players dream of stamping their names
into the history books.
Welcome back to the booth here at
Regional Qualifier Vegas. I'm Jim Davis,
Kasanova. We got day two. Day one was
incredible. Uh we had fantastic matches
up and down the board. Really, really
awesome events and uh and great
happenings. And now we get to do it all
over again at a higher stakes with big
prizes on the line.
>> Oh yeah. And we've got six undefeateds
remaining trying to continue this run.
Guarantee that spot in the top eight.
Hold on as long as possible before
taking that first loss. A lot of
familiar names of course, but some new
we mention there are Rexai even sneaking
in on those top tables. Very cool to
hear. So let's check out our schedule
and see what's going on today. So we are
of course on championship Sunday. Five
rounds of Swiss. to be a players playing
five rounds Swiss today going into our
untimed single elimination top eight.
Our players will battle it out for
champion for a trophy for prize money
and glory here on the stage in Las
Vegas. And uh let's see what they're
playing for.
So we got Oh man, that's really really
cool. The Blade of the Ruin King
champion promo and playmat. Of course,
just you know $6,000 to first place.
>> Pretty good.
>> Not too shabby. Our top eight players
will also get a Blade of the Ruin King
top eight promo. Second place 3,000.
Third and fourth 2,000. Top eight it's
1,000. And there's also prizes going
down to top 32. We got 500 bucks for 9th
through 12th. And then 17th through 32nd
250. And the bone shiver participation
promo is uh pretty nice as well. That's
a nice prize spread. All right. That's
really really cool. We love seeing uh
love seeing the dollar amounts. You
know, we love seeing uh cash money. Uh
really really cool promos as well. Uh
but trophy not mentioned on there is of
course a major factor too and the glory
that comes along with it. But they are
all deceived for another prize was made
uh for one of each of these legends.
Really, really cool stuff.
>> There's not only the trophy, the
playmat, the title of champion on the
line at this event, but also for all 28
legends, a best of metallic card for the
player who places the highest on each
one. And if you haven't had a chance to
see these in person, they are in this
case right next to the merch wall. And
they are gorgeous. Individual metallic
detailing on every single one.
Completely unique backgrounds for each
of these legends. And they are very
limited in quantity as they will rotate
out over time. So if this is your
opportunity to play your favorite
legend, this is your chance to actually
win a medal.
That case is so cool. I was I was ugly
when we first walked in. Uh on Friday, I
was like, "Oh, wow. Man, that's really
really cool stuff." It's cool to see.
We've got multiple goals here. We have,
of course, the the champion of the
event. You know, winning the events is,
you know, probably where you want to be.
But we have players who uh they just
they love or and they want to get that
or best of or whatever else it might be.
So, super cool to see prize structure.
But now, let's pop in and see uh what
events are coming up, how kind of how we
got here and where we are going.
>> Look, we're in Spirit Forge now. We had
Houston already in Origins. Bolognia has
passed. Allen ZQ the champion of that
one. Now we're in Las Vegas. All ZQ
trying to be the champion of that one as
well. I guess he's at 80 on the top
tables. But going from there, we'll have
two more events in Spirit Forge with Lil
and Atlanta coming up in April. A little
bit of a break in March. No big events
there, but that's when Unleashed gets to
come out and sends us off to Sydney and
Vancouver after that launch date on May
8th, as well as Utrich and Hartford
before we finally get even more sets
coming down the pipeline.
>> Yeah, I'm excited for Hartford. That's
my close to hometown across the Long
Island Sound. And then we have in July
the release of Vendetta. We got uh the
enemy domains finally coming together
for the first time. Very, very exciting
in late July
>> and the debut of China and the rest of
the world being all on the same set.
Yes, that's huge. Now, I'm very excited
for that. You know, get we get these the
kind of the preview with the Chinese
events. Now, we're going to be in the
same page, which is awesome. Then, we're
going to Barcelona and Singapore, two
pretty awesome locations until the
release of Radiance in late October. And
it all wraps up for the hometown event
uh for Riot, Los Angeles in late
September. That's going to be a heater.
>> Oh, yeah. Very excited for that in LA.
It's always a fun place to go down and
play and especially with the the Riot
home turf. I'm sure that's going to be
an absolute blowout.
>> All the stops I can only imagine. Don't
quote me on it, but I'm sure awesome.
>> I'll quote him. Yeah.
>> So, that's the future. We're in the
present right now and we're going to
look at our standings to see how things
are going in day two. Check out those
undefeated players. We got six of them
left.
>> And there they are. Prismaticism in
first place, 8-0. Allen in second place,
8-0. No strangers to the top of the
standings. Yeah, I mean these are
players that have topped in Houston,
topped in Bolognia, of course with that
one winning and now in Vegas. They are
at 8 and0. They are building these huge
legacies at the beginning of Riftbound,
showing that they are some of the most
dominant players out there. And I would
give a big shout out to Raccoon at 8
and0. That is our Rexai player, the only
Rexi in a sea of Dravens. And then Allen
on Ezreal, of course.
>> Yeah. Um I'm stoked for Rexai. We got
Awesome Ross, uh, former Magic Pro, also
in there playing Draven as well. So,
with this round, we have the the six
undefeated players. We're going to call
that down to three most likely, barring
some weird draws. I suppose there are
two other air quote undefeated players
in seventh and eighth place at 70 and1.
Those players are probably going to be
battling each other if they didn't play
already. Looking on the uh page two, we
have our 7-1 players. So, plenty of
players here all in the hunt. Uh, at 71
is a great spot to make a run for Top
Eye. They got to win a lot of rounds.
You know, of course, there are five
rounds today. and you don't really want
to lose one at 7 and one. Uh once you're
at seven and or uh at X and two, that's
where you might be in a tiebreaker kind
of snafu.
>> Yeah. And I want to give a a quick call
out to No Veggies on that screen. That's
another one of our top eight competitors
from Houston, you know, uh being back in
US soil here in Vegas, giving it another
run, another attempt at that top eight.
So cool seeing these familiar faces so
early in the game, too, you know,
showing the skill ceiling of the game uh
and players just dominating. It's it's
so cool to see. I love watching
excellence. That's what we have for you
today. So, we got a great match coming
up for you. We got our deck list for our
players and uh Rexi, any uh any feelings
on that? Look, I'm very happy that we've
got a Rexai undefeated and is a little
bit more towards that spellleaning deck.
Of course, the three immortal Phoenixes
going alongside this. You've got your
falling stars, your piercing lights,
call the weeks, and it is on the seal of
rage instead of, you know, the order
seal that you'd see for maybe a swarm
build. Uh but two copies of Sundisk. So
really looking to make sure that these
immortal Phoenix's get to come into the
field ready. Couple of the main deck
Brin heres as well. It looks fairly
standard when it comes to the more
spellheavy Rex size. Uh but I think
slightly more units than we've seen
previously cuz sometimes we've seen
things like vengeance or we've seen uh
drag under in the main board and instead
this is kind of leaning on, you know,
the faithful manufacturers, the Dravens,
some a little bit more unit focused than
we've seen on previous uh spell builds.
>> Yeah. Yeah, and we got Raccoon here, of
course, uh 8 and0, Rexi, you know, maybe
feels a little more like a a dark horse,
maybe a a metal card contender, but at 8
and0 to make a great run here into
possibly top eight. Yeah, I I think it
can make it towards there because I
think the Draven matchup is the thing
that you actually get to find some
value. You're you're a very tempo
oriented deck, especially with these
like additional early drops that are
being included. And so, the big thing to
look at is going to be Falling Star,
Call of the Week, how these can
immediately impact the board. And
actually the three of copies of piercing
light is specifically targeted towards
Draven that is mostly focused on two and
four might as the break points that
you're seeing in that deck. And piercing
light lines up with that either baseline
or with repeat at hitting two and four
might respectively at the very best. All
right, so we're going to see I believe
that matchup against Draven and
Raccoon's opponent will be Shisel. Uh
playing some Draven. Looks to be uh yeah
little mid-range Draven. Nothing too
nothing too crazy. Just a kind of a
baseline mid-range list. Yeah, very much
so. And you know, I'm talking about the
two and four might break points. Three
overzealous van, three tide turner,
three treasure hunter, that's one, but
you know, same kind of deal. Nine two
drops in this. So, it's really looking
to go two into four and keep pushing
from there. Two to four to six even with
the three main deck, Ferris 4runner. Uh,
so those removal spells are going to
line up quite well well, right? Falling
star being able to deal with the uh the
two mechs that get popped out from
Farah's Ferrerunner. You've got this uh
piercing light that's going to be able
to deal with things like Nox's hopeful,
Kai'Sa, Draven, right? So that's what
we're looking at in this matchup is how
can the Draven player play around the
removal from the Rex eye best and set up
a good board to not get steamrololled
early on and be able to start winning
combats and drawing cards.
>> Yeah, the three three fourers in the
main deck is not often seen with Draven.
Usually see kind of mix in the main deck
of a sideboard because they're kind of
weak against the purple spells we see
often in Rebuke and Fighter Flight. But
the full three main deck copies here are
going to be kind of annoying. Yeah, they
are because you know the Rex eye is
going to have to have two pieces of
removal to actually deal with it, right?
You need the something to deal with the
main body. Call the weak falling star,
but then you need falling star kind of
specifically to deal with the secondary
bodies that come out as two threes. All
right, so on the left we've got Raccoon,
our undefeated Rexai player at 8 and0
starting out on Z Warren and Shisel, our
Draven player on the right, starting out
on Reaver's Row, one of four Draven
players. That's six undefeated players.
Players are getting ready to go. Let's
jump into game one.
All right, game one going to be Zan
Warren's Reaver's Row. Zon Warren's very
important for the Rexilist to try and
start getting the Phoenix's into the bin
so that you can recur them by killing
things with spells. Phoenix, when you
are able to kill a unit with a spell,
uh, Phoenix can be recurred from your
trash with one energy and one power. And
that's something that this deck is
really looking to find. And we're going
to see that first Phoenix picked up
alongside a two drop. So this honest
broker headed to Z on Warren on the next
turn is going to be able to give Raccoon
that very first piece of ammunition in
the bin.
>> All right, so Raku's on the board.
Honest broker going Chisel's way. This
is of course the first match of the day.
This is a big one. You know, now you've
you played all day yesterday. Exhausting
day. Now you're in. You're on camera.
Round one of day two. You're undefeated.
You're uh you know a little bit of
nerves here I'm sure getting kind of
haven't gotten warmed up yet
necessarily. And uh the broker's going
to come in. We see a hard cast Edge of
Knight for Shisel.
Yeah, hard cast edge knight missing the
two drop for the turn. As we see,
Raccoon has ordered the triggers here.
Going to go for Zwarren's first into
void burrower. Going to find a void
rush. That is often something I really
like to see when you're playing the
undertitan version. But notably, there
were no Undert.
So instead just going to take the free
two drop off the top from that porro and
go for honest broker because he does not
want to dramp. He knows that his deck is
going to have a lot of high power costs
later on in the removal suite of that
falling star, of that piercing light.
and you can't really afford to get rid
of your runes yet, especially because
you're going to want to save some of
those to start bringing this Phoenix
back over and over again.
>> It's a big statement. Two units deployed
in the back row, the broker and the
daring porum going back way now at a 0
to3 unit disadvantage and now needs to
get on the board and figure out what the
next step is.
>> Yeah, this is where the pain train can
come through because the only legal play
as far as development here is to just
play Draven and uh if there's something
like a call the week that would
immediately be bad. So instead, Shisel
recognizing, hey, this spot is
completely horrible. If I play my unit
and I get blown out, then you're just
going to score a three and probably hold
the five. Instead, Piercing Light deal
with the whole board from Rex Eye, play
nothing and say, "Let's slow this game
down until I can find some better cards,
some safer developments, start getting
this forunner out instead."
>> All right, so at a pretty big cost there
of two runes, but the board is now clear
back on Raccoon to kind of fill things
back up and get on uh Raccoon's the
aggressor here, I would think. Right.
Yeah, I mean it is, you know, very much
the style of Rex eye that he's built for
the spell as kind of like uh playing the
spell Rex eye, but not a control
version, purely a tempo version, right?
Like using the spells willing to dump
runes and just score points as fast as
possible. Never let Draven gain control
of the board. If Draven gets the board
state, you have kind of lost the game in
the sense where you just don't have
enough removal to keep up without just
burning through all of your runes. So,
wanting to stay ahead of the curve
entirely and is going to find a seal,
but has to decide whether to draw it or
play it. If you play it now, you're
going to Damp more. However, because
this is void rush, you get to just draw
both cards. So, next turn when you
actually have another power cost to
play. That's when you go for the seal of
rage. So, love to see this from Raccoon.
>> All right, so Rexai comes in and
accelerated, hits the Warren, and we see
the uh the loot on the Warren as well.
And both cards go to hand and just say
they go. So, well set up on the board.
Now, it's Shizzle's turn to make some
moves and see if uh Shizzle can get the
first unit in play.
>> Yeah, you know what's it's crazy? We
kind of have the the question that was
asked last turn has just been delayed
because he had to DM two runes. He
doesn't get to six to play Ferrrunner.
So once again, it's like, okay, play
Draven and then if there's just a
falling star here, we're back to square
one. We're back to having nothing on
board. Raccoon continuing to score. At
least with this board not having a full
suite of units, Raccoon might be gated
to just scoring the hold and having to
run back and not actually being able to
conquer onto the Reaver's Row. And I
think that's just kind of where Shisle
is is you're forced to just make this
play. Hope that there isn't a massive
punish. And really we're going to see
there's a lot of cards that are in
Raccoon's hand, but is there a perfect
punish? Call the Weak doesn't quite get
there because it's just breacher on the
board now.
>> Yeah, there's a Phoenix in the yard as
well. So now killing a unit isn't just
killing unit, it's deploying unit as
well.
>> All right, float one for that seal of
rage that we saw earlier going to be
deployed.
>> Seals in a whole bunch of cards in hand.
floating
>> and floating. How about some more cards?
>> Yeah, I'm down to look a little bit
deeper. Sundisk found. That's going to
allow for the ability to score to four.
Really big pickup to get the sundisk.
You get to cast it for free. You still
have to pay the power cost as void rush
did reduce it and going to be able to
draw the additional seal that was found
for the next turn to keep these power
costs going. So, when you find the seals
with this spell deck, it is very
explosive and Raccoon has been able to
get there. And now being able to play
the soaring scout ready due to the
sundisk going to be able to score on
reaver's row and potentially just allow
this soaring scout to die going forward.
>> Oh my gosh, what a hit off of void
burrower finding the call of the weak.
So now not only do you get to avoid
combat with the soaring scout and give
Draven a draw, you clear the board and
reramp with that scout and even more two
drops to hit the board for raccoon to
set up to go to six on the next turn.
>> Wow, awesome. Awesome hit. Now, there
was a Phoenix that could have been
deployed, right? Over the Daring Po.
>> Uh, no runes. Well, oh, yes. Over the
Daring Porro. Yes. But Phoenix costs one
energy, one power, not wanting to expend
that power yet, especially going into
the next turn. You're going to be able
to get another seal of rage on the board
and continue to set yourself up to have
these big turns. With Rexi, you have
access to a lot of cards, and your issue
ends up being runegated more than
cardgated in the future. And so being
able to not dramp too much is a very
important skill. Knowing when you're not
actually supposed to take that Phoenix
from the yard and save it for those
better turns.
>> All right, so looking great here for
Raccoon. Four points to zero. Has the
board. We see a 4Runner come down.
Forrunner is a very very potent card.
kind of hard for Raccoon to deal with at
par, but it is just hanging out in back
row and uh with Raccoon already on four
points and the the way kind of clear
things are looking very very nice.
>> Now I know there was I I'm pretty sure
there's a call week in the hand for
Raccoon and the big question is can he
find a falling star? I think getting a
conquer with the daring porro and then
pushing in uh pushing with the the call
the week clearing this and then
conquering on his own warren and looking
for even more with the uh falling star
to clear up the rest of the board would
be massive in this spot and the question
just kind of remains does he actually
have it bring here thundersong off the
top and Draven very expensive cards but
Draven can still be a lot of might on
the back row no big reason to Brin on
this turn as there's no runes available
for Shisel.
>> Yes. So, currently in the driver's seat
is Raccoon. Needs to be careful. Want to
stay in that driver's seat. Draven, of
course, a very powerful deck. And the
foreigner is huge. You know, that is a
major major problem. That could also be
multiple bodies. So, got to think we're
going to see the Draven being cast at
that cost reduction for two thanks to
void rush.
>> There's an activated Sundisk, so it does
come in ready.
>> Uh, didn't exhausted four runes for it.
It did cost two, right? No, it's fourth
because this is full cost from void
burrier. This was not a void rush.
>> Oh, I'm sorry. Not not a void rush. Void
this. Void that voiding everywhere.
So,
>> all right. Finishes the warns trigger.
Trashing a daring porro. I believe this
is just a call that's going to come
down. And he may just have already had
the falling star. If he goes for the
call here, Falling Star would be able to
clear out the mechs, make an empty board
once more. And that sure looks like a
falling star to meow as that is another
clean clear for the Rex Eye.
>> Wow. Wow. Raccoon 8 and0 with Rexi.
Feeling good, playing good, and running
good. A great place to be here to start
out day number two. Regional qualifier.
Las Vegas. Back. Shizzles away. Shizzles
have not been able to keep anything in
play.
>> Yeah,
>> usually with a 4Runner, you that's like
that's it. You know, it's pretty hard to
remove the entire 4unner all at once. Uh
not for Raccoon. Yeah, the exact cards
that you need are the call the week into
falling star. And that's why I was
saying I was curious about the initial
look with the void borrower, but in my
mind that meant, oh, he's already got
both pieces. I thought he was going to
be looking for the falling star
afterwards, but no, it was already
there. A lot of cards drawn all rolled
up back away. Massive deficit. Six to
zero. Need to make some moves. Both Rexi
and Draven are in play. Draven at
Reverse Row. Sundisk also being in play
makes any card in Raccoon's hand very
threatening.
>> Yeah, any removal spell can potentially
lead to a Phoenix coming in ready as
long as you can play another card first
before the disc cuz there's not a window
where you can actually uh exhaust the
disc after playing the removal spell if
it's the first card in order to ready
that Phoenix. Uh so you do need some
other thing that you get to cast at the
start of the turn.
>> Tougher Sizzle here seeing some kind of
like finicky cards in hand. kind of saw
hard bargain. These kind of more
reactive, you know, cards that are good
in certain scenarios but not necessarily
go in your behind. So, we're going to
see Darius
coming and exhausted as the first card
played
the possible card number two. Now, it is
Reaver's Row where Draven's currently
hanging out. So, can just back up if
necessary. Don't think Raccoon mind
seeding the point at all.
And the followup is just an overzealous
fan. So that raises Darius plus two
might. So seven might ready to go.
Question is where to go if anywhere.
>> Well, with Darius
going in and then Shisel being fully
exhausted unless there's a hidden card
to maybe help here. Raccoon just kind of
has a a math problem on this next turn
to try and end the game going from six
to eight. So we do have the Warren's
activation. It didn't look like there
was anything hidden. I mean, he can
equip the edge of knight, at least make
this math problem a little bit more
difficult with it being seven. Uh, that
is a break point that does beat at least
some of the removal spells that Raccoon
has. Can't just falling star and deal
with it. Can't do anything with a
piercing light. Will require a little
bit more, but scoring to seven. If
there's a third call the week, that's
also just going to get rid of this
Draven and end the game. Let's see what
is found for Raccoon.
>> Tough year, of course. Uh she's going
down to four runes. I'm already behind
trying to make out a comeback. So
Raccoon's way and we see Draven is at
the reverse row. Hold seven.
And what's the next step? Lots of cards.
>> My hand is triple hopeful piercing
light. So currently that is not that is
not cutting it.
>> Okay.
>> Uh for this win now you could go for the
piercing light with repeat just to deal
four.
>> Right. So that's going to set this
Darius to three life.
>> Then you can trade the Rex eye in or
attempt to trade the Rex eye in and
still sundisk something else out, right?
Uh also I mean Darius is seven might so
reasonably you can actually just sundisk
in the hopeful now and send eight might
into seven. Darius can't actually kill
that off and if something gets pushed
back he still killed Darius.
>> Yeah, fear being a fight or flight as a
hidden card. So, just like you said,
knock Soful and Rexi coming in. And
Darius is uh we're going to see the
hidden guard is a tide turner, which
doesn't really do a ton here.
>> Yep. Still just going to be a full
trade. At least you you you kill off
everything as the Draven side. You live
another day, but for how much longer
really? Uh can you stop the Draven from
holding? We see the hand. Thank you,
Shisel, for fanning it out for us. Uh
the current answer is no. It cannot be
stopped.
>> Yep. So, Rakun deciding now. don't want
to try and hold with Darius or just pull
back and try and go for the double
conquer next turn
with Reaver's Row trying to hold is
almost free. Very reasonable. Yeah, you
would be giving a card to Draven
theoretically, which is the thought
process here. But I also think that the
uh the equity of just, you know, your
opponent has a a blank board, you're
probably going to get a chance to hold
unless Shisel has to spend a lot of
runes to force you off. Super super
clean game from Raccoon here, taking
game one. I mean, Raccoon's 8 and0 for a
reason. Uh, playing the game very very
cleanly, drawing well, and showing us uh
the power of Rexi. You know, maybe not a
deck we expected to see 8 and0, which is
super cool to see as we're going to go
into game number two here. Shisel will
be on Targon's Peak presumably on going
for first and Raccoon on Veiled Temple.
>> Yeah. Can I talk about this battle a
little bit? I'm actually very excited
about Raccoon playing Veiled Temple in
this deck. This was tech I had been
considering and I hadn't tried it yet
for the spell version. And I'm so glad
that Raccoon did and is like just
showing me that yes, you should have
tried this because it's very good is one
of the issues with this deck is runes,
right? Cards are not your problem. Runes
are Veil Temple allows you to rer your
seals and get an extra red rune. And
also sometimes you want to be able to
ready your units a lot more frequently.
You're trying to, you know, ready one
unit when you play it early. You get a
conquer, then you want to ready another
unit. Uh guess what? This is going to be
able to ready your Sundisk to be able to
have that go again and be able to have
another unit enter ready. So, Veiled
Temple a really good battlefield for
Raccoon being able to reset these gear
and let him get even more value out of
them. So cool to see in a deck that
isn't really gear focused. This is not
Jax. This is not Azir. Uh but finding
that cool synergy. Awesome stuff. So we
see a treasure hunter from Shisel uh
getting on the board this game
thankfully and just a Rex eye on Raccoon
side from a champ zone passing it right
back. So Shisle going to make a little
more of a gambit here going first has a
pretty good hand to some units. You see
it's a hard bargain again. Hard bargain
is kind of hanging out. Definitely a
little finicky in the matchup.
>> Yeah, it's like a necessary evil. It can
be very good in some spots but Raccoon I
think in the previous game was playing
around it quite well. Only one time did
he actually completely tap out for the
spell and it was when Shisel only had
one rune. Often he was casting the
spells early on the turn. Making sure he
had a lot of runes to kind of work with
and um making sure that hard bargain was
always within his range is something
that he did not want to get blown out
by.
>> Also on the Targon's peak game, hard
bargain gets a lot better too.
>> I absolutely agree with you. Yeah. So
that's going to allow the Draven to come
down and still two runes up for hard
bargain. Right the wind, you know,
whatever whatever other tricks. I mean,
fight orflight, rebuke, uh, spinning
axe, like Draven with two runes up is a
menace.
>> There are quite a few options. So, we're
going to see a seal start and another
seal. That's such a good start, uh,
especially because you're going to start
to get some of these cards back off of
the Veil Temple. The the only way this
gets even better is something like a
void rush to completely start refilling
the hand. Um, creating a lot more value.
Also, getting to reready the seal means
that something like a Falling Star is
going to be able to cast be cast without
any power on this turn. Uh, and you can
order the trigger so that the uh, the
Veil Temple trigger happens first. Ready
that seal of rage and if you see a
falling star off the top, boom, you get
to cast it without having to pay that
power cost.
>> Great stuff. So, Rexi's in. We see that
trigger from Veil Temple readying the
Seal of Rage. Here's a Rex eye.
>> And we see just a couple of units. So,
not the not the greatest hit, but fine.
>> Yeah, this is your baseline. Your
baseline is I get to draw a small unit
that I'm going to develop every turn. So
I don't have to worry about having too
many two drops in my deck because often
I'm just kind of drawing them and
developing them as part of my legend
ability. Now Rexi could accelerate
>> this unit if correct if wanted. So it
could potentially come in and threaten
the Targon's Peak, but we're just going
to see
>> uh just the back row, the Daring Porro
and an immortal Phoenix. So just
developing and getting all set up here
for the next turn. Now Rexi is kind of
hanging out a little vulnerable.
>> Yep. I want to know. So there's there's
twofold why the accelerate probably
didn't happen here. One of the big ones
is of course that he wanted to play this
immortal Phoenix. So the cost curve just
didn't work. The other thing is Daring
Porro is an order unit and his seals are
seals of rage. So in order to accelerate
the Daring Porro, it would be one energy
and one order power. So he would not
have been able to pay for it with the
seal and would have dramped. So I think
that is one of the prevailing reasons he
wouldn't want to do it. Now of course
the curve just maybe worked as well with
the Phoenix and he didn't have another
play that would have worked for readying
it and going in. But that is a big thing
to look out for when you are playing
around the Rexai breacher is what color
identity is the card you're playing
because it actually matters even on
non-power costed cards. All right, so we
see Dravy come in. Dy gets to eat the
Rex eye which is a pretty big win for
Shisle. Card drawing off the glorious
executioner and now we see a 4Runner
developed uh on a Targon speak and now
we see Shisel really getting on the
board with some serious might. Uh kind
of the wheels are spinning here. We got
Draven in play. Uh the the Ferris
4runner and get to move the back row
with the hunter. Make another gold and
looking reasonably well set up here.
>> Yeah, the only scary thing in this spot
is Shisel did completely tap out for
this.
>> Um and Targon was held on the previous
turn, which I think Raccoon is doing
intentionally here, not wanting Shisel
to have multiple turns of kind of
getting to reconquer that Tarun's peak.
And so this kind of comes down to
Shisel's going to get to eat Draven here
by sending in eight mightite. That's
just guaranteed. He's going to get to
eat this. And the question becomes, does
he actually have the proper removal
tools to then follow up deal with
Pharaoh's 4runner and this treasure
hunter like he did in the previous game.
It's an assault on both the Phoenix and
the Porum. Taking down Draven and we're
going to see power float Mile. So the
Tempo will ready it. Here comes the void
burrower seal number three and a daring
porro number two. Again, you know, kind
of mid-le hits.
>> Yeah, a bit awkward because he has two
seals already. The third seal becomes a
little redundant. Uh this deck can
utilize all three seals, but at this
point, I feel like that's not what
Raccoon needs to find, right? This game
is not uh going to be an energy issue.
It's going to be just actually getting
on board and and interacting here. And
it feels like uh you know, maybe too
many uh units in two drops hit as this
is a pretty big red redeploy. I mean,
there's eight might that has hit the
board after this conqueror. The Draven
gets cleared, but Shisel gets to untap
with two gold. The Pharaoh's 4Runner
ready to keep holding and a lot more
development that Shisle's going to get
to re uh attempt. And I think we even
had maybe like a mindsitter. That's
going to be a nice turn to just kind of
keep the pressure on.
>> Yeah, Shizzle currently up four to two.
So, has that point lead on the even
points as well. Hand flush full of
cards. You see Kais in the window.
>> Splitter must have been last game. It
looks like it was not in this hand.
Okay, we got the uh hard bar from
earlier. Is that two ride the winds
perhaps? So, a lot of uh potential
options. Again, already being on
Targon's Peak is a little awkward. Uh
the timing of when to conquer Targon's
Peak is definitely a skill when you're
playing that battlefield.
>> So, we're going to see
>> Kaiso with accelerate.
>> Accelerate Kaiso. Kais is coming into
the Phoenix. Phoenix is going to hit the
bin, which is, you know, not the worst
place for a Phoenix, but we will see two
cards drawn for Shisel, as well as going
up to five points.
And once again on the board, pretty well
stocked up. Fortunately, three runes
ready. Three might as well be two most
of the time, right? Yeah. And I think
Shisel drawing an additional Ferris
4Runner here is a great draw. Uh Shisel
has a lot of time and that's where
forest uh forest for really shines is
when you have time to develop it
especially to a battlefield and hold
it's going to be very strong. Was that a
falling star?
>> That was a falling star. Probably the
perfect thing
>> uh with these two runes left kind of mop
up this back row of raccoon leaving only
a noxious hopeful if that's what Chisel
wants to do. And that is exactly it. So
we're going to see falling star coming
in taking out the broker and the daring
porro. It could take out the the hopeful
I guess. Uh, but I'd imagine taking out
two units here.
>> Yeah, I would say often I don't like
tapping out in the spot when you
actually have a lot of interaction in
hand, but I believe Raccoon is down to
like his last card in hand because he
played the two seals early. It's been a
lot of twos off the top and then he
played a lot of twos from hand. Uh, so
because of that, the Rexai is going to
be on very low cards and the conquers
are not free, right? It's it's five
might into just the four on the
backline. So Raccoon is actually going
to have card access issues, which is
usually not the problem for the deck,
and it's going to be a lot of trouble
punishing Chisel for not having any
runes available. You see the uh the
Hunter go in there onto the Veil Temple
as well. So looking for a hold and to
defend. And you're right, the Rexi, you
know, the whole core tenant of legend is
I need to conquer to use this. Uh so
when you are behind, things can be a
little difficult. So we see a soaring
scout.
>> We see an honest broker.
>> Um a little about And a little chuckle
from Raccoon here. Definitely a bit
behind and trying to work it through.
>> Confirming that Chisel is totally tapped
out.
>> Something like a blood rush. Yeah. Okay,
that makes sense. I was I was trying to
think what card was in the deck that was
going to make this work. And and I
forgot there were blood rushes in there.
>> So that's great. So that that punishes
Chisel for adding the Hunter to the
stack as well. And uh now Vid Burough
gets to go off. He gets the other knock
soal. Probably the perfect hit there for
my for two energy. I I would say maybe
call is the only better thing that would
have I would have wanted to see off the
top. Actually, falling star would be
fine, too, because uh you just like
dealing with the first part of the the
body. Um because Shisle was at five, so
it could only go to seven anyway, and
you can maybe start to try and recontrol
the the board. However, Shizzles has a
full grip of cards and a ton of runes
available. So likely even just removing
this first Ferris for runner body is not
going to put you, you know, squarely in
the driver's seat by any means. So back
shizzles way as we see us the hand stags
have three ride the wins. Wow. We ride
the wins. Ferris 4unner that hard
bargain still hanging out and uh on six
points. So cannot win this turn. Could
possibly go to seven
and deciding how to proceed up six to
three.
>> He's trying to have some sort of big
hold a possible path here from six to
seven to eight.
>> Looks like it is. So we see 4unner join
the other forrunner at the targon beak
>> and ride the wind.
>> Ride the wind one of them over.
>> I I was you know thinking the same as
you as the hold. I was thinking you hold
from six to seven and then on your next
turn you know like untapping with these
ride the winds and rebukes and
everything. Then you just go conquer the
other side. Um but just instead going to
do it now. Look at two potential hold
options. Only one rune available though.
So no defense. It's just going to be can
two feros runners hold. Uh, and
honestly, they don't even need to hold.
Um, they can both die and just generate
a bunch of mechs that can then look for
the conquer. So, I think this is a very
valid idea. You might win on a hold
incidentally here. If you don't, you're
probably winning with double conquering
with the mechs.
>> All right, so first step for raccoon is
going to send in three units over to the
4Runner. Total of seven might, seven
more than six. That being said, leaving
behind the uh the soaring scout, not
exactly the most intimidating unit, but
there's a conquer. That's important as
well as getting the void borrower going.
But now this other 4Runner is a pretty
big issue with uh shisel at seven. It
must be dealt with or the game will end.
Uh that looks like a scoop angle. Yeah,
I was going to say those off the top are
not getting the job done. Not bad cards
by any means, but uh kind of bad when
your opponent's at seven and you don't
really have a board uh whatsoever. So,
this is where we get to see the little
bit of inconsistency with the spell Rex
eye. It's uh generally been the trouble
that plagues this deck is when it sees
the seals and the spells early and you
can take the tempo. We see what happened
in game one. That was very dominant,
right? And then in game two, we saw the
seals this time, but it was only paired
with a bunch of two drops and a bunch of
kind of kind of junk, but necessary junk
for the deck construction. Unfortunately
though, this deck can have that like
wrong half of the deck syndrome stuff
that can happen where you end up just
drawing too many small units, not enough
spells, and you're not able to really
get the job done. Plus, the power of
Ferris 4Runner in a matchup like this on
full display. Yeah, for absolutely
fantastic there. So, we're going to go
to game three as these players look to
advance to be undefeated here in round
number nine. We will have Raku going
first on Arena's greatest versus Obelisk
Power and big game. We saw Shisle able
to get on the board very very cleanly in
game two. Raccoon will try and do the
same. Little fist bump. Love
sportsmanship.
>> Players recognizing the you know the
kind of gravity of a match like this.
You know this is a big match. You know
>> so three runes to start thanks to the
obelisk of power and that allows for a
turn one Rexi.
>> Yeah I was actually really curious on
this mulligan if Raccoon was going to
ditch. He had uh two two drops in his
hand. I was wondering if he would ditch
both because he's on three runes so he
can just start with Rex eye, but he
ended up keeping one Porro. Um, so at
least still valuing having some amount
of them in the early hand. I just
thought maybe because there's enough in
the deck, but there's a chance that
maybe he sided some out recognizing that
uh it's likely to be an Obless game as
well. There's a lot of ways that this
could have gone. So Shisel valuing two
units over one, decided to deploy the
Treasure Hunter and the Nox Opal instead
of Draven. So getting on the board going
right back raccoon's way and immediately
we see seal of rage floated energy
and now what is the next step?
Post is clear for Rexside to conquer and
trigger void borrower kind of get that
ball rolling.
>> Yeah, Legion's already active as well.
If you see a hopeful off the top, a lot
of good stuff.
>> So Rexi Obelisk, that's point number
two. We of course started with one point
each thanks to Arena's greatest. We see
Falling Star and Immortal Phoenix. I
mean, Falling Star is a pretty nice one.
Uh, just clean up that hopeful. And this
is one of the reasons two units better
than one for the Draven side if you can.
Uh, because Falling Star is a card that
you have to be worrying about. And if
you had just played your Draven, this
Falling Star would have, you know, done
a lot of damage uh to you, but instead
it is going to clean up the hopeful. You
still get to keep the treasure hunter
and make sure that you can get to two on
the next turn uh in the Draven seat and
still look to develop. But Raccoon going
to look to continue his own development
with his own Noxville Knox hopeful as
well.
>> Fox hopeful so good. All right, four
might in the back row for Raccoon. Great
start going back way and uh a lot of
runes here because Obelis games are
pretty crazy. Six runes here on turn
number two. We see a fighter flight in
hand, a stack deck. Going to start
there.
>> Yeah, needs a little bit more power in
this hand. And the Ferris 4Runner I
think is kind of exactly what I would be
looking for. I feel like those spells
are great, but when I'm seeing two drop,
two drop, uh, I feel like I kind of want
the big thing that is really good
against spell decks.
>> Yep.
>> And that and in game one, the foreigners
came too late. Yeah.
>> Uh, at that point, Raccoon was already
at, you know, five or six points, able
to kind of push through this early
still. Now, it can't be deployed this
turn. Only five runes available, so a
little unfortunate, but still early
enough to make a big impact in the game.
But she's going to think it through.
And for still in the window.
>> Yeah, I'd like to see 4Runner deploy
Draven and pass the turn or 4Runner
deploy two twos, but cuz you just saw a
falling star, but you might still be
scared of another falling star or
piercing light for two twos. They feel
it feels a little bit soft. So maybe
holding the tide turner as a trick
instead or a hidden card and just
grabbing uh Ferris for play Draven and
then go from there. I think that's kind
of what I'm looking at here is how am I
beating the spell deck? And I think
Ferris 4runner is the best card in this
uh grip at beating a deck that is built
around removing your board. You want a
sticky unit. You want one that's
sticking around.
>> Could also conquer high the tie turner
uh on five runes now going to seven next
turn. Uh with the treasure as well from
the hunter and you don't really need to
be on odd runes in this deck. Almost
everything is even costed. So
>> going to take the 4Runner.
>> We'll see what the setup is for next
turn. So definitely a bit of a future
planning here.
>> Five runes left. What's the next step
for Shisel? Here comes the treasure
hunter. So, make that gold. Get a point
up to two. Currently tied 2-2. And now
there are options. There are hidden
options. There are chosen champion
options and a number of other options as
well. It's going to be an Overz fan on
the arena's greatest.
>> Okay.
>> And going to hide the tide turner. So,
not even just going to two. Well,
actually, it could be uh hidden fight or
flight. the the other card was fighter
flight to be fair. So we'll see if we
get a glimpse of the hand whether that
is Tide Turner
>> or Fighter Flight, but looking to hold
with some small units. This is
>> incredibly soft to Piercing Light or
Falling Star.
>> It is risky,
>> but we'll see if any of those are found.
Second seal for Raccoon.
>> Now the saving grace is Raccoon can't
get a conquer before casting one of
those spells because of this hold and
the fact that there is a hold on Oblisk
from the Rex Eye Breacher. So, if these
spells are not already in hand for
Raccoon, which from a quick glimpse
here, it doesn't look like they are, uh,
that does mean that Shisel has kind of
faded the the really rough situation
that could have existed by any of those
six copies of the spells. Wait, I may
have spoken to Piercing Light.
>> It's not piercing light. Okay.
>> Well, I thought
>> I think one of the two is probably I'm
sure one of us is right and we have a
very bad punish that Shisel has
potentially walked into.
>> We're going to look bad if it's not.
>> We sure are. Yeah. All right. So,
Raccoon thinking about it and uh a lot
of setup here with this Rex side act too
where you're you're trying to make a lot
of plays with incomplete information.
You don't know what you're going to hit
off of your void burrow or trigger off
of your void rushes. So,
>> but what's it going to be? It's going to
be piercing light. You got it. Piercing
light with repeat to play around the
potential of edge of knight or spinning
axe. I imagine as the the options though
spinning axe would save the fan
regardless. uh it just wouldn't be able
to save treasure hunter, so it doesn't
really get around spinning axe. Uh
depending on the targeting, this can
save something, but not necessarily. Uh
so it looks like maybe uh Raccoon said
two on treasure hunter at the
battlefield, then two on the overzealous
fan cuz if he went one battlefield uh
treasure hunter, one battlefield
overzealous fan, and then one, you know,
the other way, they both still would
have just died to that piercing light,
>> right? All right. So, the fighter flight
be able to to play around one of the
restrictions but not both.
>> Yeah.
>> So, Hunter returns, makes a gold knock
comes in
>> and we're going to pass. So, Hunter
>> making more gold here going over to the
obelisk putting the score to Raccoon at
four. Chill going to three.
And now, it's fair for time.
Looks like it.
So, for coming down again, one rune up
kind of on these odd runes. be so
awkward. Uh going to reinforce at the
obelisk of power. So down a point going
for the hold.
>> Yeah. And I think the uh slight I I will
say slight mistargeting I think of uh
raccoon on that last turn to not play
around the fight or flight as a
potential option may be a much larger
punish than we think if a call the week
is drawn because now this treasure
hunter is hanging around and can
actually prevent uh the call the week
from being able to get the Pharaoh's
4Runner down immediately. So, we'll see
what can be found out of this void rush.
That's a pretty good hit. Second void
rush. Not a bad hit either. It is power
costly, but you have the seals for a
reason, though. It is sometimes hard to
turn down, you know, just let me just
cast that hopeful for free at this
point.
>> Yeah, both looking nice. So, record of
course held to five. So, we have five to
three and void rush at number two. Call
the week. There you go. So, number
three,
>> that treasure hunter uh certainly
earning its keep. Kind of snuck out of
that piercing light.
And now Raccoon's got some serious
choices to make. Again, the the kind of
uh the unknown of the void the void
rush. What is it going to be? It's hard
to exactly know. Hard to stop,
>> but going for it. Pierce light and
falling star. Okay.
>> Now there are options of plenty.
>> Yeah.
>> Um I mean, yeah, that that there was a
perfect clear for the Ferris with the
call and the falling star that would
have been in this hand uh if the
treasure hunter was gone. on. And I
think Raccoon is sitting there like,
"Yeah, I should have just pointed at
them in a slightly different order, and
I'd be in such a good spot here where I
get to play through this hidden card,
not worrying about it, clear the
4Runner, clear both things, and be in
the same spot as the previous game where
you're at six with your opponent with an
empty board." I wonder if there's still
a way to get there. Uh, I don't know if
you can score to six with the empty
board is the issue because in order to
get rid of this treasure hunter, you'd
have to kind of run in with the Rex Eye
Breacher, which is a heavy cost. on a
float.
>> So, here comes Falling Star.
>> I guess you could pick off the the
foreigner first and then move in. So,
>> correct. So, that's going to happen
here. So,
>> Falling Star on the forerunner. Two
mechs to base. Still a hidden card
hanging out at uh the Obelisk of Power
alongside the the treasure hunter. And
now, Raccoon, what is the next step?
Paints a heavy power cost this turn.
Here comes Rexside.
>> Assault is on.
>> Yeah, I believe this was the tide turner
was the only the hidden card. So, that
can swap and at least trade. keep
Raccoon off of four points unless I mean
blood rush would have been
>> absurd in this spot if it had been in
hand.
>> Just going to be a hopeful. So Raccoon
does not get to go to six.
>> Has the two floating from earlier on.
Yep. Recycled the runes.
>> No more red power but two red seals for
the future turns.
>> Now leaving the hopeful at arena's
greatest. So could have retreated.
Decided to uh to leave it there. It
seems a little risky.
>> Yeah, I think retreating probably is
correct. I'm wondering if Raccoon got a
little flustered going through all these
motions and forgot, but it could have
been conscious as well, right? It does
stop Shisel from just sending one unit
each side, conquering, and then like
redeploying. There's some merit to the
idea of this four does individually beat
either of these units. But with a Draven
fully untapping, you have to expect
things like spinning ax. You have to
expect there's a lot of ways that Shisle
is going to get to just deal with this
four might hopeful for free.
>> Yeah, scary to lose the hopeful for
essentially nothing in such a tight
game. So, here is piercing light. Oh,
>> there's a target as well. That was not
what I expected as the punish. That's a
brutal one.
>> Ouch. Yes. So, because the hopeful was
at the battlefield, able to put that
light up perfectly. Uh, repeating it to
do four and four. Four to the
battlefield, four to the any other spot
being the back row. Hopeful's down.
Mech's coming in. That's a point. We are
now tied 55
and uh things are looking to go way
here. Also, that massive rune advantage.
Uh Lester was a hefty hefty power turn
for Raccoon. See a little bit of look to
the sky there. Wondering if this thing's
falling apart. Got to keep battling.
And Chisel now knows, okay, I'm in the
driver's seat. I'm looking to go 9 and0.
How do I close this game out?
Love the player games. Absolutely love
them. Being able to see the players, see
the human element. You know, there's so
much more to the game than just the
game. You know, it's managing your
emotions, managing your nerves. Uh,
mental game is a huge, huge part of all
card games.
>> Shisel opting potentially to tap out
again. He knows there's Call the Week. I
believe the Piercing Light was when in
when one of the looks for a draw, so he
knows Piercing Light is in the hand for
Raccoon.
>> Wow. All right. So, both players not
afraid to stack up on the boards here.
Uh, so we have got Mech on top of the
hidden card. Draven anti
>> the fastest light I've seen in my entire
life. Like I think this was known
information and and I hope I'm not wrong
about that, but I I believe this was
seen off of a void rush and then drawn
into the hand
>> immediately. Raccoon with the quick
targets going for the Draven. Two taps,
one onto the or two onto the mech
knowing that his porro can run over the
tie turner in the aftermath.
>> Yeah, great spot. And you're you're
right that pierce light was cast before
the turn was even passed practically,
you know. So now Chisel's turn. We see
Tide Turner. We see a swap.
>> Okay.
>> Okay. So that keeps one Battlefield uh
safe from the poor which is cool.
>> Yeah. I mean this is it's actually a
good tide turner swap. Shisel's going to
get to hold the six and then they're
both players are going to be contesting
six to eight on their next turn. And
Raccoon cannot actually redeploy
anything here with a single rune. though
not out of the woods yet for Raccoon as
Shisel still has these tide turners.
Maybe this is calculated. Maybe feeling
okay with that Piercing Light being the
entire turn for Raccoon knowing that
you've got this setup and maybe you have
a really good followup here, but
actually this is one card in hand from
Gizzel. Yeah, a very interesting low
resource game. Uh so Titan is going to
return and one Ter stays and that is it.
So not often you see a D player with
only one card in hand. We got a 66 going
up to six and seven. So, seven for uh
Raccoon.
>> Raccoon might just have this
immediately. I believe there's a Sundisk
drawn off of another one of those void
rushes. More of our known info for this
game. And if he's got any unit that he
can just pair with it, he can run that
into the tide turner. And as long as it
beats whatever is in the hand of Shisel,
that's just game. Porro is enough if
there is no reactive spell for Raccoon
to take the series.
>> She's going to wait. What's the card?
>> Oh boy, it's spinning axe.
That's a big buff is the response from
Raccoon.
>> This combat is for the game.
>> That's a hidden blade.
>> See a hidden blade. That's it. Chisel
got nothing left. Now the cards drawn
off hidden blade could also interact
too. So good.
>> You know, fight or flight, Rebuke,
something like that. So there's uh not
no risk here. Question is if you're
raccoon, do you go for the win? I think
you have to. I I don't think there's a
really good option of letting this porro
die and then trying to find a win from
there. I think Shisel with two units on
the board is likely taking you down
>> now. You could use the hidden blade
defensively to try and hold I suppose,
right?
>> Yeah.
>> So, so going to let it go. Very
interesting. So, Raccoon showing extreme
patience in the face of a possible win
and these high pressure spots. It's so
easy to want to just go for the win, you
know. So, showing big patience and now
probably looking to hold on Arena's
greatest with the with the daring Borro
guard. Not known for holding.
>> Okay.
>> All right. Here's fight in a hidden
blade decides the odds of holding better
than giving the two cards to Shisel. The
big thing is is losing the combat gives
a card anyway. So, Hidden Blade really
was only draw one instead of draw two,
right?
>> However, it was before the combat would
end that that draw two would resolve.
All right, so
going back to his way, the start is a
falling star. Holy moly. And that is
just going to do it. There is not any
single card that can be drawn for
Raccoon that is going to stop this. Tide
Turner on the back line will score.
Coming in and there it is. Shisel moves
to 9 and0 in an unbelievable game. Back
and forth. Rexai falls to 8-1. Still
fantastic record. Still in a great spot.
>> And you can see it on the face of
Raccoon. I think he's he's disappointed
and and upset with the maybe the
decisions he made in those last sequence
of turns cuz I think he recognizes that
if he pulled the trigger, he'd have it.
And it's hard to think about it in
results based, right? Because he sees,
oh, next two cards are falling. Sarah's
foreigner, he wins every time. But if
it's a rebuke, if it's a fight or
flight, does that change everything?
Does that make it a completely different
game? And I mean, the answer is yes. But
which was higher percentage? And he'll
sit there kicking himself, which one was
the correct thing to do,
>> right? so tough you know with the
pressure of the match on you too and you
you know it comes down to that binary
choice of like okay do I go for it or
not you know one maybe 55% 45% so hard
to know exactly and you just need to
push a button you know go for it or not
do go for it and didn't end up working
out so still 8-1 solut winner here and
see how they're feeling at 9 and0 with
Draven
>> hey guys I'm here with Shisel or JJ who
just won his round nine with mid-range
Draven. How are you enjoying the
tournament so far?
>> Uh, I'm having fun. Uh, I haven't
dropped a game yet and uh, initially my
goal was just to, uh, you know, make day
two, but definitely exceeded
expectations, so we'll see where it
takes us.
>> Well, congratulations on the win. How
are you enjoying mid-range Draven?
>> Um, I mean, it's pretty fun, but I feel
like playing as it and against it,
there's like so much stuff to calculate
that it just takes like a lot longer
compared to the set one meta. So, I
mean, it's good, but yeah, it's games
are definitely like a lot longer, a lot
slower now, so which isn't as good. So,
yeah, it's okay.
>> Uh, well, did you I saw you up against
Rexai. Did you have any games in Rexai
before coming to the regional or
anything like that?
>> Uh, yeah, I had a couple. Um, I actually
played a guy uh yesterday and then he uh
he like swiftly twoed me and I got
destroyed. So, I wasn't really feeling
confident about going into, you know,
this match up, especially since, uh,
we're both from, uh, SoCal, um, and we
know each other, but, um, yeah, I guess,
uh, I was able to pull out a win. Game
one. Yeah, he was playing so fast that I
couldn't even, uh, play the game, but
uh, yeah, I was able to pull out
something. Just got lucky.
>> Well, congrats on the win. Have you, uh,
done anything fun this weekend or how
are you enjoying the the regional so
far?
>> Uh, yeah, it's pretty fun. It's cool
that like there's like a lot of rip
people that I met like online and stuff
and actually get to see them here. So,
um, yeah, it's cool like connecting with
the community and all that stuff. So,
yeah.
>> Yeah, it's my favorite parts about card
games. Is there anybody you'd like to
shout out?
>> Oh, yeah, definitely. First of all, uh,
my girlfriend, she's here. Um, she's
she's still at the hotel or whatever,
but yeah, she she's here and supports me
and all that stuff. Um, my family, uh, a
lot of friends who helped me test. Um,
shout out to JJ's Collectibles, Coach
Cam, and JJ who owns JJ's Collectibles,
not me. Um, Collector's Lounge, all
those people, uh, all those guys have
like a great player base. Um, like
hardware, uh, I'm using their sleeves.
Um,
uh, big shout out to Coach Mo from I
don't know, Mo Emotional. I'm his boot
camp or whatever. And then that helped a
lot. Helped me prep a lot. Um,
challenger TCG, I'm in their diamond
tier discord. They help me out a lot.
Um, and then all my like close-knit
scrim partners. Uh, there's definitely a
lot of people to name. So, yeah.
>> Well, thank you so much and I hope you
have a great uh good luck going into
round 10.
>> Thanks.
>> All right. Fantastic stuff. Uh, that was
a great match. Um, seeing Rexi, of
course, great and 81 still great seeing
one of our players move to 9 and0.
Again, we're going to have three of
those probably at the end of this round,
barring some weird draws. But we got
another great match for you. We've got
uh kind of a well-known name playing
kind of a a non well-known deck.
>> Oh yeah, we got Grap, baby. Grappler
Legends of Rune Terra content royalty
playing a little bit of Lux with a
little spicy at X and 2. Still live uh
still fighting. So we're definitely
excited to see Grap.
>> Yeah, live for uh for a possible top
eight with tiebreers and then also for
that best of. Um we had a few Lux
players, I believe in day two, the exact
number was, but it was very very low.
So, what do we got going on here with
this Lux deck?
>> Yeah, the big combo to look at is going
to be the Jace Man of Progress, Vanguard
Armory setup. You want to make gold
early with your Plundering Porro or your
Card Sharp. Sacrifice it to Jace. When
he destroys a gear, he gets to summon a
another gear that costs segoring
the energy cost. You get the Vanguard
Armory out as early as turn two. Uh, and
then just start generating recruits and
then using Lux's ability to fire off
spells and draw additional cards to keep
the board clear while your your little
weenies, your little recruits run around
scoring points. Yeah. And kind of
similar to Victor, but you see the skew
towards the the five energy cost spells
to use the Lux Lady of Luminosity
ability. So, really cool stuff. Kind of
a kind of a fringe legend. Cool to see.
Uh, and going up against Draven. So, we
have kind of the, you know, the Fringe
versus the the Draven himself.
>> Yeah. Yeah, and I mean this is another
Ferros 4Runner main uh deck Draven.
Instead of just one splitter, three
4erunner, this is two and two. But I
think that the main deck 4Runner pretty
good for a lot of the matchups that are
giving players issue. Yes, it has some
struggles into purple with rebuke and
fighter flight, but often times if you
can just find an opportunity to jam it
onto a battlefield that you've already
conquered, it just is so tricky to
remove. And you see it even in the Rex
side game. Yes, he had perfect removal
uh you know one of the times for it and
that's incredible when it happens, but
it's not that easy for many decks to
actually have that setup.
>> Yeah, very polarizing card where it is
kind of weak and risky against purple
decks, but so good against all the other
decks. So, uh great to see. And then of
course deciding how many to play in your
main your board, a big question that our
players are trying to answer here. So,
we're going to see if Grappler can take
Lux to seven and two. Still on the hunt
for top eight, of course. are still on
the hunt for that best of card, but
>> Mu believe is uh going to try and uh
stand in the way as Draven Glorious
Executioner on Reverse Row for game one.
Aspirants Climb for Grappler on uh game
number one also.
>> Yeah. So, we're playing to nine with the
aspirin climb and that's one of the big
things with Lux. You just want more
time. Uh you actually end up having
pretty decent card velocity cuz your
cards kind of replace themselves, but
they're very expensive. So, you often
don't get to like dump your hand. and
you don't get to lose use all your
resources as you want to. And he also
has the one of garbage grabber that's
going to help him continue to keep
refilling the hand and keep digging for
more of the cheap spells when he wants
to actually start dumping some of those.
Uh and it just gives him more time to
get value from the vanguard armoring,
right? So, there's a lot of things that
you want with an extended game uh with
this Lux Legend. And we'll see how
Grappler is able to navigate the aspirin
climb as he doesn't really interact with
the reavers row so much and it's not as
relevant in this type of matchup where
it's not attack defend. It's spellcast
and try and get around that way.
>> All right, so Muse going to be going
first here. I think very important. Mu
definitely wants to wants to get in the
board to kind of get this game over
with. I think the longer the game goes,
the more Lux Legend draws cards, the
worse things get for you. So Hunter is
going to be the first play. We're going
to go grappler's way. Let's see what Lux
has in store for us.
>> This is not a full control build. There
are units. There are two drops. And
there you go. Card sharp. A really fun
one. So, this gives your opponent the
opportunity. If they would like, they
can have a gold. Uh, you get an
additional gold. You get one gold no
matter what. And then, uh, let's make a
deal. You can have a gold, I can have a
gold. Now, with Hunter in play from you,
um, probably not wanting for that extra
gold, I would think.
>> Often the correct answer is no. Uh, the
decks that are playing card sharp are
probably going to use it better than
you.
>> Uh, but you should look at your hand.
You should look at your spot and see, is
this gold going to help me progress my
game plan in a way that makes me not
really care if they have another goal
this way? And then you can decide. Uh,
but as you said, treasure under pretty
good reason to just say, "No, I I don't
think I'm going to need I got plenty
>> too much gold, right? You're going to
get a decent amount here.
>> I'm not greedy." You know, usually when
your opponent offers you a choice like
this, you got to go, "All right, why why
are you offering me this choice? What
are you up to?" So Hunter comes in,
makes that gold, and now what is the
next step for Mew? Of course, Draven
always hanging out in the champion zone.
Always a safe play on turn two, but
looks like we're going to see a card
from hand.
Maybe not. Just kidding. Little pump
fake. We love pump fakes here in the
booth.
>> Oh yeah.
>> So just a Draven and pass right back.
Going grappler's way.
>> Of course, Reaver's Row and Treasure
Hunter. Quite the potent combination. Uh
bouncing in and out, making tons of
gold.
Yeah, it's always hard to find time to
play the champ Lux. And so definitely
curious when we'll see Grappler get a
chance to do so cuz you need it's it's a
slow card, right? You play it, it's only
two might and then you need a turn for
it to then untap and be ready to be
exhausted again to give you those two
energy for spells. And then it becomes
like a really great ramp card in that
way. It's ramp it's ramp two runes
except for those runes must be spent on
spells, right? but they'll exceed your
rune cap when you get towards 12 runes
later on. It lets you, you know, do even
more. But we're just going to see Grap
away the treasure hunter. Get that
point, but give another gold over to
more gold piling up.
So, point for Grappler. Much of the
points for Grappler aren't as important
as they are from you.
And then what's next step? Uh, five
runes saying go. Uh, Falling Comet is a
pretty cool card in this deck. Uh, that
card's nice. Uh, pretty cool card. So,
and then when you add a draw a card onto
it thanks to the Lux Legend. Not too
shabby. Six to a unit out of
battlefield.
>> A little uh face up here. There can't be
that many other things. There's Wages of
Pain, you know, maybe one or two other
possible options, but that's the one
that would be if I'm if I'm like, whoa.
All right. You know, kind of hard for
GoPro to have nothing here. So, yeah. I
think if you want to push in with the
Draven, you have to be okay with a comet
being dropped on your head. What I would
say is if uh if we do have an axe, if
there is an axe on the side of Mew, I
would just push Asper instance and say,
"Yeah, go ahead. Drop the gummit. Let's
see what happens." Uh if uh the axe gets
to just come out and kind of answer that
going up to seven where it's six damage
and there is an axe hand.
>> Axe right in the window. Yeah. So axe of
course so potent against these damage
based rule spells. Here comes Draven.
Little uh plus two buff there. Love to
get the dice on there. It's fantastic.
And uh saying, "All right, step one is
we're reavers row. What do you want to
do?" So, we're going to see comment at
axis of speed, meaning that the reaver's
row has resolved and not pushed back the
card sharp. And here comes that axe. So,
we're looking at a trade at present.
>> Yeah, that's the thing with pushing here
instead of the aspirants, right? Cuz if
you push into the aspirins, you can play
around the comet with the axe pushing to
seven. But if you go here, even pumping
to six and then plus three, the damage
from car charp is still going to be a
little bit better here and allow the
trade. And I think for grap, this is a
huge win. I mean, you've gotten rid of
an axe and a Draven.
>> Yep. uh that a should still be in play
as well. True. And also
>> that can be equipped onto the treasure
hunter to keep it around,
>> right? When you lose it on your
opponent's turn, you know, some players
will shortcut and kind of just bin it
immediately uh for the temporary the
next turn, but it should still be there.
Um we are not exactly live. We are on a
slight delay. So hopefully will catch
that one. And Hunter goes in stack deck.
Take a peek
and
you should be at two I believe. Yep. One
conquer on the last turn. This one will
go up to two.
>> It is possible this is a stack deck at
action speed before the conquer. That is
a that is a possible. So
see what the next step is
and it's going to be a fan. All right.
So me at two passing back. Not a great
turn.
>> Yeah, losing the axe. I think yeah,
you'd probably be okay to go down one
power and re-equip the axe here as M's
side. I think just that value of that
might is possibly worthwhile especially
cuz the treasure hunter would then dodge
wages of pain. Yes. Um which I think is
worth a power especially with all this
like gold that you're generating. You're
going to kind of buy back later. Um so
definitely a tough little misstep there
as we are going to get a hard cast
Vanguard Armory for this game for
Grappler. But this is what I'm talking
about with Aspirin's Climb. The game's
going to go long. Even just hard casting
it at seven, you are going to be
acrewing value.
>> Yeah, this is a card that uh says I want
the game to go as long as possible.
Armory comes in immediately. Makes three
recruit tokens and will make three
recruit tokens for the rest of the game
in perpetuity. Uh assuming there's some
gear removal in Muse decks. I don't
believe there was in the main deck. So,
uh All right. So, we're going back Muse
way now.
>> In in essence, putting the axe in the
graveyard is not like a extreme game
rule violation where it would have just
temporary to this turn anyway. So, it
was not attached. So,
>> that's you know, it's fine. We can live
we can live with that. completely okay
for him just decide to not equip it that
have it die.
>> Yeah. So if Mew thinks that hey the rune
is more important uh I would just leave
it here and let it die anyway. That's
fine. But and the rune is important to
splitter.
>> Yep. So here comes Mindsplitter.
Unfortunately a little late for the
armory but we see a hand salvage
bellow's breath plundering borrow drag
under and card sharp.
>> Never mind we lied. He could have still
splittered. He had eight runes.
>> But but yes bit of misstep. You know,
one of the things I like to tell folks,
you know, is until you've been under the
bright lights in a high pressure match
like this. You know, it's so easy to to
armchair quarterback from home and be
like, "Oh, well, how could you miss
that?" But it's a lot of pressure. You
know, there's a lot going on in these
games, uh, and a lot of weight, the
lights on, and
>> folks are watching. We're talking about
the game. So,
>> what do you like here? I kind of like
taking the drag under cuz you just
played this mind spplitter and nothing
else, uh, from this hand deals with it.
>> Yeah, the hand's kind of uh kind of
finicky. You got a few small units. Uh,
Bell's breath, you know, take the
hunter, but I agree with the seven might
unit here. Yeah, I got to go over the
top of these recruits.
>> Yeah,
>> so makes sense to me.
>> The Dragun also draws a card, so it's
like it replaces itself. Everything else
doesn't. Uh I will say like Bell's
Breath is a very potent card in general.
Like if we end up finding uh if if
there's end up ends up being like an
Imperial decree or a Watcher, this
spell's breath can actually just clear
up a lot of Draven's board. So it is
like a a later problem to deal with. Uh
though the drag under is just saying
like if your mind spplitter ever enters
a battlefield, uh it is going to die to
this. So
>> yeah. Yeah, it's a little interesting
thought back and forth on which one
potentially is is uh maybe the choice.
>> Yeah, I think with I think Mu's kind of
behind here. I think that taking the
Drag Under feels a lot less safer to me.
I think that if you're saying all right,
if you find the Imperial decree and
you're able to pull off your combo, wipe
my board, fine. But right now, a drag
under is just a great exchange. Uh it's
two for one on a high high might unit
and a board where MW doesn't have many
high might units. So, I think I kind of
agreed.
Going back grapplers wet. Tons of ruins
to work with now that armory is pumping
out recruits at record rate. But we're
going to see a just a salvage on the
goldage.
>> So taking out that gold draw a card. So
at the cost of a room to draw a card,
it's fine.
>> Not exactly the most high impact gear of
all time, but
>> no. I mean, his hand just must not be at
all what he's looking for because it's
not that Draven doesn't have targets for
the salvage round, right? Like there
there are going to be probably two more
two more axes in the deck that you're
worried about later on, but Grap
deciding he wants a card now. Uh and
that is more important than having this
kind of toolbox answer. You know, he's
got another spell that just says kill a
unit, which is quite good. And instead,
he ends up finding a singularity off the
top for this. Gets to deal with the two
small units. We know Dragon is there to
exist for the mind spplitter. So a lot
of answers are being found and you know
singularity gets to draw a new card.
>> Yeah. And uh so now that drag under
looking very ominous you know if without
the drag under you know if splitter
could maybe kind of rule the roost but
now these recruits come in start taking
points and they are not going to stop.
Three recruits every game off the
armory. Uh
um okay we are on basic speed for the
armory. So that being used there's no
chance to use it. Correct.
>> Correct. Yeah, I think just just missed
just the nerves under the lights. That's
what that's what we've been saying.
>> That's tough. These players are also up
against it at six and two.
>> He he just saw he gave a little smile.
The camera touched his his his Vanguard
armor and he realized
>> that's all right Grap. We forgive you.
>> Yep.
>> We in the booth, our official stance is
we forgive you, Grubler.
>> So, going back muse way. That being
said, Grab's still in a good spot here.
Uh is behind on points technically. see
a thunders song. Thunders song not not
very relevant here. Just
>> just a five with only one uh energy up
for grappler. So just trying to develop.
Um but now again dragoners in hand. Mu
knows about it and it's a good exchange.
>> Yeah, it says to me uh Mu doesn't have
that many units in hand because this is
just a brin here for five when you know
there are action speed spells that
actually can blow you out towards the
end of the game. Y
>> but not being able to hold the sprint
here to look for those winning points at
the end of the game. Great though to
have the tide turner. You know the drag
hunter's there directly play around it.
I was kind of curious about pushing in
the mind spplitter on this turn without
too much of a good development behind
it, but it makes perfect sense with this
uh tide turner. I really like this this
line so far. All right, so developing
the board uh keeping the important use
in the back row. Meter is pretty good
against the you the singularity deck.
You know, having that that seventh point
of might very important. So that being
said, we got a ton of cards at hand for
Grappler.
>> Um
I saw a call of the week. We have
dragunders there as well.
>> And uh unfortunately not making those
recruits uh is pretty tough because if
there were recruits in play, they could
pop in take out a Turner. That opens up
Call of the Week. Uh so Turner playing a
little defense here on in more than one
way. But and is uh quite full now. M
also getting up to five here. So getting
into the range of where oh we could just
see a big attack possibly take this game
uh in a game where again Grappler wants
the game to go long with the armory. So
>> got to armory first here.
>> Make sure you don't forget.
>> Yep.
>> Uh but as you said it hurts. It allowed
uh M to make this line with the tide
turner going in and not have to worry
about it being taken down by just like a
little swarm of recruits. And it would
have made the call the week so much
better because you could just send the
the recruits in, deal with the tide
turner, score your point up to five, and
then play that call and go from there.
Get rid of at least the Brin or the Mind
Splitter while you still have that drag
under, you know, at the ready to stop
any conquers.
>> Yep. So, we're going to see card sharp
again once again. Do you want to make a
gold is the question. Looks like the
answer is no. So, just one gold for
grappler. Mute declines the deal. And
now five energy up. Drag under is in
hand and known information
and looks like it's going to be a pass.
So going back muse way and now a lot to
navigate. So the now the thundersong
being played on the prior turn would
have looked really good on this turn.
But I agree that it just you just have
to put something in play. So MW goes to
six on the hold and this is a big turn
in the game. I think if uh if MW can't
make really good forward progress this
turn, Grappler will really start to take
over.
A little little little headshake there.
Okay, recognizing the gravity of how
important this turn is. We see stack
deck. We see falling star. Ferris
4runner.
Going to start things off with the stack
deck. Not a bad place. Not a bad place
to start. There's an axe in the window.
I think didn't see the other two. Quick
choice though.
I think biggest card from you here would
be hard bargain. We're looking at five
runes for grappler. Drag under is the
obvious choice for what's being cast on
this turn. hard bargain is just always
winning there and it's it's always a big
blowout. You gets to go to to seven
without losing anything. Waste all of
the runes for grapplers basically entire
turn on the previous turn and then
you're set yourself up at seven uh
playing to nine. So just need a double
conquer to close out the game with one
of your big units at reaver's row and a
tie turner at home to protect against
call the week. So that would be the
biggest card that MU could have found.
But seeing as how it's pushing the
thundersong instead of the mind
spplitter, I'm curious if there is no
hard bargain and just wanting to lose
the softer unit first. So there goes the
drag under taking out the smaller unit.
Now we know there's a second drag under
in hand for grappler. You does not know
that. So goodbye thundersong. And now
mind splitter. Do you want to get
frisky?
>> The answer is yes.
>> Kind of have to go to seven, right?
>> Yeah. Yeah. I think you have to think
you got to go in here. So coming in
maybe not going to think it through. a
lot of cards at end. So,
>> I mean, if there's like Kai'Sa
accelerate, I'd do that instead. Try and
keep keep the card economy going, keep
the mind spplitter at home for that
final push. There's some other options
than pushing the splitter, but it's just
a matter of just you have them in hand,
right? Uh cuz outside of this, I you
really just want splitter big develop
and well, that's a pretty large develop.
That's that's a large lad, I would say.
>> Yeah. For the back row. Okay. So, Mewtwo
at seven now threatening. That being
said, Grappler's got a whole bunch of
tools over there. And we're going to see
a treasure hunter as well. And two runes
up and
got one.
>> I saw a falling star that he was looking
at. I It feels really awkward to falling
star like a a recruit, but there is at
least the card sharp on board, so it's
possible that that could be okay leaving
Grappler with only four might that's
pushable on the next turn.
>> All right, going to decide against it.
So, pass the turn.
What's Lil Bro tide Turner still doing
on Asert's climb, do you think?
>> Hanging out.
>> Yeah. Um, yeah.
>> I mean, he is chilling.
>> Yeah, it does seem like I mean with the
hunter in the back row, I guess that's
also insurance, but with the card sharp
available too, does seem like a pretty
safe spot to retreat. Uh, but he's going
to hang out. I
>> think maybe an axe like you're trying to
bait Grappler and just like a bad swing,
right?
>> Um, you know, it's like, oh yeah, I'll
just high turn or uh go ahead and send
send the card sharp in there and it's
like axe. Now it's five,
>> right?
>> Uh could see something like that. So,
we'll see. Grappler here. A lot of
options and a lot of tools available.
Wants this game to keep going. Is that
an Imperial Decree there in the hand?
>> Yes, I believe that is Imperial Decree
next to that call of the week. Good
catch.
>> Yep. So, some good stuff happening.
Question is, it all it is all fairly
expensive. So, what order do you want to
play these cards in? Tough when you have
so many options. Yeah, I think Grappler
didn't get to find the the real ramp up
that he wanted and he never found a spot
to play out the Lux because there's been
a little bit too much pressure. So, he's
kind of behind on the runes that he
wants to be at cuz really he'd like to
be able to maybe decree, clear
everything up and then look for, you
know, maybe holding up a drag under or
looking to double call. And I think a
lot of that starts to get a little bit
too expensive on this turn uh with the
rune count that he's currently sitting.
>> All right, so really thinking it
through. A lot of insurance against call
here too with both the hunter and the
4runner.
So
>> talking through figuring it out
frag under. What's total rune count
here? Nine. So nine runes.
Of course, Lux cares about things that
cost five. So we can't get two Lux draws
this turn.
And really thinking it through, really
slowing down. heavy spot where in a game
where Grappler was pretty ahead. Uh, you
know, had a pretty good spot, was
turning the corner, but that one turn of
the armory missing those three unit
units really gave me MW the window to
kind of really get in and get to his
spot of being at seven threatening for
lethal.
So, first step,
oh man, really agonizing over the
decision.
This first step is going to be perhaps
Card Sharp. So, Card Sharp coming into
Turner. This looks free and it is. So no
no no no tricks, no bluffs. Just gonna
give up the tie turner and give a point
to grappler. Going to five.
>> Turtle beats elephant apparently.
>> It's a really big turtle.
>> Yeah, it's a he's a big guy.
>> All right, then we're going to see drag
under on the mind spplitter. So
that will draw a card. That will take
out the mines spplitter. That takes a
lot of might off Muse board and we'll
see what the draw is. Four energy left.
Five recruits in the back with the
armory also ready to go. So, three more
on the way. Armor only plays to base or
can play anywhere.
>> Uh, armory can play anywhere that you
are. Y
>> long as you long as you got that
control, you can go ahead and
>> go for the armory.
>> So,
two energy down and is this going to be
a call a week?
>> It is. So
>> just to kill a hunter.
>> So just to kill the hunter. Now if Mew
really wanted to could sacrifice the
4Runner to maintain seven might in play.
Uh but decides to keep keep the uh the
forerunner going. There's got to be some
sort of plan for for grappler beyond
just this. So here comes the recruit
into rever that brings grappler to six.
The idea for grap is very likely that
Mew having all the might on a single
unit is better for Grappler right now.
Even though the tide turner is just or
or the treasure hunter is just one,
there's a world that can still push over
something that grappler has set up. Uh
whereas when it's just the forerunner,
only something like a ride the wind is
allowing you to kind of conquer both
sides. So Grappler trying to force Mew
to just go to eight instead of being
able to end the game and he can keep two
runes up for maybe hidden blade or
something else that he's got uh going
forward as we see him play out the rest
of these to go to nine mighted aspirin's
climb saying Ferris 400 is going to need
a little help to even take this one.
Yes, we are on Aspirin's climb. So, we
have seven to six on MU is two points
for victory and a hidden card as well.
Okay, so piling up on the climb. Daring
Mew to come in and try and break. And
now we're going back Muse way. And
again, I think every turn that goes by
for Grappler is a good turn. You know,
the more time, draw more cards, get the
armor going every turn. So, pressure on
Mew to close this game out at seven
points trying to get to nine. We see a
draw and we see a ponder.
Lot of runes available. Just the lone
Ferris 4runner.
>> Two energy up for grappler. Hidden card
is just probably hidden blade.
>> Yeah, we saw a hidden blade in the hand.
And I'm, you know, wages of pain is
another one that can be hidden in this
deck. I think those are the main two
that we end up seeing as far as the
hidden options. Um, I had spotted a
hidden blade. I had not seen a wages. So
I I'm just going to assume it's the
hidden blade that I saw earlier. And if
we get surprised by a wages of pain,
then uh uh so be it.
>> Sure.
So you thinking through a lot to work
out. Nine might on Aspirin's climb and
the hidden card. The two energy
available for Grappler as well.
So close,
but still a long way to go. Now note
that Lux is a slower controlling deck.
The clock is not too bad right now. I
love the 60-minute round timer, being
able to compartmentalize each game in 20
minutes. So, you get a quick look over,
you see, we're just a little over the
time for game one at 39 minutes, but not
too bad.
>> But it's the aspirin game, right? It's
the Aspen game. This one's got to take a
little bit longer on the aspirin game,
right?
>> We'll give 42 minutes to this game and
shout out the other ones.
>> Yeah, exactly.
>> So, stack deck start.
Of course, if you're unaware that there
was a change uh in the tournament rules,
moving the rounds to 60 minutes and the
extra turn rules to being three turns
rather than five, and you must win by
two, which we saw yesterday in dramatic
fashion. You missed the last round of uh
of a day yesterday. Holy moly. Go back
and watch that one.
So, here's stack deck. Didn't catch the
pickup. Did you see what it was?
>> No, didn't see any of the options here.
So, just
>> see we got something. I'm trying to
think like what are your really optimal
cards? And I I'm still thinking that the
hard bargain is something that you're
really wanting. I don't remember if we
saw any in the main or if they were on
the board from you. Uh but that tends to
be the card you'd be digging for.
Outside of that, you just want to
continue developing. I mean, Ferrris
Foreigner is just your best unit, right?
So, you just want to keep finding maybe
more Ferros. I think even we're seeing
this Mindsplitter now as he's leaning
forward. That's a that's a decent card
you can jam down getting the the new
hand information. Since the last one has
played, Grappler has basically cycled
most of the hand at this point. So,
getting new stuff is good. Remember we
saw the the falling star earlier. It is
still in hand. Uh that can break up the
nine might on this aspirin clan taking
out the sharp and one token putting down
to five might giving forer a pretty
clear shot.
>> Yeah, I think that's really nice and a
good call out. And there's also we did
just see a piercing light so you could
even just kind of take that further and
just burn, you know, four runes but deal
with a lot of the board.
>> Mhm. It's also has this one other
recruit hanging out on Reaver's Row. Of
course, getting to seven in an aspirin
climb game is like getting to six in a
regular game, and six is a great number
to be at. So, that's a possibility. And
there is piercing light. All right, so
here's Piercing Light going to take out
uh So, we got Battlefield and any
others. So, we've got the two
battlefields are going to be the aspirin
climb and the reaver's row. And then the
two others will be two more recruits
there. So, climb down to two recruits.
This plays around wages of pain, too.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Three there and one at
Reavers. Wages does no longer beat the
Forerunner. Has to be exactly hidden
blade.
Going to send that in. I think for grap
you consider just hidden. Oh, it is
wages.
>> Wow.
>> I said we'd get surprised by it.
>> What a play. So playing around exactly
wages here by putting it down to two
might on the battlefield so foreigner
can win it. Fantastic stuff. Really,
really well played from you.
>> So I
>> So going to go up to eight. Of course
you're playing an aspirin's climb. So
we're going to nine.
>> Game not over just yet.
>> We're going to nine. We're going to
nine.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> Players confirming that you know
We got to draw up the Draven.
>> And here's Darius. Uhoh.
>> Miscounted his runes.
>> Did you see that earlier?
>> Wait.
>> So, two spells are already cast. So,
Darius can't be
>> Oh, no. Okay. I just They were stacked.
It looked like four runes.
>> Yep.
>> Two spells cast. It's not ready.
>> Yep. So, unfortunately, that would have
been the game.
>> Yeah, that would have been it.
>> Bar barring, you know, hard and hambit.
>> He just had to play the Darius between
the two spells and it would have gotten
there.
>> Wow. Yeah, that that Wow. So great play
into the wage of pain
>> followed by immediately forgetting how
Darius works and it is it is what
happens and you can see it on his face.
He knows I mean he knows you don't have
to tell him that was a blunder.
>> That's so tough too because you know
when there when there is a mistake in a
game there are two types of mistakes.
There are blunders which is oopsies and
there are strategic errors.
>> Got the strategy right part totally
right. Uh you know perfectly read the
card executed perfectly on that part and
then just a little blunder as far as
like when to play the cards. So that's a
tough one. You guys check that one off.
All players, you know, we're seeing a
bit of the uh the nerves, the feature
match area, but here comes Imperial
Decree.
>> I He must have found a bellow.
>> Yeah, with no units in play. Wow, that's
a weird play, right?
>> I wonder what this could be.
>> Why would he do that?
>> So,
>> well, and if you're wondering why the
bell's breath was taken away earlier,
this is uh generally the reason. Oh, he
doesn't have a bellows in hand. He said,
I want to play decree and find bellows.
I think is what Graph is going for here.
That's a really exciting play when
you're at the spot where you have to
just decree and draw bellows.
>> Now he's trying to count runes because
he has the the garbage grabber in hand.
So he could play that and draw one more
card.
>> So the problem is though, even if you
wipe out the 4Runner, the two mechs just
go to base and they can just double. So
>> tough spot.
>> Yep.
>> Wow.
>> All right, got to go next game. So the
blunder does not matter here for Mew,
but they're going to go into the next
game. Valmar's oblisk.
>> That's tough. And honestly, that's a lot
of, you know, playing in these late
stages of tournaments where players are
not going to play perfectly under the
lights with the fatigue or whatever.
It's just can you manage to to, you
know, play a little better than your
opponent. And uh, great game there from
Meu. We're going to go into game number
two. MW is going to be on Obelisk of
Power with Grappler on Vile M's layer.
>> Yeah. And, you know, I just wanted to
quickly correct myself. There was never
a hidden blade in that hand. I saw it at
the end. Somehow I thought there was a
hidden blade, so it had to be that way.
Just is what it is. Happens.
>> It was really hidden.
>> Yeah, it was very hidden. So, it's not
like, you know, Grappler put the wrong
card hiding there where hidden blade
would have been better. He just didn't
even have one. So, uh, went with what he
could with that wages and it was played
around beautifully by Mu as we're going
into the Obelisk Vile Mos game. This
will be Grapplers go first battlefield
with the Vile Mos. It's nice to be able
to trap things there. We can't see, you
know, we want to see those like Tide
Turner retreat, the big unit to escape
something like a drag under that we saw
MU be able to play beautifully around if
it ever has to run into Boss. And really
what we'll end up seeing is Mu avoiding
any big units going into vile mos like
the play trying to send anything big
towards the obelisk of power so he can
have some more counterplay.
>> Yeah, and obsc force is mu's battlefield
but it's pretty good for grappler too
right with Lux with the always high cost
cards. So plundering borrows the first
play for grappler and we see a turn one
Kai'Sa over the champion zone Draven
>> going back grappler's way
>> going to be up to five runes.
And now now we're at a point where the
clock is a little more of a concern. Uh
starting game two at 29 minutes. So they
have 50 minutes for each upcoming game.
>> And it looks like Grappler forgot to
draw for turn on turn one.
>> Oh, okay.
>> Um I'm seeing if the it looks like the
judges are trying to remedy whether it
should be like a he should just draw the
card or if not. And I think they're
asking the opponent if he's allowing a
card drawn, but I don't know the actual
ruling for when you forget to draw a
card on turn one. I've not encountered
that. So, we'll let the judges handle
it. I'm sure they'll find the resolution
that that should happen and we'll go
from there.
>> All right. So, all set
and pass turn to Mew. Here comes Kai'Sa
coming in into the five untapped runes.
Now, this is a spot where again the axe
would be devastating against the comet.
We're starting off with the stupify
though. So, stupify shrink on Kai'Sa
down to three. Lines up well with wages
of pain. And here you go. The one-two
punch. Here's wages. Now again though,
spinning axe here would be devastating.
Little shake in the head from you.
>> Feels like he doesn't have a spinning
axe or else why am I shaking my head?
>> That That's my poker read, too. We are
in Vegas. You get your reads, right?
>> Bluffing. Oh, no. That sucks. Oh, wait.
Here's a spinning.
>> Yeah.
>> Oh, seven. Oh, right. Yeah. Okay. Sure.
Or six, I suppose. Whatever.
>> Big enough.
And
I mean,
>> does look really good to play spinning
axe here.
>> There's not many other reaction speed
things coming through for this deck.
>> All right, there there's spinning axe.
Yeah, it's
>> kind of
checking the uh some of the judge. And
there's the axe. So uh the perfect
counterplay. Kis is now huge. Uh I guess
to win the combat, draw a card, get a
point, and of course stick around. Very,
very large. And at seven, my that's a
great break point for Similarity. Yeah,
it is. And that is where Grappler really
wants to have a drag under here for this
next turn. He's going to get the hold
just kind of kill off the Kai'Sa. It's a
pretty like solid way to be going. Uh
and for for Mia, you'd want something
like maybe a tide turner to go alongside
this hopeful and get her out of there as
we saw in the previous game. But seems
like that's not the case. Keeping two
runes up, getting the hopeful down. Uh
and you know, seven being amazing in
this spot because of the singularity
break point. You'd want to singularity
this board really badly and uh not going
to be able to actually go for that
unless there's another stupify cuz it is
seven runes.
>> That would be incredible. Yes. So the
downside here also is that now spinning
axe is at risk, right? So if if there is
a drag under and the Kis is removed, the
axe goes away too, but it's kind of hard
to have.
>> Oh, there's a drag under.
>> All right, drag under in the window.
There you go. We got salvage there. Also
was oneoff salvage last turn, I believe.
So
>> yeah. All right, starting up. Lux likes
to tap five. What can we say?
>> We're going to see the drag under on the
Kai'Sa. This is a effectively a three
for one. Uh taking out all the Kai'Sa
drawing card off Lux and then the axe
will go away as well. So barring any
trickiness, two runes up for hard
bargain if that's a possible uh possible
response. But nope, there goes Kai'Sa
been dragged under again. The axe being
preemptly put in the graveyard. It is
not technically there yet. Still in play
temporary, but will be on its way there
soon.
I want to note this porro should be
ready. However, that is a vile moss
layer that he is sitting on. Sure, that
porro is not coming home anyway
>> as he's going to play a new plundering
porro at base ready to generate some
more gold as this luxe wants to keep
scaling those runes and the early
plundering porro the early wages is
really helping towards that end. All
right, back muse way hopeful seven runes
and the next step is
probably going to the bio biom. Here
comes no soful porro down point up.
>> This is not an aspirin climb game. So we
are playing to eight. It is two to two.
So on those even numbers
>> classic card game fundamentals draw
first. Uh go ahead and get your Draven
draw.
>> Yep.
>> Then see what you can do with your turn.
That's one I have to repeat over and
over and over and over again in my
content.
>> Oh yeah,
>> draw first.
>> If you're planning on drawing a card in
your turn or like library manipulating
any way, uh just do that first. See what
you get. So here's Skye accelerated
commented. Obless power and uh great
start from you.
Cards being drawn, points being won, you
know, being able to uh take a point and
take a card. So if you do lose this
Kai'Sa, uh you're still getting some
value off of it. Now though, Singularity
is looking pretty nice.
So, what's next step for our Lux player?
>> I mean, I think for the most part, he's
snapping it off if he sees it. And I
think that is a count of six runes if
I've ever uh
>> it's me.
>> I hate getting singularity.
All right, so your singularity thanks to
each of two units. Doesn't matter where
they are. They are at Battlefield right
now, but wouldn't matter either way. And
they are gone. So, there were two runes
up. So, another axe there would have
been pretty nice. Hard bargain does not
play here.
draw for Lux. I think Grappler deciding
if he wants to try and trap something
that MW plays in Vom or if he can go for
the obelisk. Basically, the reason I say
trap with the uh the the porro is if he
goes and conquers vile mos, MW is going
to want to put a unit into Vom to
actually win that combat and conquer it.
And so, Grappler would get to kind of
keep something there. Whereas here going
with the obelisk, this does allow
Grappler the ability. If this poral
survives a turn and holds, he he gets to
bring it home and then potentially send
it out again, go for another gold token
uh going forward as he's been able to
kind of chain these gold. Only had to
actually recycle a single rune this
game. The singularity one being paid for
by the gold then of course having to
recycle one. But garbage grabber or
garbage goober
>> garbage slammed
>> garbage grabber here is uh a little bit
of a a car drench. Let's get garbage get
garbage grabber up there. This is a uh a
card that can recycle three from your
dash for one energy to exhaust and draw
one. So, kind of a late game card.
>> Yeah. Prevent you from ever burning out.
Though, Lux usually does not have this
problem. Uh but it is still nice to be
able to keep drawing even when you're
not just finding the big spells cuz
sometimes Lux wants to chain together a
couple cheap spells and then you start
to have hand issues and the garbage
grabber is like a way that you're going
to kind of keep keep those going. So
just a pure development turn from you uh
over over zealous fan and for runner
going back grappler's way four to three
with the point lead with that plundering
porum and uh once again looking pretty
good a lot of runes available a lot of
cards in hand
and I'm going to count those out that's
a lot I can't even count that high looks
like nine again oh 10
yeah Lux has a lot better battlefield
access than backline now the singularity
we just saw is a really good one that
can hit the backline but things like
drag under being killed, hidden blade
being killed. A lot of these are more
battlefield ccentric. Even the falling
comet six damage is often just also
reads as kill in a lot of scenarios and
uh that being at action speed, you want
to wait. And this did feel like a great
turn to finally develop the Lux. We had
not seen her played in the previous
game, never found a chance. And this
time being able to play Lux and keep
drag under up I think is the really good
draw because now going forward you're
going to be going to 12 or 14 runes as
far as playing spells go on a future
turn as the Lux crown guard gets to
ready.
>> Yeah. So Lux kind of your your rare
almost pure utility unit. Uh only two
might for four is you know it's kind of
small. Uh but two energy is a big deal.
So set up turn for both players. Now Mu
gets first crack at it and Ferris
4runner is going to start running over
to Obelisk power and there is a drag
under. So you know not the the most
amazing exchange uh does stop the point.
Two mech tokens will come into play but
card drawn off of Lux not too shabby.
Good efficient use of energy as well.
All right. And then what's the next step
from you overzels fan? The last
remaining unit standing.
>> Draven's laying on the champ.
>> Yeah, Draven still hanging out there.
Usually you just see two drop into
Draven as almost every single Draven
starting turns, but instead we saw that
accelerated Kai'Sa trying to get some of
the early points for you. I want to kind
of call some attention to the hand of
Grappler after dealing with the Ferros
forer. He does have a Bellow's breath
and a couple like stupifies, might
reductions. Uh I didn't see a Imperial
decree yet, but the stupifies with
repeated Bellow's Breath can actually
still make quick work of these mechs on
the back line. So if Mew stacks too many
things at a single location, whether
it's Battlefield or base, the Bellow's
Breath is going to be really dangerous.
The best kind of place to be is on all
three locations when playing around
Bellow's Breath. and we'll see if it's
within the range of cards that MU wants
to actually be playing around on this
turn.
>> All right, so big Darius move in. Fan
moves in up to five
and we see little tide turner swap. So
protect that Darius. Very nice. So
honestly the two might unit on each
battlefield. Pretty good against only a
Plundering Bum. And we're going back
Grappler's way again. Things looking
good for Grappler. Well set up here.
Every single rune is in play alongside
Lux. of 14 energy
available. That's a lot.
>> Yeah, as two of it has to be used on
spells, but this deck is like 90%
spells. So, basically just 14 energy
flat out ready to go, ready to be used.
Can even start the turn with a garbage
grabber draw if needed, but it feels
like there is a spell.
>> Grappler is very excited to cast and
it's not a spell. It is in fact a
thousand tailed watcher, but we did
mention those bellow's breath and that
is one of the best combos that you can
do for uh this setup now reducing the
might everywhere by three and then the
bellow's breath just has to clean up
dealing one or two damage when
everything is at one or two might.
>> Yeah. So we have the mech in the
background now ones. Darius is currently
two. So we you mentioned stupify in hand
as well. So Bell is about to be a pretty
big cleanup here.
>> Yeah. Don't even have to repeat it.
>> Yep. So, here comes the porro. We got a
conquer. Here comes the watcher. We got
another conquer.
>> That puts Grappler up to is it six or
seven?
>> Uh, it should be six. I believe he's up
four on last.
>> It was four. You're right. Okay. So, up
to six and it's time to make some things
happen. Stupidified targeting Darius and
Aver Mew right now. Oh boy. You know
what's coming.
>> Yep.
>> The breath is bellowing. We're going to
see one damage to each of the mechs and
the Darius. They all conveniently happen
to have exactly one might.
>> Yeah, well set up by Grab. Finds a good
spot for a full board wipe while
developing seven might and conquering
both sides.
That is very likely going to close
things out. It's really hard for Draven
to to stop this from hand, especially if
Grappler's got a hidden card to add to
it. Draven does have a healthy amount of
accelerate and readiness. uh comes from
the Draven, it comes from Ride the Wind.
There are ways, you know, a Kai'Sa can
accelerate, but dealing with a hidden
card, seven might on one side. It's it's
very difficult to have that perfect set
of cards in hand to actually break
through this when you don't have a
backline,
>> right? And the problem, of course, is MU
at five, not six. Even breaking through
only puts MU at seven. And once again,
go back grappler's way with a full 14
energy available and a whole bunch of
cards.
So, Mew, what is the plan?
>> Grappler trying to force a game three
here. MW trying to close this one out
and the clock is, you know, now under uh
under under 20 minutes with possibly one
more game to go. So, what is uh what is
MW's plan
looking nice? Yeah, I mean very clean
lux deck. uh you know these decks are
usually quite reliant on vanguard armory
and I've seen a lot of versions that
don't play the two drops or they don't
play the watchers and I like that
grappler is ensuring that he has a
healthy amount of units to still play if
he misses armory and make sure he can
still conquer things and actually score
points even when missing that gear when
I've seen some Luxes really lean into
the Jace armory combo and the spells and
they can struggle when they miss it. So
here's a piercing light. Pretty good
taking out plundering borrow and lux.
They're going to target both the hidden
guard with wages of pain. And it looks
like that is going to target the
plundering por of the battlefield just
to get your treasure. It's going going
out anyway.
>> And now bit judge question here.
>> There's no way that uh removing the
porro would stop the
>> correct. You still do as much as you can
on the piercing light. I I think it's a
very common question with piercing light
that players have is oh if I stop the
battlefield target that should save my
other unit, right? And the the answer
should be no. Uh in fact, it still just
does the rest of the target the the
card. But if you move the the unit from
the battlefield away from a battlefield,
that will protect it from that initial
damage, but the second part of it is
still always going through no matter
what you do to the unit that is at that
battlefield.
>> Right. So that wasn't bad, but has to be
a start. That can't be the the uh the
end all be all here. So wiping up wiping
up a few small units. That thousand
watcher is standing strong. But here's
Darius.
>> Hey, that is a good addition to this.
All you need is a spinning axe. Now
you're you're really cooking as you get
to remove everything from Grappler.
>> Yep. So Darius at seven. Watcher also at
seven. The trade is not exactly what we
was looking for here.
>> Yeah. Not end of the world cuz
Grappler's likely not going to be able
to win if you can trade, right? Uh being
at six, you know, we talked about how
Draven can sometimes struggle with
accelerating readying everything. It it
does okay. It's a pretty decent deck at
it. Lux is not uh Lux has thousand of
water and that is really the uh the
immediate unit interaction to the board
that she can accomplish. She can play
spells. She can stop you from holding
really well, but when it comes to
actually, you know, getting her own
units out onto the board, yeah,
Watcher's really I mean I mean that's
about it.
>> All right, so thinking through
Thunderong two thundersongs in hand and
looks like a Oh, yeah. So here comes
Darius. We got seven to seven
and just a trade. So definitely not what
Mu is looking for. That's a uh a break
in case of emergency. Darius, nothing
more. And we're going back Grappler's
way.
>> You see a sire relief from Meu thinking
Stupify just uh ends me here. Uh and it
was not there for the one rune for
Grappler. Uh so Mu kind of gets to live
another day. Tries to find a development
turn. Is that is a Vanguard Armory that
was pulled off the top for Grappler.
That's a pretty good draw because just
playing that and developing three
recruits just says, "All right, Mew,
stop me from conquering next turn."
>> Yep.
>> So going to start things off with the
garbage grabber. Three cards recycled
from the trash and one card drawn.
Plenty of energy available.
Yeah, armory looks uh pretty good onto a
board that currently has zero units on
either side.
>> Four runes though. Oh yeah, Jace. Yeah,
what's better than just playing the
armory flat out is actually paying only
four energy and one power for the armory
instead.
>> Sure. So combo wombo not as important to
have at this point in the game with so
much energy available, but still bit
potent. Gets more things in play. A
little bit of a discount.
>> So,
>> progress has been uh has been made.
Here's the armory. Here's the recruits.
And now, not only is Grappler back on
the board, but will always be on the
board for the rest of the game.
>> Yeah.
>> And also noting in in his hand is the
one of progress day, the draw five card
in Lux. Uh so, this hand will be
refilled if he wants to be able to cast
it after this. uh but does not have the
runes on this turn to make that happen.
We will just be asking the question of
Mew, can you get on board in a
meaningful enough way for me to not just
conquer both and take this to a game
three? Mu, my understanding was this was
two Brit here thunder songs and then a
non-acelerate unit. So, it feels like
>> packing up is probably the best
decision. Yeah, try and play the next
game.
>> Very smart from me, I think here. uh
recognizing you could play this game for
another 2 or 3 minutes if you want to,
but clock's a little low. Let's go to
game three. Let's have time to win. And
game three, MW is going to be on
Tarcon's Peak and Gra going to be on
Sigil of the Storm. Yeah,
>> makes sense. You got to slow things
down, right? Your opponent is always
looking to be staying ahead of the game.
They're pushing the early game and you
as the Lux are trying to slow things
down, use your spells to clear and
you're not conquering that frequently
until you get towards that like end game
where you're trying to push for those
those last few points to win. So making
your opponent continually recycle runes
and not be able to present as many units
and flood the board as much is really
nice.
>> All right, so here we go. Game three, 12
minutes left.
You going first. A lot of work to do.
These players six and two again up
against it. The loss here means you
almost surely can't make top eight.
So if these players want to keep it
alive and of course grappler looking for
potentially that lux best of here's card
sharp.
Let's make a deal this time. There's not
a treasure hunter. There's a tide
turner. So a little more of a question.
Do you want the gold? Mute says no.
Nope. No deal. Not happening.
>> Yeah. Vanguard armory in hand. Card
sharp played for turn one. Jace off the
top means that Grap finds the combo,
gets to have the Vanguard Armory turn
two, and really start pumping out the
pressure. It's exactly what he we we're
looking for off the top of the deck if
you're a grappler fan.
All right, so we're going to see the
standard two drop into Draven on turn
one and two from you. Untap, two for
Dargon Peak and say go. Here we go. Off
the top looking for a Jace
early for Army or Jace. Which one? Which
one?
>> Jace. He's got the armory.
>> Got the armory. Looking for a Jace.
>> Did not find it.
>> All right. So, there's a clean kill with
the sharp on the tie turn. And there's
Targon as well.
>> Little risky to just ship it there if
there's a spinning axe. That could be
really scary. But now that opens up the
world where you can callull this card
sharp away and deal with Draven. Yep.
>> After having a little early lead. It'd
be even better if there was something
else that could be developed in the
followup. It's also why, you know,
Victor is often sometimes better at
bullying these situations because you
get to make a guy and then use it for
>> that call the week.
>> Just a pass.
>> Just going to say go. The conquered
Targons didn't even uh have anything to
do with that. There was a call in hand.
So, could have gone for that play. Uh
want to maintain the card sharp.
There's the Imperial Decree in hand. You
got the Comet and again the Comet feels
somewhat face up in a spot like this,
but again face up. Uh but then really
running a foul of spinning axe or um or
a hard bargain. I guess that the axe
would be be in a trade scenario again,
right?
>> Yeah, we have that same kind of spot as
last time where the axe ends up just
trading with the card sharp uh if that
is the the choice to be gone for. And
and on top of that, we do have the the
potential opportunity
of bluffing that it is drag under. The
the unfortunate thing for grappler
though is you then reveal that
information before Mew has to actually
worry about it, right? I mean, for me,
it's like if you're scared of drag
under, you're just never pushing. If
you're scared of Comet, you just want to
look for a spinning axe to have in
response. And we do see a pick and a
spinning axe shipped to the bottom. I
caught the corner of that card there.
And that makes me think he's got to have
one in hand.
All right. So, what is the next step
from you?
Definitely some options here.
Going over to sigil is also a little
tough as far as the uh the ability on
the sigil.
So where is Draven going to go? All
right gonna pop into that card sharp and
immediately following comment maybe
dropping the gun here a little bit uh as
could have seen if the Draven was going
to y
>> get the buff but probably not. I think
Grappler recognizing the time being a
big issue here and uh you know I assume
there was maybe some indication on
whether or not the uh it was being used.
Um but yeah, just dripping it just
saying like, "Hey, let's go. Let's get
this uh show on the road as these two
hopefuls hit the board as singularity."
Very very good draw for Grappler if he's
able to find it here. Keep the board
clear, keep the points kind of rolling
in his favor. Like given how fast the uh
the uh combat was cast, I'm thinking
already had been cast yesterday at this
point. So
>> I agree with you. If you had it, it'd be
on the table.
>> Yep. So car sharp hanging out. Targon
speak. It is ready technically. Um this
player's playing fast. The clock is also
one of the many pressures of the feature
match area. And the sharp's coming home.
And
armory. Just going to play the armory.
Sure. Okay. So, Armory's in. Muse only
at one. So, Armory will really start to
add up as this game goes on. Saw the
Imperial Decree in hand also. So, these
uh recruits are can be very threatening.
And we're going back Muse way
completely exhausted. So, what's MW got
for us? Two hopefuls. What's that? Seven
runes.
Eight. Eight runes.
>> Yeah. I mean something like just gem
splitter score one side of it
set eight runes so it could be stack
deck into mind spplitter information
really really good in this spot you want
to know what Lux has so you don't play
around ghost and you can start playing
you know more quickly
>> we know that he's got two copies in the
main I imagine they stay in I don't
really see a huge reason to get rid of
them in this matchup it feels like a
very useful card as we are going to see
most are pushing forward
>> all right so step one
conquer sigil. That of course requires
you to recycle the rune. Get a float
>> and also go on to Argon speak. So
>> chose to recycle the uh it doesn't
matter I guess. So fury the fury rune.
There we go. Here's mine splitter. More
runes going down and the hand is
imperial decree. Plundering portal
progress day call the week bellow's
breath has the bellow's breath plus
Imperial decree. Right now all the units
are spread amongst all three locations.
>> Yeah the bellow's breath going to be
less effective with that. You can't
actually target everything, but breaking
up the combo feels necessary. I feel
like the decree is the more important
one. Oftentimes, you'd want to actually
just take this progress day because
that's five cards that's represented,
but the combo that you'd be digging for
with the five cards is already in hand.
So, you have to deal with the decree.
Let the bellows roll for now. So, we are
going to get grappler back over
untapping looking at that hand. I mean,
progress day is going to be a bit slow.
would find every answer that he needs.
We're really just looking for something
to maybe pair with this Bell's breath to
try and push through as he has a total
of six might going up against this.
>> Yeah. So, uh we might have missed the
Targon's Peak. Uh maybe being totally
tapped out. There was a conquer here.
Again, both players are playing fast.
So, going grappler's way. Nine runes
available. The card sharp. Three
recruits
and a lot to work through.
>> How much money available?
Six minutes remaining. Score is only two
to three. These players have a lot more
work to do.
>> And what's the first step? First step is
offer a trade with the noxious open. So
send the sharp and the recruit. There
goes the hopeful. So no combat is one.
Just an even trade.
>> And we're going to see some recycling
for
>> Bell's breath deal two there. Okay, so
Bell's breath deal two. Two more
recruits in. Now you get to call the
week to take out the mind spplitter.
Pretty good setup.
>> Yeah, absolutely love it. Really good
sequence from Grappler to find. When you
have the armory, you're afforded to
treat your units like dirt uh for you
know really I mean really that's what it
is, right? Because
>> don't don't sugar coat it.
>> Yeah. I mean they're just they just
don't matter, right? Like you you are
going to just keep generating them over
and over again. So your units have uh
very little value compared to your
opponents and anytime you can find a
trade it is just going to be beneficial
for you. And Grappler doing a really
great sequence there to deal with both
hopefuls. Get the call the week to deal
with the seven drop that was put in the
back for just two energy. Very efficient
clears and then redevelop a board of the
might value not mattering but the the
just substance of four units ready to go
and start getting conquers coming
through as on the other side. Meu going
to be able to go Darius hopeful and push
to four which is you know the break
point in this game. We're on Evens going
to be trying to see if he can find a way
to keep climbing towards those A points.
>> So once again, we kind of have Mew
trying to end the game uh with Grappler
with this kind of inevitable engine of
the the armory picking recruits, drawing
cards.
Grappler hold on and turn the corner.
Looking pretty close to doing it. Fast
action here. Oh boy. Five runes and two.
Is that a decree off the top? It is.
was wondering what we'd want what what
grappler would want to be casting for
five and two on this turn and it must be
that there's just no other answer to the
Darius.
>> Okay, so
and there actually is a hard bargain
hand for Mew. Uh unable to counter that
but G comes in a just a little recruit.
Sorry, Darius. Going down and recruit
number two at conquer. Go to three.
>> So, decree there mostly just kill
Darius. So far,
>> it's an expensive drag under.
>> Yes, so far. Porro comes in, get a
point, get a gold.
>> I think likely there was no other
removal for Darius on this turn and
Grappler just recognizing he needs to
keep the tempo up, keep the pressure
going. If he does have a way to hit the
backline, that would be massive. and he
does with a call. So yeah, the dra the
uh it is just an expensive drag under
being spent for that Imperial decree,
but it is worthwhile when you keep the
board completely clear. Keep units on
board with the Vanguard Armory and you
are even four to four. The corner has
been turned for this Lux deck and now
it's just about collecting the remaining
points.
>> Yeah, great stuff. Two great turns. Just
total wipes and great progress.
>> Progress day not needed just yet. So
back news way we're tied 4-4 scores tell
the full story though as Grappler is
pretty ahead on board and Grappler is
saying you know the longer this goes the
worse it gets for you need to dig out
now Mu if you want to try and get back
into this game
>> being said we are uh getting close to
time we are under 3 minutes
>> score is 44 so we go into turns winning
by two is the win condition
>> Kaisa available but that looks like a
split being lined up.
>> Here's mine splitter.
>> Well, take the pogers.
>> Yeah. So, uh, one card draws five. One
cards draws one. One rune, then one and
then one.
That being said, progress day is most of
a turn. So,
>> yeah, it's it's one whole turn. Uh,
grappler's going back up to six runes.
One whole turn to have a full grip of
cards. Yep.
>> And, uh, takes the progress day. All
right. Pass it back. So, Pora will hold.
Go to five. can freely go to six here,
which is a magic number.
>> Two runes and a draw.
>> What's off the top?
>> Two minutes left.
>> Third call of the week. Likely ends the
game on the spot.
All right,
>> Grabber and Apora. So, Grabber's going
to come down and you'll get another look
for maybe that call, that game ending
call. Yep.
>> All right. So, Grabber
and cycle three and draw. Got to pay the
one also.
Again, players trying to go fast here.
So,
>> draw card. What's the pickup? Is it the
draw that will send Grappler into the
seven and two bracket with Lux?
Looks like not yet. So, here comes the
recruit taking over Targon's Peak going
up to six. The all important six.
>> Holding is backing out. Armor is making
some recruits. All right, so this might
be the turn.
No knockout blow, but still a great
spot.
>> Yeah, Grappler having a real might total
now. I mean, this is this is eight might
on the back line. That's actually
something that can be threatening.
>> Yep.
>> Going forward. And if he just develops
the other poor we knew in hand,
>> 10 might.
>> Pretty good.
>> So, six to four and we are closing into
what might be the start of turns. 30
seconds left.
>> Splitter ready. Yeah,
>> bunch of runes.
Mew
trying to get out of this one.
>> Yeah, we can confidently
say with this clock that this will be
turn zero, but it does feel like we are
going to get a conclusion here. Three
turns to go.
Mind splitter goes in.
>> All right. So, goes up to five. Um, you
know, which is all well and good, but
six is the number the view is really
looking for
trigger for
>> going to draw the Draven.
>> Point out the Tar guns.
>> And now our now, just to be totally
clear, our onscreen round clock is not
always exactly aligned with the judges
table round clock. So, it's possible
have a little bit longer.
So, I got this turn.
>> See if we can get our judges to maybe
uh, you know, put the turn counter up.
It looks they're talking it through now.
>> So, either way, I think at this, you
know, with still a lot of turn to go,
you're correct. This is going to be turn
zero. So, we've got three remaining
turns. At the conclusion of those three
turns, if a player is winning by two,
they win the game. Otherwise, it's a
draw. Grappler on six. It's going to be
hard to to not have a natural
conclusion, you know.
So seven to five is the only possible
outcome of a of a non-conclusion of the
game.
>> Yeah, we knew his uh his hand was kind
of worthless, but Grappler does have 10
might, which is
>> quite good. And there's a lot of spells
that are out that could come off the
top.
>> Yep.
>> And they could turn into another spell,
right? If it's a five cost like a drag
under turning into a a call the week and
that's a very easy conclusion to the
game, but two calls already played. It's
going to be tough to find the third.
>> All right, so Kai accelerates and now we
got MWA 6. So, this game will either end
in a draw or end at a natural
conclusion.
Going back grappler's way, huge turn.
That being said, there are five runes
available from MW. So, this is the the
turn of the game 100%. Six recruits, two
plundering porros, the armory, a gold, a
garbage grabber, and then an
allimportant card off the top. Eight
runes available. Still has seven after
the garbage grabber draw.
That still leaves drag under call. I'll
drag under hidden blade a five and a
two.
>> Singularity looking pretty good here
also.
>> Singularity can be quite good. Deals
with the Kai'Sa allows a recruit to
potentially trade minds spplitter.
>> Yep.
>> You can always just push more too if you
feel like you kill it.
>> So, and then grappler is on six. So,
possibly going for lethal here.
>> And there's a singularity. Oh boy.
>> Hard bargain going to be
>> repeated. So, no thank you. Um got to
pay four more for that one if you want.
So, huge play from you. And now with
only one rune left, MW is effectively
exhausted. There isn't really much you
could have for one. So now you get down
to that math problem like you've been
talking about. So we got recruits
plundering Porros. Two runes left.
It's going to be a start of cycle some
cards. Go to the garbage grabber. Only
one is really stupify, right?
>> It looks like grabber to maybe find a
hidden card and then you push on a
Kai'Sa and just hide. Yep. and then put
everything onto the sigil and just say I
will hold against whatever you do.
>> Yep. And with uh with all the units in
play and the armory as well, it'll be a
lot to push through. So to work it
through.
>> So we knew it was 10 might going in. So
if you just trade efficiently, you can
keep six might there.
Add three more from the armory. That's
only nine might. You know, ride the wind
on this mindspplitter or some kind of a
tide turner shenanigans fight or flight.
I mean, that's already most of the
might. So, a hidden card would be very
impactful to look for the hold plan.
All right, Grappler working it through.
This is the turn of the game in more
ways than one.
Officially turn one of extra turns.
Taking it through. Not a lot of cards in
hand for Draven, but enough to be
threatening.
Okay. So,
>> going to start out looking like offering
the trade. You got to look at that card.
You just flashed or
>> No, I didn't. I missed it.
>> Okay. So,
thinking about just sending in the four
recruits to start off with the trade
there. They're almost in. Nope.
Nearly there. I I like doing the poros.
I think keeping
even more resilience into like rebuke or
fight orflight being just kind of
actively bad cards. Yep.
>> Uh not even letting them be worth two
value. I I agree with sending the porros
here and then just utilize the recruits.
>> Yep. So you're saying on the following
turn if uh if Mu wants to push through.
So yeah, there's that trade. Recruit in
recycle go to seven and the remaining we
have five recruits left and here we go.
So going for the hold play. Five
recruits joined the sigil. Here are
three more thanks to the armory. So you
have nine total recruits on sigil on
seven trying to hold. Meu also going to
hold the seven. We're going to have
quite the photo finish here.
>> Didn't find a hidden card. Yep. Look
forward with the garbage grabber.
Doesn't find it. So this is all in nine
might.
>> Can Mu beat nine?
>> You going to ready? Going to go to seven
on the hold. We have seven to seven.
About as tight as a game can possibly
be.
and
>> so slight judge clarification here.
>> I'm exactly sure it was being asked.
So there's the draw. We see Switcheroo
not not so good here. Um
>> Darius
>> Darius is quite good. I mean Darius
Not quite there. Darius Axe would do it.
That is 10 to go over the nine.
>> Yeah, need Darius. You need Darius
>> plus fighterflight. Darius plus
Tide Turner or Darius plus axe.
All do this from seven.
>> Yep. So
>> they can bring the splitter back with
the fighter flight or the tide turner
and go in with Darius and make 14 or the
axe makes 10.
>> Yep. This is going into nine. But I
didn't see any of those cards alongside
the Darius in the hand. And there's no
way to dig.
All right, got to work it through. It's
got to be this turn.
There's an army of recruits holding down
the fist. Wow, not enough. Holy moly.
Grappler takes it down. Lux goes up to
seven and two in an unbelievable match.
Really, really cool stuff seeing this
Lux like in action. Um, seeing this kind
of control roll with the the recruit
tokens. Fantastic stuff. And uh cool to
see too, you know, very very human side
of that match too. There were a little
bit, you know, was a mistake or two on
both sides uh of the pressure of the
match, but it's not about making a
mistake. It's about who can make less
mistakes, who can power through. Really,
really good match. Great stuff. Lux
moves to 7-2, Grappler moves to 7-2.
That was awesome.
>> Yeah, still, you know, deep in that race
for the Lux best of is Grappler at that
7-2 score. Uh it it is a fight. I know
some Lux players have had some really
great success. uh the deck really, you
know, coming into its own in Spirit
Forge. I think Vanguard Armory being a
really important addition that it
needed. And on top of that, what we've
kind of found with this set is one of
the most potent removal combinations is
that Bellow's Breath with the Watcher.
And because you're adding order, you get
to add Decree as another out for the
Bellow's Breath. You know, where we see
things like Ezreal utilizing that
Bellow's Breath to also make full board
wipes. Bell's breath, a card that I
think a lot of people were like looking
at like, "Wow, that seems really
expensive to do something that isn't
quite going to kill things cuz damage
isn't permanent." And then people
started finding the combo. It's like,
"Oh, wait. This card is uh a little
cracked."
>> Yeah, a lot of combos with that one. Of
course, boy gate as well. But we're
going to hop down and talk to Grappler
about that win and see how he's feeling.
>> Hey guys, I'm here with Grappler after
an awesome round nine. I saw that you
were playing Lux. How are you feeling
today?
>> Um, kind of jetlagged, a lot of flying.
But I'm feeling pretty good. I'm
enjoying myself. And I played kind of
bad the first game. I think maybe I was
a bit nervous, but second and third game
I came back into it and I got it.
>> Awesome. What made you choose to play
Lux?
>> She gets people to rage quit online and
uh people don't like having their units
removed.
>> Mhm.
>> And I figured it's my play style and
I'll bring her and see how I do.
>> Awesome. Well, it's definitely working
out for you. You're already in round
nine. Have another win now. Is it seven
and two?
>> Seven and two. Yes. That is so awesome.
How are you enjoying being at the venue?
>> I love the venue. Um, first I'm in
Vegas. Pretty fun. Air is a little dry,
but other than that, I have absolutely
no complaints. It's been a blast.
>> That is so awesome. Is there anyone you
want to shout out today?
>> Shout out all my friends from Legends of
Run Terra. What's up, guys? Uh, my my
chat, my stream. Hope you guys are
watching. And, uh, I want to shout out
especially Kooie. He gave me some
coaching because I've only been prepping
for about 10 days. And, uh, he helped a
ton. good guy.
>> Well, awesome. Thank you so much and we
are so uh happy to get to watch you
play. Uh and I hope you have a great day
and good luck in the future rounds.
>> All right. Thank you very much.
>> Really, really awesome stuff here in
round number nine of the Las Vegas
regional qualifier. We got so much more
to go. We players going into top eight
best of again. Grappler there looking
pretty good with the Lux best of. We
don't know the exact records and Lux
players there are. We'll we'll check. Uh
but really really cool stuff. Yeah, I
mean it was I think Grapp had his one
mistake that he immediately recognized
on the the Vanguard Armory for getting
to to capitalize on that and then for
the rest of the time I'm looking at this
and it's just a lot of really clean
clear uh clears. He's seeing he's seeing
the lines that he needs to. He's finding
the most efficient ways to remove the
enemy units and that's what Lux gets to
do. That is how she needs to function
and we're seeing why he's seven and two.
He's finding uh the angles that he needs
against these ravens.
>> Great stuff and that that's part of good
play too is not just playing well but
mistakes are going to happen. Being able
to shake it off still play awesome the
rest of the match and a great thing to
see. So, that's going to wrap up round
nine here. We have a very, very short
break. Coming back in for round number
10 in just a little bit.
Heat. Heat.
your journey in Riftbound starts at your
local Nexus Knights. Casual, super
awesome environment where you can go
play, whether you're learning to play or
prepping for bigger events. Super
awesome experience. I love playing Nexus
Knights. They're fantastic. You can find
yours at
locator.ribbound.uvsgames.com/events
or scan the QR code.
All right, welcome back to the booth
here for round number 10 of the
Riftbound qualifier in Las Vegas. I'm
Jim Davis. That's Kasanova. That last
round was uh was a heater.
>> Oh, yeah. I mean, I I we got to see Rexi
on camera. You know, you're always a
little sad to see the underdog deck
lose, but it was still really well
piloted by Shisel on the other side, and
it shows why he's 9 and0. And you know,
the Rex eye still showing the the cracks
that happen with the less meta decks
where sometimes they're not quite as
consistent, but still getting to
showcase the power of what it can pull
off. And I think that was a lot of fun.
Same with the Lux, right? It did win
against the Draven. And you get to see
the power when it really comes out with
the big removal from something like the
Bella's breath.
>> Yeah, awesome stuff. Really, really cool
seeing Rexi Lux and uh and many, many
more. But we want to see some more spicy
brews. You're going to go check them out
and uh give us this little skinny
Is there any uh spicy brew or deck that
you've been trying to make work but
haven't quite been able to get it there?
>> Uh I do a lot of thinking about Garen,
of course.
>> Uh I've been playing Aurora Garen. I've
been playing hook Garen. I've been
playing mid-range Garen, but Aurora is
really what calls to me because I love
just putting big dumb idiots into play
every turn.
>> I cannot stop cursing Promising Future.
I love that card. It's really stupid.
I've tried it in Lux. I'm currently
playing it in Ranata. I've been brewing
with Rumble and Promising Future. Like,
I'm desperate to make this card good.
So, uh I don't know. I love playing with
the card. I think it's super fun. I
don't think it's good. Do not try this
at home, but uh yeah, Promising Future.
I'm committed to trying to make work for
a long time. I think maybe maybe never
it'll be good, but oh well. At one point
I was working on a dragon uh Volibear
deck that was playing like Minotaur and
like Fervent Forerunner and like the the
Herald of the is it herald of the dragon
or something like that that like cost
the dragons less and trying to play a
mid-range game as Voli Bear. Uh
>> and then I got cooked by Draven like
three times in a row at locals and I was
like all right never mind. I'm playing
I'm playing miracles. So yeah, I hope
that deck gets better in the future.
>> The problem is so like I got orange to
get pretty far pretty far. I convinced
prismaticism for a little while to be
playing it and then Brin here
thunderslong became like a new tech and
that card destroys Lauren and it's I
can't figure out how to beat that card.
So that's where I'm at.
>> I think Rexai is so cool. Like uh I got
my void rushes. I haven't got to play
with it much yet. Uh but I think like
conceptually like so much fun. I know
it's not doing super great right now. Uh
but like just the idea of just drawing
cards and making man double spelling and
stuff and then just having this this
engine on your legend that can always
provide more cards is like super fun.
I'm just going to play it as soon as I
get a chance to.
>> Whenever we were testing Project K back
in the very beginning, I was on Aurora.
I was trying Aurora stuff. I would
really like to make Aurora work in any
orange deck that people don't suspect
it. There's you're going to see a very
spicy list from No Veggies this weekend
who's on an Aurora list that we've been
we've been doing a little cook on.
>> Azir is my favorite. I've been playing a
lot of Azir, especially with the shears
now in the deck. uh absolutely in love
with that deck and I want to see it do
super super super well.
>> I actually do have a brew of ranata
after looking at all the uh bests both
in China and Bolognia. I do think people
have been pigeonhold on the orange. I
think playing or is a good approach but
you don't want to go all in on the so I
have a brew. I hope it works. I'm going
after the best of. We'll see what
happens. I think that I have tried to
make a miracle tee deck work for a while
now and it's not it's not good. It turns
out hiding a secret to draw two cards
when every other deck says draw two
cards is not good.
>> Fair enough. All right. Well, thank you
so much for the interview. It was great
and good luck in the event.
>> I just love seeing players just so
excited about the legend. they really
really love, you know, and it's such a
cool part of card gaming, such a cool
part of the best of in these events, you
know, where a player can feel
comfortable. Okay,
>> I don't think my my or my team deck has
a chance to win the tournament, but I
think I can go on a great run and I can
go try and get that best up and have
this cool side quest to go on inside of
the main event, which is so cool.
>> That's just me preaching Leona all of
Origins, you know, like please try it.
It's really fun. It's it's it's not that
bad. I swear
>> I was Jinx here uh in Houston. I tied
for the best.
>> Ouch. Yeah. So, let's take a look at our
metag game for day number two here, our
conversion race from day one to day two
and see what players brought to the
tournament.
Look at that. Okay, so right up top,
Draven, that has to be expected.
>> Yeah, I mean, insane conversion rate,
right? 34% converting is crazy, but
that's what you expect out of the, you
know, best deck in the room. I think
Aurelia doing quite well, uh, with that
14% as well. And then, you know, I think
the big surprises for me are going to be
that Rexai Inv 5% conversion rate, not
too shabby, pretty solid conversion rate
overall. I think a lot of people are
going to look at this Ezreal conversion
and be like, "Wait, what what happened?
Why? This this deck is really good,
isn't it? Just one Bolognia." You'd be
right. The deck is very good. It might
even be the best deck in the entire
game, in the entire room. It is
incredibly tough to pilot and I think if
people were pivoting to it last minute
after seeing the Bolognia win.
Unfortunately, I didn't think they were
going to have a very good time and we're
seeing that in the numbers.
>> Yeah, absolutely. And it's also the
issue of draws. Ezreal is a slow deck.
So, you need to not only play the deck
well, but proficiently and quickly. And
that's a very challenging thing to do
once you have a ton of time to invest
and the talent to play it. So, any of
the big surprises here at the the bottom
of this list? We got Or down there
hanging out like that.
>> I mean, the other big thing is the best
of race at that point, right? So, oh
wow, a lot of these there's still a few
people vying. We just saw Grappler on
the Lux. There's two others that are
maybe,
but you know, there's some Ranata Glass
player and Yasu player that have earned
some congratulations. If they're the
only one who have uh converted, then
they must have won their best of.
>> Yep. So, and of course, unfortunately,
Leona, Rumble, Leon, and Garen are are
low holdouts uh not making day two and
uh but hopefully they got a best of in
there in day one. And I believe in uh in
Bolognia, we had all Legends make day
two, right?
>> No, Leona did not.
>> Okay. Yeah.
>> Okay. Well, that's really cool to see
that most of Legends baited here. And uh
we got some uh some more games for you.
Want to watch some more games?
>> Yeah, I guess so. Yeah, I I suppose I'd
be down for, you know, just a few more
games. I think it's a treat. It'd be
nice to have
>> a couple more games. I'm seeing Allen's
EQ sitting down in the feature match
area,
>> still undefeated on his Ezreal on the
other side. Yeah, we got to play with
the challenger TCG.
>> That's John Ross. Oh,
>> old old Magic Pro currently at 8 and one
playing Draven. But we're going to watch
Linanity.
We just saw Lux. Now we get to see
Victor kind of a similar spell pool with
a slightly different twist. And uh
Victor we've seen on camera a number of
times already.
>> Yeah, League of Legends player.
Linsanity had a a decent League of
Legends career across his time. Going to
be on more of the ghostaster driver
version. Playing a little bit more low
the ground main deck pick pockets. has
the Synows in the main as a three of a
lot of these lower cost units ready to
go. A bit more tempo style than the full
spell, but still leaning on you know the
singularities and uh you know the some
of the late game threats. The bellow's
breath Imperial got with the cre combo
right as well. Just a few more units.
Interesting to see here. So there
there's definitely less big spells but
there is a time warp a card we've not
seen a lot here in this two metag game.
Yeah, it's scary into purple, right? You
know, this is hard bargain fodder if
I've ever seen it. But you can still
create game states where your opponent
is not allowed to hold up those two
runes and the time warp can still find
you the win. I think you have to be less
greedy with it. I think time warp not to
go from six to eight, but instead to
take the tempo of the game at some point
earlier is often better suited cuz your
opponent won't be playing around it when
you're on lower runes and it can still
create very strong board states for you
and score you a lot of points. also a
cool way to use all of his gold tokens,
you know, on for that hefty hefty power
cost. So that's player number one,
Lynsanity and Victor will be going up
against awesome Rossom playing Draven.
Yeah, we've seen quite a few players on
this detonate version of Draven. Now it
was Will Pullium on the previous day
that we saw playing this. I know there
is a team that worked together to build
this with the treasure troves, the scrap
heaps, and the detonates to destroy them
to continue to draw faster. Uh what I've
been told by these players that are on
this version is they think it is like a
turn or two faster than the other
version of Miracle Draven when it comes
to kind of getting all of the tools that
you need to build the huge board. Yeah.
And basically the one of Vi here, of
course, big player in set one metag
game. Vi here uh being used almost less
as a threat and more as an engine, a
utility piece, being able to recycle
cards uh at will. Normally when you
recycle a bunch of cards, you they're
randomized. You can't exactly stack
them. with Vi because it's a single
ability. You can go one at a time, put
the cards exactly as you want them, and
get back through your deck.
>> Yeah, really nice once you have maybe
the Rosses or the battering rams in the
bin in some of your long matches against
decks with a lot of removal tools.
Victors sometimes like that. This
version of Victor, not so much. It's
going to be a bit faster of a Victor
build. I don't expect us to be going
second, third cycle of going through the
deck and putting them back to the bottom
for this miracle deck is likely to be
more of a first cycle game. you know,
one chance at all these Rosses, one
chance at all these battering rams, and
using all the might to win because
Victor tends to be a little too fast
when it is that tempo style. All right,
so let's get to our featur get down to
our feature match area. Victor versus
Draven, round 10, regional qualifier,
Las Vegas. You got Jim and Cass in the
booth for you. Ready to bring it to you.
Awesome Rossom on the right. Awesome
Ross is an accomplished Magic the
Gathering player. Uh a lot of great
results in Magic and I think like you
said working with a lot of those
players. Will Pium uh Daryl is working
on this kind of VI version of Draven
starting on Zan Warren and then Linanity
on Victor starting on Voidgate.
>> Voidgate and ZH Warren to kick things
off. Zon Warren the easy start when you
are playing that miracle Draven. You
want to be able to bin those scrap heaps
with the Warrens, draw the extra cards
as we do see a trove detonate start and
it looks like that is what Os wants to
see. I mean, that is kind of the crux of
the deck as you're playing these early
gear that you want to be destroying with
the detonate.
>> Is this a new uh version of his deck or
was it a deck similar to this plate of
balonia?
>> Oh, this is a new tech. Yeah, the the
idea behind the trove detonate uh to go
alongside this grab heap is something
that is is brand new to what we're
seeing here in Vegas. This team put this
together. They've had some pretty good
success so far, of course, right?
Awesome at 8 and1. I know some of his
teammates are still alive, either Xin1,
X2, or X11. Uh so the deck is performing
quite well for them as the new a new
idea when it comes to Miracle Draven.
Whether or not it is the best version or
not remains to be seen, but it's working
quite well to kick things off. Yeah,
Rossam lost to Allen last round.
>> Okay, so you know,
>> I mean, that's fair. Everybody loses to
Allen.
>> Yep. So,
>> and I'm not going to hearken back to my
prediction, you know, on Friday of
saying you might see uh some new tech in
Draven doing well in the tournament, but
you know, oh, I mentioned it. Oops,
sorry. Yeah, my my bad.
>> It is.
>> So, Merchant comes in. We see blood
money. That is a pretty cool one. Kill
unit at a battlefield two might or less.
And if it was an enemy unit, get a gold.
If you kill your own, you get two. So,
Merchant gets to do the move trigger,
uh, but does not get the conquer or Z
warren. Pretty awesome play uh for
Lynsanity or getting a recruit and then
being able to have that kill.
>> Yep. And just as normal with this kind
of Draven build, uh, turn two, you're
just going to go Draven go. I mean, it's
it's two drop, go, Draven, go, and then
we start to look to combo off. That that
is no different from the other versions
of Miracle Draven. It's just the way
that you start to combo off is a little
different. You've added additional ways
to draw more with the treasure trove
detonate combo that can still work with
scrap heap if you've played out a scrap
heap instead of discarded it. So it's
just taking out more might from the deck
by removing things like the knock turns.
Yeah. Take or you're taking out some
more of the combat tricks and playing
more one of the combat tricks and
instead you cycle the deck faster and
you find the battery rams. You're more
consistent at just battery ramming uh
early on. So you're just doing the might
thing more consistently, but you're
losing ceiling with knock turns and
you're losing interactability with some
amount of tricks versus some of the
other versions. You're just consistent
and fast and always playing a lot of
might.
>> As if these decks didn't have enough
card draw. Here's the week. Col has
looked pretty awesome on camera in the
last few matches we have watched out of
both Lux and Victor. Call takes down
Draven. Goodbye to the recruit. One
point for Linsanity here taking on
Warren. And now we have a one zero lead
going into Rossim's turn. Six runes
available and now we're going to see if
we can find that big huge explosive
fireworks turn. Here's a trove.
>> Yeah, looks like he says it's go time
because the detonate is going to come
down. So this is uh two cards played on
the count so far. You get a rune back,
you get to draw three cards, two for the
detonate, one for the trove. Three runes
left. I did see a called shot found. So
that can start to get you towards
the cast of these battering rams.
Seal called shot would put you at four
and then you could still play all three
rams. Instead, it's just going to be a
ram for three. That's a pretty rough
>> initial start. But the nice thing about
this is the trove refunds the power cost
of the detonate. So the turn three go
off with a called shot, maybe a seal,
maybe an Ezreal or or turn four go off
is still on the table. And so I kind of
like the mini attempt here and then look
to re like while you still have all your
runes and then look to spend your runes
when you go to eight runes instead of
six. Don't need to up the tempo too fast
just yet. Yeah. So kind of a fizzle but
not a fizzle where the resources were
all burned. They're still in hand. So we
see Victor leader play from a champ
zone. Another recruit and just a pass
back. So Ross once again gets a chance
to go out. It's going to go for Z warns
first to filter it and try and make that
hand absolutely perfect.
>> Yeah, he had drawn a scrap heap on the
last turn. So, I think this might have
been the the indication for this go.
Maybe not having an Ezreal yet and then
uh potentially just finds it here. I saw
another scrap heap just grabbed off the
top. So, this is going to be scrap heap
discard off of Warren. Scrap heap
discard off of Ezreal. Draw a billion
cards. There's another scrap heap in
hand if there's another discard or
something that needs to go down as we
are going to get the stack deck. He
needs a seal. I think he's missing a
seal or else we would have seen it
before the Ezreal. And he does have the
called shot. So, I really think he wants
to find this first seal. Play it before
he goes called shot. And then we're
looking for the rest of the battering
rams. We're getting towards Rossa.
There's already eight cards in the bin.
The combo is here. And I like comboing
not just on turn three always. Sometimes
you can take that slow setup and then go
for a bigger combo. And we'll see how
much might he can actually get on the
board.
>> Like the crispness here of Rosam's play
too. Uh clearly very very well practiced
this deck and important to be playing
fast cuz there are so many game actions.
So here's a seal. Found that too. So
looks like it might have everything
going here. Here's called shot with that
cost reduction from Ezreal. Top two take
one.
>> Yeah, there was battering ram but I
think it was next to a cold shot. So I'm
not sure which he decided to take.
>> Cold shot went to the bottom. So
>> okay. So is the ram then
>> that that speaks to being kind of all
rolled up here, right?
>> Yeah. Well, as I was saying, this is
generally a first cycle match up, right?
Like you you don't want to put the ram
to the bottom to just like find later
with that second call. So you actually
don't have to dig as deep. You just need
to find the units at this certain point.
So uh there is some slight consideration
if you overdevelop though into Victor
and that's one thing you have to always
be careful of if you don't know the
version going in because if you think
Lynsanity is on full spell Victor the
main thing you're looking for is the
three of bellow's breath with the three
of decree and you cannot overdevelop
into it or you immediately lose the
game. All right so here's merchant
and a ram
and more followup. Another rams all
three rams.
>> Okay
>> and a hidden card
>> decree bellows. Yeah. So,
not the best, you know, considering that
was a turn four, a turn three. Could
have maybe been a little more explosive
and now a bit exposed as well. So, go
back Lanity's way and we got to see
there are some serious pitfalls here if
the combo has been found.
>> I think I saw a decree at the back of
this hand, but I don't see a bellows.
It's a singularity. Singularity not too
bad here also.
>> Yeah, also good removal deal two rams.
Yeah, this kind of like hybrid version
that Ghostaster Driver popularized at
Bolognia feels pretty good for the
Victor the more I've been seeing it
where it's like you take some of the the
best spells from the like all spell
Victor list that was popping off in
China very early on but then you just
play the very good efficient units um
and it still helps you kind of play both
ways where you can be very aggressive
but you can still do really cool things
with voidgate and uh create some really
good opportunities for yourself is
pickpocket in the main going to be
eating up the seal
>> big game so big tech car for this event
against all of these miracle decks. Got
to make a gold and got to make us a
recruit and looks like no big spell this
turn. It's going to be
it's that one.
>> Yep. Syninja going to have to ready.
>> Sinja coming in and we got that hidden
card with the battering ram. What are
your thoughts on that hidden card?
>> Uh I mean it is just likely to be fight
or flight I would imagine. Yep. uh
generally within this I mean in tide
turner would be the other option but I
don't remember seeing those in this
deck. I think that the because of the
detonate uh package everything it's too
tight. So you're you're basically just
on the traveling merchant to help you
still kind of cycle some of those gear
as we see yeah some being thrown away.
>> Right. So discard on the merchant coming
to the void gate scoring a point now
three to two in Rosom's favor and stack
deck once again. Fighter flight trove
>> deserve a bu. Okay.
>> You'll start cutting them. Yeah sure.
>> So ling going to start cutting the uh
the cards going to the bottom. Now,
whenever you recycle cards more than
one, they must be randomized. And you
know, there is this is a deck where you
most time it's not relevant, you know,
uh but this is a deck where it will be
relevant. We will see possibly going
through the deck again. So, going to
give a shuffle.
>> Yeah, I think Lynn recognizing that his
strategy is going to be a little bit
slower in this game. And because he was
not racing points, it's very likely that
we actually do get that second cycle
that I was saying, hey, maybe we don't
get in this matchup where Victor likes
to be a little bit more aggressively
removing your board and then just
pushing for the points and and putting a
time pressure on you. But instead, Lynn
likes to play this match up, it seems,
in a more controlling style. And I I
actually think the setup is looking good
based on what we're seeing from the
hand, right? The singularities. a lot of
ways to keep kind of culling away at
this board while still having I mean
look look at all this might that you
know Lynn has been able to uh compile as
well on on his base. So definitely
something to look out for as Rosson may
need to actually utilize that vi later
on to to restack batter rams and go off
again. We might even see this happen in
this game. So here's a trove. The churn
keeps on churning.
Two rams in the back row. Both bases
already uh up the home. All right. Well
there's that combo again. So detonate on
the trove, draw three, get a
>> rune draw.
>> One, two, three. So many cards in hand.
>> Yeah, another detonate found as well if
there is another trove, but I think one
got ditched earlier, so we'll see if
that rots for a little bit in hand. Gold
can also help. Seals can help. Anything
if you're afraid of the pick pockets.
>> Always cast a heap if you have to also.
>> Yeah, you can always cast a heap. But he
does have another Ezreal in hand, so
odds are heap doesn't get cast. Instead,
you just kind of go for the Ezreal on
it.
>> Sure. So see some reinforcements here.
So the ram goes to join the merchant at
the void gate. Interest place to be with
the void gate giving additional damage.
Any units uh spell damage would happen
there. And uh ram number three is going
to stay home. So we have a bit of a
split here. Ram merchant and void gate.
Hidden guard and ram on warren. And then
ram and ezro in the back row
goinganity's way. Pick up a draw. Lots
of runes. Lots of stuff in play.
>> A little rude.
>> Smart but rude.
>> Players having fun. A little little
left. It's good to see players be able
to, you know, recognize the the
importance of a match like this. Still,
we're still playing a game. Having fun
and not having fun with Singularity's
cast, though. Singularity's in. Six
damage, two targets. It's going to be
battering ram at the uh Ooh, okay.
Battering ram at the zon wars and
battering ram at the void gate.
>> The axe will come in and defend the ram,
bringing ram up to eight points.
>> They're playing at a a fervent pace.
>> Yeah, they both know.
>> Like I'm calling a hockey game right
now. It's kind of cool. They're both no
errors for sure that this is going to be
a long one
>> as there is six damage dealt to this
battering ram.
Still some might on the back line for
Linsanity that can push into this to try
and still clean up the ram and to deal
with the spinning axe. Just has to find
the right amount to send in though
because of this hidden card. And if you
send in, and this is just a fighter or
flight, which is kind of what we
expecting, it's just going to be used to
send the battering ram back home, and
then it'll heal from the combat.
>> Yep.
>> Yeah, saving that axe is pretty huge. Uh
that that might buff against these
damage based rule spells is pretty
hefty. So, we're going to see. Looks
like the two recruits coming in just
going to try and finish off. Nope. Hold
on. Yeah, if you send the two recruits
as the minimum amount of damage that you
need to deal,
then there is an issue of this fighter
flight pushing one of them and the
battering ram still being able to heal.
The same problem happens here.
>> Yeah. So, fighterfight on pickpocket
would push this back. Here's fighter
flight on pickpocket.
>> He's going to choose picpocket. I wonder
if Lani has the punish.
>> Oh, maybe.
>> And I and I assume so, which is why he
goes for the swing in this way. The
punish is going to be that stupify. And
I think maybe a little bit of greed from
Awesome Raw Awesome here to to try and
like hold that because I think you maybe
at this point on the 8-1 table need to
assume that your opponent is doing this
for a reason, but it could be a bluff,
right?
>> Great setup. Yeah, that that that was a
really high level exchange. Uh, awesome
stuff. So, works out for Lynsanity. See
the recruit coming to Zorns
Voyate taken as well.
And now I mean the might on Rossam's
board has been declining and of course
the axe going to fade away the end of
turn. Ezreal and Ram now of course this
deck is very good at rebuilding
repopulating getting things back in
play.
But Lindsy in the driver's seat.
>> Yeah I mean this has been just
impeccable Victor play so far. I really
like he's now looking at the point tempo
up to four to the three. So he's gained
that lead as well. Generally the Victor
deck, you know, wants to play pretty
aggressively with points and put the
clock on, but I think Lanity recognized
a hand that was very controlling and
instead just looked to develop a lot of
might, keep a a safe amount of point
tempo, not trying to force anything too
quickly and feed a bunch of draws. Uh,
and now he recognizes that, okay, I can
go four into six very easily over these
next two turns while limiting the amount
of board pressure that Awesome Awesome
has. And I think this has been very
effective and we'll see how the rest of
the hand works out. think there's still
that decree there that we I we thought
we saw one earlier and that's going to
be very effective if we start to see
those roses be deployed. All right, so
Ram is in. Uh is that four cards in hand
for Lynn? Just putting the hand on the
table.
>> Yeah, I believe so.
>> Okay, cool. So called shot energy
floating taking that seal is pretty big
too. Putting Ross in a bit more of a
squeeze.
And there's there's a replacement seal.
Okay, so right on time and once again
trying to go through that big turn now.
The rams are all gone, right? So we have
the two rams that are in the trash. Uh
no cycling them back in just yet.
>> You need like shovel.
>> So what is the next step?
>> Rosameir, I think feeling the pressure a
bit of being behind and slowing down a
little bit
trying to find the right way out. And
there you go. There is the shovel.
And on that Ezreal and with Linsanity
effectively exhausted, you know, one
rune left.
>> Ezreal is free to play.
What's the effect of a shovel here?
>> So the call shots get to go back in. I
actually don't have the count on this
turn for how many cards he played, but
you can still just bring back the
battering rams once you go in and
conquer. Should still have that cost
reduction.
>> So last rights is the air quotes the
shovel. This is when I conquer hold. may
play a unit from your trash. Gives a
plus two bonus as well. Great late game
tool for this deck. Here's Rosaunder.
>> Yep. Free Rossa. I think that was
probably needed for his count to be able
to get the battering ram. So, he plays
it pre-combat.
>> Yep. So, coming in, Ezreal takes down
his recruit. Takes Zon Warren. Ross up
to five. Zon Warren's trigger.
Missed the discard. A little off screen
here.
>> And now we have the last rights trigger.
And it's play from trash. You must play
it immediately. This is not going not
going into your hand. It's got to be
played immediately. Hence like you were
saying with the cost reduction for the
batting ram. So there's the ram. One
floating energy spent. And uh pretty
good rebuild so far. Yeah. Draw for
Draven first. Then he had the discard
and draw from the zone warrants.
>> Then we get the last race trigger. Play
the battering ram.
And now it's about trying to keep
recurring these rams with the the
shovel. And that's where you you really
want to find some gear destruction from
the side of Linsanity 4 dealing with
this. This is a lot of the potency on
this miracle deck. It's you get all of
this value on the board early. As it
trades down, you then recur that value
while your opponent runs out of
resources.
>> All right, so I see Imperial Decree in
hand.
These recruits are lining up.
>> Yeah, one one Bellow still goes crazy
here.
>> Yep. Yeah, game was looking pretty good
for Insanity. Now it's gotten a little
more dire, but plenty of cards in hand
and like you said with Bell's Breath,
you know, trying to find that combo.
>> Wow.
>> Yeah, just, you know, five cards left.
>> Look, they were telling me they're a
couple turns faster on on on the cycle
and I'm seeing it with the detonates,
right? I mean, like it it's really nice
when you get to the stage because you
start putting things back at the bottom
with the shovel and then you know
exactly what they are. So, you usually
just put like a called shot and then
you'll start putting things that you
want. So then you can call shot and then
grab the exact cards that you're looking
for uh every single time as you go
through.
>> Yeah. Interesting to see because this
game has no library manipulation. There
are no like tutor effects, things like
that. But this is a way to to do that.
You can just kind of put things back in
the order that you want and draw them as
you see fit. So we're going to see a
combat here. Here comes Pickpocket and
two recruits into the VM and once again
fight or flight.
>> Going to back out the pick pocket and we
see W. So sure
>> really efficient. Yeah, another great
use where getting Rosson to burn a fight
or flight in a not a very efficient uh
use of resources. Saves the pickpocket
also uh and then takes down his ram,
makes a treasure, gets to go in and
conquer again. Great clean play by
Lindsity. I'm very impressed. He has a
time warp in hand. We were talking about
this card and how its effect can happen
in this game. Not going to find an
opportunity to cast it here. Only seven
runes remaining.
probably doesn't come up in this game.
So, it ends up being a bit of a dead
card, but it's a bit close. It was the
fact that awesome Mar was able to hold
up two runes meant the time warp
couldn't find a potential spot.
>> Just going to go to five.
>> That is going to allow awesome Rosom to
now take the point tempo and be the
first one to threaten lethal.
>> All right. Yeah, on six.
Lady five, Ross at six.
Here's the draw.
fist full of cards in hand for Ross.
And uh more cards in hand than in deck
>> trying to deck me.
>> And Ross says, "Are you trying to deck
me?" Now, what happens if Ross runs out
of cards?
>> Well, that would be a burnout and he
would have to assign a point to another
player and there is uh only one other
player at the table currently.
>> Can I get a point?
>> I if we were at the table who could have
a point. We can't have a point.
>> Mhm.
>> We'll give you a point later, you know,
for for fun. We'll give you a point, you
know.
>> Cool.
>> You can have a point some other time.
>> All right. I'm on the board. I got a
point. Here comes Roso Gate taking down
the recruit. Rosam up to seven and seal
off a seal and keep things rolling.
>> Is that bushwack?
>> Yeah, this for this. I'm paying two
immediately with a red
>> and no, the VI.
>> Okay, so
>> you were talking about this.
>> So, this is Yeah, this is kind of the
the core of this deck. just one copy of
Vi. Now Rossam has the ability to
recycle any card uh in any order that
Ross wants. So usually we see Vi, you
know, with Ride the Wind in set one
doing this big, you know, crazy attack,
but this is a combo piece. This is a the
ability to stack so few cards now. No
burnout possible cuz Vi can keep putting
things in. Uh this is kind of awesome.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Put the exact cards that you
want to find. He's going to put a
battery in the ram back. Keep one in the
bin
>> for shovel. Looks like it's ram then
stack deck then.
>> Yep. And again, these are not
randomized. They are one at a time.
Shortcut can do all four at once. Uh but
>> put them in, stack them up. And now
we're exactly where Ross wants to be uh
with this kind of late game VI setup.
Effectively, Rossam is going to draw the
card that he wants to draw for the rest
of the game.
>> So, seal
and this is where this is a lot of
planning. Uh, a lot of, you know,
plotting out your next few turns. Not
easy to do. Here's a Sunder hopping in
to join the other Sunder at the at the
void gate.
So, Ezreal and the shovel alongside
Battleam at Zon Warren. Double Sunderer
at void gate. Ross is at seven. Insanity
at five.
There goes a ram and stack deck to the
bottom.
>> Yeah, I think he has the dig, but he's
going to just pass it. wants to be able
to hold on to the interaction.
>> No, you're good.
>> Rebukeing hand.
>> All right, so going for the hold at
seven. These are two pretty hefty
battlefields. Lindsanity has a lot of
work to do. Thousand Dale Watcher. Was
that the peel? That was the draw. I'm
not I'm not sure. You know, the decree
is something that we were talking about
all game, but now the board has been
whittleled away on some of these trades,
and the decree is no longer looking that
attractive unless the bellow's breath
was found. Watcher is pretty nice, but
doesn't cleanly clear everything. Uh,
and especially when you see your
opponent has drawn the entire deck and
is holding up four runes, you have to
know there is potential for something
like a rebuke to just immediately deal
with the Watcher if you try and send
that in.
>> Now, warp was in hand, too, right?
>> Yeah, there is warp.
>> So, you can just warp, make a recruit,
and uh try again next turn.
>> Yeah, that is that is a possibility.
>> It's not pretty, but if in a desperation
move. So Lind setting going to work it
through. Yeah, Imperial Degree time warp
and and there it is. All right. So, uh
not the way you usually want to cast a
time warp. Uh this is just going to be
probably effectively, you know, I guess
go down two runes, draw a card. I guess
uh down one rune because of the gold.
>> Yeah. I'm wondering what else he wants
to do with the turn though, cuz he can
still play the rest of the turn before
passing,
>> right? I think he's still looking at
>> the hand and seeing exactly what else
can be found. Can he push in?
>> Take one of these sides. Not really.
>> All right, two energy left. Nope. Hold
on. They get it through.
>> Pickpocket and Victor. Seven total might
now. Okay. They were if they were to
both die in combat, uh the Victor would
still see the pick pocket to make a
token. Correct. Yeah. Uh, no I don't.
>> No. Oh, okay.
>> So, there's there's the hidden blade and
I think that's the consideration now.
>> Okay. So, now Victor Victor and Recruit
heading over to Ezreal and Battering Ram
on ZH Warren.
>> I'm also confused by this. This is five
might. So, even if the hidden blade is
cast
inity has been very adept at laying
traps this, you know, uh kind of gotten
a number of of combats to really go his
way with really patient play. So,
>> I wonder if I'm tunnneled on the hidden
blade. Maybe there's another card he can
go for here, but he just passed it. He
went in and passed and said, "Go ahead,
you move."
>> All right, so we got a trade. So, Victor
down, recruit down, ram down, and
there's a one combat cuz Ezreal is still
hanging out. So, there's a draw for Ross
and Hidden Blade takes out Ezreal. Two
more draws. Now, with these hidden
blades and these draws, uh, burnout is a
possibility.
>> Yeah, but I think the VI already has
stymied any of that. He was on three
cards, but he put seven of them back.
>> Seven. Okay.
>> So, like the total is is very difficult
for Lani to beat. And we see that
fighter flight actually being pretty
high value there, denying Lincerity
going from to six on that last turn. So,
there's not a win in any way, shape, or
form afterwards with this warp.
>> Yeah. So, now we're the warp turn.
Lanity running it back. Just a lowly pit
pocket.
>> Yeah.
>> And Rosson looking pretty comfortable
here. The plan was there. You score with
the pickpocket. You the warp resolve had
resolved. So then you go to seven off
the hold and then you thousand tailed
watcher seven into six on the void gate.
I mean that the the plan was there for
Linsanity to win the game.
>> Oh man.
>> But Rosam's got all of the answers and
he's going to just scoop it up. So I
think Linsanity's plan actually made a
lot of sense there and we get to see
kind of that endgame loop. the once
Miracle is able to draw through the
whole deck, they're able to just set
every plan up. And really well done from
Awesome Ross to really put himself in a
position where he has the answer to
every single thing that Lani could do.
And really the only thing that Lani
could have had to bail himself out would
have been find a bellow's breath to pair
with that decree.
>> Yeah, awesome play on both sides. Just a
really clean, crisp game. And uh the
power of Rosam's deck on full display.
It's kind of hard for Ross to not have
it when he's literally seeing every card
in his deck. So, we're going to go ahead
to game two here. Rossim up a game.
These players are eight and one. Going
to nine and one's a great place to be. 8
and two. You know, now you're putting
things possibly in tiebreers making top
eight. You're still alive. But of
course, I imagine that the Victor best
of is also in play here, too. So, lots
to play for Lynanity. And going to start
things off with Obisk Power versus
Treasure Horde. So, starting off Oblisk
is uh kind of great for uh for Lynanity
with the two drop into recruit turn one
Draven for Rossom going back Lanity's
way. This is something we were talking
about in Bolognia about uh Victor and
you know how did a Victor make top four?
How did this happen? Well, Obisk is very
popular in the metag game and so you can
bring it yourself and get two Obisk
games out of it as Victor or you don't
even have to bring Obelisk in your deck
build because you're going to get a lot
of matchups where you're getting this
free oblisk game going first where you
get to do the Victor thing of two drop
into recruit. And we saw that from
Ghostaster Driver and Bolognia. We see
it from Linsanity here where look at
this. Now, this is more what I was
talking about in game one where I think
this matchup often is a point race. Uh
this time, Linsanity actually has a
start that is going to allow him to try
and at least, you know, bring it to the
miracle side. Don't let Rosom have
infinite time to go through the entire
deck and construct the endame that he
wants.
>> Yeah. So, double conquer Lynn up to two
going back Ross' way. Draven six runes
and uh some you know potentially easy
pickings out there. We saw the gold come
in off of the treasure horde as well.
When you conquer you pay one you make a
gold token. So helpful all those power
costs and now it's time for Draven. So
Draven comes into obelisk challenging
the recruit and okay so we see wages of
pain. So this can only be done after the
draven has resolved. So just the clients
that pay the power and takes a pretty
bad trade. Yeah, I'm curious about the
the no power spend there just because of
the fact that wages exists and uh this
is the answer right here. Yeah, I mean
this is exactly it. Um
>> because it felt like an easy an easy pay
there, right? It's obviously wages,
right? At least that's what you're kind
of thinking when it's three up. Uh but
Ferris 4Runner wanting to be played down
very important in this matchup. A sticky
unit that Victor can't just remove
immediately and deal with everything.
And so Ross recognizing, you know what,
there's a world that I'm just going to
lose my Draven here. But if you don't
have wages, you get very punished and
I'm just going to be able to play a
4Runner afterwards.
>> Yep. So, four runners in and we're going
to see Hidden Blade. This is going to be
target group. Draw two cards.
>> Versatility of Hidden Blade is pretty
sweet.
>> Yeah. Lynn not liking uh the the hand,
not liking what cards
>> he has available to him. So, instead
just going to go ahead and hidden blade
the recruit after the conquer. Not give
a combat. It's it's twofold, right? You
don't give a combat to Draven, so they
don't get to draw an extra card, but
also you're getting to refill. The
hidden blade can still be really
valuable uh targeting your opponent's
units in this matchup, especially
towards the endame when you are going
for the style where you race and try and
not let Miracle get off the ground. Uh
and so, you know, Lynn H having to
recognize like, okay, this is worth
denying the draw and I think I can win
with the the rest of the cards that I'm
going to be pulling from this.
>> All right, so Rossam's turn. Here's the
foreigner. Here's the Ezreal. Perhaps
the uh the big fireworks turn kind of
taking that one turn by the 4Runner and
then maybe we'll see an explosion here.
That is an old school deck box. Haras
has been playing uh card games for a
very very long time and uh so has that
deck box.
So here's called shot top two stack deck
and didn't see it too quick. It's
amazing how these players are playing
very fast as well and we're still in
game two at 30 minutes left. just
showing going to show how many game
actions these deck actually take.
>> It is quite a bit. This is also quite a
bit of cards already played by Rossom
going to be setting up for the battering
rams deciding to go off on this uh turn
three of this game. Of course, Obisk
letting you skip one. Uh so this would
be kind of like a turn four go off
instead. Uh which is, you know, often
what we're seeing out of this deck. they
get to kind of pop off a little bit
harder, dig even deeper, but they it
seems like they've been liking to wait
an additional turn to do so, which I
think a lot of experienced um Miracle
Draven players will do. A lot of
inexperienced players will always go off
on turn three every single time that
they even see kind of part of it where a
lot of the experienced players will
sometimes if they have the nuts, but if
not, they'll wait a little bit longer
for some of these plays and even go for
smaller little medium ones as you go
before going for the full thing. All
right. So, we see forer here hold strong
at the treasure horde. Lanity at four,
rosom at one, a broker, a victor, a
recruit, and a lot of runes.
Start off with the recruit. So, recruit
goes over to the obelis to five. And I
imagine Lynn really wants that six
point.
Yeah, Lynn pretty much needs it, right?
The the time is going to run out against
Miracle. They're going to get get
everything that they need assembled.
They're going to be able to draw through
the deck. curate the hand for what they
need to beat you and you need to put the
pressure on them and that's what L has
been doing and is going to come down and
allow that to continue push him in.
>> All right, guys. But that is Stupify
allowing the honest broker to be the one
to take that conquer go up to six
points. Still more runes available for
more development from Lynn if he wants
as he does decide to pay for the gold
from the treasure horde. Three more.
That's a pick pocket. Kill the gold that
he just got.
>> Go from there.
>> All right. So, stack him up. Units a hoy
and going back Rosma's way. Uh, of
course the might from the foreigners not
left the board still in play as these
mechs. So, two mechs, a ram and an
Ezreal. Step one, mech go to the obelisk
can take out a recruit put Ross to two.
Now Lynn's on six. Rosam's on two. Great
point advantage and on kind of the game
point for Linsanity.
Yeah, Rosam's at this point though where
he's not allowed to actually tap out
this turn. So, he can't go fully in
because then he just folds entirely to
something like decree with the amount of
units that are on the backline that
Lindsanity has, especially even getting
an additional recruit from that honest
broker. So, it's this kind of awkward
position where you really need to go off
to put a lot of might on the board to
deny the ability of Lindsanity going
over you with just something like a
watcher kind of ending the game and not
being able to spend all of your runes on
this turn because you've almost
guaranteed a loss to multiple different
cards that Victor can have in hand. And
it's a really tough almost no- win
situation. I'm really curious how Ross
is going to navigate this spot and what
this deck really has to offer because it
has a lot of the deep draw. You can put
a lot of might out, but we haven't seen
a ton of combat tricks. We we did see
what an axe, we saw a rebuke, and we saw
two copies of fight or flight. So,
there's a little bit, right? You can
have a little bit there, but that's all
going to cost resources, and none of
them are the most efficient things at
dealing with Victor in particular. So,
here's a merchant. Uh, so reinforcing
merchant on the hure horde. A modest
beginnings to the turn. Here's a seal.
Yeah, double seal. Three cards played
already.
Ram going to be easy to play pretty
heavily, but that is just going to be a
Rosa for six.
>> Oh my god.
>> Which is not exactly what you want to be
doing. Fight or flight going to get
hidden. I think there are a lot of cards
that Lynanity can have here to just
close this out. But double hidden, look,
that could be fighter flight, fight
orflight, buy a little bit of space. I
mean,
>> try and fade the uh the Imperial decree
and and maybe we're in business.
>> Uh yeah, absolutely desperation play
from Rossam here
>> trying to steal this game number two up
at game. Lynn looking to force game
three and yeah, Imperial Decree here uh
looks pretty good.
>> You know, as I was saying, you're not
allowed to tap out, but sometimes it's
the only option, right? Like while this
means that Linsanity just gets to play
some solitire here, dealing with of
course the two hidden cards. It's not
completely just free. has to figure that
out. But there's not going to be any
interaction from hand from Rosa at this
point. He's just like, "All right,
Flynn, if you can beat this and go to
eight, we're just going to take a game
three here."
>> So, singularity singularity is a pretty
good start. Thinking have two largest
units. Goodbye, Rosa. Goodbye, Rams. And
now merchant mech holding with a hidden
card and mech holding with a hidden
card. I see a wages to just deal with
the mech on the bottom side. And then
from there, it would be just can you
push onto treasure horde and win in that
way. Looks like that might be what Linen
is lining up is like, okay, I'll send
maybe I send everything to treasure
horde. See if that is winning and if I
need to interact there. If it is, then I
can just finish up with the wages and
push in a recruit on the other side.
Linder and the math thinking it through
on game point looking to force a game
three,
but this game I guess looking close to
conclusion. Not quite there yet. The
clock is definitely uh looking good. You
know, when when you have a game that
does not get down to, you know, a player
stacking the bottom of their deck goes a
little faster and like you're saying,
this is definitely, you know, Victor
tempo, you know, kind of coming in being
aggressive.
>> Yeah. And it's this style that has like
kind of a mix of the tempo aggressive
Victor and the spell Victor. We're just
playing kind of the best spells and
we're we're just seeing that kind of pay
dividends in this spot. as a trade
regardless of this.
>> All right, so we see uh Fighter Flight
pushing back pickpocket wages of pain uh
on the other mech on the other
battlefield. Fighter Flight there pushes
that one back. Merchant trades. Here's
Victor. Here's Recruit.
>> Yep. Beautiful.
>> And there's the game. A super clean game
from Linsanity forcing a game three.
Round number 10 of our regional
qualifier in Las Vegas. These players
now that was a good fast game.
>> Yeah, plenty of time for game three.
Both players have played crisp tight
riftbound. Going into game three,
Rossam's got veiled temple while
Insanity has vile maw layer.
>> Yeah, these players are good, man. They
are sharp. You've seen the speed and
accuracy of these plays from both sides.
Ross recognizing, okay, this is the the
most I can do as a defense. Puts all
that up and then Lynn just picks it
apart, recognizing exactly the puzzle
that he found, figuring against this
type of deck. It's double fighter flight
always pretty much. Uh so just how do
you beat double fighter flight? He has
an exact that does beat it and just
finds it and goes for it.
>> 20 minutes to play last game
>> like Rosam's play too where like that's
going to not work 95% of the time.
>> Yeah. But the five it does
>> 5% of the time if it works out that's
chance to win a game you might not win
otherwise. So Ross on the play traveling
merchant is the first play again. Bomos
Layer and Veil Temple. Pretty cool.
Battlefield for Rossom. And turn one.
>> Ooh, that is not a great start.
>> Uh, missing a two here on the the going
second.
Just going to have the Sinja. Now, it
does allow you to run over a traveling
merchant if he's hanging out alone, but
you have to be wary of spinning axe if
Ross doesn't tap out. There is also the
potential that Rossum just goes for the
Draven, defending that merchant, but I
think it's a bit risky. Usually I like
to see, you know, just play at the back
and potentially allow the merchant to
just go down. So at least in that way
it's a little bit better than two drop
in a one is the uh the syninja actually
gets to push over the merchant. But
losing the rune is not something that
Lyn sanity wants. You see a little
headshake here, but feels like uh maybe
be forced into pickpocket recruit with
these four runes even though the
pickpocket really wants to kill a seal.
>> Yeah, the turn on one's in feels kind of
like one v five from Annie.
>> Yeah, it does. you don't really want to
do it, but
>> it does some like good things, right?
Like randomly like uh that the the vibe
pushes over any other two, right? And
sometimes you even have a a card or two
in the bin after you maybe stack deck or
cleave or something to even push over
bigger numbers and Syn kind of does the
same thing. Um but yeah, the Dramp is
rough. It is a steep cost and we do see
Pickpocket recruit because not another
good development option. That warp in
hand though, it's been lurking in the
past two games. hasn't been able to get
it done. The big question will be does
that come into play for this match
because the clock is something you want
to accelerate against Draven. You don't
want to give them a lot of time and time
warp does let you speed things up. So,
we saw a couple scrap peeps here from uh
Rossom both on the merchant in and out
which is uh a big deal. Lots of cards in
hand for Ross.
So, go for the stack deck. This could be
turn three. Get things set up. Oh, ear
seal discord.
That's two cards played.
And we got an Ezreal here as well. Bunch
of cards in hand. Fireworks time.
Discard.
Draw. Must have been a scrappy. Let's
draw three.
Oh boy. So, uh, Lind, you got a hand on
the table. All right. Uh, do your thing.
It's going to be a while. Grab a
Snickers. So, here's a ram and, uh, I
guess exhausted. That's probably just uh
just it. Okay. So, not like the full
send.
>> Oh, just develop a a good healthy base
of might. Uh went to two. Going to three
is not really going to do anything. And
so, now the question is for Linanity,
can you go to two and present a lot of
pressure? We are. I mean, you know, I
feel like a broken record talking about
decree bellows, but it is just such an
important thing for this matchup to be
able to deal with the amount of units
that miracle just plops out onto the
board. And so, we're still looking for
that. This is six runes. Technically,
you can play decree bellows and clear
three of these things, but it is a very
costly to do so. You would leave behind
the traveling merchant.
>> So, Ling going to start out with some
combat.
Nope. Yep. Nope. All right. So pickpock
going into vials vile ma's layer, excuse
me, up to one.
Singinja over up to two. So we got a two
two score die. Recruit in the back. Six
runes available. We're going to see a
recruit
and hopefully a little more than that.
Five runes left.
Pass. What can be used on defense for
Linanity with the five runes?
>> I see a bellows in hand. This time
>> there is a decree. Is there a decree?
>> Look like a progress day. He's very fast
on these hand shuffles. I'm trying to
catch it. I'm I'll get there.
>> Impressive.
>> Yeah, progress day and time warp
definitely kind of guards you want to
have a little bit later. Not necessarily
uh this early in the game.
>> Time warp, progress, wages, bellow's
breath, salvage.
>> Okay, I think that's the five.
>> So, here comes the Hold on. Got to work
this one through.
Draven, traveling merchant, battering
ram, all coming in to the veil temple.
Merchant move trigger going to discard
and draw.
>> Think about the the kind of card game
term velocity and the ability of a deck
to see kind of go through its deck and
see so many cards. The velocity of these
uh these especially this version of this
uh Draven deck is just unbelievable.
>> So now passing on the Draven as well.
also allowing that to potentially just
trade.
>> Okay, so
>> Draven is only a four. No power played.
Now we're seeing wages of pain on the
Draven. So be a stupify to follow.
>> Yeah, this also does just allow Syno to
trade with Draven and the traveling
merchant. So maybe that's just a
consideration. Okay,
>> couldn't just cast on the merchant. I
mean, it doesn't really, you know, same
same thing both ways. All right, so
leave behind the ram draw for Draven.
And again, just a ridiculous amount of
cards in hand for Ross here.
>> Yeah, big small optimization we saw from
Rosen there. Uh floated a power from the
seal before going into the Veil Temple,
which is his battlefield, so that he can
rer the seal. So he can have two of this
purple power for the turn to to fuel the
big pop off that he's going to have here
as we have another draw three uh coming
through.
>> Detonate. So many cards. Still four
runes left.
>> Yeah, I saw another Ezreal. I mean, this
this is not done. If he wants to draw
more, but if he does do the Ezreal, uh
we won't have multiple battering rams
coming out.
>> Wow. Bushwack.
>> Uh-oh. So Bushwack will make the units
enter ready. Here's a gold.
>> Yeah. So maybe trying to get a Rosa on
this turn.
>> About two Rossas.
>> Yeah, potentially two Rossas. It is two
Ross.
>> That is a lot of might coming out of
nowhere.
>> And Ross number one is going to Ross
number one and Ross number two both
popping into VOS. A little bit of
overkill on that poor pick pocket.
>> Didn't even pick any pockets this game.
You know, just an innocent bystander.
>> Yeah, the seal came down like the turn
after, but Lindsanity was forced into
that play. I mean, you look that hand,
there's really just no other option. You
need to develop the units. You need to
actually make something happen.
>> Yep. And it's going to be a battering
ram as well. Maybe two of them.
>> So this is that 22 might play
>> with two of them coming in ready. I mean
it is the power of Miracle Draven. This
is exactly what he wants to see. This is
everything coming together for awesome
in this game three. And I think Glsani
is going to be a bit out of it unless
there is a massive swing that can come
through. But this is exactly how you
need to play around things like decree
bellow's breath is you have things at
all three locations both battlefields
and the base. It can't all be covered by
that play. Now, the recruits can help.
You can go for maybe a full board wipe
here,
>> but there still is possibility for
Rossom to still come back from that.
>> Yeah, Dreo looks pretty good here. I
think
>> it does.
>> Uh so, we'll see what Lynn's got in
store. Certainly uh a an awesome term
for awesome rosom.
And ooh, this is I
>> that spells no decree. It spells,
"Please let me draw a decree so that
next turn when Rossom goes to six, maybe
I can wipe this board."
>> Yeah. So, almost conceding the turn,
just saying, "All right, you know what?
You can have your two more points. I'll
let you get to six and then I'll try and
put it all together next turn." Here's a
recruit. Now, I think Lan was just
feeling jealous. You know, you have so
many cards in hand. I want to have a lot
of cards in hand, too.
>> All right. And
>> what I must do to mimic a fraction of
your power.
>> Exactly.
So, just a stub of five.
>> Yeah. Got to dig a little deeper.
>> All right.
>> I mean, decree is the only card. Yep.
>> That is a bailout if even
>> now. Rossom sure aware of this also.
Here's stack deck on the repeat. Sorry,
not stack deck. Called shot. They're
similar.
>> Repeat number one.
>> Stacking his deck at this point,
>> right? Yeah, exactly. I was just, you
know, rubbing what was happening.
>> So, more cards.
>> Another called shot in hand.
>> Oh, boy. All right. Here we go. He's
going and going and going. Was that a
hard bargain I just saw?
>> I didn't see. No. No. Seal.
>> Seal. Okay.
>> Yeah, there's there's not a lot more
that I I feel he needs, but he is
digging and just finding any piece that
he wants at this point. Right. This is
probably another detonate, I would
imagine, with the trove hitting the
board.
>> There it is. So, just going to keep
digging. Draw the whole deck. Have the
whole deck in the hands.
>> This is disgusting. Um, how many cards
were drawn this turn? Like eight. I
mean, eight
>> eight cards.
>> So many.
>> All right, so Rams already
>> Rams coming home and uh
not done yet.
>> Here we see
>> the last Rossa.
>> Rossa in the back row.
>> Well, this is every unit in the deck
minus, you know, two merchants, two
Ezreals, probably.
>> Yeah. And the VI.
>> The VI.
>> Yeah, but that's that's the big ones.
These are the hitters. That being said,
you know, um
some sort of
bell's breath decree something.
>> Yeah. I mean, and that is the weakness
of overdeveloping into Victor. And I
think Rossom kind of recognizing that
like okay, if you had decree, it
probably might have been played at this
point, but you do have to think like
progress day could have found it. And
the question is is does Rossom have a
good out after uh you know, we see
something like decree bellows try and
clear? He can also play around it best
he can by splitting in an optimal way to
try and avoid as much collateral damage
as possible going forward.
>> So folly start
>> and this is another way to to help play
around the decree cuz when it gets
played with the bellow's breath the
tokens were going to be used to help
clean up the spots you couldn't hit
>> and now taking two of them off the
table. I think that is heads up to be
like even if you have decree bellows you
are not clearing this board. Yep. I
thought I saw Bells in hand. Now, bells
will do three damage split up among
three units uh in one location. So, you
can repeat it. You can do two separate
locations. Correct.
>> Yes. Yeah, it is two separate locations.
You did see a bell. In fact, there's
three bellows. No decree.
>> Oh.
>> In the hand,
>> but not good enough.
>> Yeah. And there's the Scoopy. Yeah. He
says, "I got all the bellows. I got the
no decree."
>> Yeah. So, a little A plus B combo
action. Only finding A, only finding B.
A super impressive game from Awesome
Rosom. Um, that deck looks like
something else on a whole another level.
>> Really, really cool stuff. So, awesome.
Ross, uh, going up to 9 and one here in
round 10 of qualifier here in Las Vegas.
Lynsanity, uh, now 8 and2. Uh, not dead
yet.
>> Still still on the hunt for a possible
top eight slot. You know, not
necessarily might be a tiebreaker thing.
It
>> it'll be a breaker situation.
>> And then, of course, still the hunt for
a possible Victor best of as well. So,
really awesome games. Really, really
tight play. Let's pop down and hear what
Awesome Ross has to say about how that
game went.
>> Thank you very much. I'm here with
Awesome Rossom. That's an amazing
username. Still live for a top eight on
Draven. How's the deck been for you?
>> Deck's been great. Uh it's performing
very well. Um just kind of cycling
through my whole deck and I'm just able
to do that. Not people are afraid of
attacking in this format just cuz Draven
is the boogeyman and they don't want to
put two drops in their deck and gives me
time to draw my whole deck and put a
bunch of Rosses in play.
>> How did you decide on the deck? cuz this
were you locked or did you kind of play
a couple of other things before the
event?
>> I was pretty locked on miracle. Um I was
I found the noturn package was a little
bit inconsistent. I didn't really want
to play mid-range cuz I thought we
called shot Ezreal stack deck. There's a
lot of busted things you could do
especially if you're fast enough and
you're conf like confident at going
through your deck at a quick pace and it
kind of just I wanted to play miracle
and we kind of found this detonate scrap
uh treasure trove package that kind of
lets you go through your deck by turn
seven and it's been performing great. Uh
our record after day one was 80% um
counting draws as losses. So it's
performing very well for me.
>> That's extremely good. And this round
you actually played a Victor which is
surprisingly maybe the fifth most
represented deck I believe. How is that
match up for you? Were you prepared for
it?
>> I'm I'm moderately prepared I would say.
Um my teammates on challenger TCG uh
plays Victor. So I kind of get the ins
and outs. That's actually a pretty
aggressive deck and they're able to kind
of get under me. I kind of that's kind
of what happened in game two. I just
they got it under me and my deck's a
little bit slow so I lost but I was able
to. Game three just had a pretty good
draw. triple scrappy with traveling
merchant uncontested and then I kind of
just had a really insane bushwack double
Ross a double ram turn and fighter high
fighter flight game's over you know
>> that's why we play the deck right
>> yeah exactly
>> how do you find the mirror then because
that's obviously something you play
probably quite a lot this event
>> uh I've played four miracle Draven
mirrors that are all on noturn and I'm
40 um they're a little bit slower a
little bit more inconsistent and I'm
able to kind of don't want to give away
too much but I'm able to stack my deck a
little bit with Vi uh at the end and put
Ross's back and they are not able to do
that so uh it's it's been pretty good so
Well, you're still live. Best of luck at
top. Hope you make it.
>> Thank you very much. I appreciate it.
>> Good.
>> Appreciate, you know, Ross's crispness
crispness in play.
>> Yeah.
>> Uh quality of play even carried over to
the interview. Yeah. Chris so clear and
confident uh and knowledgeable with his
deck, his preparation. That's what you
love to see. You love to see preparation
turn into a payoff and that's just great
stuff.
>> Yeah, I mean this it it may be the the
new best way to play Miracle. It really
remains to be seen. as he said, he was
beating down all the the Nocturn
Enjoyers uh within their Miracle decks
as well. And it's definitely very
consistent. The question will just be,
can it go the distance? And I think
Miracle is a deck that is very good at
spiking tournaments, and we just haven't
really seen it do so just yet.
>> Well, today might be the day, but we are
not done with round 10, folks. We've got
a unbelievable match coming up for you.
Draven versus Ezreal. Two of our
undefeated players. First up is Colin
playing Draven and uh got a similar
idea. I might might as a VI or two.
>> So Colin Kaiser, member of challenger
TCG as well. Uh this is the player who
won that Atlanta tournament a while
back. Uh that was one of the first 10ks
on set and kind of brought set to the
forefront where everyone thought set was
really good in Origins. And now Colin
has made it all the way to the
undefeated tables playing Miracle
Draven. He is on Noctturns even though
all on the same team not going for that
full uh detonate version. However, still
having plenty of success being
undefeated. Yeah. And it's fun to see
that on teams where you know you think
that a team would work together or come
to a consensus. Doesn't always happen.
You know, there's a lot of good players
and you're not sure that the detentate
version looks riskier. You know, uh
higher ceiling. Maybe if you get it
wrong, you could be in a bad spot. But
great to see success on both sides. And
uh Colin's opponent needs no
introduction.
>> No, so we won't.
>> Okay. Yeah,
>> it's Allen's EQ.
>> Yeah, it's it's Allen's EQ. Uh he is
very familiar with this matchup going up
against Miracle Draven. Prismaticism,
one of his teammates uh made top eight
playing Miracle Draven in Bolognia. Uh
so that is a deck he is very well-versed
at playing against. He knows how to
punish if players play poorly into the
Ezreal. They don't know this matchup,
but I think Colin Kaiser is somebody who
I would expect to know how to play
against this, especially after seeing
Emlonia test a bunch against it with the
thought that I'm good enough. I'm going
to face Allen at some point during this
event and I need to know know how to
deal with it. So, I think this is going
to be a heater of a game because Miracle
can get around Ezreal. It is a deck that
can make it happen. It just produces way
too much value that Ezreal sometimes
can't quite keep up. It's so crazy to
think uh of a player in a 600 person
tournament saying, "I'm going to win
this tournament. I need to beat Allen. I
need to beat one person." But that's the
run that Allen has been on uh recently.
Just seemingly unbeatable. And it it's a
common sentiment among top players right
now is they they do have to take Allen
into account for wanting the spike. It
is just a fact. Any top player coming
into this tournament thought about Allen
once. They dreamed about Allen once,
knowing that, hey, one day I may have to
sit across from him in my run to try and
make that top eight. And you know, Colin
is an absolute powerhouse when it comes
to Riftbound already in his own right.
So, this is a clash of absolute titans.
>> Awesome to see. And for you folks who
maybe saw Allen's list from uh from last
weekend in Bolognia, saw the Ezra list,
maybe you didn't get to see a lot of the
games, you know, picked it up and was
like, I just can't win this. It's too
hard. Watch and learn, my friends,
because uh the master is going to be at
work here. Yeah, one of the big things
that we are going to look at, I talked
about overdevelopment in that last game
from Rossome. How Victor can punish it.
Ezreal is the same vein. Bellow's breath
can wipe your entire board if Colin
decides to commit everything out there.
Allen will try and hunt down the pieces
to remove it all in one swift swoop. And
from there, it becomes very hard for
Miracle to redevelop with Allen
continuing to ping things off in the
aftermath. So Colin starting off here
going first and unfortunately not the
best start. Just a turn one stack deck.
Kind of like a constellation prize when
you missed your first drop, but a little
more of a setup here too. This is a a
deck that's not it's not as important to
have that early play as long as you're
setting up for your big miracle turn.
Correct.
>> Yeah, it is. And you know, for this
game, Allen, also the Vex being one of
the cards that was talked about quite a
bit, but this matchup there's not a lot
of spells that Vex gets to hit. So we're
going to see him bin this Vex early.
They may even come out in the board in
game two and three because against
miracle draven, yeah, they have spells,
but you're not really getting
opportunities for the Vex to cause
problems. What it can do still is reduce
the cost of your own spells and when you
can force a combat to go for a big
removal. So, she's not a complete waste.
She's not completely useless, but it's
not the matchup you're looking for for
that Vex. And we see here dumped away
very quickly early on for Allen to build
up more of the spell base that he needs
to get the big removals cuz I think at
this point you see the zon you know it's
miracle you're just looking for ways to
deal with the pop off and that is going
to be finding bellow's breath that's
finding watchers to go along with it or
you're going to want bellow's breath
fizz combined with something like a
frigid touch. These are some of the
cards that Allen is going to look to
make sure he has for that endgame. And
he still wants to be able to score
points early because this is a deck that
continues to pop off. So, we may even
see him try and pick up like a Raven
Bloom that he can at least develop and
try and find some early points. Doesn't
want to give combats, but he does want
to score and look for that removal. All
right, so stack deck once again after
called shot. Tons of library
manipulation here as we're hanging out
in the back row. So,
similar sort of package, but in
different sort of payoff, you know,
where in the Draven deck, we see
battering rams kind of this big like pop
off turn where this is just a lot of
setup and a lot of kind of crafting and
finding the right cards, right?
>> Yeah. And there's the student that he
finds just wanting to have this setup so
that he can start going to maybe two
points on the next turn. I think a
really good result for Allen is that
Colin actually goes for a big
development here and then Allen has a
good answer and punish to remove a lot
of it and is able to still push in and
score. I think that's exactly what Allen
would want to see. Six runes is a little
bit hardressed but Ezreal can do a lot
with six runes, right? You you've got
Bella's breath with repeat, you can
reduce it with the Ezreal. Then you can
still go frigid touch repeat and you can
reduce a bunch of units all over the
place trying to get a bunch of clears
and say Colin, you know, gonna take it
slow from the start. This hand, you
know, not finding a ton, but he does
find a knockturn off of the search on
the stack deck. So, we'll see how much
he can put together on this single turn.
>> Yep. So, no turn is seen and then played
card off it as well. Maybe there were
two seals in hand for column 2. So,
there's some explosive potential here.
Here's a seal
and another seal. All right, so starting
to stack these cards up. That is now
four cards played.
That's a magic number for the Rams, but
we're going to see what looks to be an
Ezreal with that floating energy. Ezreal
time, scrap time. All right, both
players doing the thing.
>> Yeah, gets to draw three. I mean, this
is a lot of played cards. I think he
wants to set up some rams on this turn.
the six runes, as I said, is it's not
quite enough to really go for full
clears. It's not it's not super easy for
Allen to find the clear just on six
runes. I think there are particular outs
that all kind of crux around the the
bellow's breath frigid touch combo when
you're at uh the six runes.
And as we see, Colin had to slow down
because he didn't even see any rams on
that draw three.
>> Yeah, kind of tough here. Colin's hand
is a lot of interaction. Rebuke, double
fighter flight. Not what we're looking
for here. Looking for a little more
forward progress. So, Draven will come
in. We'll see a loot on the Warrens.
Kind of a desperation. Uh, let's try and
find something else to do here.
Discarding herbuke. And that is it. And
that is not exactly a firework turn.
Maybe one of those little uh, you know,
bottle rockets, something like that. A
sparkler. Okay, it's fun to look at, but
not what Colin was looking for. So,
going back Allen's way, Steel Discord.
Those are some nice seals. Those are
really cool looking.
And here is Vex.
Yeah, just going to jam the Vex. Still
time for Allen to just set up, right?
You know, talking about wanting to find
a big removal and then look for the
score. That's if it's a bigger
development from Colin. This was slow.
This was just a small start. Seven might
on the board. Allen can wait for a
bigger commitment to then pop off. And
Vex does allow the lower rune counts to
still do larger ceilings because if
Colin leaves any unit out of
battlefield, Allen just has to push the
Vex in and then pop off because he's
going to have the reduced cost on every
single spell that he plays. Vex is now
more about the first part of her text,
friendly spells costing less, than it is
about the second part of the text,
whereas enemy spells costing more, where
in most of the matchups she's wanting to
be used a little of both, but mostly
that second line is where the really
importance is. All right, so the
patience of Allen here, um, you know,
just multiple chances to move in, not
doing it, going back Collins away,
double called shot once again, trying to
get that full setup. and the patience
from Allen. You watch Allen play. She's
so patient. Never just never moves in,
never does anything. Just is always so
patient to find the actual right spot to
do everything. So, a lot of cards at
hand. Collins got two called shots
played already.
And uh Draven's coming back, like you
said, trying to avoid the combat
scenario with Vex if possible.
>> And stacked back again.
>> Yeah, he's gone to two. So, I'd like to
see Colin not push void gate at all.
Just stay at two. And uh you can still
look for some good develops because as
long as you're not overcommitting, this
version has the Noctturn, so you
actually have more total might in your
deck. Uh so even playing, we saw two
hopefuls in that search. It was like
with a fighter or flight, so I think
probably grabbing a hopeful develop
that. And you can still go a little bit
wide as long as you got the rams, the
roses, you've got the ability to still
go for another redeploy. Uh if Allen is
able to completely wipe you out, that's
still good. But he can still just take
it slow over time, score efficiently.
Allen doesn't have points yet. You don't
have to flinch too early.
>> Oh, like this. So, Nocturn moves in.
Just the fight orflight to back it up.
So,
>> I love this.
>> Extremely a weird looking play if you're
just jumping in the game looking right
at it, but being extremely cognizant of
this flexibility and the cost reduction.
So, saying I'm out of combat even just
going to three and the retreat. So,
using that kind of like interactive
spell isn't fantastic in this kind of
matchup in a cool way. And then a bunch
of might in the back row. Now we're
going back Allen's way.
>> Yeah. I mean, it's Colin showing that he
understands this magic. He understands
that he needs to score points, but he
can't give away material for free and he
can't overdevelop. And I don't think
he's overdeveloped. I think this is
fine. You know, you got two more
battering rams in deck. You have three
Rossas, one more Noctturn. You know, you
have you have cards in deck. There's not
a concern there. And he's going to force
Allen to have to start moving a little
bit. Allen is not going to be able to
just sit back forever. And uh he may
even want to get a Warren's trigger
himself because I'm looking at the hand
and it's not it's not perfect for Allen,
right? There is going to be this Arcane
Shift which is going to allow
potentially a draw two from Ezreal in
combat, deal some damage. Morbid Return
just going to bring back a Vex because I
think Allen recognizing, hey, I actually
don't have a lot to do right now with
this hand. I need to wait for a more
perfect combat to come a bit later. And
he is just going to play one at base. So
very, very slow and methodical for
Allen. the hand not allowing him to
affect the backline just yet.
>> So student moved into void gate not zon
warren putting Allen up which just a
single point. Uh why gate over warrants?
Yeah I mean this is a bit interesting
cuz usually you would just go warren but
he must not have had something in hand
that he actually wanted to bin. He
probably I I haven't seen this whole
hand. It's really tough to catch a good
glimpse but I'm imagining he actually
has part of the combo pieces needed for
full removal. And so he actually wants
these cards, but he's not the game state
yet where he can start spending them. I
am a little interested about the student
going at all because being only at the
the one rune, there's not a lot of
interaction that he's going to to have
access to to be able to protect the
student is very likely just going to go
down for free, especially with no hidden
card. No, there's not a lot of
interaction that went here. So, I'm I'm
actually a little bit curious about the
student. I want to see what the plan is
or if it is just um Allen being willing
to drop a student here uh just for the
one point which is a bit surprising.
>> I think this is bait trying to get the
Vex into combat.
>> Yeah,
>> I I mean this this works too. So sure
>> Super is going to let it trade.
>> That's fine as well. You know, trying to
get Colin to commit to one of the
battlefields to get Vex in cuz that the
one point doesn't seem that impactful.
But there you go. That's a trade.
>> Pretty good exchange.
>> Well, it's great for Allen cuz Draven
doesn't get a draw here now. So that's
it. I it's like exactly what Allen
wanted, but I there could have just been
a push of the battering ram to play
around Stupify with one rune up against
Ezreal. So that's where my question mark
is on this specific turn where I don't
think I'm fully grasping it cuz the bait
is fine for the knock turn and it works
great for Allen.
>> But what if the battering arm just went
>> I think if the R comes in, uh Allen just
conceds the the Raven Bloom student, but
now has a a
>> target to push Vex. Yeah,
>> he gets Vex into combat and then can use
that Vex ability to really go off and
have a huge turn. But for Ram go in
anyway to the Z warrants.
So Colin goes up to four. Warren will
trigger discard and draw. Goodbye
nocturn.
And now again that opens the door for
Vex to possibly uh come in. Start
utilizing that ability that is only
applicable in combat. That being said,
there are a ton of cards in hand for
Colin. These games were so hard with so
many with both players having so many
cards and average so many given options
at any time.
So, next step is a Fizz. Are we going to
see this fighterfly play again?
>> Uh, it it it very well could be. Yeah, I
I was thinking like usually you just
want to fizz into the stack or the
called shot, but you really don't want
to give this Vex combat and uh you but
you also need to go to four, right? So,
going to four is very important. You
need to push something in. I I like this
fizz play a lot. Continue not giving
Allen the combat with the Vexes.
>> I I love the play of this game. This has
been a very very high level game. Um,
both players kind of baiting, setting
traps, you know, Allen trying to get the
the backs into combat. Colin saying no,
the scheme will not be about that. I
disagree. You know, using fighter
flights of his unique way at four
points.
Triple Rosa in hand for Colin. I think
he's still holding off, which which is,
you know, what I've been saying. You
can't overdeploy, but I think I saw
three Rossas sitting there ready to go
for Colin as soon as this board gets
wiped.
>> There was Bushwack in Colins's list,
correct? Yeah, Bushwack is there.
Bushwack triple Rossa to end from six is
going to be the main out to deal with
Ezreal. You cannot allow Ezreal to just
have a clear and then a redeploy and
then a recar. You have to end the game
when you go with that redeploy. So
Allen's not going to want to let Colin
get to six because he's also aware of
this. He knows that the Bushwack play
has to come through. I love a kind of
you look on Allen's face like, you know,
I just want to get my stuff, you know,
like you're you're just doing such a
good job of keeping me off what I want
to do. So, here comes the Vex. Uh, going
into combat is not combat. It is just a
non-combat showdown. So, the Vex is not
active right now. Zon wards conquered.
Allen goes to two. Discard wages of
pain. Draw. Here's Raza.
>> Pays three for it.
>> And just a pass. Now, of course, Vex can
be in combat on defense, too.
>> Correct. So if Colin wants to move into
this Vex, that does open the window for
Vex being in that cost reduction to
really stack up alongside the Ezreal.
>> And this is where we hit the inflection
point of the match. Colin wants to go to
six because you you call out the
bushwack in this deck. He wants to go to
six so that when this board is gone, he
can bushwack Russell Russell Russa, end
the game, right?
>> Okay. Little live little live look in
here at prismatism. And uh
>> you know this uh this this is a a f a
little little bit of the future little
bit of the future sneaking out
>> creeping in
>> as we are back to the start of game one.
>> We had the time warp in last match but
you know the philosophical time warp is
pretty cool too. So we get things reset
up here and uh
>> be careful on the live scrub here.
>> Okay.
>> I don't want to do too much as we do
have a fizz.
>> Okay. Well, this is quite a bit of a
fast forward
>> as Colin did go.
>> Let's take Let's take one second here
and try and get this uh get this eyes or
whatever. Everyone close your eyes.
Avert yourself. Oh, we're back. Look at
us.
>> Nobody saw that.
>> Everyone look away. Everyone turn off
your monitor.
>> So, slight tech issue. I I'm I'm like
shaking out of it right now cuz I was so
enthralled in that game. Uh just the the
high level of play is just unbelievable.
Both players, you know, Riftbound, you
know, has a a certain flow to it. you
know, you kind of like you see you play,
you go in, you go out, you know, and
seeing those trends completely bucked in
this game because players are just so
aware of what's important in the game.
Uh, and you know, just jocking your
position, being patient, trying to set
little traps is just so cool to watch.
Yeah, I mean, at this point, it's going
to come down to that Vex, too. It's
really, really, really good play from
Colin to avoid the combat for so long.
And now it was, as we said, that
inflection point that we reached. Vex
sitting on zone wars,
>> call in at four. He needs to go to six
before his next redeployment. So, how do
you do that? Well, we're going to find
out soon enough, hopefully. So, yeah,
>> as a reminder, of course, we got
regional qualifier Las Vegas here in
sunny Las Vegas. I'm Jim Davis. That's
Captain Nova. And it looks like we've
got things repaired. We're back in and
uh Collins at four. All at two. So,
again, here's Called Shot. Vex is on the
battlefield on Zo Warren. Get right back
into it. Like you're saying, Colin
really wants to go to six this turn if
possible. So back Collins way getting
back into the game
again. Both players have so many cards
to work with. To further set the stakes
here, Allen has not lost a set
in a regional qualifier in Spirit Forge.
>> Just went undefeated in Bolognia.
>> Yeah.
>> Didn't drop a match. Yeah, he IDed one
round at the end.
>> Sure.
>> But like that is what it is.
>> That's not a loss. Yeah.
>> Wow.
>> That is uh that is something. Uh so what
was that? How that's what how many
rounds is that plus top eight?
>> I mean it's 13 rounds then top eight. 16
rounds.
>> So 16 rounds
>> 25 rounds.
>> That is unbelievable. Uh that is true
true dominance. So we see Ezreal here.
Colin working through Colin looking to
topple Allen and try and say, you know
what, that win streak is over. My win
streak is going to start now at nine
and0, of course. So,
>> you want to be the person to do it.
>> Oh, yeah.
>> You want to be the one who said, I was
the one
>> Yep.
>> who got Allen, who finally beat Allen.
>> And for Allen, obviously being on a
heater like that feels amazing. But
there is an inherent amount of pressure
of like people are coming for you.
When's it going to end? You're going to
lose eventually. You know, is it going
to be now?
>> And I will say Allen has
the most insane mental of any competitor
I have ever met. Nothing gets to him.
But when I talked to him before this
event, even in in an interview, we even
we even showed that interview that we
were talking to Allan, he did say, "You
know what? Even with my mental, I am
still feeling a little bit of pressure
after top eight Houston win Bolognia.
Everyone kind of just expects him to
win."
>> All right, so we got a combat here.
Draven's coming in alongside the rim.
Going to pay the one fury. So, so Draven
is now up to six. We have six on Draven,
five on Ram. And now this is the key
part of the game. So now Allan's been
trying to get this Vex into a combat for
multiple turns. Colin's been saying no,
no, no, will not allow it to happen. But
now it is finally in. This is a turn
super fight to start. So minus one to
the ramp. And now again, Vex will reduce
friendly spells by energy and power to
to minimum of one energy. But a lot of
things can happen here. And uh you can
see Colin kind of sitting back like all
right I've been trying to avoid this but
we have to get that six point on five
with Fizz taking the void gate.
>> I very good optimization from Colin
playing around Bellow's breath on this
turn. Look at how he split his units.
Two at base, two at the battlefield, one
over on the void gate. It means that the
only way it can really punish you is two
of these locations and you still keep
the fizz.
>> All right. So now we see frigid breath.
Yeah, touch minus four with the repeat.
>> Oh, breath, frigid touch, just all
things you don't want to be involved
with if you can try to avoid it. So now
we're minus two on the Draven. So is
plus two -4 down to -2 total overall. So
we got two on Draven and five on Ram.
>> Four on Ram.
>> Four on ram. Right.
>> But yes,
>> I was just doing the math in my head. I
was like, it doesn't add up. Uh so and
here is Bella's breath. So gonna see
repeat
>> and I imagine there'll be two to Draven
as well as two to the battery ram only
at the same location.
>> I guess the repeat can go to different
locations.
>> It can. Yeah,
>> correct. So and we're going to see a
spinning axe.
>> Two to Draven makes sense. Yes.
>> Right. You want to kill off the Draven.
So it's going to be double tap on the Z
warren for this Bellow's breath.
>> Good timing for Colin with the response
on the spinning axe here. There's no
reaction speed damage Allen can do to
deny this attach. Yep. So, the axe is on
and now Draven is back to five. Five on
Draven, four on Ram. Back of course
five.
>> Ain't done yet though, of course. Arcane
shift time. So, three damage and then a
banish and replay.
Banishing Ezreal, dealing three to the
Draven. Yeah, and that will kill off
Draven here with two damage marked from
the Bellow's breath. The plus three from
the spinning axe means that this will
hit as it is going to be Ezreal just
drawing two as he's the one kind of
getting flickered here by the arcane
shift. So that noting that you know the
axe falling off on your turn is not
nearly as bad. You're able to equip it
and not lose it. Uh but this combat has
gone kind of sour and now we have a four
power ram into the five power VEX. But
of course K not done yet. These players
have been building up to this turn for
almost the entire game. Here's a fighter
flight.
>> Fighter flight on the Vex. That's going
to cost three and the one power, but
Colin had ramped runes the entire game
before ever taking a fight with Vex, so
he has the resources to deal with it.
Looks like it may be a hard bargain that
can be played with repeat here with the
Vex and the Ezreal on board. Wow. All
right, so point goes to Out uh when the
dust is settled, Vex is still there. Kin
has not won the combat, so now stuck at
five. Really wants to get to six, but
coming right back in for round number
two. as well picks up the axe and
bellow's breath number two.
>> So
>> why is this free?
>> So the reason this is free, Bellow's
breath cost one and a power and its
repeat cost is one as a power. The way
repeat works is it's going to create a
total cost two energy to power. Then you
have two different re uh reduction
effects in play. Vex is going to reduce
by one energy, one power to a minimum of
one. and Ezreal is going to reduce any
repeat costs by one energy. You decide
which order reductions happen in
Riftbound. So, because the total cost is
two energy to power, you apply Vex's
cost down to one energy and one power.
And then Ezreal is able to either reduce
the energy or the power from there. So,
you can reduce the Bellow's breath down
to zero energy, one power if you have
Vex and Ezreal on board.
>> Okay, so that makes a trade. So again,
Allen trying to keep Colin off this this
uh this six point, but the last card
available is a Bushwack. And of course,
tapped out. No, not exactly. One power
for Raza, 10 or more cards in the trash
and
there is point number six. So crazy
turn. Colin has accomplished the task at
pretty serious cost. That was a lot of
resources lost, but up to six with the
Rosin. I did burn the Bushwack. Uh there
are two Bushwacks, right? Yeah, I think
this was one of the the versions, one of
the players that was playing two
bushwacks, but maybe not if we're seeing
the redeploy of the full roses,
especially because we've seen some
fizzes played already. This might be one
bush back to Fizz. Uh, which often means
you won't play any bushwack if you play
the Fizz, right? Because you're going to
be able to recur them. And I I believe
that's Colin's version. We've seen some
of the two bushwacks, but generally
those are the ones who are not on Fizz.
So, I think we're on one wish, two Fizz
in this spot.
>> All right, so Colin's all in. Uh, down
to one rune just shove all the tips in
the middle and saying, "All right, here
are my roses. Here's my stuff. You do
your thing. So Allen's going to play a
fizz. Get going get a flashback. A
called shot.
Didn't quite get a good look at those
cards there. Uh but I mean even though
Collins at six and has accomplished the
task, um Allen has a lot of resources
available here trying to defend.
>> And look at Colin's rune situation.
>> Is is there a situation? I see one.
>> So because you know he he had already
used the seals on the turn and he needs
to develop these roses to try and push
those last two points on the next turn.
So, he's gone down to a single room.
Now, he does have the seals and the
gold, so he can pay power costs that
generally would be very scary with Vex
on board forcing some power costs to be
paid. Those can get covered. However,
three energy is not a lot. You're not
going to get a lot done with that.
>> So, Allen here just called shot, called
shot. You know, got to go through and
try and find the right answers.
>> And he needs it because he was on one
card basically going into this turn. So
is the Fizz, you know, find the called
shot, try and get another one, keep
finding draw. He needs to rebuild this
hand so that he can actually defend
against
24 might cuz he gets to eat the Fizz for
free. So 24 will be left over. If he can
eat the Rosa and the Fizz, then you've
just got this total of uh what is that?
18. 18's really beatable for uh Ezreal.
It's like honestly it's it's pretty
easily beatable. I I'll have to say uh
but it comes down to still having the
right cards and he had to spend so much
on that first turn. So we'll see if he
can actually find it. Fizz is going to
be another play here that is very
helpful for Allen to keep finding more
answers and stupify being a nice one.
Not going to spend power and allow him
to continue with these free clears. So
the Vex was in combat. I didn't use the
Vexability though once the combat was
done. But little Raza trade here.
Stupidify making that one look quite
nice. Conquer the Warren, discard and
draw. Allen up to four.
Four runes left.
Having Vex at the void gate does mean
that if you know Colin wants to engage
and try and take that seventh and eighth
point, the Vex will be active. So, a lot
of setup here for Allen.
Very important card in Allen ZQ's hand
is going to be the Arcane Shift. He has
Fizz on board. That arcane shift is not
only three damage, not only can it move
the Fizz to one of the other
battlefields, but it also represents any
spell from the bin. And the repeat costs
can be very cheap when it comes to Vex
and Ezreal existing either in combat and
just on the board. So, Frigid Touch
online, that rebuke online, there's a
lot of options that can be played for
Allen and that is one of the biggest
defensive tools in the arsenal for
Ezreal. All right. So, we see we saw
Colin last turn really shoving
everything in play and now Allan kind of
saying, "All right, well, if you're
shoving, I have to shove two to defend."
So, we see multiple units at each
battlefield, a hidden card each
battlefield. And now we're going back
Colin's way. Like you said, Colin is
light on resources. So, only three
energy. A lot of power available, but
you get a lot of might on the board as
well. So, trying to get a peek at the
hand here. Looks like a lot of units.
>> Yeah, it does. And and that that happens
with Miracle, right? It is. It is. You
have to put a lot of these units in your
deck cuz that's just how it functions.
You just draw into them and you dump
them on the board.
>> All right, so piercing light repeated
>> targeting Vex and Fizz.
>> This would be pretty huge if this goes
through.
>> Yeah, this is a massive punish for being
on the void gate.
>> Vex is going to just go down. And I
think Allan noticing in that moment like
wow that is unfortunate. That is
something that maybe he needed to play
around.
>> Yeah. And now Ezra could possibly go in
on on his lonesome. Take the void gate.
And then now the point of contention
comes the eighth point on Zong Warren.
>> All right.
>> No Vex for the reduction. Just sending
nine in to force Allen to flinch.
>> So Roz is in.
>> There's a wages of pain. That's totally
fine.
Get the gold.
>> Looking at a trade currently, but we got
the shift.
>> So now it's time to shift.
>> Y. So we see three onto Raza.
>> Yep. Fizz wages.
>> Yep. So
>> Fizz replayed at the Z warns and then
we'll replay the the wages of Bane.
That's three.
>> Three plus
>> three nine.
>> There you go.
>> Yeah, that's fine.
>> All right. So Raz is gone. Axe falls to
the ground. And uh a little reinforce
there on the Warren, too. So a lot more
work for Colin to do. Colin says, "I'm
up to the task. I'm going right back in
with another nine."
>> Yeah. I mean now nine is not enough to
completely clear. Allen going to allow
the trade to happen.
>> Axe gets to come through though. Y
>> get the cascade this spinning axe using
the seal. So not having to burn all the
runes. Fizz gets taken out.
>> Conquer for Colin.
>> Okay, so now six power Ezreal on the
warrants. Colin at seven.
Little discard action. Allen was a
little low on resources. Is a hold
possible here?
>> It is. Yeah, it's absolutely possible.
uh we know it's not actually possible
because he does have a rebuke in hand.
So it so it's never actually happening,
but I would say that this kind of
situation because his cards end up being
a little bit low. Uh a hold would be
possible to happen. Singularity though
is another option that he does have. Uh
I did see a Fizz in the hand of Colin
though,
so Fizz plus the uh Bushwack is going to
be on the table once he has enough runes
to actually do that. Yeah, I mean there
were plenty of units in hand for Colin
also, but all right, just we're kind of
back to square one here. Uh it looks
like it's turn two. Uh but just going to
play two units and say go on an empty
board. So here's a fan. Here's a knock.
So here's a mindspplitter. Ooh,
>> physone.
>> Yeah,
>> it's quick.
>> Rough hand for Colin. These traveling
merchants are at this stage in the game
not very exciting. So very unit heavy,
very spell light. Mind splitter down.
That being said, Collins at seven and
there are two units threatening
potentially now. Collins down to about
six cards in deck.
So step one is the fan. The the face
down card just as a note is the other
battlefields I'm pretty sure.
>> Yeah, I think so.
>> Yep. So not a hidden card in a different
sleeve. Just making sure we're clear
here. So fan comes into the warrants
and we're going to see
>> rebuke the fan.
>> Rebuke the fan. So fan goes back to
hand. Bit of a desperation play to
rebuke a two drop here um with the
hopeful available as well.
What's the next step for Colin at this
point? So deep in the deck. Um you know
Colin can kind of figure out what these
last six cards are and what the odds are
for, you know, for drawing them next
turn or two. And again, fanning them
out, kind of visualizing, okay, I I know
what these six cards are. I'm, you know,
one and six to draw X or Y card next
turn. Here comes the hopeful.
>> That's a draw off the conquer and then a
oh scrappy draw off the warren. So
that's a lot of new cards.
>> Three cards left. Did he have shovel
main or was it side? A lot of the the
players are shovel side and and I think
we might be in that same boat for Colin
if we don't see it played almost
immediately here which means that
burnout is actually real as far as
giving Allen a point but he's not in
position to win from burnout. And really
it would just be Colin gets like a
refreshed deck, but he wouldn't have a
bin to work with anymore.
>> Though there's not really much to do
with the bin at this stage of the game
with all the Rosses in it, all
everything in it.
>> All right. Well, we see almost
everything go to the warrants. Hopeful,
fan, and merchant. The other hopeful
stays home.
>> Hidden card as well. Allen's going to
scoop it up. It looks like doesn't have
the answer in his hand. So, that's going
to be game one going over to Colin. What
a masterclass between these two players
on this matchup. Colin evading the Vex
for a very long time and Allen finding
the patience, finding spots to gain some
perches back in the matchup. Cleared
both cycles from Colin, but just
couldn't deal with the the chaff
remaining at the very end. Too many
points that Colin gained by being able
to cascade that equipment, doing
everything perfectly. Really well done
from Colin to take down the champ Allen
in game one.
>> Yeah, truly awesome game. uh just a
masterclass for both players. So we go
into game two here and the clock is, you
know, a bit of a factor with 30 minutes
left for two more games. We see a turn
two Draven and Ezreal on turn one,
Sigil of a Storm and Oblo Power, sorry,
turn one Draven, apologize, uh Obelisk
Power and Sig of Storm the battlefield.
So turn one, Ezreal, turn one, Draven,
both signature units coming in. Here's a
called shot and uh Allen has some work
to do here and Allen of course needs to
win two games to win this match. Uh so
the clock is a factor for Allen. Yep.
>> Speeding through, shortcutting the
double student play. Four runes.
>> Yep. Okay,
>> we saw another call shot picked up.
Allan just waiting till next turn when
he's got a seal available again. So, he
can cast that for free. The students
going to be a lot faster for this game.
He can try and get underneath Colin with
this kind of start as long as he still
has good interaction in hand. These
students become absolute menaces. I
think the record we've seen is is one at
at uh I believe it was 12 or 14 uh when
we were in testing and I think he even
got one up to 10 or 11 during Bolognia.
Uh so these things can become monsters
uh in the hands of Ezreal.
>> All right, so back Colin's way call shot
to start.
Colin in the driver's seat up a game and
this is one of our undefeated matches.
The conclusion of this round we will
have either one or two undefeated
players barring draws.
And Draven's in. Here's a ram
but nothing else. Just a single ram. So
back Allen's way Ezreal and Raven Bloom
currently has the unit advantage.
It's a called shot again, you know, and
uh we'll keep account of the the Raven
Blooms here. That's going to be one on
this
as that is going to be relevant pushing
in for the potential combat that will
follow flurry of spells.
>> Okay, so both students coming in. They
are both threes
and now of course Draven or Draven
triggers. Does Colin want to spend a
fury to make Dven into a six or leave it
as as a four? Again, tough with these
students not knowing how big they're
going to be.
>> Yeah, the thing with Allen is when he
sends an attack like this. I think
there's no correct answer for Colin
because if he if he takes it, then Allen
is going to have a punish in hand. And
we actually see this with stack deck can
either find an answer or we also saw a
fridge touch which can completely blow
out spending the rune. But if he doesn't
spend the rune, Allen also has the
option to blow out in a much easier way
where he just has to push above four.
>> All right, so we're gonna see stack deck
uh put an active speed focus back to
Colin Fighter Flight uh targeting the
Draven. So before Superfly was even
played, both players playing fast here,
but focuses pass back and forth. So
Draven goes back uh a little reveal
there on Superfy.
And now uh that's a point for Allen. And
on the board, Obelisk of Power
and those uh those Raven Blooms can be
pretty hard to break.
>> Yeah, this is where Allen starts to pass
with a large amount of runes open and a
lot of games. So, I'm curious what more
he's willing to play on this turn.
>> You've already seen it. I'll cash it in.
>> Yeah, does go for the supery. Still four
runes remaining after this.
>> All right, so Bellow's breath time.
>> Yeah, it means he has a clear.
So he's bellows for the draw and now
it's going to be frigid touch with
repeat and that's just going to get rid
of everything. So Allan going to tempo
this out. Uh recognizing, you know, you
showed me a little weakness. You played
out one of these battering rams and not
much more. Seems like uh not a lot of
deck velocity so far. Have the students
out and he's looking to tempo out this
game.
>> All right, so great sequence from Allen
cleaning up the board. Double student to
play. Ezra's hanging out too. And now
it's back to Colin. Try and rebuild.
Called shot's a great place to start.
>> Yeah, it's the best way to start, right?
I mean, the only the only better would
be like Ezreal first and then the called
shot, but just doesn't have one. Called
shot going to be plenty though to start
finding some units and look for a
rebuild. Allen has to be very wary of
the potential of a bushwack here.
>> Bushwack is actually
>> a complete blowout of the current
position on the board with double
student there. Bushwack into a battering
ram pushing over may actually win the
game for Colin. So there is something to
dig towards with the called shot with
the stack. If you can find Bushwack plus
one ram, you're there. But now it's a
little too late. It would have to be
Bushwack plus Rossa, but I don't think
we have 10 in the bin yet.
>> It's close, but I think you're right.
>> Wow. Okay. Yeah. So Allen went Shield's
down and Colin could not find the not
find the perfect combination of cards.
So going back Allen's way, we got a hole
for the students. Allen up two to one.
Interesting to see that the the
different pacing of game one and game
two. Game was paid so slowly, so
patiently this game more aggressive.
Yeah, and we already see a seal as the
first play for Allen. Seal pay for seal.
He did end up keeping Vex's in. I think
she ended up being pretty impressive in
that last game. Overall, I think Allen
recognizing, okay, there's enough spells
for Colin that maybe this is still
worthwhile. And the reductions uh do
feel pretty important. You need some of
your own might value on top of that. So
Allen going to hold on to the Vexes. I'm
not sure exactly how many copies that
he'll still be on. He may be on three,
it may be less.
>> All likes to tune his deck each game
kind of based on what he sees on the
other side. It's how he sideboards.
Whenever I ask him about sideboard plans
when we're talking about the game, he's
like, I see what I played against and
then I move them in. So it's not set
plans on how he likes to swap things in
and out.
>> Yeah. And even though Vex game one, it
didn't actually spend a lot of time
doing things. The game revolved around
it trying to not do things. Correct. So
going back way hopeful and Ezreal stack
deck is the start and uh a lot of might
deployed from Allen here. Uh just play
that pickpocket. Did they get a seal? I
got a seal.
>> Yeah, did missed that one. So pickpocket
double student and Fizz and Ezreal
called shot again.
>> Feels like these decks have eight called
shots each.
>> Yeah, it really does. And it's it's a
Fizz. I mean, it is Fizz that is causing
this uh to be the case, right? Uh you're
constantly playing them out and and the
seal getting destroyed is going to hurt
on the the miracle side of things,
right? Like we saw where those runes
ended up in that last game and that was
after Colin spent the whole game
methodically building up essentially 11
runes and then goodbye. They all went
away in a single turn, right? And now
this time not having that time to build
up those runes while Allen is building
up actually more might than the last
game. It's deceptive, right? Because
there were two vexes last time. That has
to be more might, right? Raven Bloom uh
when we actually get to the nitty-gritty
of it in the big turns, they're bigger
than five every time pretty much. All
right, so not a bad uh bad flow here. We
got Noxious and Battering Ram and
Noctturn all to back up for Colin.
Scores up at two with the Noxville, but
now we're going back Allen's way. It is
22, but Allen definitely definitely has
the initiative
and starts things off with a stack deck.
>> Oh, seal seal for seal. So seal seal
popped in there also.
>> Yeah. Usually a lot of players when they
shortcut it, they actually just play the
new seal exhausted. Sure. Because it's
the same thing, right?
>> Yep.
>> So stupify and student. So we have a I
believe that's two spells played so far
for this
>> four and three.
>> So stupify and student just a potent set
one combination still great here in set
number two. So Allen goes up to two.
A lot of my to worry about in the back
row for Colin.
Big pocket will take the sigil and uh
sigil will require a rune to be
recycled. So goodbye rune. Another tax
on Colin's runes too. If Colin wants to
go for that sigil, you know, with the
pick pocket taking out the seal already
a little light on runes anyway. Yeah,
it's pain. It is really painful to have
to deal with. And Allen, you know, he he
tapped out earlier and then when he
tapped it again, he brought everything
home. At this point, anytime he's
staying on field, you'll see him keep
full runes and he'll fight and then
he'll cycle back where it's like, okay,
opponent can't push in. So now I score
hold, I run home.
>> This is very big.
>> Walks into a brine here.
>> Thunderstorm comes down and uh the whole
plan always runs up is not a good one.
Thunderstorong now. Of course, there's
going to be some reactions.
>> Yep. Going to start with smoke.
>> So smoke screen rule target.
>> We'll see what the target is and it's
going to be uh the battering rams
battering them down to minus four. These
Raven Blooms are up one each and uh that
is the only spell. So shields down for
Allen. Allen's got to sit and be a
spectator here as Noctturn comes in.
Essats the pick pocket. A point is
scored. A run recycled. And now we see
Knoxville and Ezreal come into Students.
That is a seven to six.
>> Yeah.
>> And nothing to worry about here. Usually
you're it feels a little weird to kind
of go into a slim margin of error on a
combat, but with Thundersong there, that
feels great. So calling up to four. We
have 44 now and killing those students
is a very difficult thing to do. Now
that they're gone, that's a huge win for
Colin.
>> Yeah, this is massive. There there is no
better timing for a Brin and Allen only
having one response. Often times Ezreal
is able to fire off you know smoke
frigid touch with repeat and then you
know you actually can't even break the
student still after all that happens and
all you got was you traded out two of
those spells that he actually gets to
grab one back by activating Ezreal as
well. often Britain here doesn't
actually get things done and Colin
finding a rare occasion where it's
actually a very big punish against
Ezreal. You would expect this card to be
like an obvious punishing desal all the
time but there are so many times where
it does nearly nothing.
Allen still working it through here is
thousand watcher
>> bellow's breath is in the hand as well
to follow along with this. So, we get to
see this little minor combo here of uh I
guess not that not that minor. Thousand
thousand del Watcher and Bella's breath.
>> Yeah. Well, we'll start up first. So,
Watcher shrinks all of Colin's units
down minus three. Yeah. So, this will be
easy. Ezreal into sigil. Fizz into
oblisk. Bellow's breath with repeat on
the backline. Wipes out everything
except for Rosa. And the look is can you
find something to actually clear the
rasa? Looks like this time, no, because
off the draw, he's just gonna find
nothing else. No more energy. So, the
Rosa has to get left. It's not a perfect
clear, but it is Allen to six and Colin
with nothing but a Rosa on the board.
>> Yeah, still pretty good.
So, back Colin's way Rosabasunderer
holding the fort.
And now, what's the next step? Coming
right in. So, Raza for Fizz. Colin goes
to five.
Draw off Draven
and what is the follow?
>> Allen has the best followup for the next
turn. Arcane Shift
for the Thousand Watcher reacelerate it.
>> So if Colin cannot remove the Ezreal and
it gets to hold, that's always winning.
>> Oh,
>> the Bushwack is perfect. This is a way
that Colin
>> can at least set up the board where he
doesn't just lose to Allen on the next
turn. And that can buy space. That can
buy a way back in. That can buy a win.
>> And here we go.
>> It's going to be hopeful.
>> Knock, but that's enough.
>> Takes the Ezreal now. Painful. A lot of
runes being used here, but that is a a
big time play for Colin going up to six.
And then with Allen only on six, um
there isn't really a way for Allen to
push that eighth point. The only
accelerating unit in the deck is the
10,000 D Watcher, right? Yeah.
>> Okay, here we go. Back Allen's way. This
has been a slugfest. Both players
playing phenomenally.
That was a handful of cards. Here comes
Thousand Tail.
>> This is how you can conquer both though.
Push the Thousand Tail in.
>> Score to seven. Arcane Shift to base.
Shoot here. Accelerate. Score to eight.
And Allen has the win.
>> All right. So, you can play your
accelerate cost when you play it off the
shift. come back in, play the
accelerate. Thousand tales in. Allen
takes game number two in what has been
one of the most exciting matches of the
entire weekend. Game three, 18 minutes
left. I cannot wait. I'm very, very
happy they have a good amount of time.
If if we were going to game three with
like 6 minutes left, I would be very
disappointed to not see a natural
conclusion, but these players are going
to gear up and get ready to go for one
of the matches of the weekend so far.
>> Look, Jim, you're absolutely right.
There's only one accelerate unit in the
deck, but when you get to replay it,
>> right,
>> it's actually two of them.
>> So, really, really cool uh synergy
there. uh being able to accelerate off
of the cast from the shift.
Boy, game three, Allan, Colin, two of
our remaining undefeated players. At the
end of this round, we will have three or
sorry, two or one undefeated players.
This could be a match for King of the
Hill. Oh boy. Buckle up, folks.
>> Yeah. And Allen going to be on the
starting Obelisk power. I think that may
have been a downwell that he shipped to
the bottom.
something you like into the miracle
deck, but only later on. You don't want
to start the game with it. It can clog
up your hand quite a bit, especially if
you don't have the rest of what you're
looking for. On the obelis game, the
Vexes definitely come back in turn two
play that you can make. We'll often see
the skip on turn one from Ezreal if
there isn't a good discard target, but
usually Allen likes to get the Ezreal in
and online right away.
Speaking of online right away, turn one
Ezra from Colin. Discarding a knockful
draw two.
All right, speak for Colin. Oblisk of
power for Allen. That one right to four
and getting to work.
>> Yep. Going second. So it can still be
Ezreal on turn one. Vex on turn two if
he would like, but he does have a
student. Even better.
>> All right, so student pass. Two runes
up.
>> Going Collins way. needs to wait for a
better target for his Ezreal that he
wants to discard. Student is still going
to be able to actually contend with the
board. Play for Taran's peak. Resetting
those runes with a student is incredibly
potent. You already saw how potent
student was just in general in this
deck. But now when you get to actually
spend your spells, develop, and then get
two runes back that you can play with
the student, it it creates a lot of
crazy ranges because with two runes
back, you have stack deck stupify, you
have stupify, stupify, you have frigid
touch, you have called shot, stack deck,
stupify. I don't need to go on. There is
a lot of permutations,
>> a lot of ways that you can increase this
might to kind of un ridiculous numbers
like numbers that are nearly impossible
to correctly play around every time. You
sort of have to put Allen on a hand and
hope that you can play into it. All
right, so we do see the Draven play to
Vargon speak trying to find the might to
defend against the Raven Bloom student
trying to stop that student move in
Targon's untap. Two runes ready for
Colin and you know what Allens is fine.
I'll go the other place. So going to go
to the Obisk power. There's a point and
there's a Vex. So
>> Vex is in. Allen's at one. Colin's going
to two on the hold. And now Draven and
Ezreal both not not stuck at Targon's
peak, but you know, unable to really do
too much else besides go home at the
moment. But could this be the big pop
off turn for Colin?
>> Yeah, I mean that's look turn three
always can be. And it started with Seal
Ezreal. I mean this is exactly what
Colin wants. I think this game from the
outset is very good for the miracle
side. You start with Ezreal on turn one
because of the oblisk with a seal. Then
you get Draven. Now you get to go to
your normal turn three. I mean we see a
call shot and a stack deck already, you
know, getting played is getting to dig
through this deck. There's really
nothing more you can ask for as a
miracle player at this stage. All right,
steal number two.
>> Here is Ezreal number two
and discard a hopeful again.
Right. Yeah. I going to say power
crossplay as well. There we go. And uh
>> so many hopefuls.
>> Brings everything home.
>> Opals in back out at two. Sego. So Allen
goes up to two. Players at parody at
two.
Vex hanging out in base. Students coming
home.
And now what's the next step for Alen?
We've seen patient Vex playing from game
one. Game two is play a little faster.
And here she's an Ezreal. Oh, Ezreal
discarding Vex number two. Draw two.
>> He finds a bellows. There's a pretty big
clear on the backline with a repeat.
Frigid touch.
>> I don't think he has it. I think the
bellows is missing.
>> Okay, so if Vex goes in, this will
trigger Targons, put Allen to three, and
then of course now put K in a spot where
if Colin wants to contend with the
Targons, Vex gets into that combat and
the cost reduction gets happened
>> with all these runes,
>> right? with all these runes and an
Ezreal. Uh I don't even want to try and
calculate how many cards Allen can play
potentially.
>> All of them.
>> There's all of them.
>> Yeah, I would say all of them is a is a
reasonable look at this point.
>> Stack deck to start up for for Colin.
>> Really cool. The texture of all three of
these games has been pretty pretty
different in a really really cool way.
So
>> stack deck called shot.
>> Train choo choos on more cards.
Can Colin find the right combination to
put himself up to 10 and0 here in Las
Vegas at the regional qualifier?
Ooh, hello
Brin here.
>> Thundersong. Okay, so
>> once again finds a spot where the Brin
gets to be very good looking for it with
the called shot with the stack deck.
>> Yeah,
>> in her ugly head Colin finding some very
good opportunities for these Brins.
Yeah, great counterplay of Vex of course
as well. So now Vex is uh you know he
can reduce all the cost of all the cards
you want. Uh you can't play them so who
cares. So Thundong in now Allen needs to
decide what reactions will happen.
Response to desert stupify and it looks
like that might have been it. Wow.
Thundersong big deal. So here comes
hopeful. Here comes Ezreal. Vex is gone.
>> Huge exchange.
>> Draw off the Draven. Goodbye Knoxville.
Ezreal stays in.
Targon will also untap two RS.
>> Yeah, call shot again.
>> So, fire up a shot. More cards. Wants to
maybe find a good answer at two runes to
this uh push in from the Raven Bloom
student cuz Colin's going to want to go
to four here
>> if he can prevent Allen from clearing
stuff for free. That's that's pretty big
for him.
He's just going to send the Draven.
>> All right, so Draven goes over to Oblok
of Power
>> and a Ram. The next step is a ram. All
right, so endstep on tap two for
Targon's Peak. Say go. Big turn for
Allen. The Allen needs to kind of kind
of fire back here. Great turn for Colin.
These Thunder Songs have been fantastic.
Perfectly timed. Now it's Allen's turn
to figure out the puzzle and figure out
what to do at three points. Handful of
cards, so plenty of options.
>> Down on the point tempo. no Bella's
breath that we've seen so far, which is
the key piece in this matchup. You have
so many different ways to enable it to
remove much of the board, but you do
need to find that part of the combo.
Ezreal doesn't have a lot of trouble
doing so, right? You you dig through
your deck very quickly. You know, we saw
the Victor, it draws a decent amount of
cards, but not that many, and so it's
struggled to find the full combo pieces.
Ezreal almost always has it. And we are
going to see the Frigid Dutch with
repeat get a draw from Ezreal. He's
digging.
So shrink those down.
>> Combat looking a little nicer here. So
we see Ezreal come into Ezreal and uh
the mirror match is one by the one that
is not very very cold.
Seal discord
student is uh oh boy. Okay
>> he's digging further.
>> So here's a shift.
>> Shift can do three dam damage to the
Draven.
And we'll see the banish will be Ezreal
almost assuredly.
>> Yep. and he's pointing the damage. The
Draven currently at the minus two. If
Colin has a spinning axe, it has to be
deployed now.
Looks like that is what is being thought
of unless I mean it could just be hard
bargain to force Allen to drop his last
two runes.
>> That that would still be strong. You
lose the Draven, but you prevent further
action from Allen.
>> But it is the axe.
>> All right, so just an axe. So now
Draven's up to five. five with three
damage marked. Our players here, I mean,
they know they're doing super clean and
discard the bargain. So, had the option
there.
And now we see Raven Bloom is currently
plus two.
>> So, Raven Bloom at four. The Draven is
at five with three damage and going to
move in. Is this a trade or is this a uh
more spells?
>> I think he's just trading. Yeah, it it
looks like trade. He drew a new student.
I think it's trade, deploy, new student,
and just pass.
>> Cool. So getting the axe also is the big
deal. So
>> y
>> new student targon to conquer ready of
the runes. Sega going back way
>> you know weathered the storm of brin
already. Not what he wanted to see on
the side of Allen. Right. The the Brin
was very good in this spot once again
right trying to rely on more of these
action speed cards not finding the the
stack of reactions that work but he did
have the frigid touch. I think it was a
conscious decision for Allen that hey, I
actually can't contest this in a way
that is very meaningful and I need these
cards maybe for the next turn to try and
look for better clear. So he he lets the
Vex go with just a trade.
Now however K has a chance to go to six.
>> Yeah.
>> And that is a big deal as we saw in the
previous game
trying to put Allen in like a sort of a
sort of a check almost. So Ram comes in
>> stack deck action speed. Take a look one
rune over. It's going to be the fizz.
>> So take fizz
>> and stock deck again.
>> So a setup turn. Allen saying, you know
what, fine. Take your six points.
>> It's very good use for Taran's peak to
find the two stack decks.
>> Yeah, just dig
>> two energy that he wouldn't have had.
Two extra energy getting to be used.
>> Only downside here is those stack deck
choices needed to be made before the
rest of a turn was taken. So the cards
that Allen took,
we'll see if they pan out or not because
obviously we're going to see a bunch of
things happen here for Colin. So here's
Fizz. Here's called shot.
Keep those cards coming.
It was a flexible choice by Allen,
right? Is the Fizz.
Second option I believe was Fizz or
Rossa. Oh no, I think it might have been
that second Arcane Shift. So there's
another shift. So Fizz shift is going to
be available.
Okay, so Thunderong comes into our guns
and that is that all important sixth
point. Colin looking to be in a good
spot but wants to keep following up.
>> Next step is another Ezreal.
Looks like he wants to find as much
might as possible to put on the back
row.
>> Got to pay power there.
>> Likely to lose the battering ram and the
Brin here. Mhm.
>> All right. So, ready two say go. Colin
on the edge of being 10 and0 going back
Allen's way. Allen has not lost a match
in I don't know basically forever. 25
matches was the count, right?
>> 25
>> across Bolognia and here in Vegas. Allen
does not want the streak to end just
yet. Has his eyes on another trophy.
Here's Fizz. Here's Frigid Touch.
>> Judge with repeat. Just has to pay the
one extra because he has Ezreal on
board. Five runes remain after the fact.
That may be a bargain.
>> All right, so Colin with a bargain not
repeated. So says you got to pay two
more for that if you want that to go
through.
>> It's not what Allen really wants to see
because he needs all these runes so that
he can then play defense on the next
turn. I think Colin may be marching
towards being the first person to unseat
Allen
since the start of Spirit forward,
but we are going to have a response to
the hard bargain to draw from Ezreal.
He's targeted two units with the frigid
touch repeat.
>> Wants to know his options going forward
if he can let that just resolve.
>> Wow. So, the bargain uh interesting on
both sides. Colin could have repeated
for four and then Allen could have paid.
Both players just doing the thing. Two
and two. I love a bargain being paid
just to tap some uh to potentially tap
some runes and then still resolving to
counter a spell. So now Allen's back at
it. That spell was not played for Raven
St. Correct. being countered.
>> Correct. It was countered so it will not
count.
>> And now we see Arcane Shift shift the
Fizz.
Three damage will go to either the
thundersong or the rim. And then touch
again. Here's a repeat. So the
thundersong took three off the arcane
shift. The touch will shrink it down by
two. Finished it off. Ram is now also at
three might. So
a costly turn but working well so far.
Here comes student. Student is currently
a three. Ram four
>> four two
>> free to touch ar shift.
>> Right. Right. And then Ezreal comes in.
We see a fight or flight.
>> That can't be stopped.
>> That's his back it up. So Allen at four,
a student and only one rune. huge
because that denied the two runes of
Targon's peak setting up Colin to win
the game next turn.
>> Yeah, and I think Allen needed that. I
think Colin is going to have a little
too much might. It's going to be a
hidden wages of pain here
>> from there. I mean, maybe Stupify is the
best case scenario, but 369 power
might for Colin.
One of them has to go target Spak in
order to go to seven.
>> So only six coming in. I mean, wages
plus a one cost spell is going to deny
just on board victory for Colin, but
there's still untap of all these runes.
>> Oh, it's coming in quick. Bushwack time.
Oh boy, that's probably just going to
>> triple roster. The scoop up from Allen.
>> Wow. Colin taking down Allen. The streak
is over and Colin moves 10 and0.
Actually unbelievable. That match was
one of the best matches I've ever seen
in my entire life.
>> Yeah, I mean this is this is perfection.
This is this is beauty in motion of
Riftbound. This is what the game can be.
Colin is the one to finally defeat Allen
ZQ after 25 sets of Riftbound in Spirit
Forged.
>> And he might get a rematch later. We'll
see if Allen can hold on deeper into
this tournament. That's the first loss
Allen has taken,
>> right? It's a real statement to Allen's
dominance recently that we're playing
this off like Allen's out of a
tournament.
>> Yeah. No, he's still in.
>> Allen's just one loss, you know. So,
>> first one,
>> right? Still still looking great for top
eight. Uh an absolutely phenomenal play
on both sides. That was the most high
level match I've ever watched in my
entire life. Uh just truly art.
>> Look, and Allan has said multiple times
that the the only person he's scared of
is Prismat. And one of the reasons is is
Prismat plays Miracle Draven to
perfection, beautifully in the matchup,
knowing the matchup inside and out, and
he knows, hey, that is something that I
can lose. Colin just proved that he can
also play Miracle Draven to perfection
in the matchup. Knows it inside and out.
And so, it's another person that Allen
has to add to that tally list of I'd
rather not see Colin. I'd rather see
probably anybody but Prismat and Colin.
>> Wow. Unbelievable stuff. Let's pop down
and see what Colin has to say, if he can
even talk after that match.
Thank you so much. I'm here with Colin
who is still undefeated here at the
original qualifier in Las Vegas taking
on none other than Alzhe
very tricky different style of deck I
think pretty well. Uh especially for my
first time seeing it. I I think I played
it well and it certainly worked out for
me.
>> Certainly did. Now you're on Draven for
this event. How has the deck been for
you this weekend? Uh, it's been
excellent, honestly. Uh, I love the
deck. It really kind of rewards my style
of play. I think a lot of it is just
being able to understand the order of
your deck and stacking it in such a way
that I know when I'm going to get to the
rest of my cards because you draw so
many cards. You see so many things that
you get to go through your deck multiple
times. And that style of play really
rewards a good player, I think. And
hopefully I've been representing that to
show people at home what it's like.
>> Well, you're undefeated, so I feel like
you are doing a good job there. As far
as metag game goes, especially on day
two. How has it been kind of early on?
>> Yeah, I ended up actually playing
Prismat last round on a mirror. So, that
was also a difficult match, but I was
able to beat him. And then now I just
played his teammate Alain today. So, uh
was able to two or two Prismat. And then
Alain got me for one game. So, uh at
least there was that. So, it's been
performing extremely well and uh
hopefully I think I need to win one more
in order to secure top cut. So hopefully
we'll we'll be able to do that and
you'll be able to see more of me
playing. I
>> was going to say getting pretty close.
How are we feeling about tope if we make
it?
>> Uh I mean honestly I never really
thought I'd get this far. I've had been
I've done well in some of the unofficial
events, but uh when it comes to the
official events, I felt like I've been
cursed up until this one. My first runs
have been uh not not too lucky. But for
now, we're doing okay. So, I'm excited
to be able to hopefully go there and
represent my team and all my friends and
uh I think I'm going to try and bring it
home. So, if you're out there, root for
me.
>> Best of luck.
>> Thank you so much.
>> Got to say it's kind of hard not to. Uh
takes down Priz takes down Allen and
we've heard the word he is our king of
the hill. He is our last undefeated
player in the tournament which is a
phenomenal place to be in a great set to
make top eight.
>> Yeah. No, amazing job from Colin. I
mean, the the stars that have been
emerging in Riftbound, Allen, Pris,
these are the players. They've they
topped in Houston, they topped in
Bolognia. I mean, Allen won Bolognia,
and now here they started the day
undefeated. So, when you're looking at
Riftbound as a young fledgling game,
these are names that you're immediately
looking at. And calling having a
tournament where he beats both of them
two rounds in a row to stay undefeated,
I mean, that is building his own star
power and legacy here in Riftbound early
on. Yeah, you almost want to, you know,
say, "Oh, we're scripted. This could
this is too perfect, you know, too
perfect of a way to ble to be
undefeated." So, uh, fantastic stuff
here. Every round I think to myself, how
are we going to top this last round? And
we just keep doing it. So, you don't go
nowhere. All right, we got round 11
coming up here in Las Vegas.
Heat. Heat.
Heat.
What is
heat?
Oh,
heat, heat.
Heat. Heat.
Oh
yeah.
Oh,
you meat.
Welcome back to coverage of original
qualifier Las Vegas. If you've been
having fun watching the matches, maybe
try out a summoner skirmish. We can go
out and maybe try and win a buy one of
these things. You can go beyond and
begin to qualify at
uvsgames.com/riftbound-organized-play.
Ursay wins your first summon skirmish
coming up.
>> I got to find one soon. It be so much
fun to go to, I'm sure.
>> Well, I'm Patri. We're here to bring you
coverage of round 11 and a little bit
more beyond that. Already two rounds in
to the five rounds of suits we have
today. Don't forget, we also have a top
eight coming up. Feels like there's a
lot of rift bound still left to play,
but where we're at so far has been
pretty exciting.
>> Yeah, there have been so many great
games. We've seen some of the top
players really fight it out on on the
screen and some of them victorious,
others still fighting their way through
day two.
>> And I tried to ask people that are
smarter than me roughly how is the
tiebreers going to work out cuz I'm not
very good at tiebreers. And they told me
the way it's designed, X1 is definitely
going to make it. Beyond that, don't ask
me. It was basically what they said. So,
uh, still in the hunt for X1 for a lot
of these players. Still a lot of players
with that record. I don't think there's
an undefeated player left at this point,
but I could be completely wrong. Maybe
we'll check on that later when we look
at the standings later.
>> Yeah, we'll have to find out. We are
only in the third round of today with
>> Oh, god. Is that round 11?
>> Yep.
>> So, we have so many rounds more to go.
We'll have to see how they navigate
their way to it.
>> Well, you talked about some of our top
players. have a little video showcasing
three players that have been doing quite
well internationally in Riftbound.
In our third regional qualifier for the
West, we have a few names that have kind
of risen to the top. Allen ZQ after a
top eight in Houston, he took his Ezreal
on a dominant run throughout Bolognia,
going undefeated throughout the entire
event. And now here in Vegas, he
continues that streak at 8-0.
Prismaticism after a top 64 exit in
Houston, he was able to find another top
in Bolognia. Now he just looks for the
chance to finally hoist that trophy that
he has so narrowly missed. Randy the
only player to top in three different
continents. North America, Europe, and
China yet to hoist a first place trophy
is here still at 7:01 fighting for yet
another top eight in Vegas.
I have to say it is just so impressive
watching players fly to NA a week after
topping an event in Europe and just be
like, you know what, it's chill. I've
been following Alan's Twitter. He's
consistently complaining about how
little sleep he's been getting and still
doesn't seem to matter that much.
>> Yeah, there have been so many players
that were in Bolognia and came here for
the Las Vegas tournament and I cannot
imagine that time difference or the
sleep deprivation you'd be at. Well,
let's have a check in on how players in
general are doing. I'm going to pull up
our standings and see who's still there.
Remember, X and one guarantees you into
the top. X and 2. There's going to be
some tiebreaker stuff. And like I said,
do not ask me about tiebreers. So, Colin
10 and0 still our only undefeated player
left after round 10. Chris Matis though
in the hunt. Allen still in the hunt at
9 and1. And a bunch of names. Randy as
well. They're at 13 and 9 and one. But a
ton of players this entire page still
players that are live for top eight.
>> Yeah. And so of many of them are ones
that we already know. Randy which was
mentioned in the video as well at 9
and1. So many great ones.
>> Yeah. No veggies also saw on feature in
Bolognia. So another player that has
come over here. Just a bunch of really
interesting names. Manton our Victor
from yesterday falling to eight and two.
But again still in with a shot and of
course the best of medals or best of
cards are still in the hunt as well for
a lot of players. We have uh quite a few
actually that are fighting out with only
a few copies of legends. So even if
they're not in this top level of
standings, there's still plenty to play
for here on day two. Yeah, there were a
couple that are the only ones in day
two. That's a good feeling.
>> It wouldn't feel so good. And then a
couple that are like two or three and I
feel like I would be sweating bullets.
>> I feel like the two would be horrible
because just every round you're checking
like where are they up to? Did they
lose?
>> Yeah. Walk up to how did you do? I I
won. Did you?
>> Yeah. I feel like the the best thing for
you would be to get paired with them and
then you can fight for it, right? Cuz
that would feel at least at least you
would feel like the best of your legend
if you fought the other person. But if
you just like each hit Draven round
after round and whoever is better
against Draven, I don't know. Imagine
hitting round nine like the first one of
the day and one lose one one wins and
you have to continue on. Yeah.
>> Yeah. Interesting. We do have some
bangers coming up of course in the
future match. See how players are just
walking on by everything getting ready.
Uh very impressed to see just in general
how the the games have been going. I
think a lot of surprises as far as
legends go which has been fun. As we are
going to check out some deck list here
cuz we do have the man himself
prismaticism on stream I believe for the
first time today. I think so as well.
And I do love uh Prismaticism's list. It
is running at least one of those knock
turns that we talked about yesterday.
Obviously is running that Ezreal or
Miracle package trying to discount a lot
of those different cards.
>> Yeah, some changes I think from Baloney,
which is always interesting. I think
both Allen and Pris have changed their
list since, you know, less than a week
ago. So it's interesting to do so well
in a tournament. Prismaticism, I might
remind you, was the best finishing
Draven at Bolognia. just barely eaked
out his teammate Randy to win the best
of Draven, which I think is a pretty
prized metal card given the how powerful
and how represented this deck has been.
But we've seen a lot of it before. Very
complicated, very powerful, and kind of
at every stage of the game once things
start going well, you can basically take
over any bullet state. You just make so
much might for so little energy.
>> Yeah, it's kind of crazy and just such a
strong way to take these wins. I wonder
if they'll be fighting for the best of
again today, but I do think Colin, who
is currently undefeated, is running
Draven as well. So, they're going to be
fighting it out here. Really excited to
see how they decide to play this deck
and try to make sure they make get it to
the top eight today.
>> We'll take a look at the match up cuz
what's on the other side here for Chris
Madison and we can take a look at his
opponent's deck list. It is a Draven
Mirror Dantelus with a very similar
looking build. See all the Russes, the
seals, but you know, a couple
differences between the two as you might
expect.
>> Yeah. one is two nocturns instead of
one, but the the side board is very
different.
>> Yeah, I think uh always interesting to
see what choices people make. Thr is an
interesting one. Factory recall, not a
piece of gear destruction. I've seen a
lot of uh maybe you respect the fact
that is action speed and you can maybe
save your own gear as well cuz it only
goes to hand, which in some cases is
good for your opponent. They just get to
replay it. In some cases, it's you know,
something like an Aurora that can be
tough to replay. But I mean, this is
also the color with access to
accelerated losses. So, a lot of
interesting choices. I mean, again, with
how prominent gear has been, it's funny
to see that these domains are the ones
rising to the top cuz they actually also
have the best gear destruction.
>> Yeah, I love red and purple. I mean,
both do have it. As you mentioned, we
see thermmo beam is another option for
uh gear destruction in the sidebar as
well as factory like you said.
>> There are two players in the
battlefields are going to be a bit
different here. Prismaticism on the
left. Zorn Warren's going to be the game
one battlefield. Reaver's row on the
other side for Techo Techo. Yeah, both
of these leaders are really going to be
well, we should keep an eye on the
reaver's row. So, as we know, Draven
gets to draw cards off of winning
combat, but if you on Reaver's Row, when
you defend, you're allowed to choose if
one of your cards goes back to your
base. And if that does happen, you still
win combat.
>> Yep, that does count as winning combat.
Same reason why Rebuke, same reason why
Flutterflight gets all that done. One of
the reasons you see those cards in all
these lists. So, it's going to be uh Al
Draven on the right. Techo starting off
here. Travel overzealous fan, excuse me,
is the first drop return. Prismaticism.
I'm sure both these players, in fact,
have played a lot of driving mirrors to
get to this point at 9 and one. So, see
what Pris's first play of this game is
going to be. Just stack deck. Set
something up. Find a two you like.
>> Yeah, it is so nice to get to pick
between those three. Go a bit deeper
into the deck, choose just the one that
you're going to want for this matchup,
and then start getting at least an idea
of what is going to be going to the
bottom of your deck. I think one of the
things that's so powerful about uh these
decks and I think in general the decks
running purple and why stack deck was
such a prominent card even from Origin
is that getting selection very early on
feels extremely powerful. So does
finding every seal in your deck. It's
not quite the LZQ3 at once, but two to
start your first turn is pretty good.
It's going to be followed by battering
ram as well.
>> Yeah, and we've played so many cards
this turn that battering ram is really
discounted here. And those two seals of
discords are going to be so strong of a
start for prismaticism. I mean, it's
only turn one and he already has a five
cost five might unit on the board.
>> Yeah, it's funny. You know, people talk
about Darius early in Origins. So, you
could play uh get your Legion trigger,
play your big might unit by playing a
seal. Yeah, this is just a battle ram
alongside two seals in a stack deck. Not
so bad. Fen channeling one extra rune is
overzealous Fang going to visit the Zorn
Warren again. Both these players pretty
interested in getting the conqueror
effect, cycling through their deck,
drawing some cards, sculpting their
hands, and we are going to put a hard
bargain into the bin.
>> Yeah, and building out our trash pile is
going to be so important for these
games. I believe both of these players
did play Rosa, I could be wrong on that.
>> Uh, so they're going to want to have a
rather large trash pile to have another
unit that's at a discounted price, one
less for each card in the trash. All
>> right. All right, well over fan and
Draven going to be played from the
chosen champion zone. Pretty good start
as far as getting some points on early.
Obviously already won for Techka side,
but that Draven is not just a four if he
wants to recycle that fury rune when
Pris chooses to come in if he does want
to. Then D can get even bigger. So
there's a potential eight might sitting
on that battlefield on turn two and
Overz can obviously have something to
say about it as well. So seems like that
second point for holding is going to be
all but guaranteed here, but we'll see
what Prismaticism can come up with on
this turn number two. Yeah, Overzilla
Span has an ability very similar to
Reaver uh not Reaver's Row, but Fight or
Flight, but to do it, Overzilla Span
will have to die and go to the trash
pile, which may seem bad to go down one
unit, but again, another card to the
trash pile is going to be so nice for
Techo Tech. Yeah, it's one of those
things where Firefly already feels so
good in a deck like Draven because again
when you lose combat against Draven when
you you often ask questions when you
answer them wrong Draven gets to draw a
card and that often means Draven gets
further and further ahead. So battering
ram going to be the consideration
charging on in again already just
printed that is six might versus five.
>> Yeah, you have to wonder what is in in
Prismaticism's hand to be putting five
might already in a six could be eight
just like you mentioned. The of note
here, there are two defenders actually
that Tech Tekko has to take with
Draven's one to recycle a rune and maybe
get bigger and overzealous fans to maybe
push this battering ram out of the Zorn
Warren. So again already sitting here at
six might what order you want to do
these in and and what you want to do
with two pretty important things to
figure out and it's just going to be
Overzan going to take the free draw here
basically as battering ram gets kicked
out.
>> Okay, Rub sure.
>> Okay. Yeah, Rebuke is going to send
Draven back to Techo's hand, which will
mean he won't win the combat since one
of his units does not stay at Zon
Warren's at the end of the showdown, but
we will see be able to replay it again
next turn since it's only in our hand.
>> Yeah, stack deck here going to set it
up. If there's something better than the
Draven to play, maybe consider that
here. But, uh, we already know, as you
mentioned, Draven sitting in hand ready
to be redeployed. And I think one of the
things that's very powerful about Draven
and it is almost always red Draven in
these decks. I don't think I've seen a
single purple Draven in these list.
Certainly Aurelia does like that card
from time to time. Doesn't cost any
power either. So doesn't even d ramp you
just a little bit when you do want to
play your turn two Draven. So Draven
instead going to be replaced by a
Darius. Feels a little bit better here.
Bigger unit going to be readied up right
away. And perhaps we'll send ourselves
on over to the battlefield. So a little
bit more mid-rangey here for Techo. Not
going for the full miracle even though
he does have again seals and rases if I
recall correctly. Yeah, you called uh
Darius earlier when we were talking
about battering Ram, but one of the nice
things about Darius as well is when you
play that second card, he doesn't only
get ready, but he also gets larger. So,
Draven, you do have to pay an actual
power cost to make him two larger. But
Darius, if you play two cards, it
suddenly seven might.
>> Yeah. And sitting on this battlefield
here, a hidden card has been placed on
the Zone Warren. And uh again, the
assumption is always it's fight or
flight. There's lots of other options.
There's quite a few hidden cards that
these decks play cuz it is good to kind
of mix up the potential options for your
opponent even in a theoretical world
where the deck lists were open. Much
easier when you look at a deck list to
see say six different hidden cards if
even though if half of them are fight or
flight than it is to see like oh it's
just fight so I always know what it is.
>> Yeah. Almost adding those different
cards also adds a sense of you know
almost like mysticism you might say. Uh
you don't know and it's less information
that your opponent has which is really
really nice in these games. Doesn't make
sense to get value out of hidden if
you're only hiding hiding the same thing
every single time. Shout out to the
Victor trial decks where it was always
hidden blade hidden at the battlefield
as prismaticism considering whether this
bing around wants to go back in if it
even can right now. Darius is a five
again. Have to think about all the
different options, all the different
permutations that this hidden card could
be. And also falling behind on points
while trying to make this happen. This
battle ram looked pretty good early but
Techo start has been nice and Draven's
going to get deployed. Here's a
traveling merchant. Looks like we're
taking a turn off. going to pass it on
back.
>> Yeah, we did take a turn off, but adding
six might to that base is going to be so
nice for prismaticism. He's just
developing the base and saying I can
come back later, which is what a lot of
miracle decks can do.
>> Yeah, you do want to again pick your
spots carefully against Draven in
combat. Uh maybe waiting on something
like a rebuke, maybe a way to push the
Darus off the battlefield, which would
remove the hidden card. On the other
side though, Techka very politely
fanning most of his hand just barely uh
barely in front of our overhead view of
the table. I see an overzealous fan
which may be joining Darius here in just
a moment. And indeed it will.
>> It does look like it. And Darius now is
safe to move out of that battlefield as
well. If he had moved base with that
hidden there and nothing else, that
hidden would have been destroyed. So by
placing overzilla's fan there, it does
save it. And it looks like we're going
to beef up that battlefield as well by
adding our our Draven Vanquisher as
well. Yeah, replaying the Draven that
was there, readying the Darius, hiding
another card, and just saying, you know
what, I want to take these two points.
I'm already ahead. I'm kind of racing
towards eight at this point, trying to
put a lot of pressure on Prismaticism,
who's again looking to build up a force,
but it just every turn doesn't seem
quite big enough to contend with what
Techo's got going on.
>> Yeah, we're kind of just stalling out
trying to figure out what pieces we need
here on Prismaticism's side. We have
those two seals. We do have, what is
this? 11 might already in our base. And
maybe we'll finally find our way into a
battlefield here with eight runes up as
well as the two seals.
>> They're going to move in. Both Dravens
get the opportunity to trigger. So, uh,
Prismaticism, I think, has to go first
on that attack trigger, but does at
least move get the traveling merchant
trigger. And looks like passing on the
attack trigger for his Draven.
>> But we have so many cards in our hand
now as an option. We were lucky enough
to have scrap keep in hand for that
discard on traveling merchant which
means while we discard it we now get to
draw two not just one which means those
eight runes could be so many options.
>> Yeah. So like you said it is uh 11 might
there. You can kind of consider the
Dravens as roughly equal but looks like
Techo is stacking it up. Wanted to put
the Draven trigger under the Overzel fan
and Overz fan's going to kick out yet
another unit. I'd have to assume the
battering ramp cuz it's currently the
biggest. I believe prismaticism has
already passed on his Draven trigger.
So, this Draven is not going to be
recycling a rune to get any bigger.
>> It does look like he is still a four. I
did see we tapped the Draven, so I
wonder if we became a six on Tech Teko's
side, but if he did, it is now six
versus six. Still that hidden that could
help us win this showdown, though.
>> Didn't see a red rune get recycled just
yet. So, looks like uh now we're going
for Okay,
interesting. Looks like the way triggers
are resolving prismaticism was allowed
to wait.
>> Oh, that's ah it's defense triggers goes
on first. I think that's why.
>> Yeah, I think that's why. I hope I'm
remembering how my triggers work
correctly, but I believe defender has to
choose first. So, it makes sense.
Prismaticism is now deciding. And I
believe Techo has passed in that case if
that is correct.
>> And now we're going to play our hidden
card in showdown and push that Draven
away.
>> Yeah, that is a fighter flight hopefully
pushing away. Hard bargain is going to
come down which does make that fight or
flight cost more if we want it to
resolve. We
>> don't have any runes up though, so we
are going to lose the showdown.
>> Yeah, hard bargain being very much like
a hard counter spell there in that
instance often can be uh not so good
later in the game when your opponent has
maybe an excess of resources. But in
this spot where resources are very tight
and so are the might values of the units
battling, prismaticism does successfully
fend off that battlefield and win the
Draven mirror. also draw a card. Don't
forget, thanks to the uh ability of the
legend, which is kind of a fun one in
the driven mirror. You know, both
players want to win combat, so it's very
important to win them.
>> Yeah, it is so nice to get those draws
off. We get to draw from our Draven. We
get to discard and draw off of Zan
Warren as well. Slowly procuring a hand
that is going to be perfect hopefully to
win this game. And Ezreal is going to
come down. We'll get to discard one off
of him as well and draw two. But more
importantly is the ability where he now
discounts by one additional costs which
is going to make things like calling
shot only one power but can discount
other ones as well.
>> Yeah, lots of uh good things you can get
even if you're not playing Ezreal the
deck. If you're playing purple and
Ezreal, you can still do the things with
C that we've seen all weekend long. But
battering ram going to be the selection
here. And here's a cold shot. Oh, it's a
hidden card. I lied. There's only one of
two things. And now Prismatic hasn't
picked the second door, but does hide
something under the zone warrants as
Techo at least going to go to five here
off of the Darius still chilling on the
bottom battlefield. So Prismaticism
pretty behind in points but has now kind
of gotten back ahead on board.
>> Yeah, and he's presenting a lot of might
in that Z warren as well. If Tech Tekko
wants to get him out of that
battlefield, it's going to cost them a
lot.
>> All right, we'll see what's lined up
here. a spinning ax, a switcheroo, a
ferris 4runner, and a second ferris
4runner.
>> I think ferris 4runner is one of my
favorite like random units in set two.
It is a six might unit mech as well,
though it doesn't really matter in this
one. And does have a death meal that
when this ferris warrunner, which is six
might already, dies, it creates two more
three might mech units. And that's kind
of crazy. You can try to take him out,
but he will regenerate two more of
himself. Yeah, definitely a sticky unit
to try and kick off a battlefield can be
quite frustrating. So, it looks like
just Ferris for to base not going to
reinforce the bottom side of the
battlefield and pass it on back. A point
now for Prismaticism, one for
conquering, one for holding. So, two to
five is the score in that metric as a
runes get channeled. Card gets drawn and
uh Pris starting to get through the deck
a little bit more now. But again, has to
kind of figure out, okay, I do need to
do something about the Darius on the
other side eventually. Maybe not right
this turn, but for now I'm holding the
north battlefield. It seems very well
locked down. So, what do I do about the
rest of the game? We go in apparently is
what we do. Five on five right now.
>> We'll have to see if this trigger comes
down. I would be more guessing towards
the hidden first before that type of
thing, but it is an option for this
Darius to move back to the battlefield.
Instead, that hidden will be flipped.
Fighter flight potentially pushing that
battle battering ram back to
Prismaticism's base.
>> Interesting little tidbit here. I
believe because as a hidden spell as
it's a reaction I think you can choose
your rea trigger and then respond to it
by fight or flighting. So if for some
reason like another hard bargain say
came out I think you still have the
option of retreating a Darius on the
river and of course if that happens uh
your opponent wins the combat draws a
cloud of draven and takes the plane off
the battlefield. So you don't
necessarily want that to happen but
tekko just kind of had it all anyway.
Pris gets his battering ram pushed off
the reaver's row and Darius maintains
his position down south. Yeah, Darius is
feeling nice in Reaver's Row. I do
believe we'll be holding up to six as
well, which is going to be a really nice
number for Techo Techo and a really nice
lead versus Prismaticism who is only at
two, but we are really adding more might
to Zon Warren to try to hold it looks
like
>> and had the option for something like
Rebuke Q with the Fizz, but decides to
filter a little bit more. Not so worried
it feels like about the Darius at this
stage of the game despite being a few
points behind. Prismaticism navigating
through all of the very big units that
Techo is playing here.
>> Yeah, Techko does seem to have a lot
like these larger might units. Uh, and
so I hope his man is able to find the
card that works best for him there.
>> Yeah, certainly more of a miracle versus
mid-range kind of match up here as cold
shot going to do its thing with Ezreal
in play. Costs a single purple power to
look at two and draw one of those. And
of course, when you find a nocturn, you
get a nocturn and you get to draw a
card.
>> Yeah, that is so nice. And I think one
of the really nice things about running
Noctturn in this list, when you find him
off of looking at cards versus drawing,
you're able to play him directly, which
does mean he's being able to be placed
in Zon Warren. And he's one of the few
ganking cards that Prismaticism has in
his deck, meaning it'll be able to move
directly from Zon Warren over to
Reaver's Row if it's time to knock that
Darius out of Reaver's Yeah, I don't
remember if there's a vile knight in
Prismacisms list, but uh Noctturn may be
the only one. There's only one Noctturn
in list. I can tell you that much. True.
>> So, I did find it there with the cold
shot. Must feel pretty lucky.
>> But that top battlefield is getting uh
sieged at this point.
>> So, looks like both players are kind of
deciding, you know what, I'm just going
to stack on either side. Techo I feel
like might not feel too bad about that
decision given that currently ahead on
points by a pretty significant number
but have to suspect that when uh rebuke
is not getting recycled by Fizz that
there is a plan for this Darius in the
future.
>> Yeah, I'm sure prismaticism has some
type of plan at least. He's obviously a
seasoned player. He knows he's going to
have to deal with Darius sooner or later
but maybe he feels confident, you know,
in having some patience towards dealing
with him.
>> Now shot going to give you more
selection. in the hand is looking very
thick for prismaticism. Tons of options
to choose from here. Just going to move
a unit through. Want to retreat the
Ezreal. Keep that passive text safer in
base, which you see pretty commonly.
Doesn't really need the might right now
with how much is stacked in there thanks
to that Noctturn being found off the
cold shot. And uh
just going to maybe deciding the next
play. There's quite a few runes still
left available. So probably wants to use
most of them.
Yeah, it looks like we still have six,
which is a lot. It looks fighter or
flight is going to move the Draven
Vanquisher back to base. And to note,
when you move the card with a spell like
Fight or Flight because Draven ready at
the beginning of the turn, Fighter
Flight still keeps it ready. So ready in
base, it's now a move into Reaver's Row
and attack into that Darius who does
take the Reaver's Row trigger and move
safely back to base.
>> Yeah, going to give the point and the
card to prismaticism though. So
preserving your Draven, sorry,
preserving your Darius, excuse me, must
feel pretty good. But I do like that uh
players are starting to use the let's
call it the other text on fight or
flight of going back with your own unit,
which when I first saw the card felt
like the intention cuz again was the ASO
player, but I've certainly seen a lot
more of the let's call it offensive
fight or flight usage, but it's nice to
see again very flexible spell you can
use for just about anything. So,
Prismaticism taking the uh the more
defensive line, get that Draven back
over to the other side and going to have
Noxus Hopeful reinforce the battlefield
down there now. Now, trying to take full
control of both sides of the rift.
>> Yeah, Knox hopeful is so strong for his
price. Obviously battering ram, another
one that's discounted. But Nox is
hopeful as his Legion when another card
is in play that turn. He only costs two
for four might, which is absolutely
gigantic.
>> Yep. I had uh Jim Davis have the triple
hopeful draw against me uh when I was
playing him earlier.
>> That is tragic.
>> It was tragic. Certainly tragic for me.
I lost that game very easily. But the
that is not going to be the case here
for either of these players is still
jostling for position here in game
number one in this pretty tense Draven
mirror. Very important as far as at
least results go here in round 11 as
Tekker considers options again. Has a
lot of might to play with. Darus can get
bigger if he plays two cards. It's
ferris 4runner already there sitting at
six. So 11 total already which is bigger
than the numbers printed and potentially
buffed on the bottom side of the map.
>> Yeah and we also only have about 12
might on warren. So a buff Darius plus
ferris runner is enough to dece them as
well. And with all these runes up I
think we have some options to do it. It
looks like like it's going to be the
spell falling star. So you get to do
three damage twice to any of the units
on prismaticism side. Looks like we put
three onto the Fizz as well as the
Ezreal taking out some of those tech
cards that help discount some of those
different spells that prismaticism could
play.
>> Yeah, looks like just trying to kind of
cut down the overall units and just take
out the ones that are naturally already
small enough to be killed by falling
star. could also doubled on a unit there
as well. But again, feel like we have
enough mind at home to just bring it to
bear here in the top lane. And that is
going to be 11 to nine right now. Ticker
Tech passing it back. Seeing what
Prismaticism has available. It's going
to say, "I'll take out the Darius. You
can take the battlefield."
>> Mhm. And Darius was only a five, I
believe. We've only played one card this
turn thus far, but Ferris 4runner. We do
not want to kill him just yet because if
we do that's going to be six more might
in Tech Tekko's base which prismaticism
wouldn't like to keep 11 might for
Techo.
>> Yeah, it does feel like Ferris 4Runner's
job has been to is going to sit on
battlefield cuz nobody wants to trigger
the death nail which again especially as
you get later in the game and maybe
threaten to hold for a win. It's a
pretty powerful place to be when nobody
wants to deal with you. Rubik obviously
can be quite good. So Ferris 4unner not
without his counterplay, but a very
frustrating unit to deal with directly
>> for sure. And it looks like we'll be
discarding that switcheroo for Zan
Warren. Another hidden card that Techo
is threatening every time he's he hides
one.
>> Six and a power for another Ferris
forunner. One was pretty good. Two seems
a little bit better.
>> Yeah, I would like to have 12 might I
think in my Zon Warren. And at six six
points on Techo's side, he would very
much like to hold this if possible and
try to get the win here. He doesn't have
to rush into, you know, creating combat
in this southern battlefield that
Prismaticism is holding.
>> Yeah, can just kind of stack and hope
that it's good enough with again these
very sticky units that mid-range Dravens
play. So frustrating to deal with here
as seal is going to get popped. Ezreal
number two is going to be seen and scrap
peep going to make it a draw three. It's
funny to put a card like Scrap Peep in a
deck like this cuz it kind of does
nothing it looks like. But its real job
is just to make sure you draw extra
cards whenever you want to draw cards
cuz realistically you look at the card
and it's got a lot of text on it but all
the text just says do a thing and draw a
card.
>> Yeah, it is so nice just to get all that
card draw. So strong in card games.
Surprise, surprise. Uh I think last set
we saw some scrap heaps still especially
in those Annie lists. Yep. that also ran
ZH Warren. But sometimes you would see
as you would use Zon Warren in your game
one, you could side out scrap heap, get
some extra slots in your deck. But now
that we have Ezreal and all these
additional discard cards, a lot of times
scrap heap is staying even into game two
and three.
>> Yeah, even traveling Merchant here,
which did the same trick uh that the
Ezreal did, but only for one fewer card.
Discarded another scrap peep, drew two
cards this time as the Merchant just
going to again keep cycling through the
deck. We did see Prismaticism count the
cards in deck as well, which is a pretty
telling sign that uh this is a player
that's certainly remembering what has
been recycled under there already and is
figuring out how close am I to getting
back around to the cards I've started to
recycle.
>> And it's also just double-checking
because you while it is rare in these
miracle decks that you do deck out and
give a point to your opponent, it does
happen. There's a couple different cards
in the deck that does try to mitigate
that, but your opponent can play around
it. It's an absolute tragedy if it
happens to because uh as a reminder you
shuffle your entire trash into your deck
when you burn up which is uh you know
basically the opposite of what your deck
is trying to do where you're trying to
curate a very specific list of cards as
you get deeper into the game. So I see a
bushwack in hand. This is that's often a
card that these miracle decks use when
they're trying to have kind of a big
comboesque turn and put a lot of might
lot of rases onto the battlefield. And
as you can see it has a seal, there's
some purple runes and there's a whole
lot of cards in the bin. So if Raser is
on the menu, Prismatic can play just
about every Raser at in his arsenal
right now.
>> Yeah, Bushwack is so nice. Not only do
you also get a gold token, but your
units do come in ready, which red
already having big might units is really
nice,
>> especially when they don't cost very
much energy as cards being floated onto
the table. It does cost two.
Prismaticism has exhausted two runes,
turned him sideways, and trying to think
if this is the line he wants to take. It
is just Nox is hopeful. So, not the two
drop I had in mind, or at least the one
I saw floating to the top of the hand.
Doesn't seem to be too worried cuz uh
seven points is not eight. And there's
Rasa number one, but no Bushwack. So,
going to be exhausted in the base just
chilling out, seeing if Chris System can
hold on to the bottom battlefield and
maybe let his opponent get to seven
points just once. Yeah, if we thought
two, you know,
two cost for a four might unit was
really nice. A, you know, six might unit
for zero and one power seems pretty
nice, too.
>> Does seem pretty good. That gold token
also helping out with some of the power
costs in that turn. And yeah, just
passing it back. You can go to seven.
These first four runners are a little
frustrating to deal with, but uh his
medicism seems to have a plan. There's
quite a lot of might being built up in
base and there's more to come after
that. So, I'm just trying to get a
glance at Techo Tech's hand. I thought I
saw a rebuke.
>> Yeah, I think Teot Tekko has a lot to
think about this turn. He probably wants
to leave up extra runes this turn so
that he can threaten cards in his hand,
but he also wants to get enough might
down that he can try to do something
next turn if someone does deceit him out
of Zon Warren. And he wants to try to
stay in Zon Warren to take that win by
holding to eight points.
>> Yeah. And you can kind of see one of the
differences here is Kai's going to be
the selection maybe taken off the stack
deck as uh these investments of the
seals of discord, right? They do cost
your own when you have when you place
them down, but slowly but surely as the
game goes longer and both players are
paying power costs, the seals are kind
of an investment you make so that later
down the track you can have more
resources. And if you just use your eyes
and look at the runes on either side of
the table, Techo just has way less
resources to work with on the upcoming
turns. and Prismaticism again counting
the deck once more shuffling through his
hand. I just feel like there's something
brewing here even though he's behind a
few points and Taka has to think it's
the best way for me to win just to try
and hold the top battlefield. And I
think that's the decision we're making
because we're passing it back with
everything up.
>> And there looks to be some really nice
cards in Techo's hand just to hold. I do
see two spinning axes there which do
pose six might for four energy as well
as Rebuke. So, we left six of these
runes unexhausted, which is just enough
to play all of them.
>> I think the main problem is uh if you
get in combat, spinning ax is pretty
good. If you get pushed back or maybe
pushed back to hand, all of a sudden,
spinning axe is a lot less attractive.
So, uh stack deck going to go ahead find
another card as prismaticism keeps him
pretty close to his chests.
>> Yeah. Well, I wonder what it could be.
We do have a good number of might just
waiting in base. We do have.
>> There's Fizz.
>> 19 might in base right now.
>> Yeah, something like that.
And
>> there's the rebuke from the trash.
Again, this is the thing. Techo's cards
real good when combat is happening. But,
uh, there's not a lot of combat
happening here. So, Matism does have to
put his stack deck into the trash first
of all. Did uh did find that one first
and I believe found this Fizz. maybe
knew it was there from uh earlier
recycle, but I don't think we've seen
that. We haven't seen a last right, so
there's no way a Fizz would have got
under there. Also, you know, at some
point you've seen most of your deck. You
know what's left in there. So, you can
play the percentages as well. You don't
have to have recycled them to find out
what's on the bottom or at least likely
to be in there as you're shuffling
through and filtering through so many
cards. And we talked about one rebuke
and one spinning axe being pretty good,
but uh there's a lot of might about to
launch into the top side.
>> Yeah, and rebuke is just so painful for
Techo Techo. One thing that isn't so
fierce 4Runner is even if they did get
killed, we would have had 12 might in
our base from those baby mechs that
would have been created and instead
rebuke sends that ferris 4runner to hand
meaning Death Note does not get
triggered.
>> 10 14 19 22. Well, you got to there's
another one.
>> Ouch.
>> I think that's 28 might. I'm not going
to count it again, but it's a lot. It's
more than one fairer. I can tell you
that much. And Bushwack kind of enabling
this turn. Everything sent into the zone
warren. And Techga says, "Yep, I'll
think about this." And uh maybe I'll
play an X to kill one more unit
>> cuz you're definitely not winning this
combat.
>> Yeah, we definitely are not winning
here, but we could do a couple different
things to try to decrease the might we
have to deal with next turn. We won't
win by just taking one battlefield next
turn, but we could try to hold again
potentially.
>> All right, Ter doing a lot of math.
Perhaps we'll count alongside cuz again
it is a lot of mayo on this battlefield.
So, uh, the two rams are 10, the two
rases are 12. That's 22. And then it's
three for Ezreal, and four for the
hopeful. So, 29.
>> That's a lot of might.
>> I think that's the number. It's close to
that. Uh, someone could check my math in
the chat if you're so inclined. They do
say never do math on air. Unfortunately,
uh, I think they don't say that during
card game streams cuz you have to do
some at some point.
>> Yeah. You know, I think math is very
important in card games. I will say so
myself. Miscalculating might can be a
deathly error that leads you to losing a
game.
>> Well, these players are not doing that.
I can tell you that much. Even if we
make mistakes, I don't think these
players are going to be making mistakes
like that. At least not making them very
often as
>> just trying to figure out what to
recycle. Purple rune goes away. Spinning
ax comes in and that is now nine might
on the Ferris 4. So going to be able to
at least cut a few more units down.
That's enough for Arasa and the Ezreal
if you're thinking about things we might
take down in combat later on. Techa
says, "Okay." SP system says, "Yeah,
what do you want? I'm obviously taking
out your forrunner." And it is Rasa and
Ezreal that go down. Drawing a card from
near combat thanks to Draven as two
mechs finally make their way into the
base.
>> The baby mechs and Techo was so careful
this turn making sure to recycle a
purple so that he had two red runes for
next turn. I'm interested to see what he
does use them for coming up. Uh but it
is important to note. Yeah, we know
about the Darius, of course.
Prismaticism, I believe, rebuking that
one earlier with I think the Fizz from
remembering how this turn started
correctly. Going to go all the way to
five points right now and already held
for the turn. So, Prismaticism is now
resolving the Zorn Warren trigger,
discarding a scrap peep, drawing a card,
and we'll see what else is on the menu
here. Bushwack, by the way, still
active. So, if he finds another unit, it
is going to be ready. I don't think
that's going to matter, but it is going
to be ready.
>> Yeah. Uh, and with holding both these
battlefields, we could just play them
directly into it if we have a unit that
needs to be there. Our mechs are going
to ready though on Techot Techo's side.
And with I believe eight runes, we're
going to have to figure out to do here.
>> I believe this is the first time we've
seen two uh baby mechs in the base
thanks to Ferris 4unner. I don't think
I've seen it on stream at least with you
this weekend, but uh it's first time for
everything. At least Ferris 4Runner
finally gets to do the thing it wants to
do. The question is, is it too late?
because all of a sudden the miracle
draven deck has kind of done the thing
the deck is want to do and that is just
put huge numbers of might onto both
battlefields and positions and say you
know what figure it out
>> he has succeeded in that and I'm
questioning myself how do you get out of
this position we have some cards in hand
but it doesn't seem like it's going to
be an easy idea
>> it's 20 on top and 13 down the bottom as
far as Mike might go but there is a
hidden card in at the reaver's row as
well so I see rebuke I see a Darius I
see these two mechs. I mean, there's
maybe something getting stitched
together here. Also important to note
that Techo does at least have to
dislodge one of these battlefields cuz
uh if two points are there for holding,
prismaticism is going to take game one
nice and cleanly. There's the Darius
card number one and it's kind of like
reverse legion for Darius cuz when you
play a second card, a bonus effect
triggers.
>> Yeah, I actually love Darius's effect.
It's anytime you're playing that second
card. So even during Brismaticism's
turn, if Tech Tekkco can play two cards,
he will grow back to that seven might.
>> Be fun for the future sets where we
eventually get uh fury and calm in the
same set. They can do some really silly
things with Darius. I don't know if
they'll be good, but they'll certainly
be fun as there's rebuke on the Draven.
That Draven's been there for quite a
while, by the way. Has clearly bought
the all day parking pass. The reaver's
row has been chilling since I think
about turn three. Now back to hand for a
little vacation. might change his name.
>> Uh yeah, I mean he has been there
definitely since the beginning before we
put that first Paris 4Runner I believe
in to Zon Warren. So we are going to
have a moment here to check on this
chosen champion sleeve. But really
excited to see what Techo tries to do. I
think choosing to rebuke the Draven
Vanquisher from Zorns where there's a
hidden card means Teot has a plan. I
personally would be very afraid to go I
feel like into that hidden hidden
battlefield, but it does look like the
hidden battle or the hidden card will
push Darius back.
>> Yeah, I mean getting to the top
battlefield basically wasn't happening.
So, it's kind of a matter of well the
softer of the two I can try and get in.
Obviously, there's a hidden card there.
It's almost always a fighter flight. And
unfortunately for Tech Toko, it was a
fighter flight this time. So, game one
going to prismaticism continuing a near
flawless streak so far. But again, both
these players, no slaps coming into this
round at X and one, trying to hold on to
that record cuz the longer you can hold
on to that one, the easier it is for you
to make top eight. If you do all the way
through round 13, you've made it.
Congratulations.
>> Congratulations. But we are still have
so many rounds to get there. Uh that
being said, these next battlefields look
really interesting. It is going to be
that Obelisk of power. We've seen it a
couple of times. Well, yesterday, I'm
not sure if we've seen it today. Uh but
with obliter during your first turn
during the beginning phase you can
channel one extra rune which is nice to
start with three or four but most
interestingly will be this targon's peak
which is when you conquer you're able to
unexhaust two of the runes at the end of
your turn which may not seem like a lot
but for both Dravens two is the magic
number for a lot of those cards that
we're going to see changed through the
combat and move in. Yeah, even things
like this where Tega Tech was playing a
stack deck and then maybe looking for a
two drop. This is exactly what happened
actually on Prismaticism's first turn in
the last game where getting an extra
rune as the uh player going second did
allow this and Obnoxious hopeful is the
kickoff there. That is very good as far
as early might goes. But four runes on
the other side kind of makes sense. You
see Obelisk a lot kind of when you are
the player going second kind of in some
ways uh undoes the disadvantage of not
being able to play uh play cards first.
And I would be willing to bet that
Obelisk is the most registered
battlefield at this regional qualifier.
I think we've probably seen it more than
any other. Many, many decks want this
effect. But Draven's going to be the
first play here again. That benefit of
those extra runes here enough to play
Draven from the champ zone.
>> Yeah, I mean does definitely doesn't
feel bad to be able to play our Draven
Vanquisher directly to base. And now Nox
Hope will get Targon's Peak. We do just
go on and show that these are our two
runes that we will be unexhausting at
the end of the turn. But now let's
actually use them. Yeah, it's a it's a
funny one. Targets peak when you conquer
uh ready to ruins at the end of your
turn. So, you kind of get a delayed
trigger that goes over at the end, but I
think you do have to remember it when
you conquer it. So, if you're playing at
home, just point at it as soon as you
conquer it and make sure you don't
forget to do it at the end of your turn
as another Draven's come through and
some runes have been untapped. So,
already passing back with another Draven
on the other side as stack deck going to
kick off the festivities here for the
other Draven this time.
>> Yeah, we got to play our Draven as well.
just slowly getting all this might that
we need on Techo's side. What will
Prismaticism find here though? Because
he is at six or yeah, six runes because
of obsc power turn one.
>> Yeah, Draven obviously could shuffle in
here down the bottom battlefield. But
yes, you can recycle a fury rune to make
Draven a bit bigger, but it feels a
little scary with uh runes being left
open very clearly here by Techo Teo. It
is kind of funny to me that a two a two
drop in effect is as big as the four
drop on the other side as Nox's hopeful
looking pretty big.
>> Yeah, I thought Nox's hopeful was the
largest to my unit that I would see
probably ever, but when battering ram
last game was, I think a one cost for
>> Nox's hopeful doesn't look so cool to me
anymore.
>> Yeah, it was a very big one as uh first
bit of power getting recycled. It's
Ezreal, everyone.
>> Throw a three after this guide and the
scrap peep. Everything's feeling pretty
good.
>> Yeah, it feels a lot nicer to play this
Ezreal. What? Our second third turn here
versus much later in the game. So, we
will get this Ezreal down. And the one
card that we're I mean that we were
looking to discard is exactly what we're
going to hit with that scrap heap. I'm
going to discard one, but I'm not just
going to draw two. Now, I'm going to
draw three.
>> Yeah, Prismatic isn't playing another
hopeful here. So building up a pretty
formidable force in the backline, but
Techo is off with the early points lead
once again. Hopeful been good for two so
far in this game and likely going to be
a third if Draven wants to wander up
north as well.
>> I wonder if we'll choose to do it. I
will say the one thing that I think
Techo also has to decide this turn is if
Nox is hopeful will stay in Targon's
Peak because Targon's Peak's ability is
only when I conquer. So he won't get an
extra true this turn. It's kind of
better to retreat. Nox is hopeful as
well, but that leaves it open for
Prismaticism. But we're going to check
out his hand first here before we
decide. Mindsplitter, not only seven
might, but gets to discard one of
Prismaticism's cards.
>> Yeah, this card you don't see too often
in Draven List, but certainly in the
mid-range list, you will, especially in
matchups like this. Big seven might unit
cost seven. And when you play me, choose
an opponent, you only have one opponent
in a 1 v one, I suppose. They reveal the
hand, you pick a card, and they discard
that card. So Rasa maybe not the most
attractive discard because of last
rights, but uh Ezreal seems like a
pretty good target here just because
it's going to draw so many more cards. I
mean Prismaticism's hand is not that hot
here. Double bushwack is not what you
want to do when you're trying to get
things off Battlefield. That's what you
want to do when you're trying to close
out the game or have a really big turn.
So Ezreal is indeed going to hit the bin
and all that draw power and filtering
that prismaticism and maybe wanted to do
there just denied by this massive seven
might unit as you correctly predicted.
Nox is hopeful going home which makes
sense playing against a deck that
punishes you for being in combat. The
best way to win a combat is to have no
combat at all.
>> I that is a great way. What is it? The
best offense is a good defense. I think
it was really smart as well not to take
the Ross out of hand. There's only two
cards in the discard pile. So while we
do have to watch out for a Rosa coming
up, you know, Ezreal is the more current
threat.
>> Yeah, you're right. Actually, that's
even I didn't even think about that
part. But yes, as we'll not only get you
more cards, but also gets you deeper to
playing Rasa for cheaper. So,
>> you're right.
>> That was completely unintentional, but
I'll take it as prismaticism has a
hopeful in hand, but that one costs four
if you haven't played another card.
Seven runes is kind of an awkward break
point. Not too sure what we want to do
here cuz uh it looked like we had a
decent amount of might at home, but
mindsplitter is changing the equation,
especially with a hidden card in that
top battlefield. So, it's 11 might
already. Could be 13 with the Draven and
something to contend with up there.
Switcheroo, fight or flight. Guess
Titturner technically is a card that
could be in these decks. So instead
going to take the easy points perhaps in
the bottom side. Go back down to the
Tigon's Peak and get the uh ready
trigger for the runes himself. No
hopeful going to go collect the first
point of the game.
>> Yeah, and we're going to get those two
runes back as well, meaning Prismaticism
will have a lot of options during his
opponent's turn. But we are really just
adding cards to Targon's Peak. A lot of
times I feel like you don't want to hold
Targon's Peak like we mentioned earlier,
but Prismaticism does seem to be
committing to it. He didn't just put
Nox's hopeful up. He then added nine
more might on top of it. So maybe he
wants to keep Techo from getting the two
runes this turn, which would also draw a
card from combat. But that's a lot of
commitment. Yeah, it's interesting to
see so many different Draven decks and
uh how they want to approach the game.
But at the end of the day, they do kind
of want to do a lot of the same things.
And most of that is take advantage of,
you know, Draven's legend techs, which
is when you win combat, you draw cards.
And turns out the easiest way to win
combat is to put as much might as
possible onto a battlefield. So, they're
doing it in different ways with
different units, but Prismaticism still
sticking to the plan, stacking the
battlefield that he feels like he can at
least have control over. and uh paid a
full five for the battering ram which we
don't see too often but the Noxus
hopefully at least was able to uh be
paid for the discounted two. So going to
pass back here after playing a couple
more units. Techo playing it slow
feeling pretty good about the mind
splitter draven combo that's hiding up
top and again still ahead on points. So
if we just hold forever in this exact
situation well the play roll with more
points is going to win it turns out.
>> Yeah that is very true. I will warn I
feel like we do need to watch out for
Techo Techo's hand here. He decided to
play a Nox's hopeful for full cost which
you know in some world 44 maybe it's not
the worst thing but when you know you
can pay it for two it doesn't feel good
and I'm wondering why he decided to have
to pay that cost in full.
>> Oh there's Ras. Oh again we're just
paying we're just paying six.
>> Paying six actually recycle one. No dis
no seals anywhere. No uh no way to pay
that power. No gold tokens. Desriel does
not help with that cuz it is not an
additional cost. That is just a cost
trade up as the full price rasa gets
popped down to the bottom side and it's
double spinning axe and another
mindsplitter in Techo's hand. The first
one already felt pretty good. The second
one's going to feel really bad for
Prismaticism.
>> Yeah,
>> there it is.
>> Another Ross in hand as well. Still only
three cards in the discard pile, but
Prismaticism has committed to paying
full price for so many cards right now.
Both of these players haven't seen a lot
of their draw cards, very few called
shots, very a few stack decks, and we're
seeing the price of that, which is full
cost units.
>> Yeah, I feel like I I must have misread
Tech's deck list there at the top of
this cuz I don't think he's on the
miracle shell just based on what we're
looking at. We do know, of course, Pris
is. So, not nearly as much draw
available for Teot Turko, but you know,
the thing is you hope to get draws off
your Draven. That's the thing that's
really powering your deck. I mean, if
you're holding and they're not fighting
you, you're winning. And if they're
holding you and fighting you and you're
still winning combats, you're also
winning. So kind of like, you know, a
lot of a good thing here for Draven. You
don't get nearly the amount of digging
power that a prismatic system has. But
again, with no seals to speak of,
everything's had to be done quite a bit
more fairly in this game. And despite
both players racing to the top with one
point at a time, holding their
respective battlefields, uh,
Mindsplitter is very disruptive and very
big. And again, prismaticism at some
point is going to have to break, I guess
we can call it a stalemate in some ways
where if players just want to hold on,
then it's not going to go well for the
player that's fallen behind in points.
And I wonder if two minds splitter is
enough disruption with a deck that is so
good at looking through the top of its
deck and finding key cards is enough to
kind of knock Prismaticism off a perch
at least for a game.
>> Yeah, we'll have to see. And
Prismaticism finally does get that first
called shot. Starting to actually do
what you said this deck does best.
looking at cards, procuring the best
hand possible, and also getting those
cards in an order that you know what's
going to be coming next. Both these
battlefields so interesting to be
holding like this. Obviously, obelisk of
power is kind of just a battlefield at
this point since we're past the first
turn, but Targon's Peak when holding it
doesn't really do anything. Yeah, I
think both players just like, you know
what, the way these decks play is that
you get once you keep reinforcing cuz
apart from Bushwack, not many ways to
really ready a bunch of units. So
unlike, you know, other decks maybe like
Jinx from Origins where was in the same
domains but wanted to had a lot of
assault units where you wanted to go in
and out of battlefields and really try
and get your offensive pressure going.
Really just playing uh units. It's
funny. We're playing units at unfair
costs but in very fair ways I feel like
in Draven.
>> Yeah, I would say sometimes you know
>> a 10. Oh, invert timeline coming down
here.
This is going to be kind of painful.
Each player is going to discard their
hand then draw four. We right now
Prisma's hand is only at one. So, he's
actually going up three cards, but I
think Techo was over four, meaning we're
actually going to be decreasing our hand
size.
>> Yeah, was at four, so I think it was
neutral, but didn't have an opportunity
to play another card. Had two spinning
axes in hand. Did not have two runes to
maybe put one down. So, uh, not a bad
little reset there from Professor Matism
digging through the deck, kind of
getting back the card draw that kind of
been missing otherwise without being
able to power out more Ezreals, more
cold shots, especially missing the seals
of discord. You can kind of see this
game the rune the runes are much closer
as far as total resources go. And I'm
just so curious like Techo is looking
really good here. This top battlefield
just looks kind of impenetrable. And
yeah, the bottom side looks a bit
problematic. We can say it's 11 + 8 that
is 19 might with a hidden card down at
the Targon's peak.
But I feel like mid-range Draven has
enough big units that you can find a way
to break this assuming you even need to
cuz again you're still currently winning
this game if you just hold on.
>> Yeah, it'll be interesting to see what
Techo does. It does seem like I mean
obviously we did not want those two
spinning axes to go to the discard pile
at all but we're starting to find more
cards that we can actually use it feels
like cuz before we were having to pay
full costs versus getting a discount
Noxis hopefuls and now we're back to
stack decking finding the perfect cards
for our hand here.
>> Falling star just spotted in the hand
here. Draven's unit pretty big so Ezreal
is kind of the only obvious target. Edel
and Fizz often meet the eye of the three
damage spells.
>> Mhm.
>> But Falling Star twice on the Rasa this
time. Kick that one out of there. Does
go down a decent amount on runes, but
definitely worth it to trim down that
battlefield cuz can make it a one-point
game instead of a two-point game, which
when you've been holding this top side
for quite a while, seems like a decent
spot to be as Techo going to exhaust a
few more runes and maybe commit a little
bit more to this board. Ooh, fight or
flight. Move to the top of the hand.
Kicking on out of there. Get the
battering ram out. I want to take this
battlefield for myself.
>> Yeah, it looks like we're slowly
chipping away at all the cards that
Prismaticism has slowly been bulking up
this Targon's Peak with. I wonder if
Techo Techo is going to be able to
successfully take Targon's Peak back. It
is currently, you know, equal might, but
we're going to see blood rush come down
here.
>> You don't see that card often at all.
And it's just a bush. I forgot you could
hide that card. That's actually just for
a gold really. That doesn't do anything.
It was a buff almost from Prismaticism.
All of a sudden, the hopeful lives. The
assault off the blood rush looking good.
No repeat needed. And Techo Teo is one
point away holding both battlefields.
>> That's going to be so nice for Techo
Techo. Also, even though we spent
through all of our runes here, we will
get two back at the end of our turn
because of Targon's Peak. But, you know,
half this game is the mental battle. So,
playing that card face down hidden was
so smart by Prismaticism. It smelled
like a fight orflight, but it wasn't
one.
>> Was not. And uh I just I'm trying to
think about the bottom battlefield looks
easy to take and you need to take it.
Techo did tap out kind of target peak
readying two runes at the end but
batting ram does get the job done in the
bottom side. So what do you do now cuz
overzealisan was added to the top side
of the map and it is 14 + 4 that is
eight. Uh yep 18 we got there 20 if the
Draven wants to recycle a few runes. So
we can pretty reasonably call it 2022
might with overzealous fan chilling in
there and another hidden card. Yeah, and
there's a couple of worries here.
Obviously, we do know that Techo Techo
does play Switcheroo as well. So,
Switcheroo, I mean, Fighter Fight could
literally push one of these big cards
away that comes in, but in this case, it
could actually change the might of two
different units. You're able to switch
the might of one of your opponents, I
believe, with yours. And so, something
like this six might roa could become two
might. And now, Overzilla's Fan could
also be six might. Yeah, it's swap the
might of two units at the same
battlefield this turn. So you actually
can swap you can swap both yours and
your opponents as well. So certainly
there could be quite a wide overzealous
fan which would be extremely punishing
if you choose to activate your Draven on
offense to make it bigger. All of a
sudden getting swoopsy daisy back down
to just a lowly two or so. So
prismaticism is digging and I I need to
remind everyone he needs to find an
answer for the top battlefield. It's 19
m at home or so if you include the
Draven's attack trigger, but it's
already 22 with the Overz fan. A flat 20
with the Draven defend trigger with
Overz fan. Over basically erases the
highest might you're bringing in. So
it's like a minus six right now on this
board, which is pretty good.
>> Yeah, very potentially is so and
Prismaticism is digging for an answer.
We saw that called shot come down. Now
stack deck. Hopefully his spacism can
find something, but if he isn't able to
get this obelisk of power or at least
clear it out, then Techo will take that
eighth point to win the game.
This micism clearly thinks there's
something playful here. There's only 9
minutes left in the round as well. So,
uh, game three, time could be an issue,
but if you're not conceding at this
point, you believe there is a way out of
this game. So, how do you get through
double mind splitter, single Draven,
overzeal hidden card on a battlefield
that you must break this turn or this
game or this series is going to a tie.
>> Yes. And it another stack deck, another
draw here. Hopefully, he's able to find
something, but I think at this point
he's looked at 10 different cards and
gotten to pull four three four of them
into his hand.
>> Yeah, certainly had a lot of selection
here. just manism going to go ahead and
put some on the bottom. Riding down I
think what's on the bottom of the deck
as well. So also getting to maybe that
second cycle but again uh the issues are
at hand recycle two. What do we got?
Piercing light
>> deal two unit out of bin two to up to
one other unit not restricted by
battlefield. So over fan going to get
one bullet to the brain which is good
cuz that was a very rough card to get
through as far as might goes. feels a
bit more even now as two damage going to
be marked on another unit here.
>> Mhm. Piercing.
>> Oh, it's repeated. It killed the Draven
as well.
>> That is going to be really nice for
prismaticism. Piercing light is one is a
uh new removal spell that we got to see
in Spirit forge. It is repeat two to
battlefield as you said and two to
another and you can repeat it. And so we
are able to clear out two of those, but
still 14 might at the battlefield and a
hidden. Well, there's more might now for
Prismaticism because we've done the math
already. And Techo is close to tapped
out. I guess you just have to consider
the fight or flight, but I think we're
going in. Prismaticism charging on
through cycling a rune cuz Draven's
going to get a little bit bigger.
>> 7 19 versus 14 right now. A hidden card
and two runes up, but we do still have
three up for prismaticism.
>> Yeah, two damage marked as well. Can't
play hard bargain for the full Actually,
you can clear the Ezreal fight or
flight. M
>> going to try and kick I believe Draven
out of there. Kind of Rasa and Draven
are very similar cards here so it
doesn't matter too much. And that does
indeed work. So Draven going to go back
home. And now it's 13 might through 14.
But two damage marked means we might
just be trading it off here. So need a
little bit more. Rebuke now going to be
the card for Techo take Russa out of
there. Now do we have the hard bargain?
This was Matism played the patient game.
Indeed he has. Rebuke not going to work.
And now we're going to trade things off.
Everything going to the graveyard. But
that's five prismaticism. That means you
do not lose the game.
>> Yeah, that is going to be really nice.
And to be said, we are still at only
seven points here for Techo versus four
on prismaticism. So Techo is in the
lead, but Prismaticism has saved himself
at least one more turn.
>> That's so much patience cuz Ezreal means
the additional cost for repeat on hard
bargain was reduced by one. There were
three runes up. Prismaticism could have
chosen to fight over the fight or
flight, but instead just waited. I think
you have another spell. If you do, I can
still win this combat and I want to make
sure I don't lose to rebuke.
>> Yeah, that was so smart, so patient. And
now I mean and Techo Teo probably was
saying it seems like he doesn't have it
in hand. It's a bluff. Maybe I can play
a card that has a high higher price, but
I'm sure will help me win, but instead
we paid two power to do nothing.
>> And now Dar's coming down, but you know,
not going to be ready by another card.
Not going to contain with the battleing
ram. Just says, you know what? At this
point, my plan for holding is gone. I
have to play for a double conquer here,
which always feels a little rough when
you're at seven points and not six. And
prismaticism just cleaned the
battlefield up that he needed to and is
now kind of on the wall path here.
>> Yeah, it looks like we're going to get
another point by moving our Draven into
obelisk and that's going to be a Oh my
god, Ezreal as well. It's be difficult
to get through especially with just one
Darius.
>> Scrap peep also doing the thing again.
And I think Chris Bison has discarded
Scrap Peep three different time, three
or four different times between
traveling merchant and Ezreal that I've
caught so far. I think in this game, not
even just in this series. As battering
ram going to join its twin down the
bottom side. 10 might there, seven might
up top and probably more because that's
again what the Draven deck wants to do.
There's another battering ram and
there's a recycle. So that must be a
rasa. No, it's a hidden card.
>> Oo, two
>> two hidden cards. Battering ram in base
as well. But decides don't need the
extra mind up top. The hidden cards are
good enough. This is good enough to hold
for two points by the way. So now
Prismaticism is in the point where is it
going to hold for a win.
>> This is looking really nice for
Prismaticism. Just a moment ago we
thought he was going to lose. Thought
Tech Tech was going to hold for that
final point, but Prismaticism
it does look like it's going to be a
double hold into a win here. These two
hiddens are threatening a lot though.
All of Prismaticism's runes have been
exhausted. So Techo Teo if he has the
correct cards could still pull this off.
>> What does the other Draven have in
store? Counting it up. Kai'Sa I see not
all that helpful here.
>> Well, Kai'Sa could accelerate is an
option. And it looks like that's a
potential for what's coming down. Kai'Sa
accelerated. She is a four. So we have
nine might right now on with the Darius.
If we have another card, it would be 11.
>> Yep. Could go to 11, which feels good
for the bottom side. Again, uh it's not
the same situation where Prismaticism
can hold from seven to eight.
>> Mhm.
>> Getting one of these battlefields taken
care of would make it happen. But here
we go. Moving on in. And Prismaticism
can't snub off the hidden card fast
enough. Flipping over the final flag.
Kick the Darus away. Prismaticism's done
it. The only point in Riftbound that
matters is the last one. And
Prismaticism finds the winning point for
the victory. That was a fantastic job by
Prismaticism being able to be patient
when he needed and knew exactly when he
needed to attack and hold.
>> That game looked so over
>> from about the fifth point that Tech
Tekko had just nothing. No seals, very
awkward break points in some cases for
both players, right? We saw full value
battering ram, full value rasa, full
value Nox, full price Nox hopefully. I
suppose just all these really efficient
Draven units that both the players have
looked way too expensive for what we've
seen all weekend long and somehow our
best of draven from Bolognia is still
alive here in Las Vegas.
>> Yeah, that was absolutely insane. There
was so much might that he had to deal
with in that top battlefield and somehow
he was still able to pull it out.
>> Well, we do have a winners interview
coming up and I think I see a familiar
face on the other side. So, let's uh
let's check it out.
I'm here with Prismaticism. You just
toped a uh original qualifi. Still in it
here in Vegas. How's it feeling?
>> Oh, I mean those games were crazy. I was
on some really awkward early draws. Uh
really was tough to navigate those, but
I think I mean I'll have to rewatch it.
But right now, I think I played
perfectly. We'll see when I go back. I'm
going to give myself a scathing review,
probably find a lot of errors, but u
maybe not. We'll see. We'll I'm feeling
really good about that win. I feel like
I really showed myself as a player
there. Showed off what the deck can do
as well. Like at the end of that game
two after I wiped his board and just had
everything go through, I was like,
"What? What even just happened?" I
didn't like and then like the fighter
flights line up, the Rams line up. It's
like, "Oh, I can actually win this
game." I didn't think I mean I knew I
had a chance, but
I knew I was very far behind when I'm
playing Rossa for seven mana. And like
it was it was a very sad early game for
me, but I got there in the end. And then
game one too, I knew like when he played
the double forrunner,
um where was my rebuke? I think it was
in my trash already cuz I used it early
cuz I got I got forced to use it turn
two because that was already an awkward
spot where I had to play the ram turn
one. I had a triple seal opening hand
and then I had to rebuke turn two just
to keep him off points to slow the game
down. And then both of my fizzes I saw
the first one pretty early. It went to
the bottom. The second one I saw when
the ram came out, but I wasn't sure if
he was going to hold the ram in or the
uh the ferris 4runner, sorry, in base uh
or if he was going to put it on a
battlefield. So I put the fizz on the
bottom and then I just knew that I'd be
able to at least dig all the way to the
fizz. But then he played the second one
which is a bit a bit scary but I got rid
of one. He had the mechs but he didn't
have anything else in hand. Uh I mean I
think once I get set up a standard
mid-range Draven deck isn't going to be
able to push me, but there can always be
like wild cards like against the odds.
Uh he had blood rush, there could be
switcheroo. Uh there can be a lot of
weird stuff that they can do that can be
a lot more swingy than just like a a
Darius from hand.
>> So still 11 getting close to that top.
How you feeling about your chances
assuming you make it again?
uh chances in top eight. I mean, we'll
see how Allen's doing. He's right over
there. Uh he also had a loss. We lost to
the same guy, Colin from Challenger TCG.
So, that guy's pretty much locked for
top eight, I think. Uh so, we'll get a
rematch against him hopefully. I think
he drew a lot better in the match that I
lost to him, but I think I also had one
or two misplays, things that were
suboptimal. I I learned something as
well for the matchup for the future,
which it's a secret. I'm not telling
anyone yet. That's But I'll I'll pull
that out when I see him again. Um, but
yeah, I think overall I'm feeling way
better than at Bolognia and I think the
deck is a lot better. I think I made a
lot of improvements to the list. Uh, I
was on the triple noctturn at Bolognia
and that was really inconsistent and
that was part of the reason that I lost
in top eight there. And then I've also
just made one other change few and
changes to the sideboard which are
really big making things a lot smoother.
>> Well, you're up for the best of event.
Best of luck getting that best of once
more.
>> Thank you.
>> A comprehensive review of the entire
match. after just playing it. That's
quite impressive.
>> Very much so. How did you get back here
so fast?
>> He talks a lot. So, it had a lot of time
to what way back to the booth. I think
the thing that really strikes me though
is hearing him go, you know what? I
don't really like my list in Bolognia
that won the best of Draven by the way.
So, just changed it. Took a couple days,
couple flights here, a long flight from
Italy over here to Las Vegas. Just
change a couple cards, you know, doing
about as well.
>> Yeah, I think it's the one thing that
always surprises me when I talk to like
top players. They're so critical of
themselves and I always got to be like,
"Bro, you're like the best guy in the
room." But then that's why they're the
best guy in the room because they are
critical of themselves.
>> Well, round 11 is in the books. Round 12
is coming up in just a moment here at
Las Vegas. It is incredible to witness
the matches of Rift Round. We are
getting There has been so many plays, so
much thought, so much sweet stuff going
on today.
>> So many great games I've gotten to watch
today for sure.
>> Yeah, I'm sure there's more coming up.
We are getting to kind of the pointy end
of things. There are not too many rounds
of Swiss left here after round 11. It is
just 12 and 13 the Swiss and then there
is more to come. Ripbound is coming up.
Don't go anywhere.
Heat. Heat.
Heat.
Heat. Heat. N.
Heat. Heat.
Heat.
If you're enjoying Riftbound, maybe you
want to go down to your local game
store, your friendly local game store,
and join the battle at Nexus Knight,
located.bound.uvsgames.com/events
is where you should go. And I have to
say yesterday I have a problem because
uh I've been uh wanting to play lots of
different decks and I thought Aurelia
was the one for me and now when I go to
my next Nexus Knight I'm going to have
too many choices to make. So what am I
possibly going to do?
>> Yeah, that's a great question. But I do
think we all need to go to Nexus
Knights. They have the most awesome
promo packs at Nexus Knights as well.
And the arts this set for Spirit Forge I
think I mean there's only been two but
is my favorite. It's got little cherry
blossoms on it.
>> That is nice. I mean, the GG easy Teemo
was looking pretty good uh in the
original packs for Origin. So,
definitely a great thing. Go out,
compete. Doesn't really matter what deck
you play. Have fun, meet some people,
make some friends, make some teammates,
maybe start a little testing group.
Really get more serious, stop play
testing, get competitive, come to a
skirmish, get your buy, and come to
original qualifier and I'll cast your
game. That's how it works.
>> Yeah, easy. Just just a really quick
step plan all the way here where then we
can cast your awesome games on screen
just like today.
>> I certainly can. and has been fun here
uh with Riftbound in Las Vegas, but Las
Vegas is a city known for many things.
Let's hear about of a few stories that
people might have of their time here in
the city.
>> Do you have a best or worst Vegas
experience that you can tell us about?
>> My best experience in Vegas so far was
definitely the first Vegas Open and so
since it's returning, I'm really looking
forward to that and hopefully this Rift
Brown stuff that I can do there as well.
Um, but yeah, so far my best experience
has been another Riot convention.
Basically,
>> the last time I was in Las Vegas, I was
14 and we went on one of the roller
coasters and uh they stopped it in the
middle of the roller coaster and we were
stuck there for like 90 minutes.
>> Uh, I came in fifth place in the Magic
World Championships like a few years ago
in this building. Uh, which is pretty
cool.
>> So, that's a Chevy, right?
>> That's a pretty good That's a pretty
good story, I would say. Yeah. Uh, one
time I came to Vegas for a card game
tournament and I started feeling like
little sick while I was on the plane
flying over and I thought that it was
just going to be like travel symptoms.
Turns out that I was actually sick. Uh,
played the tournament like masked up.
Don't remember the the whole tournament
almost. Still top to be.
>> We're in Las Vegas. I wanted to ask you,
do you have a best or worst Vegas story
experience that you want to share with
everybody?
>> I think actually Cog events in Vegas
have just been great. I remember like at
a con all day just jamming games, having
fun, and then like randomly went to Top
Golf with some mates till like think 2
a.m. cuz for some reason in the middle
of the strip there's a driving range
that is somehow between all these
buildings. It was super fun. I think
like in general like it's corny, but
events are just about the people you
hang out with and there's always great
people at these things. Last time I was
in Vegas, shout out to everybody from
Green Bay, we went to the casino and I
started off with a humble $20 beginning
and then I was up 3K at the end of the
trip.
That is effectively the kind of
experience someone that this tournament
is going to have. Show up to Vegas, uh,
spend some money to enter into a thing
and maybe win 3K.
>> Yeah, that would be absolutely awesome.
And there's so many different prizes you
can win from, you know, the 3K to the
best of prizes as well.
>> Certainly are. We'll have a look at who
is kind of in the running for all these
things, including our top eight, which
is nearing closer round over round. Miru
still undefeated at the top. 100 and
one. A draw is not a loss. Don't let
anyone tell you otherwise. Other than
that, that is actually the only
undefeated player left. Colin losing
loss last run now at 10 and one. Yeah,
we'd seen him do so well on stream, but
it does look like he did get his first
loss of the day or of the whole
tournament here, but also obviously a
lot of other great players as well.
Prismaticism, who we just watched, uh,
billionaire Randy
Min wins is also another known name in
the card game space as well.
>> Yeah, I think the uh, the 591 ones are
really interesting, right? Cuz XM1 is
uh, definitely the spot you want to be
by the end of round 13. This is the end
of round 11. So, we have two more rounds
of Swiss to go before we do cut to our
final eight players. And it does feel
like X1 is good, but how good is X101?
We'll have to find out as Alan's EQ
picks up a second loss.
Ouch. Uh, that does not feel good after
going undefeated just in the way that he
did, but I'm sure he'll be able to bring
it back still. I think we did hear that
some X and 2s will make it. So, that
he's still in the running for it.
>> I can tell you that XN1 is guaranteed by
the end of round 13. X and 2 is based on
tiebreaker. So, we'll have to see how
that all shakes out. Again, I am not
going to be the person to tell you how
the tiebreaker shake out. That is
absolutely not my job for very, very
good reasons.
>> Yeah, that is very complicated math and
I won't try it either. I'll try to count
might, but I'm not going to try to
calculate tiebreers.
>> I think it's a fair thing we can uh we
can guarantee on the stream a might
calculations only. We have another
feature match coming up. Pull up deck
list as soon as they're ready cuz I'm
very curious to see what happens here in
a feature match area. And I spy a very
familiar looking hoodie on the right
side of the shot.
H
>> Oh, that is not who I thought we were
going to see. Villionaire, great
username by the way, playing Master Yei,
the terror of Origins back in Spirit
Forged.
>> Yeah, it is. Was a very painful memory
for many of us who played set one. Uh,
and it does seem like you guessed it
correctly because we saw him against
that interesting hoodie uh on screen a
second ago. This Master Yelist, I think,
is fairly interesting. We think of
obviously Aurora Misfortune that did
well last week in Bolognia, but that
deck can go so low on units because of
the purple recycling. And that's just
not the same case in this deck.
>> No, this is a Aurora Master Y deck,
which is kind of cool to see. Has some
weight, you know, has some protection,
which is especially good with how much
gear hate is running around these days.
You can, you know, not so faster or defy
to protect your Aurora, which is a
pretty big investment you have to make
when you do get there. something uh
actually the points that that's sorry
sticking out to me is actually desert's
call as a three of in this deck which is
a really neat bit of technology if you
play it only costs two it makes a uh a
two might sand token something I know
you're very familiar with even has a
repeat we actually saw this class in the
feature material by an Azia player but
the neat thing about this is it's a
basically a two drop unit that isn't
actually a unit so when you go flipping
through your deck for Aurora you can
never hit this two drop
>> yeah that's a great point I was actually
talking to billionaire I think yesterday
about this list and he pointed out just
this card he said that it is, you know,
it's a two might unit that you normally
don't get a play. So, you could do it
your turn one if you need to go a little
bit faster and it doesn't cost power so
it doesn't stop you on that ramp up to
Aurora either.
>> It appears I have stolen your homework
cuz I knew someone else had told me that
and it turns out that someone was
Ursula. We go have a look at his
opponent though as we did tease before.
It is a familiar hoodie in the feature
match once again. Really a familiar
person in the feature match. Randy still
here, still locked. Still sorry, not
locked. live for a top eight here with
Miracle Draven.
>> Yeah, we've seen a couple of these
today. It does seem we have two Miracle
I mean multiple Miracle Dravens fighting
it out for Best of Draven. Uh and a lot
of great cards here. We do obviously see
a little bit more, you know, might in
this one than some of the others, but I
absolutely love to see it. Very excited
to see how this deck list plays out,
including those three piercing lights.
>> Yeah, this list is really interesting
actually just based on kind of the
general miracle shell we've seen.
Obviously see a visuals see a lot of
seals but only two seals main for Randy.
A lot of different tech cards vi one
fizz only one rasa only which I think
his teammate was also sticking there
with prismaticism. A lot of different
things you can do with the deck that
basically draws its entire deck every
game. Makes a lot of sense. And now
Randy the kind of player that does like
his one-ups cuz he's a player that
really gets through the deck quickly. He
was known for shovel civer when he was
competing in China in the regional
qualifiers there. And that is a deck
that goes through its deck rapidly where
you have to remember everything you've
recycled. Not so much burden of
knowledge perhaps, but we are going to
kick things off as both players are
still exing one and getting very close
to top eight. I don't know if this is
exactly a win in, but it's got to be
pretty close at this point.
>> Yeah, I think he he got top four in
China with the civer list, but it is
very interesting. He brought it to
Bolognia as well. And we'll have to
watch out for the beast under in his
side deck. I keep wanting to call it
like
>> beast below.
>> Beast below. Beast blow. It's a
different synonym. It is
>> difference, but we will be mulliganing
here. Two fun battlefields. That
aspirant climb is going to make us have
to get to nine points to win today.
>> Makes sense for a master, especially
when you're playing a deck like Aurora
that is trying to resolve a nine drop as
early as they can. Want the game to go a
little bit longer. Try and get your
value cuz the more turns that pass on,
the better your Aurora gets cuz it
starts spitting units out of a deck. I
think especially for this kind of Aurora
where there's quite a few units. We saw
Voli Bear actually on day one with they
think 15 units because there's only 12
in this list if I'm remembering
correctly, but you know, you have to go
through 12 turns with one Aurora to get
maximum value out of your cards. So,
>> 100%. And if you are interested in Nexus
Knights, Randy is showing off those
great Nexus Knights runes that I was
talking about earlier. I think they I
thought the last set was my favorite,
but this one is as well, and I'm
debating buying some here today.
>> A classic era. In fact, I'm surprised we
haven't seen this a little earlier.
Villionaire trying to flip over the top
cards of his rune deck, which is good.
You're supposed to do that at the start
of your turn. Uh, pick the wrong deck
was flipping over, but unfortunately
revealed the charm off the top of the
library. Judge is just sorting it out
now. Randy, I guess, has been in this
spot before said, "I believe the policy
is just to shuffle and rerandomize and
go from there. Maybe you get a caution,
maybe get a warning." Nothing uh too
major going to be happening here. Civil
is in fact going to be shuffling up.
>> Mhm.
>> Shaking his head. You know, little
nerves perhaps in the future. Merit late
in the tournament. It's been a very long
weekend so far, but it's the kind of
thing you just shake it off. It happens.
It's fine. It's a minor mistake. It's
not going to affect the game in a major
way.
>> Just random
>> accept it and move on. Random is still
random. That is correct.
>> Yeah, but it is nice to see that
mobilize. Mobilize is the card that
Villionaire is going to want to hit here
because he needs to ramp up to Roy as
fast as possible. He's making the game
longer with Aspirin's climb, but he
still has to move fast.
>> Actually, I might have been slightly
wrong about what happened there cuz that
was immobilized. So, it could have maybe
mobilized and tried to flip a card.
might have thought it was a no. Catalyst
doesn't draw cards either. Okay, so must
have just been trying to channel a rune.
Actually flipped up the wrong deck. It
does happen from time to time as Tide
Turner makes its way onto the aspirants
climb and begins the journey upward to
nine points
>> 100%.
Uh he Ry's got more of these smaller
units which
>> not
he keeps stopping himself it looks like
but it it did seem to happen again. We
are going to go on and get that first
point from Randy though. Starting
upwards to nine hopefully. Um while
Billionaire does hit Catalyst of Aons,
another one of those ramping cards that
we mentioned. Mobilize a little bit
small smaller, but Catalyst of Aons
actually gets to do I believe two.
>> Okay, so it looks like I I figured out
the the issue. Villaina, I suppose, is a
player that plays with the rune deck on
his left. And the way the feature map
play is laid out, you know, there's
zones for your deck, for your graveyard,
for your champion, all that stuff. You
don't have to abide by the playmat. It's
not like legally binding. It is simply a
recommendation to make things easier for
us on coverage. So, you know, you have a
spot to put your things and we clearly
know where they are. Players have been
playing, you know, one side or the other
the entire weekend long. It is totally
fine to play on the other side, but I
guess Villian was just trying to be very
courteous to the future match area. Put
things in their proper places, quote
unquote, and unfortunately has revealed
three cards off the top of his deck as
we go, but everything has been resolved.
We have shifted the runes to the the
rightful place for Villionaire. And
we're going to kick things off as uh you
know despite some of the oopsies we can
say uh that is enough Aurora runes the
next turn. So Villionaire off to the
races if there is an Aurora in hand.
>> Yes, that is what Villionaire is going
to want. But Ry's going to be looking
for some card here that could
potentially try to I don't know if he
actually has card removal in his deck,
but often times you're going to want
this turn to be the one that you try to
check the hand if you're worried about
Aurora at least.
>> Yeah, no sabotage in this unlike the
shovel civer we've mentioned floating in
energy right now. Now a seal of discord
does come into play and it's Ezreal,
everyone's favorite purple three drop
coming down and drawing some cards.
>> Yeah, Ezreal, as we know, is so strong
for drawing more and more cards and also
discounting cards that can draw us more
cards.
>> Shuffle them through the hand. Ride the
wind. Don't need that one right now. Let
me draw two different cards. That might
be a bit better in the situation I'm in.
Don't think there's any main deck ways
for Randy to take out the Aurora. for
Aurora if it is in hand. I don't know if
it is, is going to stick around. Zorn
Warren though going to be the next
visit. This will be the second point on
the turn for Randy.
>> Trigger, discard, draw a card. See you
later. Vi not going to need you this
matchup either. And of course, as we
know, can probably get it back later if
needed.
>> Yeah, and I think it's really
interesting that Randy decided to go on
and retreat back the tide turner. I do
think it is correct. But some one thing
to note because Villionaire is actually
running ye with this Aurora list is if
you have any units in any of these
battlefields and he flips a dead bloom
predator, he can go in and play that
dead bloom predator into one of the
battlefields immediately. So something
we sometimes saw during set one when you
come up to that like eight rune nine
rune mark is people would pull all their
units out so that you couldn't
capitalize on this eight might dead
bloom predator with deflect.
>> Yeah definitely trying to dodge that
unit very very uh very powerful and of
course even with the legend ability
which we haven't seen in a while it is
plus two on defense if you're out of
battlefield. So Y's plan obviously is to
play an Aurora, get big units, and then
stick them on battlefields until the
game ends one way or the other. There's
Aurora right on time here for Master Y.
>> Yeah, he does hit it. Dazzling Aurora
triggers at the end of your turn, just
to note. So at the end of the turn,
Villionaire will be able to flip through
each of his cards. It does, you know,
Randy can see them, so he'll know it's
there. And look at that guy. I wonder if
we know him.
>> Would that be competitor?
>> Yeah,
>> definely do. lost a lot of games to that
card in Origins.
>> As have I.
>> Eight might deflect. You may play me to
an occupied enemy battlefield. Decides
not to waddle over to the battlefield
with nine might add at it already. An
astute choice from Villionaire cuz again
Marty very good at giving you extra
might. Basically for free out of your
legend zone, but only on defense, not
when you're trying to get on the Oy
going to go ahead awaken and shuffle
some units forward. Thinking about point
number five unlike our usual game. So we
are playing to eight. Uh this time
playing to nine means you do want to get
an odd point total which is a very odd
thing in rift. Usually not the heristic
we use for points and cadot is going to
eat a defy something that I think is
probably happened thousands of times
this tournament already.
>> Yeah I would not be surprised. Green may
be a little bit more rare than shot for
sure uh or than purple but it is
definitely something I would like to
defy. The nice thing is too is when they
commit to paying the repeat cost, which
they have to do when they play the
spell, you do get the entire spell. It
doesn't make a copy of it or anything
like that. The whole spell simply gets
enhanced. It gets repeated. So, defying
it gets the uh gets all of the effect.
You don't get half of it or anything
like that. So, lot of value for
something like Defy versus something
like Culture. And again, these are cards
that can help protect the Aurora. No
need for that right now. Certainly in
game one, I have to imagine. But the
plan is still here for Randy. I'm going
to take points early because Aurora, if
it's one thing, especially with
something like Aspirin's climb deck is
pretty slow.
>> Yeah, it is slow. But we did hit
dazzling Aurora so we can start mo
moving our game plan forward. Uh it does
potentially riding out of here over
>> that's so fun. Get the zones tricky. Get
a point in your opponent's turn. That's
a way to break the math on aspirin's
climb.
>> Yeah, that's going to be painful for
Billionaire. You do not like to see that
happen.
But we are at least going to get our
first point. It looks like Randy is now
in that showdown with the tide turner in
this game. A lot of times you I mean
everything remote for the most part
happens in a stack, but showdowns are
actually Q.
>> That's really interesting. I was
actually wondering how that worked, but
I'm glad you knew. Randy Cu, by the way,
he's like, "Yep, we do this one first,
then do the other one." Everyone's
waiting in line. Dead Bloom Predators
waiting in the hand straight to the now
occupied zone. So Randy says, "Fine, you
got my little tide turner. took you two
dead blooms to do it, but you got it.
>> The only problem is now they're in spot,
right? Because a lot of times maybe
decks have trouble uh with defending.
Eight might was already a lot to deal
with before, but now Villionaire
actually has 10 might in both of them
because of that Yi ability we talked
about earlier.
>> So, I will remind everyone of an
important piece of text of Ye's
legitability that I did just remember.
Ye's legit ability specifically says
when I defend alone.
>> Mhm. So stacking the battlefield there
would give you 16 might. Uh but on its
own it's just 10. So you lose a little
bit of extra legend value if you go to
stack more. So deciding to leave one of
the dead blooms at home. So now there's
dead blooms in every possible area. I
think it's the smart choice. It's not
only because of the ye keyword like you
mentioned alone, but having more units
in your base to push up later. It's not
like if Randy clears one battle or field
or both of them, all of the units are
gone now because he'll still have to
deal with that dead bloom that's in in
billionaire's base.
>> All right, so 5 + 4, that's nine. Dead
bloom, as we noted, only eight, although
is two more. So Randy going to recycle a
fury rune and make Draven up to six. So
that's 11 total versus the 10 thanks to
the legend ability. And Villiona says,
"Yep, you got me." Randy up to seven
points which in this game is very
similar to six points confusingly.
>> Yeah, it's just slightly different
because of that aspirin's climb. Uh
Villionaire did leave leave up one rune
but he decides not to use it here. It
could be a bluff, but there are multiple
cards in Ye's list between Ong Guard.
Yep, you could, I guess, punch first as
well. Uh we're having some punching over
here in in in the booth, but uh or even
Defy.
>> Yep. Lots of options here. Again, it's
kind of the I think the advantage to
playing Aurora in these domains is you
get access a little bit more
interaction, particularly on the chain,
which again when people are trying to go
get after your gears isn't a bad thing
here is seal of discord the second and I
will remind you the only other seal in
Ry's entire deck list. Not running
three, which is a very curious choice.
Again, Randy and Prismaticism are
teammates, so it's really odd to see
them have different takes on the same
archetype.
>> Yeah, it is so cool though. I think at
the same time to see uh what you know
while they're on the same team they do
have their different takes and they're
hoping to still you know pilot it to a
win. Really excited to see how these
different deck lists play out and the
versatility though of Draven to have so
many different deck lists is so
interesting.
>> Yeah, I mean this the shell is very
powerful. There's lots of different
things you can do as Ry go to point
number eight which is one point away
from winning this aspirants climb game
that is going to nine. And even though
the deflect had to be played on the dead
bloom fight or fight more than enough
there to kick that one out. In fact,
seal of discord doing the other thing it
does sometimes that doesn't happen all
that often which is pay for deflect
cost. Something that you are allowed to
do with the power that seals generate.
So we are going to move noxious hopeful
to the zorn warren. We are going to
commit some might over zealous fan. Play
that one there. Reinforcing as much as
we can and just saying you know what I
only need one of these battlefields to
win at this point. So let me try and
hold either of them. Yeah, I think you
know normally you think of Miracle as
the deck that comes from behind, but in
this place, Villionaire has a slow
start. That's how his deck is built and
Randy was still able to capitalize on
that from the tide turner into the
Draven. He was quick and he's been
making a lot of lot of points and now
he's saying try to take them both.
>> Yeah. How how big is Double Predator
again? Eight. Might
>> eight 16 if they both go into one. But
we actually have to take both. Hm, that
seems tricky cuz there's 15 might at the
zone warren right now and there's only
three at the top. But again, with only
one point needed and holding is enough
to win to claim that special point in
riftbound that you need to push the game
over to a victory. So you have to feel
like from this stage, unless there's a
way for billionaire to ready another
unit, one of the deadlines is committed
to the top side.
>> So then the question is what on earth do
you do on the bottom
>> for sure? And I think there's like a
couple options. We did see a lot of
Tasty Faith Folk in Billionaire's list.
While Dead Bloom Predator is the one
that you really think of from the, you
know, Dazzling Aurora, it would be
played directly in, Tasty Faith Folk has
accelerate, which means when you pay him
as play him as an eight instead of a
seven with one power. He can run in one
of these battlefields. And also, if he
dies, you still get a death nail. You
get to channel two more runes, which you
can't really use in this situation
unless we clear both battlefields. But
we also get to draw a card which can
just be so strong.
>> Visile's fan going to make things tricky
as well. That's the other piece of the
puzzle here. I mean it is two might on
the battlefield but realistically it's
just another copy of fight or flight
sitting and waiting. So whatever units
get pushed over there. Uh I mean as it
is right now this game is actually not
winnable. So find your center going to
be here for an extra draw. Channels are
run as well. Very very cheap because
Randy is very close to winning even the
aspirin climb game.
>> But going to need something here. You're
going to need probably an accelerate
unit, maybe something like a challenge.
There are some spells here that can
maybe do some work, but just a lot of
units presented cuz there's only so many
deadl Predators as Randy decides, you
know what, I can probably give up this
point here. Looks at the hand, maybe has
nothing, maybe as something, but going
tohead going to go ahead and give up
this battlefield cuz the bottom one's
the one he's really trying to hold on
to.
>> Yeah, the one thing we could see here is
a charm over that could pull one of
these big units from Zan Warren and
decrease the might. It looks like first
though our choice is going to be
discipline. Make our our uh dead bloom
predator a little bit larger. But we
need to figure out something for that
overzilla fan like you mentioned because
the problem is is overzilla span can't
be defied or anything like that in the
way that you know an actual fighter
fight could. However, it looks like we
are going to scoop this game one and
we're going to a double double obelisk
of power.
>> That seems really good for the Aurora
deck
>> I would say. So yeah, I think I think
that could be a nice little curve. We
are gonna be going first I guess but we
will have four which means catalyst of
Aons will be turned on in that first
turn.
>> That's pretty much all you can ask for I
feel like as an Aurora deck and I mean
again both players happy to play Obelisk
here. It's does play into both of their
game plans as we are going to get into
game number two. Randy up one and zero
as I will explain something fun that
could have happened. So you mentioned
over a little tricky to counter and that
is very true but not so fast does work.
However, the way you have to do this is
that when you push into Overz fan, they
say, "Okay, I want to use I'm going to
I'm going to use the trigger." But they
don't have to choose until it resolves.
So, if you want a not so fast over fan
trigger, you have to do it when they
say, "Okay, I'm doing this."
>> Which basically means that you waste a
spell on the fan to stop it if you
really have to stop it or you say,
"Okay." And then they can choose to say
yes or no.
>> Interesting.
>> So, it's it's very Overz fan favorite. I
think that's the only current way to
really interact with an ability like
that. So even in that instance, not so
fast doesn't really work. But you know
what does work? That catalyst of AON
right on time for the Aurora player. And
yet just as you said, we hit that
catalyst of AON. We're already up to six
runes. We're going to eight just one shy
of that Aurora. But Randy is trying to
find his unit. Obviously, we do have
that Draven that's in our chosen
champion spot. But up against Aurora
Yei, it's going to be really, really
important that we start taking these
battlefields, start getting those points
and, you know, getting an early lead
before Villionaire can start.
>> Oh, Kaiser. Oh, the one of Kaiser in
fact here for Randy,
>> I think. No,
>> just playing it straight up, I guess,
after stack deck only had four runes, so
not able to pay the accelerate cost.
Five is a pretty big number of starting
runes, but is unfortunately not uh six
after one energy was committed. Master
ye leaving the champion zone for the
first time in this match. Off we go to
the obelisk of power. Uh the top one I
guess there are two. The one written in
English if that matters to anyone else
cuz all of Ry's cards of course in
Chinese from competing in China for so
long.
>> Actually I'm pretty sure both players
maybe I'm thinking someone else. I
thought oh no matter who also had
Chinese cards but I will say I played
Master Y a bit during set one. Uh, and
you know, something bad about myself. I
guess my toxic trade is I would forget
that Master Yi was in my chosen spot.
>> Yeah, I mean, look, you get a lot of
value out of things that are your legend
ability and sometimes uh you're quite
expensive seven energy champion just
chills on in there. But Aurora is pretty
good at getting that ramp and couldn't
play Aurora that turn anyway, so might
as well play the E. And it's still uh 3
4 5 6 still not enough runes actually to
Aurora the next turn. A mind spplitter
coming down. maybe going to take the
card from him, but it's not even there.
Actually was moving in towards an eight
drop and one of them is going to get
stripped away.
>> Yeah, I will say even if there Well, it
would have been taken here, but because
we have this double obelisk of power,
Ye's power cost, which would might have
normally taken us out of Aurora range
that next turn, still kept us going into
nine runes. uh versus, you know, either
this white flame protector which costs
two or that dead predator who will also
cost two if we're actually playing him.
But I do think this white flame
protector is really going to play into
our later game here versus Randy. Randy
has been really stacking different
battlefields. But White Flame
Protector's ability is when you play
him, you get to give a unit plus eight
might, which is absolutely massive. And
uh it would be definitely difficult to
deal with when it's time to hold.
>> Yeah, pretty interesting that in general
there's just going to be a lot to crack
through as far as might go. That is
something that Draven can impressively
present, especially later on in the
game. It's kind of funny to me to see
Randy with the one of Kaiser in this
mind spplitter. I think from the board
kind of like we've talked a lot about
mid-range versus miracle draven this
event and Ry's kind of got a miracle
draven deck with some random mid-range
cards scattered in there. It turns out
those cards are pretty good on their
own. So Randy, you know, taking a couple
slots here and there, stripping away
maybe small pieces of the engine just to
play some really good cards that are
just good on their own as Dead Bloom
Predator gets taken away and White Flame
Protector joins Master in the top
battlefield. There's no Aurora this
game. We just playing the cards we draw.
Yeah, but master he has ganking which
means that white flame protector does
make him a 14 might unit going to the
southern obelisk of power. Sadly fight
or flight is hidden in that battlefield
and Master Yi will be pushed back but 10
might in Obeliska power up north is
still going to be difficult for Danny to
deal with.
>> That was a really sweet play by
Villionaire. Unfortunately the fighter
flight completely undoes it all but I do
like the attempt there again. No Aurora,
but still not out of hope. In fact, they
start looking quite good thanks to the
double obelisk here as both players are
tied at two points a piece. But Randy
getting on battlefields early here and
trying to rack up advantages as
Villionaire is falling a little bit
behind in runes. And that wouldn't
really matter cuz again, they're both
relatively equal right now. I think the
big difference is that uh in general,
Yei spells are just more expensive than
Draven's
>> for sure. And I would like us to keep an
eye on this hidden card on the obla
power up north just because
with ye something they like to do oftent
times is they hide the zonas. Uh and
normally you can't play a gear into a
battlefield because it's hidden. You can
in this situation and normally zonas you
don't get to decide who it kills or no
it kills but saves. But in this case
when you flip it is when it would be
able to save something. So you're
actually going to be able to decide, oh,
if Randy kills my E, even though it's in
the other battlefield, I could flip it.
It goes to base and now it could save
that E as well.
>> Yeah, I think get a lot of selection.
Again, especially when you're really
holding battlefields with one unit at a
time. Just kind of a general bit of
value as Randy puts the mind splitter
straight in the bin before it got
charmed over to the battlefield where it
was going to perish anyway. So just a
little bit of shortcutting here for our
players as I did about Randy playing
mid-range in disguise before. He played
a ferris forrunner for the turn before
that. So, kind of just playing all the
good Draven mid-range cards and trying
to kind of outmuscle or I guess match
muscle with the Aurora deck, which is
kind of fun to see.
>> Mhm. Uh it is really nice to kill some
of these, but yeah, Ferris Bunner is not
the card we would want to pull. My
>> another mind spplitter. I mean, Sabotage
looking pretty good here. There are
three choices. Sabotage can only take
non-unit cards, so gears and non-units
are all available. does get recycled
which isn't gone forever but you know
gone for probably long enough in this
matchup. Rebuke pretty good against
Aurora in general so I have to think
that one is maybe going to get taken
away. Hard bargain not bad. Ride the
wind pretty good but maybe not so scary
in this exact spot. I think you wish you
could take the mindslitter.
Unfortunately the only thing in this
spot that could take mind spplitter is
another mindspplitter.
>> Yeah, I think that's something I'm was
always jealous of mine spplitter when I
was a Yi player. I'm over here like my
sabotage. Why can't I take the units
too? Um, but it does look like I mean we
will have to choose. I didn't see which
one that was chosen by the sabotage. Um,
and it did get recycled. So you it's not
Oh, it was rebuke. It looks like
>> locked away forever production for
flashing rebuke on the screen. Makes
sense that that seems like the most
powerful card that Randy could have here
against this deck. In general, Aurora
really hates that card. Yeah,
>> they're trying to sit on especially this
version with master where you get all
this value but only when you are
defending.
>> Yeah, and also Aurora Yi, which where is
the Aurora is a whole different question
this game.
>> Just Y today.
>> Yeah, it's just Ye for game two. But
normally you want your units in your
deck, not in your hand. So rebuking it
to hand kind of uh really hurts the the
dazzling Aurora later, but what we
mentioned earlier does look like it's
going to happen. So ZAS was flipped up
because Gears get moved to base. It is
not only affecting that one battlefield
and Ye does get saved.
>> Yep, nice there to save the year.
Unfortunately does mean Randy still
claims a better gets a point and wins
the combat. Going to draw a card off
Draven there as well. Kaiser does go
down. So no extra draw from the conquer
trigger out of Kaiser which is I think
at this point the least of Villionaire's
worries. Although still at four points
having some pretty big units can maybe
look to retake here versus 4Runner. But
again I'm just struck by Randy drawing
all of these really good mid-range units
in a deck that's trying to play a bunch
of seals and cord shots and his
overzealous fan to add to the problems.
At this point it looks like Randy
sideboarded the miracle package out of
his deck. He has absolutely not done
that but that's what it looks like just
based on the cards he's drawn this game.
Yeah, he's having he's putting so much
might into play and with Ferris
4Erunner, even if Billionaire is able to
take out that six might unit, he'll
still get six might into base again. So,
Villionaire is facing a lose-lose
situation here if he wants to come into
Obelis.
>> Yeah, cards feel like they're running
out is the other thing here for
Villionaire. Again, not that much draw
power in a deck like Roar. You really
get a lot of your card advantage by
flipping units for free up the top of
your deck. And we don't have an Aurora.
Obviously, that's made a bit more
challenging. There are the runes
available to play the very expensive,
very powerful piece of gear, but have to
imagine there is no Aurora
>> available. Yeah, it does look like we
haven't hit it. And I think set one, we
were able to still win a lot of times,
even if you didn't actually hit your
dazzling Aurora. At least from what I've
been talking to players about, they've
said that it's been really difficult to
still get that win when you're when you
don't need dazzling.
>> I mean, this is a deck that certainly
can play its units, but this is a little
too slow, I feel like, sometimes,
especially in this meta game. So,
Protector the second is going to make
this year massive once again. And Ferris
forun going to hit the bin. Overall was
charmed over to the top side into the
other wel protector. And this game is
looking quite good now for Villionaire.
We're actually threatening to win. we
are. If we can hold both of these
battlefields, it will be a win. But
also, obviously, Randy could take one,
save off another turn, but Ye does
definitely defends best.
>> Certainly does defend best.
Unfortunately, it's only one unit at a
time, and that rule is not true for
Randy. So, those two little mechs and
Draven could go rumbling over to either
of these battlefields. And with no buffs
in play and no runes awakened, does seem
tough for Villionaire to have any sort
of interaction here.
Yeah, I mean we're threatening 10 up
north, eight on bottom. Sadly, no runes
out. Well, unexhausted for Villionaire,
meaning we don't get any extra might
other than that E ability.
>> And here's spinning axe. Actually,
Draven matching might after recycling.
And now the ax is going to make this a
very unfair fight. Draven with his
signature equipment equipping it
himself. Feels very flavorful as Ry's
going to get a gold for conquering,
sorry, for winning combat. going to get
a card for winning combat as well and of
course get a point for his troubles at
the end of the day which most
importantly does prevent Villionaire
from winning uh in his next beginning
phase. Still possible to win next turn
but generally tough for Aurora to find a
double conquer a deck that really just
wants to hold until the end.
>> Yeah, it's going to be tough. I will say
the one I feel like the one line on
Draven that is most forgotten is that
generates gold win-win. But we do get
it. And I'm sure both of these players
are very much they don't forget it like
I do. Um, but Draven's holding here
seven threatening nine. This dragon is
only an eight, but with green cards,
Villionaire does have might increasing
cards in hand or could have might
increasing cards in hand.
>> Yeah, could get bigger but not going to
get bigger this turn. And I feel like
that is mean meaning that the impetus is
on Randy to try and deal with the top
wip protector right now if he can.
Instead, it looks like we are just
deploying big units to base. Not the
cheapest battleing ram I've ever seen.
Not the cheapest ras we've ever seen
either, but still pretty good for 11
might for only six runes
>> for sure. We are now up to seven points
here. Uh, and
>> I guess actually it does look a little
spooky. Uh, you already scored one
battlefield. If you score both
battlefields, you can score the winning
point. And white flame protector is an
eight. Draven currently, I mean, you
said it is a nine. So enough to stave
off the white flame protector on its
own. But I mean another white flame
protector might do it here.
>> Yeah, another white flame protector
could definitely do it. But I do think
normally a lot of these battlefields
they either run three dead blooms and
two white flame or three white flame and
two dead bloom. So I'm not expecting to
see it. Looks like we are just going for
the hold on this Obliska power leaving
up eight runes. There's a lot of
different cards it could be. I wish I
could remember all of his in his deck,
but primal might is one that threatens a
lot of of might and we have the runes to
do it.
>> Yeah, Villina clearly leaving up all the
interaction here. I think it's only two
cards in the hand I can see being
shuffled back and forth, but punch first
would be a card. We see discipline
already.
>> Uh not going to be alone, so it doesn't
get the bonus might from the Ye legend,
but 16 might is a bigger number than 10.
So I understand why Villionaire just
wants to play for the hold here. But lot
of tricks in this Draven deck as cold
shot is going to resolve. No defy this
time
for Villionaire and Ry's going to try
and look to see if he can find a rebuke
a fight or flight or something else to
get it done cuz it doesn't need too much
more. Even though conquering both,
sorry, scoring both this turn wouldn't
win the game for Randy. I think if these
W protectors go bye-bye, it's going to
be very tough for Villionaire to win
this game.
>> I'll definitely definitely agree. I will
say I do think Villionaire had the Defy
in hand. Uh, so I I think I spied it
earlier when we were looking at when he
was showing his hands a little bit more,
but we're definitely being a little bit
patient here. Maybe making Randy think
he doesn't have it in hand by not
playing it on these earlier cards. That
might not actually get him the win.
>> Yeah, makes sense again to try and save
off fight or flight, which I believe
Randy was at least considering among the
two cards in that second piece of cold
shot. Don't know what he selected at the
end of the day cuz we're going to start
by rumbling on in. Here is 11. Here's a
couple more. 11 + 5 is Oh, that's six.
Sorry. All right, level six is 17, which
is exactly one more than 16, it turns
out. And that's it. Big just can't win.
He had nothing. He had to die.
>> That was a great bluff, but Randy called
him on it. And that is going to be the
entire round for them.
>> That is not how I expected that game to
end at all. I mean, not a lot of cards
in hand left for the Master Gear player
at the end of it all, but
>> why not, right?
>> Usually, especially when you leave
everything untapped, you have to have
something. I mean, could have played the
Aurora, I think, flipped another unit
onto the battlefield.
>> I think he only had eight M or eight
runes.
>> Then no Aurora,
>> just one shy. I do think that is a huge
problem when you're playing those white
flame protectors and dead balloons from
hand is they stall out your runes.
You're at eight. Next turn, you're still
at eight because you had to pay two
runes. And next turn, you're still at
eight because you had to pay two runes.
And you can't really develop the board
way you want to, especially with dowsing
Aurora. That's nine. Well, uh, the
player that made Top Eight in Bologn is
still live for Top Eight here in Vegas.
Let's hear from Jim Davis, who's down
with a winners interview.
>> All right, I'm here with Randy. Just
took down Master Yi. You are 11 and one
of a tournament. Were you expecting to
see Master Yi uh here at this stage of a
tournament?
>> Uh, I wasn't expecting to see Master Yi,
but I did face three in day two, so I'm
pretty happy about that. I'll take it.
Uh, I've beaten all three of them. All
three guys were like running for the
medal. That's pretty pretty high quality
for me. So, I'm pretty happy about that.
>> Um,
>> that that's awesome. So, you're playing
Draven.
>> How are you feeling? Of course, a lot of
Draven in the field. How are you feeling
in the mirror? How you feeling about the
deck overall?
>> Uh, I'm feeling pretty good. Uh, I got
top eight with a deck last week at
Bologna. Lost in top eight, but uh I'm
feeling pretty good. I have a lot of
practice on the deck. My deck is really
strong. I think probably have the best
deck in the room with my friend. So, uh,
mirror, not a problem. beat uh four
mirrors on the way, lost one, but uh
yeah,
>> awesome stuff. And you're coming all the
way from France, so uh you're in
Bolognia. Um how are you adapting to,
you know, the time change and uh you
being a new location being in Vegas. Are
you enjoying Vegas?
>> Uh I am not very enjoying Vegas very
much. The hair is very dry. I hate it.
I'm a bit uh sick from Bolognia as well.
Um but I do think that's mostly because
of the fatigue. I was in China just
before that. So I did three times only
in three weeks. That pretty rough. Um,
yeah,
>> gamers got a game. We'd love to hear
that. So, uh, what are your thoughts?
You got a few rounds left. Um, you know,
you're in striking distance of top
eight. How are you feeling overall?
>> Uh, I'm feeling pretty good. Feeling
pretty rusted. I'm going to get a
coffee, maybe another one. And, uh,
we're just going to play ours. I'm
looking for the win now. Uh, I lost in
top four, lost in top eight. Want to
lock this one in.
>> All right. So, going for a win here in
Vegas.
Water is wet, air is dry, and Randy is
still live at top eight at original
qualifier. These are all things we know
for sure.
>> Yes, it is. And you can just hear how
committed he is. He was in China
directly over and now
Las Vegas where even though he's
unhappy, he's happy to play the game.
>> Certainly is. And this is round 12. This
is the second to last round, the
penultimate round of Swiss, if you will.
We have one feature match, but once
again, we have second feature match.
Always a treat. And this matchup is
going to be quite a fun as we check out
some of the deck list. Bet you didn't
expect to see the very best gamer on Jax
this late into the tournament, but here
it is.
>> Oh my gosh, I did not expect Jax. That
is for sure. Green and orange. I think
my favorite color has been yellow this
set personally. So orange a little bit
surprising, but I think Jax has been
posed really well this tournament. I was
hoping that, you know, maybe we would
have one super late into the game and uh
not to say the exact name, but the very
best gamer may bring Jax in.
>> Yeah, really interesting stuff. We did
see a Jax yesterday. A lot of the
similar tools here, Ruin Runner, Silicon
of course is your draw engine of choice
in a lot of your com decks. Lucian,
Warmox, Brutalizer, all of these other
things. Triple Counter-Strike, Bone
Shiver, not one I think we saw yesterday
when we had Jacks on stream. When I
conquer China, one exhausted. That's
fun. It's also the promo for this event
if you participated. So, there's some
fancy bone shivers lying out there
potentially if you want to go buy them
on the internet cuz quite a few players
participated in this event. So, there's
going to be quite a few of the promos
given out.
>> Yeah, I hope he's using the promo one.
>> I certainly hope so. Hope they got two
cuz I got two on the deck. We'll have a
look at the other deck list. It is of
course a player that I know you are
quite familiar with on a matchup we've
seen many times. It is Colin on Draven,
our former only undefeated player. Yes,
Colin has played in so many of the
grassroot tournaments for Riftbound. I
think a lot of players know Colin's
name. He was known as the set player of
set one, but he is now in a little bit
more of a meta deck. He's playing uh
Draven here. So, interesting to see his
take on that same deck.
>> All right, as a reminder, we are going
to move into sphere jump. We are
starting in game number three. So, I can
tell you Jax can beat Draven. It has
already happened. We didn't see it, but
it can happen. But so here is the final
game between these two. Not sure
expected to be in this spot with top
eight potentially on the line, but
target peak is going to be the
battlefield of choice for Draven. And it
is the dreaming tree for Jax and master
drums. That is an extremely powerful
battlefield.
>> Yeah. And I'll also say this game, I was
told before we came in here that it is a
win and in for top eight because whoever
wins this game will be posed to be able
to tie into top cut. Makes sense cuz
these two players probably a pretty good
breakers for how long they would have
stayed with such a unblenmished record.
Colin again for a long time I think was
10 and zero at one point before this
round. So only lost very recently which
is always good for your top eight
chances. You want to lose if you're
going to lose you want to lose late
except in top eight. It's a little bit
confusing but two runes channel here as
Colin is going to be the play going
first in our third and final game and
Guardian Angel Go is going to be the
first here for the very best gamer on
Jax Grandmaster at arms. Not a champ,
not a legend. I expected to see this
deep into day two as Draven is going to
be the play and we're going to pass it
on back.
>> Yeah, I will say I if you're going to
lose in top eight, it better be late as
well. So, at least you can get second
place. But I am feeling kind of
confident here. Targon's Peak is one of
the strongest battlefields for Draven.
I'm not sure if how that plays into Jax
per se since I haven't seen Jax as much,
but especially a lot of times when
Draven is into different matchups.
Targon's Peak is the game he's sure he's
going to win.
>> So, this is a unit we saw the other day
when we had Jax on stream, but we didn't
actually see Aphelas really do anything.
When you equip Aphelius, choose one that
hasn't been chosen this turn. It is
ready to run, channel a rune, or buff a
unit, I believe, are the three choices
available. So, Jax using the legend
ability to equip the equipment without
using power. Then, Aphelio getting his
power back that he was paid to play the
champion unit by channeling a rune off
the top of the deck. So, a really cool,
very efficient kind of multifaceted
little mid-range card for these
equipment decks and one that pretty much
just Jax gets to take full advantage of.
>> Yeah, and it's so versatile with those
three options. I did see in the game
too, they had sunken Temple, so using
that buff could help create more mighty
units to be able to draw cards off of
Sunken Temple. It does look like Colin
decided to play Draven and it's going up
into that Targon's peak. That does mean
that when he passes his turn, as you can
see here, he will be able to write two
of his units. And if the very best gamer
wants to take that battlefield, he will
have to contest with those two runes
being up on Colin side, which is that
magic number for so many different
spells in his hand.
>> Yeah, as you said, it just represents so
many possible tricks here. And uh is
there something hidden under that
battlefield or is there some sleeve
action going on? I don't know what's
happening.
>> So, what's happening is some of the
players will stack all three of their
battlefields. Um, and so I do believe
it's his battlefield one and two
underneath it.
>> Okay, you know what? Just wants to
remember what happened before.
>> Want to make sure you don't select the
wrong one as Dreaming Tree going to be
conquered here by Jax. And is there a
spell to play just to cycle a card?
Maybe don't want to commit something
like a punch first just to draw one. But
you know what? It's it's a thing you can
do. Ooh, going to re-equip and ready
some runes. That is a very cute piece of
tech here for Aelios.
That is so nice. And I think that's one
of the great things about the Jax
leader. He does have two options like we
mentioned yesterday. Uh but you're able
to either reattach a unit that's already
attached. In this case, it is on that
Felios to himself or attach one that's
not attached. And instead of having to
pay the power that you normally have to
for the equipment, you'll only have to
pay an energy, which is going to be so
nice for keeping those resources.
>> And this time using the ready to runes
to basically make extra resources, which
is really sick. Challenging the Ezreal.
punch it in the face, but not with punch
first. It gets a little bit confusing.
Getting maximum value off the Dreaming
Tree by drawing a card and then playing
your jacks from the champion, which is a
pretty spicy one as far as champions go.
This gives your equipment quick draw,
which basically makes them all reaction
effects. So, a very strong start for
both players here. As Jacks are match,
you can see the text on your screen.
Deflect and each equipment in your hand
has quick draw. So, it gains reaction
when you play it, attach it to a unit
you control. So, now they're all combat
tricks.
>> I love it. And I mean, I think these
Jacks champion champion units have such
great synergy with the different
equipment. I'm really excited to see how
the very best gamer is going to be able
to utilize them to maybe bring a win
here today.
>> So, it looks like we're retreating from
the Targon's Peak. So, that's two points
now for Colin versus the one, but going
to go up to two after holding with the
Aelios. And that's a pretty big base
being built in the back there by Colin.
But
I mean, if you're going to play uh a
domain like body, you really just are
trying to play big units. And there are
some pretty big units that only get
bigger here with his equipment in play
as well. So, I can see why Jax has been
a uh pretty threatening deck here all
weekend long for the very best game cuz
this is certainly not the first Draven
he's played this weekend and may not be
the last Draven he loses to depending on
how game three goes. So, off we go to
Targon's Peak, take our third point,
reset some runes, and say, "You know
what? I'm pretty happy. I'm going to
hold here with all my runes untapped.
And that feels really scary when you
have your champion in play.
>> Oh my gosh, for sure. And I think
something that Jax is really, especially
with this unmatched Jack unit, um, we
have a little bit of an extra threat
here because normally you're saying,
okay, he could have extra might in hand.
He could have those different spells
that will give him that might for this
turn. But because he's turning those
equipments into combat spells, like you
said, because of the Jack's unmatched
ability, it's not just might for this
turn that Colin's going to have to deal
with if it gets played. It's might that
he potentially has to deal with every
turn.
>> So, this Draven's going to get bigger.
It's going to be a six and a five
crashing into Jax. So, we might have to
answer a question for ourselves. I also
realized that you can quick draw equip a
Felios and then buff your jacks, which
is kind of a fun bit of tech if you so
desire. But looks like maybe just a
guardian angel here going to make a
trade happen. Oh, it's counter strike
instead. And now unfortunately I have to
ask myself a very important question
because I did not look this up before
this match. And thankfully Colin's going
to save me by rebuking the jacks.
>> I mean there are answers to rebuke. Not
many here in calm. Not so fast being
really the one that jumps to mind. Wind
as well, although not played all that
often. Counter-Strike still going to
draw the card, but unfortunately not
going to prevent the problems unless the
very best gamer has another reaction.
>> It is not so fast. Oh no. Now I have to
answer the question I don't know the
answer to. So I'm going to ask you
something here. Counter-strike prevent
all the prevent the next damage that
would be dealt to a unit. Obviously
chose Jax.
>> Okay.
>> Does that work for It does. Okay. So the
my question was when you go to damage
you just apply you just add up all the
might and then you do the damage to the
units you want to deal damage to.
>> So because there's two units my question
was does that count as two instances of
damage and I'm guessing based on that
interaction the answer is no. So all of
the might gets counted up and Jax is
still there chilling on the battlefield.
>> Yeah I think it's all added up like I
know when you can't like split up
damage.
>> No
>> unless you kill one. So I I can see how
it is just like a one instance of
damage. So that counter-strike being
pretty valuable and unfortunately
there's a few more units coming on
through now. Punch first is just going
to make the biggest jacks you've ever
seen and spinning axe is going to turn
the tides here for Colin. Both players
running low on cards, but it seems like
Draven's going to win this combat. And
Draven loves winning combats.
>> Yes, Draven does. And there's so many
different things he will get if he's
able to do it. He'll be able to get gold
from Draven Vanquisher. It looks like I
think it's in the battlefield with them.
Uh and also that draw from the leader.
But I mean, Jax has some options. We
have three runes up. We pot I mean, we
potentially have more.
>> Yeah, just G.
>> Yeah, it's gonna be a G that's gonna
give plus one might to this J.
>> So is going to eventually uh perish, but
is at least going to trade some units
away with it. So Colin had to commit a
lot here to but two units are going to
go to the bin. Jax is going to lose his
G and go back to base. and a decent
amount committed there, but the very
best gamer holds onto his units, which I
feel like is the important part of that
exchange.
>> I completely agree. Keeping those units
and having that might is going to be so
important for the very best gamer to be
able to figure out how to deal with
Colin's Draven. He's adding so much
might here to Targon's Peak and he's
going to get two more runes because he
was able to conquer this battlefield.
>> Yeah, also uh does get the card draw as
well from the Draven Legend ability. So
all in all looking pretty good here as
that battering ram was reconsidered.
Nope. Going back in. Just wanted to
count the cards make sure they had
enough runes. Does ready two more thanks
to Ton's Peak which is Colins's
battlefield of choice for the final game
here. And now at three points a piece.
Jackson Felios are going to keep on
chilling. Make it four points as we hold
up for one more for this Jax. And I am
just getting more and more impressed the
longer this game goes on.
>> For sure. And just for clarification, it
does look like Draven is not on Dargon's
Peak Battlefield. It is in base. I saw
him move it away uh just to make sure it
was more clear. But we are actually
going to get Stella corn herder here on
the very best gamer side. I do think one
problem that this Jax deck maybe does
present is finding its resources getting
more cards and I think Celorn herder may
potentially be the answer to that. When
she moves, she gets to draw a card very
similar to Traveling Merchant, but no
discard needed.
>> Yeah, really powerful thing and really
the the engine that powers a lot of com
decks. I mean, even Aurelia takes full
advantage of this card despite having a
lot of chaotic stuff to do as well in
her domains. You can see the Aelius
trick again, reattaching that guardian
entrance to the Aphellows to give it a
buff this time around. So, you're going
to present a little bit more might at
the northern battlefield. A seal of
discord going to actually recycle one
there. Looks like he already paid a
power for something else. It's called
shot is the reason for Colin digging
through a couple more cards. No SL
needed. And very gamer, he says, "Hey
buddy, tap that seal."
Yeah, I mean getting to use these seals
instead of actually having to pay power
is going to be so nice for Colin. Uh
these seals are basically like a
permanent resource to use and we saw
both of them having to spend power in
these last couple of turns. The very
best gamer doesn't seem to have that
those same seals and it could be a
problem later in the game.
>> Yeah, I think important to note seals
are a resource that you continually use
but they get better the longer the game
goes on.
>> Mhm. This game might not last very many
more turns. Both players are at four
points. There's also less than four
minutes left in this round cuz as a
reminder, we did jump into this series
in game number three. So, Ras are going
to get deployed back to base. Kong going
to have to keep recycling some runes
here. Just looking to build as much
might as possible. And now passing the
turnover and quite a bit of might on
that bottom battlefield is looking good.
But the race to eight points is on and
each player is holding one at a time.
>> That's I mean slowly getting there to
eight points. We'll have to see what the
verb gamer has here. I'm so excited to
see Jax.
>> Yeah, Jax is looking real nice right
now. Should also be awaken for what it's
worth. But again, players are playing, I
think, a little bit more quickly with
how much time is or isn't, I suppose,
left in the round.
>> Mhm.
>> And at this point, I don't know if you
can realistically crack through the
bottom side. So maybe we're just trying
to stack and hold all the way to eight.
Very best gamer technically in the race
to holding point by point is ahead by
one. And that's all you need to be ahead
by. Yeah, one is all you one extra is
all you need to win. As long as we don't
go to time. If we do go to time, we are
only two and a half minutes from it.
When you go to turns, you have to be two
points apart to be able to win the game.
Otherwise, it is a draw. It looks like
we're actually going to play a we've
seen him a couple times this weekend,
but his ability is so interesting.
>> Yoink. Taking an equipment. You actually
can take uh any gear, I believe. Yes.
Moving enemy gear to your base. can also
take seals, which is pretty nice. But if
you take equipment, you get to attach it
for free. And that feels pretty nice in
a deck like Jack Grand Master at Arms.
It turns out cares a lot about equipment
as Telecon her going to have a ride up
to the top and join their buddy Aelios
and draw a card on the journey.
>> I think my favorite auction so far this
weekend was the one that stole a
dazzling Aurora. Uh but yeah, the other
option is also seals, but I think
getting extra might right now is more
important than denying Colin resources
when it wouldn't help us as well.
>> Yeah, absolutely. It feels like this
game is just a race to stack as much
might as possible. And Colin says, "You
know what? I can do it, too." Cold shot
going to find a knock turn on the top of
the deck and continue to go through and
build up the hand. Both players actually
with a pretty full grip between the two
of them, but we are going to challenge
in the top side. Colin deciding, you
know what, I'm going to break the
stalemate. I'm the one technically a
point behind. So, I'm going to try and
get ahead and knock you off this
battlefield.
>> Yeah. And he's presenting so much might.
We're looking at 12 I believe here. Yep.
>> Versus what appears to be seven and then
plus quarter. Stellic corn herder being
10.
>> It's uh I think six for Aelios and nine.
G is only plus one. That buff is good.
And again, we do have quick draw for the
equipment and that could also buff a
friendly unit. Counter-strike also going
to make things a little bit better.
Which unit are we choosing? have to
think of Felios going to have to hold on
to all those fancy weapons. Very
thematic, by the way, for Fellow to be
equipped with lots of weapons if you
haven't played League of Legends. Uh he
has a lot of guns. That's his whole
thing.
>> Okay. Oh, that makes sense. That makes
sense. Uh he was a little bit after my
time when I played League, but I'm so
happy to hear that he matches his lore
very well.
>> Well, uh Fight or Flight is continuing
to be problematic for these units trying
to hold on battlefields. Very best gamer
asking cards in hand cuz going to maybe
want to find a Defy and there is one
available. get that final fight out of
here.
>> Yeah, I feel like purple I mean Colin's
deck is uniquely positioned to be able
to deal with these huge might units of
purple and not purple of orange. And
what I mean by that is these purple
cards like fight or flight, they don't
really care about your might. They just
say get out of the battlefield.
>> Yeah, very best gamer really willing to
hold as much as he can. So a second
fight or flight, I believe.
>> No, not yet. I think he I could have
sworn I saw one but maybe just
considering the other options here.
Thermob beam also pretty good against
the weapon deck but not going to be so
destructive right now. So it looks like
it's fight or flight get defied.
Counter-Strike still resolved is on the
Selios I believe.
>> So Stellin Hood is going to get involved
but probably going to perish in combat
here in the top. And there is the second
fighter fight that I did see. Colin just
deciding you know what I'm kind of
priced in. I'm going to return a unit
and actually Stellin's going to be the
one that goes back. And if that move is
a move, you do get to draw a card.
>> Mhm. That is true. All these different
movements are card draw. And it's really
nice to get through your deck in that
way. Drawing cards. I feel like we've
said it a lot of times this this
weekend, but if you didn't know it
before, drawing cards is really strong
in card games.
>> Certainly is. And Counter-Strike was
actually used on the Sticon Her very
best game wanting to protect the draw
engine in this instance. So Felios does
lo the G and go back to base should
technically be exhaustive, but I don't
think it's going to matter in this
instance. Yeah, I don't think it
matters. And both these players do know
that time is running out. It looks like
time did run out here. We'll be going to
turns, but so they're both probably
playing slightly, you know, shortcutting
to get there, but they're doing it
together.
>> All right, so again, playing quickly,
but I believe
>> I believe turn zero is very best gamer.
So action going to go in, get a point,
go to six, but it feels like this is
very close. And as a reminder, three
additional turns starting at turn zero.
So, call it two a piece per player, but
we also have to either win the game or
be ahead by two points in order to claim
a win in overtime.
>> Yeah, that's a great point. So, we're
going to have to figure out what to do.
It does look like we're going to use our
Jax ability to be able to unattach what
was on Axon, which is that spinning ax
and reattach it to ax. O
>> cannon is going to do a big amount of
damage here at this battlefield. Is that
two or three damage to all units in
comb? I think it's only two. It is. So,
that's not enough to actually take out
quite a bit unless there's a second one.
>> So, wonder what the plan is here.
>> And oh no, we just replayed it. We just
showed it again. Uh for there, I thought
we actually did have a second one. That
would have been absolutely crazy. Uh but
we are just spreading out some damage
here trying to, you know, remove Colin
from the battlefield even if we aren't
able to take it ourselves. And we still
have more units in our base that could
conquer it even if our Jax dies.
Oh, I think that beats overzealous fan.
Is that how that works?
>> Okay, Jack's trading with everything.
So, I think that's the tech. I do
remember players talking about cannon
barrage into overzealous fan
specifically. So, I have to brush up on
that interaction before the top eight.
It seems like, especially if this Jax is
there and right now, very best game are
threatening to win by two. Also, just
straight up threatening to win.
>> It does look like that threat is coming
in. And is this at seven points that
we're at now if if this moves in?
>> Yeah, at seven right now for very best
gamer. So threatening to win by holding.
My brain is still trying to figure out
the counter brushing. It is a reaction.
I think I know what happened, but I'm
going to speculate later because
Lucian's moving on in and very best
gamer is going to steal
>> axes. It does belong to very best gamer
still. Actually stole it. So wants to
re-quip it. So weapon master is going to
pick it up. That is extraordinarily
confusing, but we did figure it out.
>> Yeah, Auction is able to control it
until Ouxion dies. So, if you kill Oxon,
you would reclaim that same gear.
>> And of course, if it's not equipped, you
do lose it as well, thanks to the Axis
temporary, but Jax is very good at
re-equipping. And we are just loading up
on units as Aelius is going to move in.
I don't think Colin has anything left
here.
>> This is absolutely insane of a game.
>> It's winning in right.
>> It is. the very best gamer going to take
it in additional turns. Gets all the way
to eight points and 11 and one with
where we are in the standings in the
tournament. That should be enough to see
a jack in top eight.
>> That is absolutely insane and I don't
think it was in my bingo card for this
weekend.
>> Okay, so I am going to go ahead and do
my best to puzzle out what happened with
the Overzale fan cuz that was the
critical moment of that game and clearly
based on what happened over fan did not
go off. So canon emerges a reaction that
deals two damage to all units in combat.
Over fan, let's remind everyone, is a
two might unit. When you move in for
combat, attack and defend triggers
happen. Overzar fan is a defend trigger.
When over fan uh activates, I want to
use this trigger. I'm going to choose to
use this and it starts a chain. Now,
typically in attack and defenders, you
can't actually cast anything. You don't
have a showdown window, but you can use
reactions if a chain has started. The
overzeal trigger is starting a chain. So
because it's a reaction, you can cannon
barrage to deal two damage to all units
in combat. And because there's an
attacker attacking, combat is happening.
I believe overzealous fan needs to be
sacrificed in order to get the effect.
So if barrage is dealing with it, turns
you can't sacrifice a unit that's
already dead. And that was enough to get
Jax into top eight.
>> That is absolutely insane. But I think
that is just exactly what happened.
Killing the overzealous fan before it
was able to sacrifice. Cuz you know
what's even better than me explaining
it? The winner explained it. We have a
winners interview with their Jacks and I
can't wait to hear what they have to
say.
All right, I'm here with the very best
gamer fresh off a win with Jax going to
X1. And that may be Jackson top eight.
How are you feeling coming off that
electric win over Colin?
>> I mean it's it's good. I didn't expect
to win today, you know, a single game.
>> Seriously, not a single game. So you
didn't come in with expectations for
Jax. So, is this a best of pick that
you've just non-stop kept winning?
>> I
I had Jax. He was cheap, low rarity. We
bailed him, brought him to here.
>> So, there's no even allegiance to this
Grandmaster at arms. He's just Is there
any draw towards Jax for you or this was
just the deck you had and you just are
that good?
>> I like Counter-Strike. Good card. That's
about it.
>> All right. Well, if this is the uh the
lock on top eight, I mean, how are you
feeling if that is what has happened
here today?
>> I'm I'm feeling pretty good. Looking
forward to playing top eight, you know,
show people I live up to my username.
>> Yeah, looking to prove that you are in
fact the very best gamer. Well, thank
you so much for the interview and good
luck in that top eight. We'll send it
back over to the desk.
I wish I had that kind of aura. Just
showing up to a regional qualify with a
deck I bought because it was cheap and
uh yeah, turns out that's good enough to
I think probably make it a top eight
based on what we know.
>> Yeah, actually insane. I wish I had that
confidence for sure. I love that answer.
I mean, it's a cheap deck and he you
heard it here, folks. If you're
interested in Jax, you could go buy it
and take it to Nexus or, you know,
regionals coming up soon.
>> If you do want to do that, by the way,
do it. Do it right now. It's not going
to stay cheap for very long after the
game that we just witnessed. I mean,
this is a deck that can take out Draven.
Any deck that can take out Draven is
going to have people's eyes on. We are
ready for the break though. This round
is in the books. We do not have very
many rounds of Swiss to go, but top
eight is looming ever closer. Who is
going to make it? Plenty of the
challenger. TC boys are ready and so
close to those final eight spots. We
have former top eight, former champions,
new faces, new heroes, all in the
running to make top eight here at Las
Vegas. Now, whatever happens, I just saw
a Jack's win on camera, so I have no
idea what to predict other than, you
know what, it's going to be one hell of
a ride to get there.
Heat. Heat.
Heat up
here.
Heat. Heat.
Heat.
Heat up here. Heat. Heat.
If you want to get involved with a
regional qualifier, your best stop is
your local summoner skirmish where you
can win a buy for the event. You can get
prepped, kind of get rated up, kind of
your bridge between your Nexus night and
then a large event like this one. Check
it out online at
uvsgames.combound-organize-play
or scan the QR QR code.
All right, welcome back to Las Vegas,
the regional qualifier. I'm Jim Davis.
That's Kasanova. And we got round 13,
our final round. Perhaps the most
exciting round of the tournament yet as
we decide what players will be going
into top eight.
>> Stack of winningins ready to go. players
down on their very last chance to make
it into the top eight to have a shot to
be crowned champion of the Las Vegas
regional qualifier.
>> Nothing like a winning. Nothing like it.
So, let's look at our standing. See what
players are are currently at. Some
players are already in and some players
are fighting for those last few spots.
>> And looking at that, Prismaticism at the
top is going to be in uh at that can
just ID. You know, a lot of these X1's
can ID unless they get paired down. So
you have to see where those pairings
come through. So Prismat at the top,
Randy in there as well. Very best gamer
we just saw win as well, but there are
five X1. So somebody is going to have to
play. Can't say they're all immediately
locked in just being at X and1. And from
there, anyone at X1 and one is going to
be on a guaranteed win. If they win,
they are in 100%. Everyone at X2 is
going to be fighting the tiebreaker boss
at the end of the day.
>> Yeah. So those X2 players, you know, you
got to win, you know. Unfortunately,
your fate is no longer in your hands.
Uh, all you can do is win and pray. And
then we see here, you know, ninth on
down. That is in tiebreaker standings,
but those can change. Tiebreers are
based on the quality of your opponents
at the entire event. So, you've played
against a lot of players at this point
if they were all to win or all to lose.
Things could shift pretty dramatically.
And we have our pair down. Randy is the
unlucky pair down uh at 11 11 and one.
So,
>> so congrats to the other four.
>> Yes. So, we most likely will see
Prismaticism, uh, Deluxe, TTA, and the
very best gamer, uh, drawing in. We have
to shake hands and, uh, taking an hour
off, a very well-earned hour off, and
then Randy going to be in there battling
with the X11s, trying to make it in. So,
we got our M, first match for, you said,
is going to be Randy versus Sam in a
Draven mirror.
And, uh, this is about as high stakes as
it gets. We see here Sam Sham Sam Sam D.
Sherman uh, with Draven.
>> Sam D. Sherman going to be on the
mid-range. Draven does have the Ferros
4Runner at three copies. We were talking
about this in our earlier set that we
had Jim where it was how many Ferros
4Runner are going to be the main, how
many minds spplitters? It looks like
three in the main. No mind spplitter
main but two in the board for Sam D
Sherman. Uh this card is going to
struggle a little bit more in the Draven
mirror which is what we've got here.
Randy also on Draven due to purple being
a struggle for Ferris 4. We could see
three copies of this actually being a
hindrance in game one and then it can
come back later as potential side out
fodder, but the rest of this very
standard. Uh very few one-ups. Often
we're seeing a lot of one and two ofs in
Riftbound, but this is a a pretty
collated deck for Sam Sherman for this
mid-range trade.
>> Tight list doing well so far. And Randy
on the other side again. That unlucky
pair down. That's tough. You know, it's
a kind of a mental like, hey, okay, I I
could have drawn in. I'm watching
everyone else draw in, but now I got a
battle.
>> Yeah, Randy on the spicy uh middle of
mid-range and miracle. It's uh uh mirror
range something. It's Yeah, it's it's
it's a mix of the two. It's it's uh only
two copies of Seal, only a one of Rasa,
and instead having the ability to be
playing things like the 3x Piercing
Light, which are really nice in the
mirror to deal with the twos and the
fours. uh you know being able to play it
on repeat to kill off something like a
hopeful plus a Draven or a Kai'Sa plus a
Draven uh and then also being able to
deal with things like Overzealous Fan.
So a really spicy list with a lot of
one-offs included as well having the
Fizz in the list ready to copy any of
these spells throughout and and yeah as
I said I mean you know the two seals
using the VI to restack the deck and
have a lot of might later on.
>> So we're going to go right down to our
feature match area. Randy on the right
starting off on Zon Warren and Sam on
the left starting on Reaver's Row. Uh so
Randy kind of miracle but not exactly uh
versus more mid-range. Who does that
favor? Uh I think this does favor
towards Ry's deck. It's actually very
teched towards beating mid-range. The 3x
piercing light is the big thing to look
at as far as when it comes down to this
matchup in particular. mid-range Draven
is going to be kind of playing that fair
two, four, uh, you know, play another
four, play another four, play another
two, and the piercing light actually
starts to really pick those off. And
Fizz can recur it as well. So, there's
actually just a lot of ways that you
can, uh, clean up a lot of the board and
then utilize your own might to overwhelm
while having more draw without having to
take combats than the mid-range does.
So, you can avoid combat, have a big
card advantage, then take combat when
you have the card advantage and win from
there. So, I think Randy has a slight
edge going into this. And just a
reminder, this is a true win and end.
Sam D. Sherman is one of our X1 and1's.
101 and 1's. A win here immediately gets
him in. A win for Randy, of course, at
X1 will put him in.
>> Yeah. And if Randy loses, there's still
an outside shot as well.
>> There is an outside shot for Randy to
make it in uh with tiebreers. There will
be some amount of X and twos that get
in. So, it is not purely a lose and out
for Randy. Uh it is, however, for Sam D
Sherman. This is a mustwin for Sam D
Sherman. If Randy loses, there's a
chance he still sneaks into that top
eight.
>> You want to control your own fate. So we
see here Sam going first overzeal comes
in, takes these on warns and then that
double unit uh on turn two instead of a
Draven. So treasure hunter knock coming
down just a tide turner on Ry's side. So
Sam D currently ahead on board and it's
Ry's turn to to make some moves
and going to think it through. tie turn
of course if you need it to it's
serviceable you know just uh on the
first turn
not particularly exciting
>> yeah and this is I mean this is big for
Randy right uh it's big for both players
but but for Randy he did top 32 in
Houston was able to top eight Bolognia
flew to China top four at Dalon Regional
Open and then comes back here looking
for yet another top one game away from
making it to top eight at Vegas as well
and immediately we're going to that
first piercing light get a little bit of
value. Yeah,
>> clear up the chaff. Doesn't deal with
the bigger unit, but got rid of the
little stuff. Don't have to worry about
that overzealous fan.
>> Fantex and fantastic stuff here with uh
also a knockful developed as well. So,
great turn as far as swinging the board.
And now we go back Sam's way. And here
comes Hopeful into Rivers row. Tie
Turner backs out. There's a point.
There's a card off Draven. Sam now up to
two. Two to one. A lot of runes
available.
and Sam Stern are trying to affect this
board. Nox noxious Opal is everywhere.
You get a noxious hopeful, you get a
Noxious hopeful. A lot of stats for a
very low cost. This is where that
Piercing Light, you know, tends to be
very good as well, right? You're seeing
all these fours. So, Piercing Light with
repeat gets to clear this up. Fizz can
recur the one that's already there. So,
there's still three copies of Piercing
Light in this deck to start dealing with
this board state. And that's where you
start to see why Ry's version is teched
quite well for the the mirror for the
matchup against Draven in particular
because of this three of in the main
deck. All right, so we see Ezreal here
discarding treasure hunter draw two
and now starting to set up that engine.
Not the full miracle package, but a lot
of it.
>> Yeah, you know the two seal is always
funny, right? Because you want the
consistency of finding it, but for Randy
is like, well, I need slots for some of
these other things. And you actually
kind of don't want all three seals out
on the board. You do want to find one,
but you don't want to find three. And
often you can discard, but for Andy, he
says, "You know what? I'll just play
two." And we'll we'll see him when we
see him.
>> So, gut check. Here comes Hopeful into
hopeful reavers row. Sam is exhausted
and has to decide, do I want to back out
or do I want to stay in and fight?
>> He says he'll stay. Randy deciding if
he's actually just kind of fine with the
trade. Uh trade is reasonable.
>> All right, so no spinning axe or trick.
Just a little trade.
And now Ty Turner uh clear to go into
either the row or the Warrens.
Randy wants that second point. Want to
be on even points if possible.
Taking it through. Big match. You know
the as if the lights weren't light
enough when you're playing a win in on
camera. A lot of pressure. Here comes
Tide Turner and he's on Warren
discarding a the the one copy of VI too
early.
>> Yep.
And this is more of a fair VI, not a
stack the bottom V.
>> Correct. It it will still stack the
bottom of the deck because it does have
those like miracle components, but
that's it's not like the main purpose.
It still kind of actually plays like a
VI where you actually want to give it a
bunch of might and send it in. Yep.
>> Um
>> especially with the one Ross, right?
Once that's played, you don't really
care if the trash is that full.
>> Yep. So here's Ezreal number two
discarding overzealous fan and just pass
him a turn going back Sam's way knock
and Draven hanging out Randy Draven
still hanging out in the champ zone and
we see a hand of Overzel's fan looks
like stack deck first things first
though Draven's coming in and
immediately Tai Turner hits the bin so
another point for Sam
>> gold card drawn off Draven
>> Draven does love those combats and Now a
chance to go to four and really push the
issue. These Ezreals are they're not,
you know, tiny, but they're not big
either.
>> Yeah, three might not very threatening
when you have a bunch of four might on
your own board. Yep. And that is uh one
more the last I checked.
>> Yep. Comes down to it. Rip bound is a
numbers game. My number bigger than your
number. That's good.
>> So here is the Noxious into Reaver's
Row. That's up to four
now. What's the followup?
>> Oh boy. Okay.
>> Scar is very good. I mean, you see that
nod from Ren, he's like, "Yeah, that
sucks."
>> Yeah. Uh, perfect. Uh, killing two three
might units. So, uh, you know, just the
perfect cleanup. And now ahead on board,
ahead on runes
cards. Uh, it's hard to tell who's up on
cards. Randy probably up on cards, but
maybe not though. There's some some
combats won here as well. So, it's like
four cards. I have five cards in hand
for Sam. So, both players pretty heavy
on resources. Here's a stack deck. I saw
a hard bargain in there. I missed the
other two.
>> Looks like a Brin here. Thundersong and
uh Darius would be my guess on these
two.
>> Pretty good selections. We've seen
Thundersong do some serious work.
Darius, of course, very powerful as
well.
>> So, Sam's going to plan out this turn,
plan out the next turn.
think about
what is next.
Didn't quite catch it.
So, five runes left.
Looks like might be Darius coming to the
window here.
All right, so there's Darius.
Recycling down and a pass. Going back
Ry's way. A lot of might on Sam's board.
Randy has some work to do. before there
is still the miracle package in here to
get some stuff done. Explosiveness kind
of get things outgoing whereas of course
Sam is playing a more fair game.
And Randy, what do you got for us?
Looking to punch to get in the top eight
on three continents.
>> Three continents. He's already Well, he
wouldn't have top eighted on three
continents. He's topped on three
continents cuz the top 32 in Houston.
That counts as topping because it was
just a cut to 64. But as you're saying,
a top eight for the third continent.
>> Yeah,
>> could happen here.
>> That's a pretty good place to be.
>> So here's a Raza. Here's a Draven.
>> And we were going back Sam's way. We got
hold hold to six. So massive lead for
Sam.
Now Sam possibly just back out. Try and
go for a big win next turn.
See if Sam wants to try and hold. A lot
of tools available. Great spot.
One interesting thing I find is uh in
these big matches whether they're
playing for top eight or in top eight or
even playing for a championship is
players to slow down when they're ahead.
Uh you not want to be in a spot where
you you make some key mistake and let a
game you know that you're winning slip
through your fingers. So you're going to
come home. Here's hopeful. Here's Draven
and a tide turner treasure hunter just
deploying those units and passing the
turn. So at six points, ready to go try
and go for the double conquer and take
this game one. And Ry's going to try and
put up a defense here and see if that
can be stopped.
Clean game so far from Sam.
>> Yeah, this feels like a very tough spot
for Randy in the game one. I think that
Falling Star lined up beautifully. Deal
with the Ezreals.
Really good early stuff from Sam finding
these great deflements. Has a good mix
of spells. He's got these spinning axes
ready as insurance.
So Roz is going to come in. Conquers on
Warren. Discards Scrappy draw two. Not a
bad place to start. Randy up to three.
Now what is the next step?
A lot of pressure here uh for being able
to defend. There's a lot of might
already on Sam's board. And then uh you
know is Randy going to have to just
stack up on one battlefield and try and
defend to stop a double conquer and to
have to forfeit that fourth point? You
know what is the next step? So
>> your stack deck.
>> Quick take from Randy. I think he has to
know what he wants at this point. I'm
trying to actually think about what I
want if I'm in Ry's shoes, right? Like,
you know, is Rebuke's not going to be
enough on its own? You you need you need
rebuke maybe plus something else. And
there's exactly two purple runes
available here for a single cast of
Rebuke. And then we're looking at three
more runes afterwards.
>> I just recycled one for two.
>> So, we got called, we got seal down, and
called shot down. now off of Rebuke with
only the one room and uh just clarifying
you know communication as far as uh
>> was energy floated die indicates the
energy
>> just fire in that seal fire in the cold
shot I see
>> y just clarity because he does need to
pay two uh for this so Randy was quickly
going through and got rid of two
immediately so that he could play the
seal and then play the call shot.
>> Yep. Um
>> Sam was looking at his own board, missed
it, wanted to clarify.
>> Yep.
>> Interesting that dynamic here, too, is
that uh Randy would love a draw.
>> Yeah.
>> You know, so Randy would have loved to
have intentionally drawn in. Uh if
players are paired up and they can just
bowl and make top eight. Uh Randy
couldn't do that, but a draw would still
work. Whereas Sam does not want to draw.
Uh 10, one, and two not good enough.
That'll be on the outside looking in. So
we're going to see that reinforce. Here
comes the fan onto Vison Warrence.
>> Yep. Fan is a good card to pick up. That
is essentially like picking up a fight
or flight that you get it on the board
now.
>> And here comes Draven into Rever's row.
So on that fourth point, so at least
maintaining, you know, an even point
total. That being said, defense is key
here.
I'm going to think through the next
step. Four energy available.
>> So I think one, two,
>> counting counting the uh cards played so
far. This turn
>> played four. Here comes the ram. So, one
energy for a ramp and how about another
ramp? The first one's nice. Second one's
great, too.
>> And then question is where is it going?
>> So, playing kind of having it back with
the runes saying
>> I'm not I have not selected where I'm
playing.
>> Correct. Kind of saying it it can't be
with my runes. So, I'm still deciding
it's going to go onto Rever's row. So,
pretty good turn as far as just raw
numbers.
another stacked. Maybe looking for the
third and final ram and just putting
numbers on the board, but just giving a
math problem to Draven is not always the
best.
>> Sometimes you don't have a better option
though. We've seen this a couple of
times throughout the tournament.
Sometimes you just kind of have to put
the cards on the table.
>> Wow.
>> Hope your opponent can't beat it. It is
the third ram that Randy is going to
find on this turn.
>> And a hidden card, too. I mean, listen,
from the start of the turn to now,
things are looking a lot more solid. But
that being said, a ton of runes
available for Sam next turn. Ton of
cards in hand, so good chance to break.
There is a lot of might in play,
>> but for Sam this turn
to a break means a win at six points.
>> And this is what you're saying. Like I
mean, this is still a miracle list,
right? We're still getting, you know, we
still played a Rasa and uh there's a a
couple of these battering rams getting
slammed down. That was 15 17 might on
that turn. I think the Rosa was on the
previous turn. So 17 might on this turn,
but there's still a few more combat
tricks, some removal spells like a mid
Draven would be playing.
>> Oh wow. I think I see two axe and a
rebuke.
>> Yeah, and I think that is likely to be
able to clean up this board. I haven't
gone through and checked it yet, but
>> yeah, I mean each axe is three. The
rebuke is the biggest six. So I mean
>> 12 might swing under this.
>> It's going to be pretty tough to beat.
>> Yeah. So Sam needs to push her in now.
Noting that, you know, we're in that
sort of like, all right, Randy is all
exhausted. This is now in that kind of
math problem of all right final line.
The one wrinkle here of course is that
hidden card. So fight or flight very
likely. There are some corner case
options as well. Could be a tide turner,
edge of knight. And you do need to play
differently around all of those.
So Sam going to plot out what is the
first step. Where's this turn start? Sam
knows how this turn wants to be finished
as of course battlefields. First up is
just Darius on its lonesome into Raza
fan and Ram.
>> Yeah, the hope for Sam. I I like this
idea. You're just hoping that you know
the overzealous fan will pop and send
him home. Uh so he'd be ready. But if
you know if I'm ready on the other side,
you just say no cuz you know that this
is the same thing that's going to
happen. Uh, so instead it's going to be
double axe onto the Darius, pumping him
up to 13, which is exactly equal to what
Randy has on the other side.
>> All right, so is there one more step
here?
>> Trading is uh not really what Sam's
looking for.
>> Trading is actually the best because
drop the axes and be able to cascade and
reattach. It's one of those rare rare
occasions because as Draven normally you
never want to trade because you want to
win the combat and draw the card. But
this is just a unique spot where the
double axe getting to go back to your
base and re-equip. It's actually I think
really flawless execution here from Samy
Sherman on this attack for getting the
most amount of possible might that he
can out of these axes.
>> Right. We counted the axes as threes.
They're actually six here. Yeah.
>> So it's each ax is six. And now the
rebuke would be a little bit less
targeting a five most likely. Uh but
yeah, great.
>> They can actually be even more because
you can actually equip both of them onto
a tie turner. ship it in uh let it trade
down and then uh afterwards you re-equip
them again and go again. So really these
axes I mean this is the power of
equipment in this set. When you are
going for the win and your runes do not
matter at all anymore. Equipment has
this very high potential based on the
amount of units you have and the units
your opponent has.
>> All right, so Hunter gets to go in. So
only one might to conquer zon to seven.
And I mean you can kind of see it in
Randy uh Ry's table of meter at the
moment. Not super thrilled because these
axes represent like you're saying a ton.
You can just kind of go in, pants up one
unit, make a few trades, and it's a
very, very large amount of might.
>> So, one axe on Turner. Turner comes in
as a five now. Saying, "All right,
Randy, what's up? Got a hidden card."
Going to see the Draven trigger go off.
Put Draven up to six. Now, important to
note, every time you go in for a combat,
you do give Draven the chance to get
bigger and bigger.
Randy has a a cap of three for this one
because he's got two more fury runes
ready to go. Yep.
>> So, there's fight or flight. Back it
out. That does lock one axe onto the
turner.
>> Yeah. And that seems to be what Sam was
uh playing around in this in this
instance, right? Instead of equipping
both axes to the turner and sending it
in, recognizing, okay, that could be
fight or flight. And if it is, then I
don't want to lose both axes cuz then I
actually can't push in with the hopeful
and the Draven to push over the top.
All right. So,
>> with Rebuke here looking quite nice.
Rebuke takes care of Draven. Now,
there's only 10 left and I count more
than 10 uh with Draven and Noxious and
the axe.
>> I count 13.
>> So, there's an axe coming in. Going to
trade a Noxious for a ram and then pop
it back on. Here comes Draven.
>> Could have sent it all at once. Doesn't
matter. Still works
>> either way. Good stuff. Sam taking down
game one in pretty dominating fashion.
Yeah, definitely felt like uh the
falling star closed this thing out,
especially since a lot of the early
stages Sam still was able to keep
developing. Just lost some of the early
units, but still had some good
developments. Was able to take a couple
fights due to the Reaver's row into
Randy where he got some card draw. And I
think because of that, being able to
find those refills, not falling behind
in cards, which tends to be the the
issue that mid-range can run into
against Miracle is they fall behind in
cards because they're not being given
combats while the Miracle players
continuing to draw. Um, but that was not
the case in this in this game. Sam was
able to find a couple combats, draw some
cards, stayed within that similar amount
of cards, played a bunch of units out,
and he was able to outmite in this case.
>> All right, so Sam one win away from the
top eight spot. Randy has some work to
do here.
Starting off with Reaver's Row for Randy
going first and Obelisk of Power
>> for Sam.
>> So, three runes to start. And for Randy,
you know, the the mental aspect of this
is pretty huge as well. You're 11 and
one and you you watch all the other
pairings and you see that they can draw
and you kind of get that feeling like I
got to play. You know, you really got to
be ready to play. Can be easy to kind of
tease up there, but there's a very
important match to win here and two
games to do it in.
Randy deciding on this turn one.
>> Sam with the obelisk going second able
to play Draven on turn one
>> overzealous fan and a pass. So going
Sam's way. Four runes
>> and Draven. Turn one. Draven. Not too
shabby.
Slight lead at the start for Sam
Sherman. Kind of making up for that
going second. Quote unquote
disadvantage, right? Sometimes, you
know, it feels a little bit better to go
first oftent times in Riftbound, but
when you get to play Draven on your
first turn, doesn't feel so bad anymore.
>> Draven hits. All right. So, we're going
to see Draven for Randy. Fan stays home
passing right back. So back Sam's away.
The first Draven on the board and now
six total runes.
See an axe in hand. Ride the wind.
Those two cards between the ride the
wind and the axe.
Ride the wind.
Wait. See be a four. I think it's a
4Runner.
>> Uh is that or a Draven? Uh it actually
might be both. Or not sorry Draven.
Darius. Yep.
>> Might be both. Darius and a Forrunner.
>> Yeah, this so this is a good spot for
because you're you're at the point in
the game where it's so early. You're not
risking it. You're running into a BU or
a fight or flight where you kind of take
that lump uh just being so big. So Dy
comes into Reaver's Row.
Two Reavers Row games in a row here.
And Sam, what's the next step? Looks
like he was thumbming that Ferris
4Runner is going to just cast it into
the Reavers Row. Often wanting to play
that to a battlefield. You do want it to
kind of try and get that hold value
immediately and then spawn those mechs.
Yep.
>> If your opponent can break it.
>> Yeah. And again, this early, you know,
if Randy has a rebuke or a fight or
flight, a rebuke would be still pretty
annoying. A fight or flight, you know,
it's still there. You know, there's not
enough of a tempo in this game to where
pushing it back means well, it's still
there. You know, it still do its thing.
So, here's a seal and here's a Mind
Splitter. Let's take a look and see
what's going on. Falling Star, Stack
Deck, Spinning Axe, Darius, and Ride the
Wind. Pretty good hand for Sam about to
get a little bit worse.
>> Oo, sision is actually not so clear. Um,
often times you actually want to remove
selection from your opponent. Stack deck
is often a very good take because you
recognize, okay, I can play around Star
and Axe and Darius and Ride the Wind and
we'll get rid of your optionality and
your card draw going forward. Um, but
from there it's also Randy has to look
at his hand and say, is there any of
these that I absolutely cannot beat? If
any of them you absolutely cannot beat,
then that may need to be the choice that
you end up making. We look at the board
state now. Star doesn't seem unbeatable.
Darius seems to be the biggest problem
for Andy. And also good note with the
Darius was the only unit in the hand.
The rest of it was all spells or gear.
Yes, stack deck can likely be another
unit, but Darius being the only unit,
you start to splitter away the units,
trying to deny that hand as much as
possible. Randy popularizing shovel
civer, the one that's digging through
the deck and then sabotaging a bunch of
times and you take all the spells from
them. This is the other side of it. You
play the mind spplitter, you want to
take the units, leave the spells behind.
>> So that Darius gone now and both units
locked at Reverse Row. Hard for uh for
Sam to threaten here. The fan comes in,
takes the uh obelisk. Randy up to one.
Sam at two off the hold. Sam has a lot
of spells, but again, those those spells
lose a bit of their luster. You know
what? All's fair. I I think this is the
the best draw for turn Sam could
possibly have is not only is it a unit,
but it is a mindspplitter specifically.
So now he gets to attack Ry's hand back.
And you can either go for units or you
go for one of the called shots cuz shot
is actually two cards. You're getting
two cards for the price of one when you
splitter away a called shot. But I can
also understand not wanting to get mine
splittered backto-back turns.
>> Yeah, the seven might, you know, and
then seven more might's a big deal. So
splitter back up 4Runner and Draven
still hanging out row and uh Sam's at
two and going to send them back home. So
a lot of might in base for Sam passing
back to Randy. We're going to see a hold
on the 4Runner I'm sorry on the uh
overzealous fan up to two.
And now Splitter and Draven both viable
attackers
but kind of on that odd number now. So
can go to three this turn. Not super
exciting to do that. But if they kind of
go back and forth here, Sam go to four
and so on and so forth. So here's Ezreal
>> discarding noxious drawu.
>> Not complaining.
>> And uh
>> now these call shots get to come out.
>> The real on board.
>> Yep. Called shot time.
Definitely a bit of, you know, where
Randy plays a mind spplitter and Sam's
hand isn't going to change a ton turn to
turn. Ry's hand, however, those call
shots could be anything.
>> It's a whole new world.
>> Yep.
>> Yeah.
>> Sam, you know, doesn't even need to
bother writing it down because it's not
going to be the same cards.
>> Right.
>> So, while Ry's playing with not perfect
info, but like close to it, uh Sam does
not have that luxury.
So, working through the cold shot, we
see uh another seal.
>> Yeah, Randy looking to push probably for
finding
a couple of battering rams on this turn.
A lot of spells cast already.
>> Quick choice there on second gold shot.
>> My guess would be a ram when it's that
fast.
>> Both very fast. So, all right, Randy,
what do you got here, my friend?
A lot of cards. Not only cards just in
in mass, but cards that were wanted. You
know, these are all cards that were
selected off these call shots. So,
ideally a good one. So, fan comes home.
Ezreal, Fan, Mindsplitter, and Draven
and base. Lock to base.
>> And is there more?
>> Yeah, I mean, that's already
the the four prerequisite cards to start
making these uh Rams cost one.
>> All right, there's Ram number one. One
rune left
this point. I feel like if Rand number
two, it's already in play, so just going
to pass back. So, pretty good
development turn. Uh, but now we go back
Sam's way. Both players at two. Sam with
an opportunity here to go up to four.
Some pretty large units in play.
Fourerunner, the mind spplitter, and uh,
that a falling star in the window. Yes,
it is. Falling star that he had earlier.
The stack deck still in that hand.
Spinning axe and ride the wind trying to
catch the new card.
>> Yep. Yeah. And then again, Randy knows
about those. So,
>> correct.
>> All right. Here's stack deck. See a
fight or flight.
Two others that I missed. Fight or
flight in a spot like this. Looks pretty
good. Uh with Sam kind of applying the
pressure.
>> I believe it was splitter falling star
fight or flight.
>> Oo. Okay.
>> The optionality here.
>> Wow. So, currently a rune short on
splitter. So that'd be I'll be surprised
to see that one taken
>> though. It is good.
>> It It is good for sure.
>> Just can't be played this turn. I agree
with you that you know sometimes it's
tough especially if there's no other
good play in hand. You kind of have to
>> find something to do on this turn. I
guess to be fair neither fight or flight
nor Thalling Star are actually something
to do on this turn.
>> Yeah. I mean, fight or flight though, it
it pushes things ahead where the
splitter next turn, you know, you you
can play cuz you can reinforce with it,
you know, but fight or flight once
you're trying to get ahead on points,
that can be that kind of that that one,
>> especially I mean, you consider the
might levels on Ry's side and it's a a
mind spplitter and a Draven, these are
very prime fighterflight targets uh in
in the amount of value you're going to
acrue from that push.
>> All right, so Sam looking to go to four.
Looks like it.
Here comes the 4Runner to Oblo get power
up to three and going to go for Ride the
Wind.
>> Yeah, I I'm a really big fan of this in
Draven Mirrors. Uh using Ride the Wind.
Uh when you have a unit ready to start
the turn, conquer, ride the Wind over,
conquer again, go home. Uh you don't
want to give any combats. Uh you're
ahead in points. When you are ahead in
points, this is amazing. It is
incredibly strong to do this with your
ride the winds uh because you maintain
the lead and you don't give your
opponent any chance to try and come back
in with one fights or anything of that
nature.
>> All right, so stay out to four with a
impressive backline. Now it's Ry's turn.
Now Randy did develop a lot of might
last turn. Now it's time to see how he
wants to use it. So going to think it
through.
We got a fan in there as well. So
going to start with Ezreal going to
Rever's rope. That's point number three.
Randy also wants to get to four points
here as well.
All right. And we see the fan go into
the Oblok power. So Esor could back up
the Reaver's rope. Fan could always push
back one of these large attackers.
Okay, it's going to be a pouty porro for
Randy just continuing to further
develop. Definitely had to go to four.
Wants to give up the least amount of
might in doing so. And while the fan is
very useful at holds later on, it would
be the best unit to sacrifice. Now,
there is a chance that Randy can still
look for a hold, but he also recognizes
the value of the fan is quite low
because he's aware of a falling star in
the hand of Sam. So, he can never rely
on this overzealous fan doing anything.
And so potentially using it as a
sacrifice is very safe with the
information that he was able to acrewue
uh via the mind sppllitter.
>> Yeah, both falling star targets are now
exposed in a way that you don't really
care that much. So
good play from Randy
looking for the next step. Pouty Porro
not so exciting here. Neither is
Treasure Hunter. So, couple of those
early game units, not really what uh
Rain is looking for at this exact
juncture, but going to pass back. So,
Sam at four and now wants to go to that
allimportant six and seems to have the
tools to do so.
>> Was the mindslitter taken?
>> All right, so here comes Splitter.
Rebuke Piercing Light.
>> What are you taking here?
>> I think
This ends up having to be rebuked.
Piercing Light isn't lining up into
these sevens and sixes, right? It's very
good against the fours and the twos, but
the rebuke is going to line up very well
into the sevens and sixes when it comes
to combat. Yes, you don't want to really
rebuke a mindspplitter, but you do if
it's winning you the game or it's
winning you the combat in a very big
way. So, it is going to be the rebuke
taken away. So, Sam agrees. Rebuke's
gone. Now, perfect information. Now, Sam
can really plot things out.
So,
got to think this through,
>> you know, noting here the clock is
starting. It's a little relevant, you
know. So, kind of coming with the
foreigner, the fan will immediately push
it back.
And it's time to see who's next.
>> Sorry about the 4Runner. That's the one
you feel like want to get pushed back
the least almost.
>> It's the one you you most likely want to
have on the battlefield.
>> I'm I'm fully with you there. Yeah, I
think maybe that was not the most
optimal choice uh out the gates to try
and bait out that overzealous fan. Um,
but there is still consideration. I
guess at the end of the day, what Sam is
achieving is the two lowest might units
are on the battlefields. Now, of course,
uh, Draven is the same might as a Ferros
4Runner. Um, but he is on Reaver's Raw,
so maybe get to run down. The only
sacrifice here is going to be a treasure
hunter.
>> Sure. So Hunter's in, Draven's in, and
Sam is at six in striking distance of a
top eight birth. Randy, however, stands
in his way. Still a lot of might on that
back line.
Now here comes Mindsplitter in Rever's
row. Dven backs up. That's a combat win.
That's a point. That's a card up to
five.
>> Splitter's also pretty huge as far as
just, you know, defending. I mean,
Randy's going to need to need to defend
on this next turn.
>> So, thinking on the trigger for Draven
still is what I heard from Sam.
>> So, accepting ordered the triggers to
allow the reavers to happen, but still
considering I I wonder where Oh, pumping
the six here to play around the piercing
light. Actually, it's a it's a very
reasonable idea for Sam because he knows
that Randy can just piercing light
through either the mind spplitter or
through the uh treasure hunter and take
out this Draven. And so the question is,
do you want to be at six instead of four
in order to be safe around that piercing
light?
>> Okay. Says yes. So
Randy didn't need to start with a
combat. Could have started.
>> Could have started with piercing light,
but Randy wanted to draw a card.
>> Sure.
>> And piercing light would deny his
ability to draw a card. The question is,
is, you know, was Randy hoping that he
could still piercing light this uh
Draven or is this all kind of by design?
You just actually wanted to win two
combats and you're looking for other
tools where the piercing cuz the
piercing light is an expensive cast to
kill it,
>> right?
>> And you're not you're really just
getting the Draven. I mean, the treasure
hunter is not that's not a real thing
you're getting. It was going to die no
matter what.
>> So, I'm not sure the Piercing Light
wanted to be in the plans for Draven on
this turn.
>> Okay. Well, heads up play for Sam either
way. Yeah, it still is to recognize
that's an option.
>> Yep. So, so now we have the Porro on the
obelisk and the mindsplitter on the row.
Ry's at six. So, both players at six.
Both players threatening. But now, of
course, Randy has to kind of batten down
the hatches here and try and stop this
double conquer on Sam's next turn. Sam
has a lot of might in play, cards in
hand and resources. So, we're going to
see another Porro. His Porro's, you
know, not looking awesome.
So porro porro and then a fan at the
obelisk power line spplitter at the
reaver's row. We see hunter going in as
well.
>> Yeah,
>> make a treasure. Just
>> big reminder that this fan is kind of
fake. Fake fan after all because the
falling star we know is still in hand
>> for Sam Sherman. So
>> are you calling Ry's card a poser right
now?
>> Yes, absolutely. Okay, just not even
Draven's biggest fan anymore. Yeah, you
know, this is this is the overzealous
fan. Fake fan.
>> Okay, so
Now the question is what else will
reinforce? So there's still a lot of
power in that backline. Draven noxious
hopeful the ram. Ezreal. We're going to
see Draven go to the reverse row. Ezreal
go to the obelisk. Ram go to the the
Ram's going to the obelisk and the
noxious
to reverse row. And starting really fast
there like everything been mapped out. A
little bit of pause. And now we see a
whole bias up on Obelisk power and two
very large units on reverse row. And now
Sam's turn to break.
>> Yeah. So card knowledge for Randy is
still that he's playing around that
falling star.
Other than that,
I think everything else has been played
that was in that hand. The ride the
wind, the stack deck, the Darius was
taken, falling star.
>> Am I missing one spell? Maybe not.
>> I I feel like maybe
>> feel like I am.
>> I have a very bad memory. I should have
wrote it down.
>> Yeah, I write these things in in a game.
>> Yeah. No, it's okay. Randy knows exactly
one or two cards in this grip from Sam
and the rest is mystery information.
>> So, four.
>> It was the axe.
>> Ah, yes. Yep. Yep.
>> The plus three.
>> So, a good one to know about, of course.
>> Yeah. So, when he was doing the
calculation for this, he had falling
star and axe in mind and then the rest
is whatever mystery cards had been
drawn. You have to assume there's a very
big range with mid-range Draven. A lot
of different cards that be can be cast
for two energy. Rebuke, fight or flight,
another falling star, right? There's a
there's a lot of different ways that it
can go. So, we got 19 might up top on
Abos for Randy and then we have 11 could
be 13 on reverse row.
>> Start things off with a splitter. Now,
these again, these individual attacks do
allow Randy to possibly pump the Draven
multiple times. So, maybe looking for a
trade here with the Mindsplitters. Also
seeing Reavers Row as far as pushing
back. Pushing back here seems pretty uh
>> yeah six to I don't think you're allowed
to do that.
>> Pretty risky thing to do. So, we're
going to see a rebuke on the mine
spplitter.
>> So, splitter at seven, Draven six.
>> Is there a response from Randy?
Hold on.
>> Hard bargain.
>> Okay, so trying to force
>> runes out of Sam. Hard bargain with
repeat Ezreal on board. Only costs three
for Randy. So he actually still has two
energy up that maybe that last uh card
can matter for.
>> Yeah. So now Sam has to decide, okay, um
I can pay for this. Am I willing to
spend most of my available energy to
push through Mr. Rebuke or rather just
do multiple other things instead?
>> Yeah, in fact, it would leave him with
just a single energy. He says, "Okay,
you've countered that."
>> Okay.
>> Yeah,
>> that's crazy.
>> So, bargains in. Now, you see Fighter
Flight
>> push back. Draven's gone. That's a win.
That's a point. Sam to seven
>> and now only has this ridiculously
stacked AOA to push through.
>> And Falling Star is a great start.
Goodbye Ezreal. Goodbye fan.
And here they come. 2 4 5 6 7 8 9. And
that's game one.
>> He's got it.
>> Woo. Oh, wow. All right. So,
>> oh, that's game two. Sam is advancing
into top eight. That was two quick
games. Wow. My bad. Sam is in. Randy.
That's tough stuff.
So, Sam is uh locked up for top eight.
Fantastic to see.
>> yeah,
but like
>> it's tough for Randy of course
>> and having to deal with the the pair
down. Has to play it out. Ends up
losing. But fate in his own hands to try
and win that, make it finally for
another top eight. Another marvelous run
for Andy. I mean, insanity on the
consistency that he's had so far. Now
he's just waiting on Breakers to see if
he can make it. But with a couple pair
downs, Breakers are going to be tough.
We'll see after if he gets in once we
have the standings. Yeah, still live at
X2, but there's going to be quite the
scrum fighting those last few spots. And
still a great run either way. One of the
things these tournaments are, they are
very, very large. It is very difficult
to go X and two in a tournament like
this. So, still a fantastic run.
Consistency a really big deal in card
games. Let's let's pop down and see uh
see what our winner has to say.
All right, Sam, I'm here. You just
locked up your top eight slot in a
Draven mirror. How are you feeling? I am
over the moon. I just cannot believe it.
I'm so happy.
>> So, Draven Mirror, kind of like a pseudo
mirror. Um, obviously you're prepared
for the mirror, but how how comfortable
do you feel playing the mirror overall?
>> Uh, I think it's one of my worst
matchups.
>> Why?
>> Uh, well, I basically I think that all
of the metal card people are great
matchups. Um, and uh, then besides that,
the only decks that we were kind of
taking seriously in our testing was like
Draven, Kai'Sa, Aurelia, and Ezreal.
>> Um, and of those, I think, uh, Ireelia
is kind of a good matchup. Um, Kai'Sa is
kind of a bad matchup. Ezreal I'm not
really too sure about. And, uh, the
mirror is the mirror. Um, so I mean,
every time I draw a Draven, I'm wishing
it was something else. But on the other
hand, I I think that the uh Miracle
Dravens are kind of a good matchup um
just cuz their cards kind of have a
little less text and they're more just
about vanilla numbers and my deck is
pretty good at handling vanilla numbers.
So um yeah, I mean I I like my match up
against Randy a lot. I think that the
way he built his deck doesn't line up
great into my deck. So
>> awesome stuff. So obviously it worked
out great. And you said this this is
your first major Riftbound tournament.
>> Yeah. Uh I uh sort of retired from Magic
like a year ago and I was kind of off
doing these tournament traveling things
and um so I didn't sign up for Houston.
I I wasn't really intending to play
Riftbound, but my friend uh Tom
uh
enlisted me to help him test for for
Houston. And I was just having so much
fun. Riffbound is just such an awesome
game that, you know, I I'm I'm kind of
in now. So
>> just when they thought you were out,
they drag you back in. So that's
awesome. So this being your first event,
how are you enjoying it?
>> Enjoying the game.
>> Oh, the event.
>> The event. Um
I uh I mean I'm having a great time
obviously. Like I mean this is crazy
that I'm doing so well. Um I think that
the atmosphere here and like just kind
of the the hype around the game is just
a totally different world from Magic
events I've been to. Um,
and I mean I played a a $50 side event
on Friday and I went four and two and I
won $1,000. Like
is this is just absolutely insane.
>> Awesome. Great stuff. Well, you're going
to top eight. How are you feeling in top
eight? You're saying it's first first
major airbound event, first really big
finish. Are you feeling confident? Do
you feel think you're playing loose? Do
you feel any pressure? How you feeling?
Uh I I'm playing pretty good today. Um I
played pretty well yesterday. Uh you
know, things are kind of coming up me in
in a lot of the
>> To be clear, I meant loose as in like
relax, not badly. Like like playing
loses in your you know, got nothing to
prove. You're just here on your first
big event.
>> Yeah. Yeah. I'm I'm just taking it one
game at a time, you know, just doing
what I can. I I've kind of been, you
know, a little
uh you know, this is a long event. I'm
I'm a little tired, but you know, I'll
I'll I'll buck up to play the you know,
the biggest Riftbound match I've ever
played. So, and hopefully more than one.
So, good luck in top eight.
Congratulations.
>> Thank you.
>> All right, we are back here in round 13.
We have one more win in a true win in.
Nothing like it sending a player into
top eight. One player will, you know,
end up with a result that is very, very
good, but not quite there. and uh top
eight playing for the trophy and playing
for a lot of money and a whole lot more.
>> Well, yeah. I mean, big congrats to Sam
for making that top eight. That's so
incredible that he's first big Riftbound
event coming in. He he like you said, he
was he was out and he's been roped back
in Riftbound, grabbing everybody from
every game and bringing them here so
they could all compete at the very best
of the best. And it's just so
incredible.
>> Really cool to see too is the genuine
like, yeah, I'm I'm here. I'm I'm doing
this. This is awesome. So, really cool
stuff. We got one more match to go and
we're going to see Meiru more Draven.
Little shovel Draven. Yeah. What?
There's a three Rex eyes in this deck.
Is am I seeing that right? Uh yes,
actually. This seems like so many cards.
But yeah, Rexi I I don't even know what
to say about this. This is not something
I expected to see in Draven. Uh I have
not seen Rex Eye Breacher in a Draven
build. So, this is I mean that's some
serious spice uh for that to be in here.
Um but other than that, this is looking
like a pretty classic uh miracle build,
right? This is a miracle shell. You've
got your Ezreals, you've got your call
shots. Uh just just everything that
you're looking for in that the few maybe
spicier pickups. I guess it's going to
be the two of Fizz. And actually, no uh
why can I not remember the the card the
>> No, the uh the ready everything.
>> Oh, Bushwack. Yeah, no Bushwack. Yeah,
that's the the part that I'm very
confused about actually cuz we've seen
the power of Bushwack in these kind of
builds. Also, am I seeing no Ross? Am I
blind?
>> No, no Rosses either. Yeah, this is kind
of
>> What is happening here?
>> What is going on?
>> The chosen champion variety pack. Rexai
chosen champion. Ezreal chosen champion.
Darius chosen champion. Kaisa chosen
champion. I apologize. I've never been
so lost in my life. I I I've seen a lot
of miracle builds that have been kind of
trying to break the mold, but no Rossa,
no Bushwack, and then Rexai Breacher is
that is the tippy top of some spice that
I have not seen.
>> And two, Minotaur Recker on the board.
So, uh, innovation abound here in our
Draven Deck list and Mirror doing quite
well of course is X1 and one and playing
against Jab MTG. Uh, and this is that
one of VI list we saw Jonathan Rosson
playing earlier. I've seen this deck
before.
>> Yep. And uh this one, you know, has the
one by and we saw uh Rossam on camera
doing some, you know, going through
almost the entire deck in the first like
six turns using VI to put these in the
bottom. And uh this is really really
cool list. I was lost and now I'm found.
I I I
seen I've been here. I go here. I I
don't go to the other one. I don't know.
I don't know anybody there, but I know
the people here. I've met them before
and so I'm a little bit more comfortable
here. You know, I'm not good with new
people. All right. So, Rosabus under
treasure trove and detonate. going to
try and detonate Jab's way into this top
eight. Let's see. There's Raza, of
course, going to sunder along. This
detonate package is quite awesome.
>> Yeah. And jab MTG here. This is uh Jacob
Ba, very accomplished Magic the
Gathering player, but also very
accomplished flesh and blood player
taking his talents to Riftbound. And
really fun fact about Jacob Ba is he is
on the same team as Shawn Dollywal. And
he was the player on that team that
brewed up the Annus first and brought it
to the rest of the team and said, "Hey,
uh, this is going to win us the
tournament." And um well it did. Shawn
ended up winning that event in Houston.
>> Yeah, really really cool to see. And now
Jab getting his own shot at top eight
glory. So we see the Draven Mirror Veil
Temple on the side of Jab on the right.
Candle at Sanctum on Meiru on the left.
And these players are of course these
players are both X1 and one. So there is
no room to give here. You know uh as we
saw Randy Randy still has an outside
shot even with the loss at X and two.
But at X1 and one, loser is out and the
winner is in
>> as this will be an absolute fight
between the two of them. Top eight birth
on the line.
Draven mirror both miracle variants in a
sense. I am perplexed by the lack of
Rosai. Can't wait to see how Miru plays
this out. This is uh not something I
have ever quite seen.
>> These Rex eyes are very interesting. Uh
not really able to use the Rex eye
ability. So
>> off of shovel.
>> Sure, that works. Yeah. Okay.
>> In the beginning phase, but I think
you'd still get the accelerate ability.
You could just still it would it would
be readied.
>> All right. Cool. Innovation abounds. So
we see no play on turn one from Mirum.
Jab gets to do the stack deck into two
drops. They get to use all that energy.
Turn two. Draven. Seen that a few times
this weekend.
Going back Jab's way.
Jab to think it through. Five runes.
Draven hanging out in the champ zone.
That merchant is uh I believe ready.
>> Hasn't gone anywhere just yet.
>> No,
>> no travels.
Very very untraveled merchant.
>> Yeah, this this merchant stays at home.
He's a brick and mortar. Yeah.
>> Yeah. This this merchant is it's
>> all body.
>> He's not out vending at, you know, the
Las Vegas regional. He's he's he's
staying back at his shop.
>> Yep.
>> All right. So, no move on the merchant.
Going back mirror's way and we see a
Darius
and just a pass. So both players contend
to develop and not score any points.
Going back Jab's way.
Jab. You start things off with an
Ezreal. Great place to start.
Discard a card. Draw two. There's a
scrappy. Make it three.
So three cards in and now we could see
could see an explosive miracle turn
here.
Yeah, this can be the start of it,
right? You get the three draws, no seal.
Often times, you really want it to start
with a seal. However, there could still
be an opportunity to draw one now before
the called shot. Does not find it.
You see, Jacob is keeping that count
though. Two cards played on this turn.
So, it does look like he wants to start
going off on this one with the Ezreal
into the called shot.
All right, so first iteration of Called
Shot on repeat. This definitely a song
we've had on repeat this weekend. Called
Shot probably the card of a tournament.
And repeat number two. There's your
first seal. There's your seal. All
right. So that could be grounds for
takeoff here for Jab in this game one.
>> First seal vi to the bottom. So once he
goes around that cycle, he can then find
that VI again, start putting things on
the bottom of the deck to go over and
over again.
>> Great spot to put it.
>> So seal and another called shot. That is
the requisite four cards being played.
So those Rams costs one now.
>> Yeah, any snap take potentially would
just be a Ram. That's exactly what Jacob
is going to want from here on out.
>> Pretty fast choices. Shot to bet.
How much might can you produce, jab,
here in your winnon?
>> Well, there's one. There's two.
>> Not too shabby. All right. So,
>> do we have a third
>> floating energy?
Two runes left.
>> Treasure
>> drove. And again, just saying go. So,
neither player wants to get into combat
just yet. Doesn't want to give up any uh
any units or any Draven cards. So, it's
just a a solid zero zero treasure trove.
You see here, this is kind of the the
core of Jab's deck. these treasure
troves and these detonates to really
turbocharge the draws.
>> All right, seal for Meiru and we see a
move into
the temple. Yep. And as you can see,
floating that power out the gates so
that you can rery it after the conquer
on the veil temple. Get an additional
purple power gives a lot of value when
you start going towards the called shot
is just going to be a stack deck for
now.
It does ready Darius. Another seal found
and gets second seal ready.
>> Yeah, pretty nice here. Kind of going
with that flow of not wanting to be uh
on the board in combat losing units or
giving cards cuz Darius can pop right
back out in a hit and run.
And
here we go. So, stack deck
coming home. That's the first point of
the game. First blood here.
And what's Mirror's next step?
Ezreal time.
>> All right. So, Ezreal on both sides. So,
both players getting very well set up to
do their thing here.
>> There's a Rex eye going to the bin.
>> So, that's the uh first first time we've
seen the Rex Eye do something and it was
uh to to go to the trash.
>> So, we'll see how they do later. I want
Yeah, I want to see what this card does
for this deck.
>> Everyone's got a job to do.
>> No shame.
So called shot resolving fist full of
cards for Meiru. Here comes Noxious
hopeful and perhaps a Ram as well. All
right. So Ram hopeful everything staying
in the back. Both these players trying
to avoid losing a combat and giving a
free card off the Draven Legend. So back
jabs away
might abound.
>> And there you go. So there is the
detonate on the trove. You see two cards
from detonate, one card in a room from
the trove. Just turbocharging the draws.
>> Yeah, just drawing three more.
Setting up to keep building and
building. It works beautifully with the
trove cuz you get to reamp the rune that
you lose to detonate.
Really, really smart combo from this
team being able to find this. And Jab
trying to be one representative of this
team of this deck to make it into the
top eight.
>> Yep. You've seen him on camera all
weekend.
>> Rossom
Ross said they were like 80%
>> on their win rate.
>> Yep.
>> Believe Daryl errors as well.
>> So merchant time finally finally leaving
the shop to go do a little traveling and
we see a discard of Scrappy a draw of
two as if Jab did not have enough cards
already. Ready event seal. Little extra
power
squeezing every bit of juice out of this
orange.
>> And now Meiru watches on. Both players
have both players have kind of traded
blows, but not in the combat sense, just
in the like, oh yeah, here's how much
stuff I can do.
>> Yeah. I mean, it's it's like this it's
just kind of this arm race of mice of of
might, right? You're just kind of
building up these boards as much as you
can.
waiting for one big showdown, one big
fight. Uh, you know, it's a standoff.
Uh, both people waiting to see who is
going to draw first. And, uh, it's
so far, I mean, slight edge towards Jab.
A little bit more has come down, a lot
more cards in hand,
but still not a ton more might. the the
the big edge would be that you know
Jab's got the Rosses whereas on the
other side Miru did not. So that's 18
more might in the deck. Uh whereas kind
of the replacement are those three Rex
size which is is just less might. Um so
there is potential if this just keeps
going eventually Jab ends up having just
more might in deck.
>> Yeah. And then also Jab's just building
towards the buy.
>> Yeah.
>> You know Jab kind of just keep going and
going and going.
>> Infinity Knight
>> although that does you need to make some
trades first you know. So, if you're
just putting everything in play, then
the requisite units are not in the
trash. So, we see the Ram come in.
That's point number two. So, we finally
see some some progress here uh in the
point front. And we're going to see
a hidden card on Candleit.
Do we catch what the Candleit tops or
bottoms were?
>> I think he missed it. Uh I think that
was a second ago he asked. He said, "Oh,
I missed. Should I do it?" And opponent
said no.
>> Okay. So again, a lot of pressure under
the lights in this final round. You
know, for one of these players, it's
going to be their final round. You know,
they'll go home happy with a great
finish. Some prize money, but you want
that trophy. You want to keep playing.
You don't want them to tell you to stop
playing
back Mirror's way. Now, the question of
course is now now that Jab's kind of
pushed the issue and put some units onto
battlefields, I think we're going to be
out of that standoff phase into more of
a combat phase. Yeah, Miro has a bit of
a rune advantage going into this. Not of
course jab is tapped out. So that is
obviously a big rune advantage, but it
is 7 to five still coming into Mirror's
turn. So very slight uh or 8 to five,
sorry. Very slight rune advantage for
Miro. Will just be a few ahead each turn
going on for the rest of this game.
Especially because there's less power
cost overall for Miro
>> not having to worry about the roses in
that in that way, right? just bigger
energy that you need to find for some of
those units.
>> All right, so looks like Draven's up
first. Draven going to jump into the
candle sanctum. We're going to see an
energy floated and a fury paid to make
Draven a six fight or flight going right
back home. So that's a combat win. Draw
a card for Draven's a draw.
>> However, that is uh all the responses
that Jab can have this turn. Yeah, that
it was trading a fight orflight for a
card, but also trading a battering ram
for a card because realistically
now once Mirror has played two cards,
Battering Ram does get run over by
Darius.
>> Though I I do think that maybe Miru
wants the Darius to be able to run home.
So, we'll see how this exactly gets
piloted for Miro because if you send the
Darius in to take out the battery ram,
you've now stranded your Darius, right?
Uh unless you can play the second card
of the turn once you've already pushed
Darius in. So ready at mid combat, pump
it to seven and then bring it home. And
so that really just depends if there's
action speed stuff. If it has to be two
units, then you're not going to be able
to do this. But if you've got, you know,
a unit plus an action speed spell that
can get there and there's a good amount
of cards. So So you would think that
that would be the case that there would
be some amount there. All right. So here
is Darius number two. That is first card
played.
And now
>> how is the rand going to be dealt with?
I
>> believe mirror is also is at three,
right? Or is it two?
>> I think it is two.
>> There's two here. Okay. Right. Sorry.
>> Yeah.
>> So going to three here is is it's fine.
They're not incredible, but here's
Darius. So entering the showdown and
there's the axe. So just like you were
saying, axe will go onto the Draven
ready, but Darius goes to seven.
Oh, the ready too technically, but not
really that relevant. And we're going to
see the candle go off. Top two cards can
go top or bottom. Setting up for next
turn. And I mean there is a lot of might
in Mirror's back row with these two
Darius, the axe, the Draven. A lot going
on.
>> Yeah. Finds an Ezreal. Just going to
continue
for the draw.
>> Okay.
>> Um
Tiru, what's the next step? What did the
uh Ezreal come to? Did he cast another?
It was another call shot, right? Okay.
>> Uh yes. So
>> Darius coming home. Double Darius Draven
Ezreal. And then we're going to see uh
some reinforcements. The Ram will join
the Noxious Hopeful at the Veil Temple.
And that is a pass. So we're going back
Jab's way. 22.
Nine might defending the temple.
Jab has good combats to take. There's
always going to be some amount of trade
unless Jab can find a push or BU
something of that nature to get over the
top. Axe will never do it. The highest
amount of might that he currently has is
six. So Axe just ties with the nine
there.
>> It takes two.
>> Takes two. You're going to have a trade
or going to require a spell to push
something so you can get a free clear.
>> Jab taking it through. Kind of cool to
see like we had the setup phase and now
we have Okay, now it's time to run some
units in. So here's Ezreal coming in to
candle with sanctum.
That's a point and that's two cards top.
Look like a called shot and a seal.
>> Cot seal. There's an argument to maybe
just put the seal to the bottom cuz you
already have two out. Uh maybe you don't
quite want to draw it, but it is just
going to be top top. Uh makes me kind of
think that Jab has some decent draw
engines coming up. You do want the seal
to be in play realistically. you don't
want to keep redrawing it as you're
cycling through the deck over and over
again. So, as long as there's enough
cards in hand that you're not worried
about uh being kind of bricky on that,
it feels like this version with the
detonates just it's almost impossible
for it to kind of brick in that way uh
is just going to be fine finding that
next seal.
>> Okay, here is the shovel.
So, now
cards in the bin trash goes to the
bottom gets recycled.
We're going to see an equip onto Raza.
>> Call shot. Call shot
>> going to the bottom.
>> And uh now we see the engine starting to
come in. So uh just Jab will just never
run out of cards and the recycling will
choose whatever cards Jab wants to keep
there will stay. Here's an axe.
>> Yeah, and we said axe alone, you know,
three plus six that does not beat nine.
But guess what? Yeah, the shovel that
gets the job done.
>> Oh boy. So Roz is in. That's a conquer.
We got a ready here on a gear and we
have the last rights trigger
>> and a draw which also a draw off the
combat first.
>> So now what's in the bin? Battering ram
>> travel.
>> Uh it's it's ram or merchant. Uh if Ram
is at
>> cost one then he'd do it but I think
he's just declining here. Doesn't
actually have the shovel conquer. The
shovel was just useful for getting a
positive trade.
>> Yep.
There's a seal.
>> There's a stack deck.
Just keep the churn churning.
>> A lot of might in play. Converting some
positive called shot again. Just keep on
going.
>> Yeah, I think he's getting very close uh
to the cycle, right? The VI that was put
to the bottom earlier
should be arriving there shortly.
So the cycle being Jab's now gone
through the entire deck.
>> Yeah,
>> we saw Vi bottom earlier and uh once
that VI is found now with the deck size
so small,
>> Jab can just kind of put whatever he
wants on the bottom and find it and that
infinite resource train begins. So a
hidden card on the Veil Temple
and a pass. So good turn for Jab up to
four points
going back Mirror's way. kind of lost in
all that is that Mirror's board is still
great. Devil Darius,
Draven with an axe,
Ezreal for, you know, getting the engine
going for moral support. That's
>> Hey guys, I'm here too.
>> I'm also some might. Don't worry.
>> You're doing great, Ezreal. You just
keep doing what you're doing. All right.
Okay.
>> Yeah. I mean, this this Ross is still
pretty tough to move initially. Uh, it
is just 11 might. Um, just 11, you know,
with the spinning axe on it, you really
want to deal with that, but Meiru has to
kind of find a way to deal with the Rosa
without trading too much might away.
Already a bit behind on this might race.
So, not able to to really give an inch
here. Not able to actually trade units
for the Rosa without falling even
further behind is Java is ahead in
points. So really for him at this point
any kind of these trades is good because
he's going to be able to retake. Go up
to six and he's got more might on the
board.
All right. So Draper uh sorry Darius is
in Mir to four. Jab to four.
Jab threatening a hold to five. And if
Miru were to take this battlefield Raza
would also go to five. Five can be an
awkward number.
Lot of cards in hand. So many resources.
This is a both these decks I guess you
know being the same deck for the most
part really really good at just piling
up the resources having so many things
to work with
>> start with an Ezreal.
>> Here's Ezreal number two.
What to discard? Pick up two. The called
shot was put on top with the start with
the candle lit. Correct.
>> Yeah.
>> So keep that train aan piercing light
hits the bin. This is where I'm here to
learn, Jim, because normally what I
would be thinking right now is I'm
looking for my Rosses to start
establishing those.
>> Keep looking.
>> I would be I would I would not be
finding them. Um and so that's where,
you know, Meiru is 10 one and one. I'm
not going to sit here and say, "Oh, this
deck list is silly. This shouldn't
work."
>> Why Why has he won this many games if it
if that was the case? But unfortunately
for me, I have not seen any of this
gameplay where it's like no Rasa these
Rex eyes. So I I I want to see from Miru
kind of the the proof in the pudding
where what are these Rex eyes doing?
What are they bringing to the table?
Because I'm not picking it up. And often
times I can infer and this is one of
those really interesting moments where I
get to see a deck
>> that is something that I've not seen
before.
>> And I love that. Yeah, I love this in
coverage where it's a moment where,
>> you know, often times I can think about
these tech choices and I can I can tell
you exactly, you know, maybe what I I
get in the mind and think what my uh the
player is thinking.
>> Hello.
>> Can't find that there. That's a great
hard bargain.
>> Yeah. So, we see uh Darius move in with
the blood rush and the axe. Jab goes to
save with the fighter flight, but
because totally exhausted, hard bargain
says no in a big time blowout in a
combat. Yeah, very big here. Uh, of
course for Jab, this has to be something
that's in your range when you're setting
up for that hidden card, but it is the
worst case scenario. It's what you
really hope doesn't happen is that you
end up getting hard bargained. Uh,
you're hoping you get to save that axe,
save that rosta, save all that might.
And this is what I was talking about
going into this turn for Meu is you're
not allowed to trade. You need to be
taking these kills essentially for free
and force jab to then do the same back
to you because you do not have enough
might on this board to deal with jab
long turn. More call shots. I think a
ram was to pick up for a little more
might. Could be wrong.
And there it is. All right. So ram
reinforces the veil temple. Ram and
Draven are hanging out.
Still two Darius in the back row. Now
we're going Jab's way. Meu on five. Jab
on four with a good turn here. Jab could
threaten to go to six, but Or a good
amount of work to take down that Bale
Temple.
>> Yeah, I mean shovel's time to continue
to pick up the Rosas. It's time to
shine. Uh Rosa being free. There's three
seals on the board. Use one to equip.
There's more than 10 in the bin. Ross is
just going to come back. And so this is
really great. Start with Bushwack.
>> Oh boy. If you conquer onto the candle
lit with the shovel, the Ross is going
to come in ready from the bin and be
able to help this attack onto the Veil
Temple.
>> All right, so all units will enter ready
for jab this turn. That really throws
off the math.
So, uh the the shovel can't go in by
itself. Has to be attached to a unit.
So, going to pick up the the Rams pick
up a shovel.
Bushwack going to hang out. Remind
everyone that hey, yeah, all things
coming in ready. So that ram's ready to
rock and roll.
>> Deciding the other card to go to the
bottom. It looks like he's going to take
a ram to the bottom. Recognizing that
Rosa is his play off of the shovel. He
actually wants to redraw into this ram.
He put two called shots to the bottom
earlier. That's going to be a really
great way that you can find this ram
again. All right, so Ram comes in
a conquer candle lit and the play from
the graveyard effect.
Candle lit. More cards going on the
bottom. Just even turbocharging this.
Yeah, he wants to find the call shots
into the ram that he just put back on
the bottom. That's exactly what he's
looking for as he finds some of these
draws.
>> So, jab to five
and now still more work to be done. It's
going to be detonate on the gold. So,
not the main plan, but certainly a fine
plan.
>> Just digging a little bit deeper. May
have put some other spells to the bottom
he was looking for. Finds one of the
called shots that was sent earlier. So,
now he knows he's back. This should be
called shot plus one more.
That's called shot rasa.
Not exactly what he wants to see, but he
could put the rosa back down. Called
shot again. Dig four more. Refind the
rasa that he just put back to the
bottom. We'll see if that was the case
or if just one rosa was enough.
>> So crazy to be in the spot where you're,
you know, you're work with known
information in your library. The zone is
supposed to be hidden information. So
Raza comes in. It is ready of course
because of Bushwack and uh still plenty
of energy available for Jab.
So Draven with an axe and the ram
hanging out on the temple. Dven's four
could be six plus the axe is nine. You
got 14 with the ram as well. Easy
pickings here for all this uh might that
Jabz
>> talking it through. Thinking it out.
Again, there's still these two Dariuses
on the back line for Meiru. So,
potential reprisal next turn, but here
comes Raza, Raza, Ram into
>> Draven, Ram, and Axe. Yeah. So, we're
going to see nothing. No Draven trigger.
Just trading off two for two. The Ram
does get in as a one combat. That's a
card off Draven. And that is the
allimportant sixth point.
Now Jeb just has to look to reset for a
double conquer. The VI is in hand. He
had already hit that signpost a little
bit earlier. And that is one that can be
established and used to take one side
especially because the second bushwack
should also be around for Jab. I believe
it's either in hand or it is well within
grasp uh between the stack here.
>> Jab at this point knows the full stack.
>> Yep. Uh it is just a matter of getting
through it to the exact things he needs
knowing he has the right draw. Treasure
trove funny enough can just be
sacrificed like this. Get a new rune
when you have a seal draw one deeper.
>> Believe five cards in deck for jab.
>> See there was even a detonate there.
Didn't want to cast it though. Wanted to
ensure still having a red rune. Only
needed to draw one deeper. Find the
battering ram.
>> Right. So ram's in. That's ready. Thanks
to Bushwack.
>> That was the ram that was put on the
bottom earlier when he used the shovel.
>> Yep.
>> So he knows that that was the next card.
>> All right. And then get a pass back. So
some units at battlefields, some are at
the back. And now it's Mirror's turn.
And this form of can't go on that much
longer. Jab just has everything. You
know, in this this point of the game
where, you know, especially with Vi in
hand as well, uh Jab kind of can just
keep going through over and over and
over again.
>> Yep. by bushwack in hand. Jab just has
to evade rebuke fight orflight are the
big things. One of the two sides is is
conquered. We are we we don't have to
worry about it, right? That is bushwack
vi so long as there isn't a fighter or a
if jab can play through it. There's
another rosa in hand as well. Plus the
shovel conquer can get another rosa that
can be ready. The the second bushwack is
there. It's happening.
So, for Meu to actually hold here is
going to be a feat of brilliance and uh
a lot of help from this hand. We saw
there was a myriad of different uh
one-offs that were in Meiru's version
alongside some of some of the spice uh
with the Rexai. So, there is a question
of
maybe there are the answers to be found.
Rebuke fighter flight.
>> Well, there's enough might rebuke off
that stack deck. So, it is one of the
many pieces that Mirror needs here.
Handful of cards, ton of runes,
ton of mites,
and a ton of pressure here in this win
in in round 13 regional qualifier here
in Las Vegas. This is a win- in for top
eight. The winner's in, the loser is
not.
>> 25 minutes in game one already. 35 left.
>> Yeah. Uh one thing is these players do
not want to draw. Uh this is a win in
where one player is in one player is
out. Uh but at 101 and one uh draw would
not be a good place to be.
>> Yeah, draw is a good chance to maybe
fight your way into top 16, but not
certainly not getting you into that top
eight.
>> Win is big here. Players are definitely
going to be looking at that, paying
attention to the time, doing their best.
But this is a tough matchup. the miracle
mirror.
Lots of game actions to be taken between
the two players.
>> Top 16 is great. It's a great prizes for
top 16. Absolutely. You know, but you
know, when you're one step away, Jim,
>> right? You don't come to a tournament,
you know, win a couple thousand bucks
and say, "Hey, top 16." You come to take
the whole thing down and win that
trophy, be in that photo, smiling,
holding up the trophy. It's a good
feeling. It's very nice. 34.
>> So, it's been a long turn for Meu and
you know one thing about you know these
rounds they are timed of course and
got to make a move.
Darius both Darius here mutations as far
as they can get buffed. They can ready
come back in and come back out.
>> Looks like it's going to be just the
Darius going into the candle sanctum.
And spell number two will be
>> just going to rebuke. Okay. I mean
that's one rebuke down already.
>> Yep. So
>> we know about this VI for Jab. Yep.
>> This is potentially a problem for Meiru.
>> So we see Rebuke. That'll win the
combat. That'll also Darius.
Plus two. What's the minus two for?
>> I couldn't tell you.
>> Okay. Your guess is as good as mine on
that one, J.
>> That's good.
He's hungry.
>> Yeah, minus two hunger points.
>> Oh, not hungry anymore.
>> All right, so other Darius going into
the veiled temple. Uh, and this one will
not be able to ready and get out. So
coming in as a seven to the Rams five
and that jab says it's okay. So Meu up
to seven points.
The question is seven is not eight. And
can Mirror survive the onslaught? Jabs
got rolled up for next turn with his
Bushwack and access to basically
everything in the deck.
>> Yeah, my initial guess is is no, right?
I mean, we know the Vi is there with the
Bushwack, so that's already a might
issue is just not going to happen for
really either side. And it comes down to
interaction, but we know it's, you know,
Vi, Rosa. Once one side gets conquered
with shovel potentially, you just are
able to play another Rasa. And these are
all coming in ready because of the the
bushwack. So it starts to become very
difficult to find a spot. And I think
Mirror must just have some amount of
spells here that feels like maybe he he
has a shot to still win this and he
wants to stick through it. And he's he's
got, you know, he played the rebuke
already. Maybe he's got another rebuke.
Looks like he's lining up a hidden card.
And it looks like that was another
rebuke in hand. Yep.
>> Very very important. And to be honest,
>> Miru hasn't seen a VI yet.
you know, if Mu in a search,
>> right? You know, if Miu has, you know,
been kind of watching it on matches, you
know, but these this is a closed
deckless tournament. This is not known
information. So, this VI could come as a
surprise. It might not.
And here we go. So, Bushwack will start
the turn. Hard bargain. This is awesome.
>> Yeah.
>> So, just saying, all right, you know
what? Here's a hard bargain and uh two
discounts. This is the full hard
bargain.
>> Yeah.
>> And that eats up a lot of jabs, runes.
Yeah, that that was a big pickup trying
to deal with the bushwack. Fortunately
for Jab still keeps two. So Vi is still
on the table and most of the other units
that Jab likes to play actually don't
cost any energy uh due to them being
Ross of the Sunderer and reduced by all
of that beautiful pile in the trash
there.
>> You think there's 10 10 cards there?
>> Uh you know it's real close, but I I
think we I think we're I think we're
getting there.
>> We'll call them judges get a count.
>> Yeah. Yeah,
>> we'll call it 10. We'll call it 10.
That's it. It's about 10.
>> A gentle gentleman's 10.
>> Yeah.
>> So, here's a seal. Here's that rosa.
>> And
>> another one. Oh, this is the equipment
of the the shovel. Not
>> soon enough. Don't you worry.
>> Uh there there's one in the bin. In
fact, there's there's two in the bin is
my understanding. Yeah, there's two in
the bin. So, another one can actually
come down until the uh the shovel is
able to complete a conquer and then and
then and then another one. All right.
So, here comes Raza with the shovel.
Eight against five. Mirror says
thinking.
>> Well, I mean
it's either Rebuke or the Ross of
Conquers.
>> Yeah,
>> I at two energy. Is there anything I
mean there's Fight or Flight, right? Uh
could be an option. I didn't see one in
hand when we quickly went through, but
it's a big grip of cards. It really
could be in there, but would that be
better than Rebuke? Probably not.
>> Yeah.
>> Um
>> I mean,
>> well, actually somewhat. It takes the
shovel off. Well, it's also the Raza if
it's Rebuke gets to come back in
essentially for free ready.
>> That's true. Actually much better than
uh Fighter Flight's actually much
better. That's a really great point.
Fightfly actually is much better than
Rebuke in the spot
>> cuz can just Okay, cool. Let me just
just do that again. Looks he shows the
VI.
>> All right. Yep.
>> Shows the Rosa.
>> Mirror's going to scoop it up. And now
they're going to go to game two. But
halfway done through the timer for that
first game, you can see them puts it
through the shuffle. Neither of these
players wants to draw. They they want to
get through this series.
>> Yeah. And Braz Jab really, you know,
just seeing the power of this build of
the deck, being able to just go so deep
and just kind of have this really strong
inevitability.
>> Really cool stuff.
>> End of the day, Vi still powerful
Origins MVP in the purple deck, right,
with the ride the win. This time around,
they said, "Well, Bushwack's pretty
good, too." And you know there's the
side the the main purpose of it is
restacking that deck. But it it does
have that side purpose of just coming in
with that bushwack and being way too
much might that no one can really deal
with this. Once again we see this combo
this this pairing in the opener from
Jabs deck of that treasure trove and the
detonate over and over again.
>> Great stuff. Yeah. Vio looking to win
another United States regional
championship in a slightly different
fashion. But hey Rexi, you wanted it.
You got
>> Well, I wanted to know why. I still
don't know why, but going first on
Oblisk, this is a great play. I mean,
this is going to be four might when it's
attacking, three on defense. Has some
additional text with the last strikes,
but I think that's the only time it has
that additional text.
All right, so here is Draven Rexai
staying home. We have a slight graphical
glitch here. So, of course, Jab did win
game one, so we have the the marker on
Meu, but Jab was winner of game one. So,
try and get that fixed if we can. Here's
Tro.
And here is a uh a detonate.
And here you go. Draw three. Doing the
thing. It's what this deck is all about.
>> You've been here time and time again.
>> Draw three. Ramp.
>> And if Jab, if Jab has it his way, we'll
be here many, many more times.
>> Up again.
>> Now once you draw so many cards, it's
like, oh, okay. What do I do with all of
these? I have so many options and and
you start to see
>> why so many of these miracle mirrors
start going towards time and they got to
make sure they're either finding that 20
victory or you know from there that's
that's that draw column. They each have
one of those.
>> Yep.
>> I think we've seen uh how some of that
has been able to happen with so many
game actions being taken.
>> Yeah. In in most decks you're able to
kind of plan out your turns. You look at
your hand, you think about how I want to
sequence these next few turns, kind of
plot things out, but there's so many
unknowns because there's so much card
draw in these decks. You just can't
know. So we see a scrappy played to the
board as a not a common play but works
well you detonate your deck a steal and
discord a battering ram. So a mini mini
turn
and once again Draven staying home. So
we're in that kind of early phase of
neither player wants to get into combat.
Just going to hang back and set up. No
rush 20.
And here is a Darius
>> just continually developing as we've
seen in the previous game, right? This
is this is the play pattern of this
mirror.
>> Once you jump in first, it becomes a bit
of an issue because it's on.
>> Yeah. You're you're for most of these
these turns to develop, you're tapping
out, right? You're just completely going
out of run. So if you push in to score
now your opponent full untap and they're
going to start taking some free trades,
drawing some cards cuz they're Draven,
drawing some cards cuz they're red
purple and still, you know, finding more
from there. So you just can't move in
until you're you're done until you're
done putting units on the board and then
you're ready to to fight.
>> So Scrappy gets hit by another dead
Nate. That's three more cards.
>> So many cards. It's like that Uno meme,
you know.
>> Yeah. Would you like to enter combat or
draw 24? And I think draw 24 is the
prevailing answer for these decks.
>> Yeah, Jab has made his choice. Here's
Ezreal.
>> You know, let's draw some more cards.
Detonate number three goes to the bin.
So, detonating is uh off the menu for
the moment till we get fully cycled
through
Ram and Draven hanging out. Here's
called shot. Got to pay for this one. I
think it's partially.
>> Yeah, I mean you got the one power to
draw two. There's second seal. Uh what
we've seen from this one because it
cycles so efficiently. I I've pretty
much never seen one of these guys put a
seal to the bottom of the deck. I I
think sometimes you see second or third
seal go to the bottom for these miracle.
Usually it's third seal. Second seal is
often drawn, I will say. But the third
seal sometimes heads to the bottom to
try and take something else and and play
the turn. But for this version, you you
you just take you need these seals out
of the deck. You're putting them on the
board because you are making it to that
bottom of the deck. who are making it to
that second cycle to that third cycle.
Sometimes even to that fourth cycle of
this deck list.
>> It's like groundhog day.
>> Oh yeah. Yeah. I I've been here before,
you know. I've seen this. Are
>> you positioned to call this deck
groundhog day?
>> I look I'm down.
>> All right.
>> I hate miracle.
I'm certified biggest miracle hater as
the name of this deck.
>> So called shot again. You see rebuke in
there.
All right.
So much velocity. Just burning through
cards.
And now we'll see what player is going
to blink first. Which player will be
kind of going in entering combat. It's
just it's just funny to see, you know,
considering the set one metag game.
These decks just don't want to score.
You know, you just like just three or
four turns go by and nobody scores a
point despite there being units
everywhere. But now we see the VI early.
Is that the scheme?
>> Yeah. Yeah, I mean it's not that risky.
He didn't see a falling star the entire
time. Um he did see a piercing light hit
the bin. Piercing light is a potential
side out uh after seeing Jab's list. I
think you saw it in basically in full.
Uh there's not a lot of very good
immediate hits. I know we talked about
how in in against Draven, Piercing Light
can be good, but I think it's better
against mid-range Draven. There's more
twos and fours, and this there's a lot
more threes and fives. Piercing Light
doesn't line up nearly as well there.
Uh, in fact, Falling Star actually lines
up a bit better into these versions than
than the Piercing Light does. But, uh, I
think it's relatively safe to just
develop this VI. I think he did need the
the count of plus one more uh for the
battering ram, but I have to imagine
there must have been some other card
that could have been played instead. So,
must be some reason from Jab maybe
wanting to start putting these call
shots in uh back in a little bit
earlier.
>> All right. Well, the seal has been
broken. Jab is at two with the battering
ram conquering power. see Draven
conquering the Veil Temple and a hidden
card as well. So now we'll see if Miru
wants to fight back. I think you almost
have to, right? Once once the seal is
broken, it's time to get some combat. So
we see Miru first seal online
and
plus two on the Darius. So Darius uh now
with this the cards being played first
doesn't have the ability to kind of get
in and get out just the buff.
>> Yeah. The the big thing of course
anytime someone decides to break the
seal they're out of runs tapped out.
>> You have to take this ad.
>> You have to be able to punish when this
happens. If you can't jab runs right
with the game the game is if Meu cannot
stop this now Jab probably just wins.
And that is, you know, a big statement
to make in a card game. There's a lot of
cards to be played, right? And a lot of
turns to be taken. But when you end up
in a position like this and you can't
punish the tap out, then Jab gets to
reestablish, run home, score those extra
points for free, force you to then be
the aggressor, and then hold on to those
runes. And because of that, Jab really
wants for a situation where Miro can't
actually attack this or this hidden card
can make a big difference. But really,
best case scenario for Jab is that maybe
one of these cards trades. Uh maybe
that's a fight or flight and he gets a
window where he can send Draven home or
trade for a draw card. Maybe a big
mistake from Miro, but only one Fury
rune remaining. So not multiple
activations available for Draven either.
All right, so we see stack deck again.
More deck massaging trying to find the
right pieces and put together a quality
attack this turn.
Rexai still hanging out
just chilling. He still hasn't done
anything. I'm very like again benefit of
the doubt towards this 10 one and one.
What is she doing here? I don't know.
Hanging out for now.
And Miru thinking it through again. That
clock starting to be a problem. It's
very easy to compartmentalize each game
in 20 minutes, 60-minute round. Uh so
we're currently in game three's clock
despite it being game two. And again, as
a reminder, Jab is currently up a game.
We have our graphic incorrect. So jab up
a game. This is game two. And here comes
Darius. Seven might in Draven currently
at four. Could go up to six. And of
course that hidden card.
And the way jabs deck is constructed.
The hidden card just can't be anything
but fight or fail.
>> Yeah. From Yeah. From Oh well, you know
what else it could be? It could be
bushwack. And I don't think that's ever
going to happen.
>> Okay. That you are not wrong. That is
true.
>> I am technically correct. The best kind
of correct of course is that uh there's
one more hidden card in this deck.
>> All right, it is fight or flight. We see
we've seen hard bargain be very
effective on these tapped out. Well, I'm
going to play a hidden card turn. So,
counter that. Draven's in. Sorry, Darius
is in.
And now Rexi going to reinforce on the
top. Mirror up to two.
All right.
And a reinforce of a ram to go along to
Darius. Not done yet. Here's a hidden
card
on the temple.
And now a uh a pretty good setup. So a
good amount of power on both
battlefields and a hidden card. Only a
ram and Ezreal on sorry Vi is there too.
>> Yeah, I was going to say an attempt to
hold into Vi with no hidden card, no
runes up seems ill faded.
>> Yeah, Vi Vi is kind of off to the side
there a little bit. And uh yeah, we
we've seen Vi more as a late game piece,
but Vi also just punches really really
hard. you punch first, ask questions
later. I mean, that is that is really
the motto for Vi.
Just to reiterate the stakes here, Jim,
I mean, the winner of this is in the top
eight of the regional qualifier here in
Las Vegas.
And so, they really want this to finish
because a tie is not getting you there.
A loss sends you out.
>> Yeah. And both players with with fairly
innovative takes on Draven. Of course,
Draven, the most played deck, had a
amazing conversion rate into day two.
Uh, but two basic versions, the basic
miracle version, the basic mid-range
version. Cool. That's great. Lots of
those. But both players here on very
innovative lists.
So, there's a bushwack.
Now, what time is it, Jeb? It's time for
Rossa.
>> Yeah, time to play the Rosses out with
the Bushwack. Now, after the Rosses are
played, you can actually start using the
VI ability as needed.
Yeah, kind of a fun little little side
anti- synergy.
>> Three cards in the bin might count, but
there may be some offscreen.
>> You could be if you go too deep with
buy, but that's pretty hard to do.
>> So, Roz's are ready. Ram is ready.
Ezreal's ready.
And uh Mirror's forces are lined up.
Only one energy available. You know,
it's mostly just that hidden guard and
the numbers on the table.
Jab really thinking it through.
>> There's battering to do. There's
Sundering.
>> There he goes.
>> All right. So,
these cards, of course, as a reminder,
the viability. It is a single ability
for a single card. Recycle one card from
your trash to give me plus one might.
And uh even though it's often done in
one lump, uh each one's individual.
Therefore, it is not randomized like
most mass recycles are. So Jab can put
these cards back in any order he wants,
making for a huge push.
The thing is for most decks and
especially in Origins, the order
wouldn't matter. And when you were
playing Annie and you went to buy ride
the wind, most people would just flip
the whole thing over, shovel it up,
throw it at the bottom of the deck, and
end the game. But here, Jab is uh almost
deterministically going to find this
order once again and will need to
remember it and know exactly what it is
and also stack it in a way that's
beneficial to him. Yeah, huge amount of
cognitive load here. Um so many cards
thinking about not just this turn, but
the next turn and the next turn and then
plotting out how we're going to get to
all these cards. So
big bumps on the VI. Now it is important
to note that both players are only at
two. usually just kind of big VI attack
happens later in the game. Uh so bunch
of cards to the bottom. That's a reload.
Three cards left in the trash. Vi is at
uh I assume that's 13.
>> Yes, not not one and three. So I guess
there's no 13 12-ided die. So Vi comes
in and crushes as she usually does.
>> Up to three for Jab taking over the
obelisk.
And now bigger question mark here is the
other battlefield with the hidden card.
We see Rasa Rosa Ram. Here's a
switcheroo. Hello
>> Rexi. Gotta do a little little Raza
impression. You want to know what Rexi
is gonna do? It's a Raza impression.
>> Yeah. So the Rexi's best form that we've
seen so far.
>> His form of Rosa.
>> His form of Rosa. Yeah. I mean it's
slightly better than just being a Rasa
there because it let the Switcheroo by
being worse than Rosa. It made
Switcheroo a better card. Jim, I'm
really not getting sold on this card
yet.
I I want to be I want to be on board. I
love Rexai. We love Rexai. We talked,
you know, but
>> we do love Rexi. So, Ram takes the
combat and jab goes to four. And now
Miro is really running out of resources.
Uh an Ezreal, a seal, and that is it.
Two Ezreals. And now, not only uh are
there is Jab ahead on board and points,
but kind of hitting that point where
we're going to see second time through
deck. being said, you know, with the VI
vulnerable and possibly able to be lost
here as a shovel could bring it back,
but you know, um, that part of the
engine could be shut down for a while.
>> Yeah. And I mean, I think the other big
thing for us to look at in this moment
is seven runes for Me, three for Jab.
Had to commit a lot of resources to make
this happen over these last few turns.
And if Mu can have a rebuild, a refill
of this board, Jab may not be able to do
so because of this lack of runes, the
the the Rosses have kind of been
expended. They're in the bin. There's
not a lot else in the bin there. There's
no shovel yet to kind of bring them back
out. Even if there was a shovel, now
there's only five cards in the trash.
So, it's a little bit more of a
struggle. And it's possible that Miro
can look for a big rebuild. And it it
starts here. It starts winning a trade,
getting your seal back, so you're
continuing to stay ahead of the curve
when it comes to runes. Draw for Draven.
Big grip of cards,
and now it's what units are going to be
able to come down and continue to win
off of that Rexai. Now, hey, look, party
time.
>> The first time I'm happy to see this
card. This comes in accelerated.
>> Doesn't have to pay the power cost on
the accelerator. Just four runes because
of Azreel.
>> Yep. Additional cost. And four is bigger
than three. We have established this.
Rexai breacher is going to get that
conquer. And that is something that
Rossa would not have done.
>> Yep. So assault one and then a falling
star mops it all up and all of a sudden
a big swing. Meu now taking a a say
strangle hold but taking the reigns in
this game for sure. So Ezreal and Rexi
at battlefields. Jab's got the full
seals as you said only five runes.
Jab also has, you know, some good
knowledge of uh what's going on in the
deck and stack deck will put push
towards that. So remember Jab, these
bottom 10 cards are stacked up in the
theoretical what Jab thought was perfect
at the time, perfect order. So once we
get into that, you have to assume it
it's got to be good for Jab.
>> Yeah, this stacked look does find a
Rosa. I think there may have been a
called shot as well
and it may have also been the shovel
which that's certainly a a spread of
cards that you want to you want all of
them in the hand not sending a few back
to the bottom that you have to find
later especially after you had to put 10
at the bottom. There is going to be the
bushwack that feels necessary following
the removal of the board.
All right, so two cards played so far
and we're starting to feel that rune
squeeze.
So we see a bushwack here only will have
one rune left
like
I think we're over 10 again in the in
the trash.
>> Yeah. So without a called shot the
bushwack cannot work with a battering
ramp. We need bushwack called shot or
bushwack roasa if we're above 10. I
think we are.
So jab does go for just a battering ram.
Going to have to fall behind on point.
So just ram pass.
>> Wow. All right. So last turn for Mirror
looking even better now. We got a double
hold from Ezreal and Rexai. Mirror up to
six. This game swung hard.
>> Yeah. All off of Rexai bring well off of
falling star off of some of this big
turnarounds.
This is what we're talking about. The
rune advantage actually maybe making a
large difference here. for that batting
ram. If more things could be cast by
Jab, if you add more runes, the
battering ram becomes free. The bushwack
maybe comes down and Jab actually has an
answer to tap out. But as we've said for
this matchup before, if you can't answer
the tap out develop and push,
suddenly you're in big trouble and
sometimes the game is just over. And
Miro gets the big swing, gets the units
onto the board after responding to Jab's
push and there's no answer back. Going
up to six versus four on the hold. Now,
just one last push being needed to find
the win in game number two.
>> That being said, the clock's getting
low. There are eight minutes remaining.
Again, once again, as a reminder, Jab is
up a game. Miro is not won a game yet.
Uh, graphic is backwards, so sorry about
that one. So, this is game number two.
Jab up a game. Mirror looking to be in a
good spot to take game number two here.
That would put them in a very awkward
spot for game three with seven plus
minutes left.
stack deck.
Not the card you want to see when we're
talking about time, of course. You know,
a little fiddling with the some cards.
And now what's the final push? Noxious
hopeful.
Got a pass. Six to four going jabs way.
Two runes and a draw. Top eight on the
line. The last round. Round 13 of
regional qualifier. Las Vegas plays
players vying for a top eight slot. Top
of the champion slot at a shot at the
championship.
>> You got that
>> slot
>> a fight
>> shot.
>> And here we go. So battering ramp comes
in conquers the Veil Temple floating one
power off the seal.
>> Jab to five but jab going to six then
being in a spot where Mirror is going to
go into the turn at six looking to
double conquer to win. So here's Ezreal.
>> Yeah, Ezreal. Two more looks. Most of
his hand, three more looks even with the
scrap. He most of his hand felt like it
was not the big developments, right? We
even saw Britain here. I feel like
Britain here struggling a little bit.
It's good in theory for the matchup. You
stop hidden cards from affecting you.
you stopped the ability to have maybe a
rebuke blow you out, but not often are
you able to actually find the ability to
have that many runes and the board and
everything to go send.
>> All right, so that is it. So Jab's
saying if I got something, it's
interaction because there's so many
cards in hand. There's not a lot of
might in play. So we're going back
mirror's way called shot to start.
Mirror looking to take this game at six
points looking for the double conquer.
Now, this is the spot where the Brin
here we saw in Jab's hand would actually
be massive as Jab looks for that soft
hold. Eight in a hidden card. Four runes
remaining to try and fight back. This is
nine runes. Remember
would end the game.
Think if the song was available, it
would already be sung. So, Miru has to
find the best way to proceed to get this
double conquer down and win this game.
All right, Ezreal into Obelisk. That's a
point. That's seven ongame point. If
Miro can conquer this last battlefield,
Veil Temple, that's where the defenses
lie for Jeb.
>> Rebuke.
>> Rebuke on battering ram. That's a great
place to start.
>> Just going to fighter flight it back.
Dodge the rebuke, but the effect is the
same when it comes to this turn, this
combat.
>> Yeah. So
that fighter flight could have used
defensively. Saving the ram is cool and
all, but not cool if we don't get
another turn. So here comes the party.
Rexai Ezreal knockoff coming in. Here's
a rebuke. Rebuke targets
>> just doesn't have enough.
>> Packs it up.
>> Oh boy. All right. So have our players
getting ready for game number three
here. Uh and unfortunately uh as they
get all set up
>> going into game three,
There's not enough time.
>> Yeah, not enough time to do it.
>> And these players unfortunately
>> are going to draw and that is a a very
very tough result. Uh a super hard
fought match, a super difficult match.
We've seen these Ramros
>> just you know knock down drag drag out
battles. Uh but so an unfortunate draw
still a great finish for both players.
>> Yeah, I mean a great finish. uh they're
fighting maybe for top 16 birth at that
point at the 101 and two stage but in a
a pure winning in losing out tying out
neither player is going to grab the win
this time around and opens up another
slot for an X2 who is fighting tooth and
nail in that final round to make it in.
That is a big a big point. So of course
these X2 players might have room for one
maybe two in top eight. Uh, but the ones
that could breakers are chomping at the
bit because that's kind of the oh man I
think I'm going to come in ninth if only
for some weird thing that happens that
knocks one of these players out of the
top eight. That draw is it. So two
players in a win in a win in producing
only one in theory actually producing
zero. So for our X2 players got you got
a little more of a shot there. So let's
take a look. So we are taking a short
break. We're going to have final
standings for you. We're going to have
top eight for you. Do not go nowhere.
Grab some popcorn. Sit your butts down.
Heat. Heat.